hey this is Andrew Brown over here on
free Camp bringing you another free
Cloud certification study course and
this time we are looking at the ads
Cloud practitioner also known as the CF
C02 and the way we're going to achieve
ads certification is through lectur
content Hands-On labs and as always I
provide you a full free practice exam
the best way to support uh more free
study courses like this one is to
purchase the optional paid additional
materials it's going to help you on your
exam and it's going to allow me to
produce more of these uh great Cloud uh
certification study courses if you don't
know me I'm Andrew Brown and this is the
fourth time I've taught this uh
certification so it's really refined at
this point and I've taught a bit of
everything in the cloud so we've looked
at adabs Azure gcp terraform kuber dedes
you name it I've taught it uh but that's
about it and I will see you in class in
the next video
ciao
hey this is Angie Brown and we are at
the start of our journey asking the most
important question first which is what
is the adus cloud practitioner well it's
ad's entry level certification that's
going to teach you things like the cloud
fundamentals so we're talking cloud
Concepts architectures deployment models
it's a close look at adus core Services
which would be our compute our storage
our Network our databases and it's a
quick look at the vast amount of adus
services and functionality around adus
so we're looking at identity security
billing pricing support and a lot more
stuff and we'll get into that in the
course and we'll even look at the exam
guide outline but uh yeah there is a lot
of stuff um the course code for this
certification is now the clf C02 the old
one was the
c01 uh the way to know if there is a new
course is if this becomes the c03 if you
see that then this course um may be out
of date um but uh yeah right now it's a
C02
um often people refer to this
certification as the CCP to stand for
the certified clock practitioner how you
want to refer to it is up to you but uh
there are a few ways of describing this
certification I want to point out that
adus is the leading cloud service
provider in the world and the cloud
practitioner is the most common starting
point for people breaking into the cloud
so even if you're going to uh utilize
another cloud service provider I'm just
going to say that you're going to get a
really good uh Foundation with this
certification even if it's not the uh
same provider uh so who is the
certification for well consider the
cloud practitioner if you are new to
cloud and you're learning the
fundamentals you are at the executive
management or sales level and you need
to acquire strategic information about
Cloud for adoption or
migration or you are a senior Cloud
engineer or Solutions architect who
needs to reset or refresh their adus
knowledge after working uh with cloud
services or adus for multiple years
um it's always a surprise that when I
come back and I refresh this course uh
the things that have changed and it's
very easy to uh miss those things so
yeah this this certification is for
everybody so what is the value of the
certification well this uh certification
provides the most expansive view
possible of cloud architecture and ads
it uh we I would describe this as having
a bird's eye view or the 50,000 ft view
so with that in mind uh the idea here is
to promote big pictures thinking we're
zooming out and assessing the cloud or
itus landscape for things like changes
Trends opportunities um and it's
important to understand about being
strategic about the approach and process
for your journey and that's why I like
the certification so much and I strongly
uh recommend it for everybody's Journey
so what is the value of the
certification well it's not a difficult
exam uh it's it's not going to validate
that you can build Cloud workloads so if
you are trying to obtain a technical te
implementation role like develop Cloud
developer Cloud engineer devops engineer
uh it's not going to be enough to attain
those technical Cloud roles um but it
could help short list your resume for
interviews um the exam covers content
not found in other certifications so it
is recommended as an essential study
guide uh for your adus journey do not
skip this one uh some people like to go
straight to the solution to architect
and then they realize that they didn't
set a good foundation or they just have
gaps uh in their knowledge which could
really help out in their careers so
really do not skip this one um I like to
make these road maps to give you an idea
uh in terms of where you can go after
this certification so here is uh all the
certifications currently that AOS has
notice that I have the data engineer
it's a really small one it just became
uh came out as a baa exam it's not as
hard as the professionals it's just
where I place it on this diagram um but
the idea is that we have a lot of
different ways that we can navigate or
uh work through these certifications and
these can generally map to particular
roles in the cloud so uh very often
people go right to the uh Solutions
architect I'm just getting my pen out
here but very often this is the approach
that'll go straight to here uh right
after the solution architect because
they're very similar um in terms of uh
scope and Challenge and difficulty where
the solution architect is a broad
certification just like the cloud
pratitioner but it's more focused on the
technical knowledge uh whereas this one
of course is much more broad the cloud
and then after that people will
generally go for the developer or the
CIS office administrator in my personal
opinion I really do think that people
should study all three Associates and do
all three Associates at the same time uh
because really I don't find that uh it
makes sense to leave out the ssops admin
or developer knowledge um it's just the
way that itus Engineers their
certifications but when you go to other
ones like let's say Google they only
have one associate and they have all the
um they call Cloud engineer and it has
everything in it and so again I just
feel like you should take all three but
you decide what works for you um and you
know you can see that there are various
routes but I want to just make it very
clear that certifications do not
validate programming they do not uh make
you do technical diagramming they don't
necessarily make you do code management
and there's many other technical skills
that are required for obtaining
technical roles like these roles um and
that is not the purpose of certification
certification is supposed to give you
knowledge specifically on AWS and so
just understand that you need to make
sure you get those skills uh somewhere
else I do try to uh slot in a lot of
these uh technical skills uh where I can
and so if you're uh if we're doing
something in the course and you're
wondering why are we doing this when
it's not on the certification it's
because I'm trying to give you those
adjacent skills uh so that you are
successful um in the future okay so how
long does it take to uh study to pass
this exam well depends right it depends
but if you're a beginner we're probably
looking at 30 hours so this is someone
who's never used databus or cloud
provider before uh you've never written
code or had a technical role if you're
experienced uh your study time is going
to be very low like as low as 6 hours
even lower uh if possible um especially
if you've already taken the
certification I sat it um uh blind right
I didn't look up anything and I passed
it no problem um but uh so it says here
you know if we've practiced we have
experience working with ads if we have
an equivalent experience in another
cloud service provider some people are
coming over from Azure or gcp so they
can kind of map their knowledge over to
Ada of us or if they have a strong
background in technology uh you might
really be already familiar with these
kind of offerings from
another uh like from another discipline
and so your study time can be really low
but I would say that um you know the
average study time is probably 24
hours so yes it's closer to the beginner
level but that's the average study time
that we found in and so it's basically a
split between 50 lectures and Labs so
labs are Hands-On skills and 50% with
practice exams uh a lot of people forget
that practice exams are part of the
study process so make sure that you do
do that uh we do recommend a study a
study time of one to two hours a day uh
for 14 days uh what does it take to pass
the exam we're still going on with this
here but you know you have to watch
those lecture videos and memorize key
information this is a knowledge based
exam it's not a uh it does not test your
skills so knowledge is key here uh you
should do Hands-On Labs we call those
follow alongs within your own account uh
this is just going to help uh cement the
knowledge in your head it really makes a
a huge difference so really do those
Hands-On labs and get practice exams to
simulate the real exam you absolutely
need to do this because if you don't
you're going to find that you did all
the study materials and then uh the exam
is its own uh Beast so make sure that
you go get some practice exams there's a
lot lot of places that you can get get
them from uh we offer a full free
practice exam I think we're the only
provider that does this but um we give
you like a full free practice exam and
we also have some paid ones so the best
way to support this this content that we
produce is to purchase our additional
paid materials uh if you don't have the
money that's okay we still have at least
one full free practice exam to help you
out you can find that over at exam
pro. cfy
C02 it looks like but it's a zero uh
let's talk about the content outline so
there are four domains and you have to
understand that each domain has its own
waiting this is going to determine how
many questions in that domain will show
up on your exam the first one is cloud
Concepts so that's for 24% so we're
looking at between 15 to 16 questions
domain two is about security and
compliance so that's 30% it's a a quite
high up there so we have about 1920
questions for cloud Technologies and
services it's 34% so understanding the
offerings of adss is the most important
thing in the exam it's the highest
percentage here so we're going to
definitely get 22 questions and then uh
we have domain four so billing pricing
and support where it's at 12% so we have
eight questions not a lot for billing
pricing support definitely important
because it's very easy to get overbuild
in the stuff but just you know point out
that you need to know a wide range of
adus services you need to know about
core Services more in depth so where do
you take this exam well you can take it
at the um at an inperson test center or
online from the convenience of your own
home I personally like to take it in a
test center if there is one near me I
used to live in Toronto now I don't so
there's no test centers near me and so I
have to do it online it's just so much
less stressful walking into a building
and everything is uh controlled whereas
at home you might have a lot of things
going on and that can cause a lot of
stress but you know do what makes sense
for you so adus delivers the exams via
Pearson View and so uh there's Pearson
view they have the online system which
you do uh you install on your computer
and then they also have a network of
test centers they partner with uh
previously adabs also offered it via PSI
um they don't do this anymore I'm not
sure why they changed this before it was
only PSI then they added Pearson and now
they've dropped PSI so your only option
is Pearson view I just want to point out
what a prct exam means it means that
it's it's someone is supervising uh your
um your exam while you're taking it so
you're not cheating so it's very common
that when you check in they're going to
ask to look around your room you might
even have to talk to them uh and it's
just again to make sure that what you do
is um your exam was legit legit so when
they issue your badge you know it's for
real anyway let's talk about grading
here so the passing grade here is 700
out of a a th000 points and so you need
to get around 70% to pass ad of us like
many other Cloud providers use scaled
scoring so um that doesn't mean if you
get exactly 70% that you'll pass but uh
I mean more or less it works out to to
be that okay so the response types uh we
have here well first of all we have 65
questions and there are 50 questions
that are scored and then there's 15 that
are unscored and if that sounds bizarre
I mean I I agree with you I think it's
odd that they give you 15 unscored
questions but the reason ads will do
this is that they want to introduce new
questions um to help test against the
difficulty of the exam um because you
know maybe some people know more than uh
what they're expecting so they can
adjust the difficulty of the exam I
think that they use it as an anti-che
mechanism as well but from the test
taker it can get a bit stressful because
you can get 15 really crazy wild
questions that were not in your um uh
course studies and it's just adab us
testing things out and so I just want to
point out don't get stressed out when
you take this exam and you get a really
funny question it's probably one of
those unscored questions but on top of
that you know there are 15 scored
questions you can get wrong so you can
get a total of 30 questions wrong on
this exam and pass I just want to make
that uh really clear there there is no
penalty for wrong questions so
absolutely always submit an answer and
take your best guess the format of the
questions are multiple choice and
multiple answer so you know it's not too
stressful in terms of the formatting of
questions
um there are again 15 unscored questions
of the exam they will not count towards
your final score why are there unscored
questions uh they're there to evaluate
the introduction of new questions
they're there to determine if the exam
is too easy and the passing score of the
question difficulty needs to be
increased to discover users who are
attempting to cheat the exam or steal
dump exam questions if you encounter
questions you've never studied for uh
that seem really hard keep your cool and
remember that they may be unscored
questions just really want to emphasize
that there in terms of the duration you
get 1.5 hours so you have about 1.5
minutes per question your exam time is
90 minutes your seat time is20 minutes
what are we saying when we say seat time
this is the time it takes uh or that you
should allocate for the full exam uh
that includes uh things like reviewing
the instructions uh showing on uh
showing the online Proctor your
workspace reading accepting the NDA
completing the exam provide the feedback
at the exam so a lot of people go okay
my exam starting or I have 90 or 90
minutes exam but really you want to show
up 30 minutes prior uh because that
checkin process can be really really
stressful so you know just consider that
uh the full scope of time you need to
dedicate for these exams this uh
certification is valid for 36 months so
that's 3 years before recertification
some other providers uh like Azure if
you do the fundamentals it's forever um
other ones have require you to refresh
every year other ones um you don't have
to take the full exam you have a
reassessment that is free inabus likes
to do it this way the nice thing though
is that when you do pass a certification
um somewhere ads allows you to get the
next exam half off uh so at least there
are cost saving mechanisms if you do
pass an exam for the next follow-up
certification but yeah uh that is pretty
much a breakdown of uh the exam guide we
will go and take a look at the actual
exam guide so we can uh understand the
full scope of what's in there uh but
yeah we'll see you in the next one okay
[Music]
ciao hey everybody it's Andrew Brown and
we are here on the training and
certification page on the adus website
and what I want to do here is I want to
pull up the exam guide so that we can um
make sure that we know exactly what it
is that we're getting ourselves into uh
we did cover this in summary in the
previous video but uh I think it's
always useful for you to know exactly
where these things are adabs is always
changing their marketing pages and I've
already noticed a few changes here so um
just understand that's the nature of
cloud notice here that it's talking
about the uh beta exam certification so
even earlier we talked about the data
engineer or we at least showed it on our
journey map and it's not even it's not
even 100% out beta so you can see we're
kind of prepping for the future here I
also want to point out that they have
this like certifications path uh thing
and I I don't really like it because I
don't think it's very accurate so the
first thing they show is Solutions
architect and they don't even say you
need to get the other two associate
certifications which you absolutely
should do if before you go for your
Solutions architect professional the
data analytics is no longer a uh
certification that adus is producing so
this is an out-of-date document so I
just want you to understand that these
are marketing Pages they're here to
maximize the amount of certifications
you need to obtain my goal is not to
make you take every certification my
goal is to make sure that you are
prepared uh to do the job and um I just
want to you know help you avoid going
down the certification route and getting
too many certifications that aren't
going to benefit you so just take these
with a grain of salt when you're reading
them okay so anyway what I want to do is
drop this down and go to Cloud
partitioner um and here on the cloud
cloud practitioner page if we scroll on
down we got prepare for the exam and
here we'll click the exam guide and
it'll open up a PDF and it'll give us
all the information we need to know this
is what AB has been doing for a long
time is making these um examp guide PDFs
which I really like uh but anyway the
first thing we should do is confirm the
course code so this one says CF CO2 so
we know we are on the right track and
then down below here it says this exam
validates the candidates ability to
complete the following task I want to
highlight some key wordss
explain understand describe and identify
so understand that this certification is
not checking whether you know how to do
Cloud it's more if you understand Cloud
um and the majority of aable
certification
in fact all of them are multiple choice
and multiple answers so they can't
really check if you were able to do
something in Cloud so just understand
the limits of certifications at least
eight of the certifications based on
their testing mechanisms so when it says
Target candidate it's saying uh where
you should be in order to pass this exam
and so they're suggesting that if you
had six months of exposure to adabs uh
with Cloud design implementation operate
operation then uh you should be able to
pass it it's just weird uh worded
strangely because it makes it sound like
you should have this experience um
before you even start studying which is
not true they just mean like if you want
to pass it you don't need six months to
pass this exam that's crazy you just
need what we recommended which was um uh
the amount of hours we said the average
hours is 24 hours so um I'm not sure why
they put six months I guess it's just
they're for those who are really having
a hard time with Cloud they give you a
lot of uh um scope or room there but you
can see they're pointing out from non-it
backgrounds recommended us knowledge
Cloud concept security core Services
economics that's that's just a repeating
of the
domains um notice it says job tasks that
are out of scope is
coding um Cloud architecture design load
performance and testing I'm highlighting
these three because I just want to point
out that in associate level professional
and Specialty they actually do ask
questions around troubleshooting mation
and I suppose they do architectural
design but they never ever ever No
certification in ads is going to test
your coding skills architectural diagram
skills and they're not really good about
load and performance testing they have
like use case scenarios but um just
understand again the limits of these
certifications coming down below to the
response types we got our multiple
choice our multiple
response um so that's pretty clear there
there is uh 50 scored questions there's
15 unscored questions so that is very
clear C the uh the the the point system
is based out of a th to th000 points the
lowest you can get is 100 points I don't
know how that works why like why can't
you get zero points I don't know the
passing score is
700 so that's what we need to score
there then down below here it's just
talking about the course outline and it
actually has a comparison of the old clf
co1 so we can take a look there and see
what actually has changed so down below
here we have our Cloud cont Concepts as
security compliance our Cloud technology
services our bilding pricing support and
then it comes in and starts describing
all this stuff now I need to make it
very clear how IUS makes their exams
they give you a huge list of things you
need to learn but if you learn um each
one of these things you can end up
overstudying or you'll find that the
like the exam guide outline is not one
to one I'll give you an example we'll
look at something else so I'm going to
go to Hashi Corp here for a second Hashi
Corp terraform
certification as a as an example of how
different adab certifications are so for
hashicorp they will this is their exam
guide they'll give you each of these
items and you can be 100% sure that
every single thing every one one of
these things will show up on the exam
one to one so it's very easy to know
exactly what you need to study for um
and uh if you know all these things
you'll you will pass in us they list all
these things but they won't all show up
they they're pulling from a very large
pool so to kind of narrow down what you
need to study you need to have a good
sense of um overall everything and and
you're just going to get some things
wrong but um anyway coming back here the
first Cloud Concepts they're talking
about the benefits of
cloud so we have a section on benefits
of cloud and so they talk about the
value proposition so there's like six or
nine of them I forget we have a multiple
slides on that and so we're talking
about economics scale benefits of global
infrastructure advantages of high
availability elasticity and uh agility I
think we call these Cloud architecture
terminologies because they're not really
benefits I mean they are benefits of
cloud but I I like to group them a
little bit differently then we have
identified design principles for abis
Cloud so we have the well architect
framework this uh was for the most part
never in the clf1 for 90% of its history
and then they decided last year or
something to add it in um and it and uh
before even wasn't even the solution
architect associate but now it's even at
this level and that's totally fine you
only need to know it at a very high
level so um it's not too difficult to
learn but it it's a white paper it's a
PDF that um you know just describes how
adus thinks that you should design uh
your architecture then we have
understand the benefits of strategies
and migration to the cloud so we have
Cloud adoption strategies uh Cloud
adoption framework so um this was this
was not in the last exam but uh luckily
I included it because I thought it was
something that was very important and so
I already have it in the certification
course even from the last one they
actually do ask quite a few questions
around the cloud adoption framework but
when you look at and again this one's
like a white paper just like this one
above here and we'll talk about what
white white papers are if you if you
never heard that term uh it'll make
sense in the course but the cloud
adoption framework um there's not a lot
to it but on the exam they'll ask you a
lot of questions around it so you just
have to have good common sense um about
choosing those answers if that makes
sense um identifying appropriate
migration
strategies sure I guess so I never got
any snowball questions um they they say
snowball here we go down below here
understand concepts of cloud
economics so cost Savings of moving to
Cloud aspects of cloud
economics uh fixed costs compared with
VAR able costs they're talking about U
Opex Opex and
capex understanding the associate of on-
premise
environments uh understand the
difference between licensing strategies
and adabs never ever really ever
mentioned uh bring your own licenses
ever in their certification courses and
I never got this on the exam and other
people I sat for the new exam never uh
encountered this still good to know but
I'm just saying that I don't know why
it's listed in here because it's
definitely not on the exam but it is a
good thing to note the basic level
understand the concept of right sizing
um and maybe I'll go back and make a
slide on that cuz I don't think I
actually make a deliberate slide on that
but I think what they mean there is
understanding uh like how horizontal
scaling and stuff uh stuff like that
works but um again no questions on the
exam for right sizing at least not from
its technical definition like that
identify benefits of
automation I think there might have been
one question of saying like hey which
one lets you automate stuff and you just
chose Cloud information but they really
don't talk a whole they don't ask a lot
of questions on the exam about iic
infrastructure as a code identifying uh
managed a services this is something
they do a lot in exams like describe a
service you pick it we have security and
compliance so we have the Ed shared
responsibility model you absolutely need
to know that that for sure always always
appears on the exam um customers
responsibility they'll do this a lot
they'll say like they'll give you a
scenario of um of like a typical
workload or resource and then you have
to uh determine if it's the customers's
responsibility or adab Us's
responsibility describing responsibility
of the customer itus share so again this
is just all the share responsibility
model still here describing how the itus
respons responsibilities and customer
responsibilities can shift depending on
the the service used so yeah this is
basically the sh responsibility model
understand the it Cloud security governs
compliance so uh compliance governments
Concepts benefits of Cloud security they
don't really talk about that uh they
really directly ask that in the exam but
yes we do cover that where to capture
and locate logs that are associated with
Cloud security they absolutely do not
ask that on the exam I'm not sure why
that's here um identify where to find
A's compliance information that will
absolutely be on the exam understanding
compliance needs among Geographic
locations and
industries um sure I mean they're
talking about we have a slide in this in
the um Global infrastructure but it's um
like data sovereignty and like gov cloud
and things like that describing how
customers secure resources for ads so
just generally knowing the security
services y that absolutely is on the
exam identifying different encryption
options I never got this on my exam I
never heard of anyone else getting this
but um if they are going to talk about
this they're probably going to talk
about it around S3 recognizing services
that Aid in governance and compliance
absolutely absolutely for sure that the
you will get questions around uh things
like fips or Hippa or like common common
compliance certifications not specific
datab best but just in general um here
they're just talking about specific
Security Services this is kind of a
repeat of what they're talking about up
here um but there's the say there's
identity service governance service it's
all the same thing here recognizing
compliance requirements that uh vary
among adus Services sure identify adus
management capabilities so they're
talking about IM am um the adus root
account we got
a separate slide on that uh principal of
leas privilege absolutely absolutely
will they will ask that there a single
sign on also known as it identity Center
I don't know anyone who's gotten this as
a question on their
exam but uh it's we got a slide for
it understanding access Keys yep we
cover that PO uh password policies
credential storage Secrets manager
systems manager um just a bunch of stuff
identify components and resources of
security describing a security features
so ACL
a wff security groups they really don't
ask these on the exam so I'm just trying
to make a point that they're asking for
all this stuff and they don't even it
doesn't even show up in the exam so um
and you know we can just keep going and
going through this and I can keep
telling you what is and isn't but if you
go down below it gets even crazier
because they go any of this stuff could
show up in the exam it's just like a big
list it's
crazy so you know I know that seems
stressful but you know just follow
follow me uh in this course and I you
will absolutely pass if you go through
my content you'll have no issue there
and we'll avoid all the stuff that
doesn't show up and don't stress out
about this exam guide now let's go take
a look here and see where the rebalance
has changed so notice here that this
went from 26% to 24% they never used to
do this so I really appreciate this is
now in the exam guide but we got 25 to
30% 33 to 34% 16 to 12% why they would
reduce this one I don't know but it is a
shuffle whatever um they of course
increased uh the technology section more
and did some basic rewarding support
should have always been in there so it
was always under that section but uh
it's nice that they labeled it as such
um so notice here it says no content was
deleted from the exam and um this was
the largest struggle for me for the
certification because I already made all
the content for the last one my old one
is not spired and I was struggling
because I already had this as well this
is the only thing that they added that
was new to the certification and then
they just rework these numbers here and
so um you know I just I added I did add
more I add more Labs I added more um
other stuff there but I'm just going to
say like I don't know why they did an
update from co1 to CO2 because barely
anything changed now I shouldn't say
that the exam questions did change I
noticed that the exam questions um the
quality of them kind of uh have dropped
I'm wondering if they're using
generative AI to generate out questions
or or something but um there's something
the quality of questions are are
definitely um different and I would say
that they're more uh they're not worded
as clearly as they used to be for
whatever reason um but anyway you'll
still be okay it's totally fine uh
recategorization of clf CO2 and so they
just did a shuffle of um of these points
and I again I really don't think that
the the new one is better how useful is
this exam guide I should probably give
them uh survey feedback but anyway just
give you an idea how much stuff there is
in here do not stress out just stick
with the course you'll absolutely pass
uh and uh you know hopefully that gives
you uh some better confidence there but
we'll see you in the next one uh chiao
[Music]
chiao hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and what we're looking at here is a
free practice exam that I provide with
you uh for this course and all you have
to do is sign up on exam Pro you don't
even need a credit card and you can
redeem uh the free available content
here and this is really up to date and
very well simulates what you will see on
the actual exam and it's a full set full
65 questions so you're getting a real
simulation here but what I'm going to do
is just start it off here we're not
going to do the whole thing I'm just
going to click through and show you a
couple of them so you have an idea um
the level of difficulty these questions
are so the first question we got
presented with here is which a support
plans provide access to the seven core
trusted advisor checks and so that is a
question that you might need to answer I
don't want to spoil this for you so I'm
not going to tell you the answer we'll
go to the next one so a large accounting
firm wants to utilize OS to store
customer accounting information in
archive storage and must store this
information for 7 years due to
Regulatory Compliance which dat service
meets this requirement so the first one
you'll notice this one is multiple
choice or sorry multiple answers so you
have to select multiples before you can
submit your answer and the the next one
here is just a single choice so those
are the two types of questions you will
see on the exam they're not going to ask
you anything about coding you're not
going to see any kind of code um in
terms of length that's pretty much what
we'll see in terms of the uh questions I
think in many cases I wrote a little bit
more more like um in the style the
solutions architect associate to make it
slightly more difficult just so that
you're a little bit overprepared so if
you do well on these practice exams
you're going to do uh well on the exam
okay so I just wanted to kind of get you
that exposure there
[Music]
okay hey everyone it's angrew brown and
I have opened our exam simulator this is
on the exam Pro platform and this is the
free Set uh that I promised uh folks in
the course so no cost to go get this one
you just have to sign up and and access
it but the reason I have it open is
because I really want to talk about a
very specific type of question that
we've included in here that will not
appear on your exam so uh for those who
are familiar with Azure certifications
um at the associate level or higher
there's this question type called a case
study and what a case study is I'll I'll
just pull it up here but I believe uh in
this randomization of this practice exam
set I think it's this one here but what
a case study is it gives you a scenario
that you have to read through or a a
case study about a company so you read
about the company you look at the
objective its requirements constraints
this St can all be different there could
be diagrams all sorts of stuff in here
but the idea is that you are
contextualizing a business use case and
they're going to be asked a series of
questions uh multiple choice multiple
select and it all ties back to that case
study so the reason we included this is
that um we believe that this is going to
give you better comprehension and a
higher chance of passing so it's not
going to appear in your exam but we
include it as an extra challenge to you
so that you have um a higher chance of
passing now if you don't like this we do
have other practice exams they of course
are paid that uh that are just the
normal style which is all multiple
choice multiple select for um this this
course the cloud partitioner um but you
know we do have them in half of the
practice exam sets because uh again I
think that it's going to be good for you
so hopefully you see that as a bonus but
I just wanted to give you a heads up um
about this uh because you'll counter me
like what the heck is this um the other
thing I want to point out is that when
you enter a case study it's like having
a mini exam within your exam so once
you've answered all these questions uh
you can't go back and and um you can
while you're within the case study but
if you get to the end of this and submit
the case study you can't go back and
update it so just be aware of that um
and you know again hopefully you like
this we love feedback to hear what
people like but it's just they always
appeared in Azure exams and uh we want
to see them in 8 us ones as well because
I think they're just really good for uh
testing your knowledge but anyway we'll
see you in the next one okay
ciao
[Music]
hey everyone it's Andrew Brown your
favorite Cloud instructor and what I
want to do in this video is to show you
um a unique feature that is in our
platform um just in case you come across
it while you're while you're uh doing
the materials I can't remember if it's
in the free or paid tier I believe it's
in the paid tier so I'm not trying to
upsell anyone but I just want to make
sure people are aware of that while they
are um taking this course but sometimes
what you'll see in the follow along so
like for example we have S3 down here
which is for uh Cloud simple storage uh
and I don't have them always included in
the videos but um at some point I might
do that but the idea is that um we have
these validators and validators what
they can do is they can verify uh
whether you actually have uh the
resources uh deployed in your cloud
account um so it's like an additional
check to make sure that you did it right
so for example we have this one for S3
so it says setup an S3 bucket it is
account validation so so this tool
performs an automated check on your
personal cloud infrastructure to confirm
its alignment with the build project
requirements make sure you input precise
values for your infrastructure
components so let's go through that and
show you this I'm showing this as an
example but you know you'll see them in
other in other fongs and lookout for for
that stuff I believe in the to-do it'll
even show it uh here so if you watch the
video and you watched it to the end or
you press that button there but you'll
get your your uh your star uh for that
but the way it works let's go through it
so the first thing is I want to uh click
on this new run button and then what
we'll do is we'll have an agreement so
this agreement is confirming that you
understand that you are using your own
cloud account uh and we are going to uh
need to get readon access to it and just
understand that you are using uh you're
providing us access to account that is
your own account and it's not your
company's account because obviously we
don't want to get in trouble for
accessing data that we're not supposed
to have and you don't want to get in
trouble for that so that's just a a
friendly reminder so I'm going to click
the I agree and the accept the next
thing it's going to ask for is your itus
account ID the region that you're
deploying in and then it there might be
additional uh parameters that it wants
to know so that we can test against it
so what I'm going to do is just log into
my adus account it'll just take me a
moment and we'll fill this out for real
okay now of course I'm filling out this
example here but I just want to point
out that um uh you know you're just
going to have to follow this procedure
and it'll be slightly different for each
one uh for that okay be back in just a
second all right so I'm logged into and
uh one of my ad's accounts I have a lot
of them uh I think this one is my
developers one so uh for this particular
follow along you would have created an
S3 bucket right and so um what I'm going
to do here is go to S3 and I already
know what to do so it's not too hard for
me but I'm going to go ahead and create
myself a new bucket I'm going to make
note of the region that I'm deploying in
so S3 is a bit unique because it shows
Global but you are still deploying to a
specific region so we'll go ahead and
create that bucket I'm just going to say
my validator bucket as a test notice
where it's deploying Us East one I could
change that to anything else like ca
Central um I am in Canada so doesn't
hurt to deploy where I am and we'll go
here and go all the way down and I'm
going to go and create this bucket okay
so um that bucket name was I forget it
was like something like validator and so
what I need to do is copy that name
we'll go back over here and so it's
asking for the bucket name so there's
the bucket name we need to it account ID
that always appears in the top right
corner and they have a nice um clipboard
button there to get that in there and
the region so we deploy that in CA
Central 1 so it says there CA Central
one you're always using this uh
programmer's name not the full name but
this this fun handle you can see them
all here on the right hand side if
you're not sure about that but what
we'll do is go back over here we'll
paste in that user region and so what
this is going to do is create a um a
cloud formation template that's going to
give access to us to uh your account so
we'll go ahead and hit save and continue
and so now we uh We've inputed our
parameters those have been saved and now
it's saying we need to access your Cloud
resources so we want you to generate
this cloud formation template we're
going to press the button we'll wait a
moment and we can either download this
template or use the adab CLI to run it
um the CLI command is a lot easier to
use and I'm going to recommend that you
always do that and uh so what we're
going to do is generate out this CLI
command and we're going to get this
oneline command and I'm going to go back
over to AWS sorry I know I'm going
really fast but it's just how it is and
at the top left corner we have this
little button here that's for cloud
shell we're going to open it up I know
coding scary but it's really important
to get as much coding experience or
scripting as you can so strongly
recommend you follow along here but uh
it's going to open up and once it's it's
open we can paste that in now sometimes
this wants to have some kind of EBS
storage so you might have to say yes and
wait a little bit um that's just the
norm for cloud storage but I'm going to
go back here I'm going to copy this
command okay and we're going go back
over here I'm going to right click and
paste and this always happens when
there's a multitext line we got a pop up
here and we're just going to review it
looks good so notice it has a template
URL so that's the template it's pulling
in um there's temporary credentials to
uh to allow that uh it's going to create
a stack name called exam Pro validation
and it's going to say capability named I
am now this might fail because I've done
it before but we'll go ahead and paste
it in I'm going to hit enter
and it looks like it's creating the
stack so we'll go over to cloud
formation and uh we'll go
here and I'll just get this out of the
way I don't want that open right now and
so I'm just going to give this a
refresh and did that create that right
now that was the name of the stack right
exam Pro validation that is correct and
if I go over
here uh what's the date today I don't
even know because that might be an older
date I mean it's November so I I don't
think that one worked because I already
had it uh working there before um so
what I'm going to do
here I'm going to go ahead and delete
this one okay so I just want to point
out like if you're doing multiple
validators in the system you always have
to roll it back tear it down okay like
the old one so I'll delete that one
again cuz I just don't have a strong
confidence that it was actually deployed
so I'll be back here in just a moment it
tears down all right it actually did uh
finish tearing down so that is um there
but I'm going to go back here I'm going
to attempt to run this command again so
go ahead and copy this and I will paste
it in again we'll say paste and I'll hit
enter and uh it says already existed in
the sack well what are you talking about
it's definitely uh definitely not there
that's what I thought I would get as an
error the first time around so this is
CA Central 1 oh oh you know what it is
I'm in North Virginia so you got to be
very careful with your um your regions
so I go over
here so I I I did delete one that was
from another one that's why I was
confused because I thought it already
existed I have to delete it out th this
is normal in Cloud right so just
understand that when I do follow alongs
I don't edit out the tricky Parts
because I know it makes it a little bit
confusing but it really does help to
demonstrate uh how confusing Cloud can
be and how to work through those proc
but over here CA Central so this is
deployed 11:15 that's the date that I've
deployed this on so that makes sense uh
here so we just got to be very uh aware
of that so this is in C Central one uh
but we'll go back over here and so this
is done so we know that it's done
because it's here it's in the region
that we expect it to be in so now the uh
the permissions are done we can run the
polar so what the polar is going to do
is it's now going to pull data from your
account uh uh and that way we're going
to to uh be able to then validate
whether things are correct so we'll go
ahead and run the pull and notice it
says S3 API list buckets it flashed it
really quickly but the way this tool
works is it's actually using the adab
CLI underneath so I'm just going to go
ahead and just show you what this
is uh and just show you a quick
reference here so the ad C is a
pragmatic way to um uh access uh
information uh for eight of us we
probably show that somewhere in this
course and so the command it was running
I believe was I should know I coded this
was S3
API and then it was like list
buckets uh list buckets so that's the
command it ran so really what the
validator did it it did ads S3 API list
buckets okay and if you notice this it
returns back Json so we get back the
payload that's what we are story in our
own adus account which by the way we
delete after a period of time I don't
remember how much time but we we don't
hold on to your data for long cuz we
don't really want it um but yeah so here
it's returning back that data and so
somewhere in here that there the the
buckets in here right so we've pulled
that data and it's there and so now we
can run the validator we'll click run
validator and it's super fast because we
already have the data downloaded and
it's doing one check here so it says
should have bucket matching name so you
can see it's it's doing it's loading
from a Json file that's called S3 API
list buckets we always name our the Json
files app after the commands and it's
looking through buckets so if we go over
here all the top here for a moment you
can see buckets so it's looking within
this array and it's trying to match a
name called my validator bucket which
which which you provided to
us so somewhere in here I have a lot of
buckets in this account somewhere in
here uh there it is it's there and so
that's how that works um but yeah just
look out for those validators um and uh
try to run them and and validate that uh
you are able to uh do this stuff okay
but we'll see you in the next one okay
ciao oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait I didn't show you how to clean up
I'm just running off screen here so once
you're
done uh what you can do is you can go
over to Cloud information here and you
should do this is go ahead and delete
the stack okay um because that's going
to tear down the permissions so that we
no longer have access to your account um
so that's kind of an important thing to
do um but uh we'll go ahead and the
other thing about these permissions is
that we're only asking for exactly what
we need access to so in this in this uh
permissions it only generate out to get
access to uh the S3 bucket specifically
what we're accessing for so even if you
left it up it's usually okay it's safe
but um you know if there's no reason for
us to have access anymore you should all
obviously delete it um but yeah that one
is now gone and so now we are absolutely
done I'm going to go ahead and just
close this out here but yeah hopefully
uh that makes it pretty clear how
validators working in our system and you
see the benefit to getting that uh check
in your real account
[Music]
ciao hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are at the start of our
journey asking the most important
question first which is what is cloud
computing so cloud computing is the
practice of using a network of remote
servers hosted on the internet to store
manage and process data rather than a
local server or personal computer and so
when we're talking about on premise you
own the servers you hire the IT people
you pay or rent the real estate you take
all the risks but with a cloud provider
uh someone else owns the servers someone
else hires the IT people someone else
pays or rents the real estate and you
are responsible for configuring cloud
services and code and someone takes care
of the rest of it for you
[Music]
okay so to understand cloud computing we
need to look at the evolution of cloud
hosting going all the way back to 19
1995 where if you wanted to host your
website or web app you'd have to get a
dedicated server so that would be one
physical machine dedicated to a single
business running a single project a site
or an app and as you can imagine these
are expensive because you have to uh buy
out write the hardware have a place to
store it the network connection having a
person to maintain it um but it did give
you a guarantee of high security um and
they still do as of today so this model
hasn't gone away but it's been
specialized for a particular use case
then came along the virtual private
server so the idea is we still had one
physical machine but now we were able to
subdivide um our machine into
submachines via
virtualization and so essentially you're
running a machine within a machine and
so you had better utilization of that
machine um running multiple web apps as
opposed to having a physical machine per
project so you got better utilization
and isolation of resources and so uh
these two options still requireed you to
purchase a machine a dedicated machine
and so that was still kind of expensive
but then came along shared hosting and
so if you remember uh the mid 2000s like
with GoDaddy or HostGator or any of
those sites where you had really cheap
hosting the idea is that you had this
one physical machine shared by hundreds
of businesses and the way this worked it
relied on uh tenants underutilizing
their resources so you know you wouldn't
have a submachine in there but you'd
have a folder with permissions that you
could use um and so you would really
share the cost and this was very very
cheap um but you were limited to
whatever that machine could do and you
were very restricted in terms of the
functionality you had and there was just
poor isolation meaning that you know if
one person decided to utilize the server
more they could hang up all the all the
websites on that single server then came
along Cloud hosting and the idea is that
you have um multiple physical machines
that act as one system so this is
distributed computing and so the system
is abstracted into mult multiple cloud
services and the idea is that you
basically get the advantages of a lot of
the things above so it's flexible you
can just add more servers um it's
scalable it's very secure because you
get that uh virtual isolation you get it
extremely at a low cost because you're
sharing that cost with the users where
in the shared hosting it might be
hundreds of businesses we're looking at
thousands of businesses and it was also
highly configurable because it was a
full virtual machine now uh Cloud
actually uh still includes all of these
types of Hosting they haven't gone away
uh but it's just the idea that you now
have more of a selection for your use
case uh but hopefully that gives you an
idea what cloud hosting looks like and
it really has to come down to
distributed computing
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and before we talk about ads we need
to know what is Amazon so Amazon is an
American multinational computer
technology corporation headquarted in
Seattle Washington and so this is the
Seattle skyline with the Space Needle
and Amazon was founded in 1994 by Jeff
Bezos and the company started as an
online store for books and expanded to
other products so as you can see this is
Jeff Bezos a long time ago and he has
this interesting spray painted sign and
his desk is held up by cinder blocks and
it looks like his uh desk is like an old
uh table or something and he's working
really late and he used to be a
millionaire at this time and he would be
driving into work his Honda Accord
because you know he just his motivation
was always to put all the money back
into the company so he really shows that
he worked really hard and it did pay off
because Amazon has expanded uh Beyond
just an online Ecommerce store into a
lot of different things such as cloud
computing which is Amazon web services
Digital streaming such as Amazon Prime
video Prime music they bought
twitch.tv they owned the Whole Foods
Market grocery store they have all this
artificials intelligence they own low
orbit satellites and a lot more stuff
it's hard to list at all and so Jeff
Bezos today is not the um the CEO it's
actually Andy jasse is the current CEO
of Amazon he was previously the CEO of
AWS so Jeff Bezos can focus on space
travel so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from xampro
and we are taking a look at Amazon web
services and this is the name that
Amazon calls their provider service and
it's commonly referred to just as AWS so
here is the old logo where we see the
full name and here is the new logo but I
like showing the old logo because it has
these cubes which best represent what
AWS is and it is a collection of cloud
services that can be used together under
a single unified API uh to build uh a
lot of different kinds of workloads so
adus was launched in 2006 and is the
leading cloud service provider in the
world I put an aster there because
technically
adus existed before 2006 and a cloud
service provider uh which is what adus
is is often initialized as CSP so if you
hear me saying CSP I'm just saying cloud
service provider okay so just time to
look at the timeline of when Services
rolled out the first one came out in uh
2004 it was simple Q service sqs and
this service still exists as of today
but at the time it was the only service
that was publicly available so it wasn't
exactly a cloud service provider at this
time and it was neither ads it was just
sqs but then a couple years later we had
simple storage service also known as S3
which was launched uh in March of 2006
and then a couple months later we had
elastic compute Cloud also known as ec2
um and ec2 is still uh like the most
used service within AWS and is like the
backbone for pretty much everything
there then in 2010 it was reported that
all of amazon.com's retail sites had
migrated to to AWS so even Amazon was
using AWS uh Full Steam and to support
industrywide training and and skill
standardization itus began offering a
certification program for computer
Engineers on April 2013 uh and this is
the type of certifications that we are
doing as we speak um so I just want you
to know that ad us was the one leading
uh Cloud certifications if we just want
to take a look here at the executive
level as of today the CEO is Adam he's
the former CTO of tableau and he spent a
decade with adus as a VP of Marketing
sales and support so he was there he had
left for a bit and now he is back then
we have uh wner and he's the CTO of AWS
he's been uh the CTO for pretty much the
entire time ad was existed with the
exception of sometime of the first year
he's famous for uh quoting everything
fails all the time and then there's Jeff
bar who's the chief evangelist so um if
you're ever wondering who is writing all
the blog posts and talking about ad bus
it's it's always Jeff bar
[Music]
okay all right so what I want to do here
is expand on what is a cloud service
provider also known as a CSP just
because there's a lot of things out in
the market there that might look like a
CSP uh but they actually are not so
let's go through this list and see what
makes a CSP so this is a company which
provides multiple cloud services ranging
from tens to hundreds of services those
cloud services can be chained together
to create CL architectures those cloud
services are accessible via a single
unified API so in ad's cases that is the
adus API um and from that you can access
the CLI the SDK the Management console
those cloud services utilize metered
building based on usage so this could be
per second per hour uh vpcu memory
storage things like that those cloud
services have Rich monitoring built in
so you know every API action is tracked
and you have access to that so in A's
case it's Aus cloud trail and the idea
here is those cloud services have
infrastructure as a service offering so
IAS that means they have networking
compute uh storage databases things like
that those cloud services offers
automation via infrastructure as code so
you can write code to set everything up
and so here's just kind of a example of
an architecture where we have a very
simple uh web application running on ec2
behind a load bouncer with the domain
with r 53 but the idea is just to show
you that you know you're changing these
things together if a company offers
multiple cloud services under a single
UI but do not meet most of or all of
these requirements it would just be
referred to as a cloud platform so when
you hear about twio or hashy Corp or
data bricks those are Cloud platforms
and adabs Azure gcp are cloud service
providers
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look here at
the landscape of cloud service providers
this is generally broken down into tier
one tier 2 tier three but I've modified
it to give each tier its own name as I
don't like to think of them as rankings
and more so that uh these cloud service
providers are specialized for a
particular thing um and I've also added
a fourth tier because you know the
internet has always talked about three
tiers but there really is a fourth tier
and I wanted to make sure we had uh the
full scope here included so in the top
tier you're going to recognize uh some
common names there Amazon web service
Microsoft Azure Google Cloud platform
and Alibaba cloud in North America and
Europe uh adab us Azure and gcp are
known as The Big Three um but Alibaba
cloud is huge as well if you're in the
Asia region specifically China so it's
really just going to be dependent on
where you live where uh which are
considered the most um commonly known or
popular uh but we'll talk about that
here in a moment but the reason um I
call tier one top tier is that these are
you know very well-known providers
they're ear early to Market they have
strong synergies between their services
um they're just really good cloud
service providers you cannot go wrong
with uh these providers then we have our
tier two or I would call our mid-tier uh
these are backed by really well-known
tech companies but I would just say that
um their ability to become top tier uh
did not work out the way they planned so
IBM at one point was looking to be a top
tier provider um but they just did not
keep up with um AWS and they just
slipped into this mid- tier and kind of
specialized at least for a while into ml
AI services and now they're just more
like very expensive um Enterprise U
managed
infrastructure for their existing
clientele Oracle um very very
inexpensive that's their play they try
to uh be the cheapest but their uh
service um overall is not uh fun to use
interestingly enough I believe Microsoft
Azure was just signing a contract to use
Oracle Cloud so it's not unusual for
some of these cloud service providers or
these organizations to use other
providers because they want to use their
Global infrastructure but uh yeah Oracle
cloud is uh not doing that great there
are other ones in the Asia region like
uh Hawaii cloud and tensent Cloud I
honestly don't know a whole lot about
them but they do show up on the magic
quadrant so it's possible the Asia
region that these are the big three and
uh AWS Azure and gcp do not play a
larger role but from our perspective I
put them into that mid tier because they
just don't have Global uh awareness or
Global um market dominance like the
other three uh up there looking at the
light tier uh these were traditionally
virtual private servers so they just
specialized in that and they turn to
offer more core infrastructure service
offerings so we we have a vulture I
always thought it was pronounced Vol but
it's actually vulture digital ocean and
aimi connected Cloud which was formerly
known as Leno or Leno um so they merg
their companies together and I mean they
want to be like a cloud service
providers but they're very very light in
terms of their offering so um you know
they'll have things like serverless and
being able to run a kubernetes cluster
and some cloud storage and stuff but
they won't have things like uh the the
same level of event
driven metered billing or or other kinds
of functional that you you come to
expect in the top tiers but you know if
you're working with a smaller
organization they are a lot simpler to
uh to utilize so they are a great
introduction to Cloud for companies that
find the top tier uh too complex and
then looking at the fourth tier I call
this the private tier this is uh
basically software that you can deploy
onto your own uh machines in your data
centers to get the same kind of um
functionality that you would if you were
using let's say adabs or any of these
other providers and um you know
previously I would put open stack into
the mid tier because in a sense that it
was kind of like a cloud service
provider that was using uh quite a bit
but I didn't feel like it had had good
fit there so that's why we made this a
fourth tier and we have a few different
softwares we have open stack Apache
Cloud stack those are both open source
and there's VMware vpar I have an aster
there because it's not really the same
thing but it is used a lot everywhere to
manage a lot of virtual machines and so
I I kind of feel like it should fit in
there but that gives you kind of an idea
of the landscape of cloud and we'll see
you in the next
[Music]
one so how do we determine who is the
leader in Cloud well one way of
indicating that is the gardener magic
quadrant for cloud so the magic quadrant
is a series of market research reports
published by the IT consulting firm
Garder that rely on proprietary
qualitative qualitative data analysis
methods to demonstrate market trends
such as Direction maturity and
participants so it says a series of
reports uh but the only thing I've ever
seen are these Graphics where they show
um a uh the quadrant it's a it's a
diagram that summarizes all the
information so I think you have to you
might have to pay to access uh the
reports um because it's definitely not
just uh publicly accessible knowledge
and I don't think they would show all of
uh how this stuff is calculated but uh
let's just take a look at this graphic
here so notice we have challengers in
the top left corner leaders in the top
right corner in the bottom left corner
we have Niche players and then in the
bottom right corner we have Visionaries
so the idea here is that The Closer you
are to this top Corner uh the better you
are doing and the one that is closest to
it is Amazon web services followed with
Microsoft pretty close uh in second
Google to the left Alibaba cloud X
Oracle and then we have IBM 10cent and
Hawaii and there are other players but
they are so small that they are not
showing up there and we showed that in
the landscape of csps or um maybe this
is only for first they consider what uh
we call First tier or top tier cloud
service providers it's really useful to
look at last year's uh mq and to see how
things have moved so it looks like uh it
uh Microsoft has shifted a little bit
forward here and gone a little bit
closer to AWS Google has significally
moved up and um Alibaba Cloud it seems
to be moving more uh to the right um and
again I'm just showing what their
movements were from this year to that
year so they are over here now Oracle is
way over here now and for whatever
reason Huawei cloud is on the board so
it's interesting to see how they move
another thing that's um interesting here
is that this one is 2022 of June and
this one is July of 2021 and right now
as the time I'm recording this video
it's 2023 near the end of the year um
and I could not find a 2023 one so even
if it says June or July they will
release these out in October November
Etc way later in the year and so for
whatever reason they have yet to make um
the latest one available so I'm still
curious to see what that is here so I'm
just giving you the information that we
have but you can look at this stuff um
basically on the The Gardener website if
you want to see um any of these magic
quadrants for any of the industries
there and what I find is is that if uh
companies doing really well they'll
always post it on their website so it's
very easy to find the uh Magic quadrant
for cloud on the ads website because
they're the leader so they definitely
want to show that there U but yeah there
you
[Music]
go so a cloud service provider can have
hundreds of cloud services that are
grouped into various types of services
but the four most common types of cloud
services for infrastructures of service
uh and I call these the four core would
be compute so imagine having a virtual
computer that can run applications
programs and code networking so imagine
having virtual Network defining internet
connections or network isolation between
services or outbound to the internet
storage so imagine having a virtual hard
drive that can store files databases so
imagine a virtual database for storing
reporting data or a database for general
purpose web applications and uh AWS in
particular has 200 plus cloud services
and I want to clarify what cloud
computing means because notice that we
have cloud computing Cloud networking
cloud storage Cloud databases but the
industry often just says cloud computing
to refer to all categories even though
uh it has computer in the name so just
understand when someone says cloud
computing uh they don't just generally
mean the subcategory they're talking
about all of cloud
[Music]
okay so adus has a lot of different
cloud services and I just want to kind
of go quickly over the types of
categories that we can encounter here
and just mention the four core so any
CSP that has IAS will always have these
four core service offerings we have
computes so Nat this would be ec2 VMS
storage this could be something like EBS
virtual hard drives database so that
could be RDS SQL databases networking
and content delivery but really it's
networking uh and this would be VPC so
private Cloud Network okay so uh let's
just look at all the categories that are
outside the four core so there could be
analytics application integration arvr a
cost management blockchain business
application containers customer
engagement developer tools and user
Computing game Tech iot Machine learning
management and governance Media Services
migration uh and transfer most mobile
Quantum Technologies robotics satellites
security identity and compliance if
there was more I would not be surprised
but you can see there's a lot of stuff
that's going on
here so let's take a look at all the
itaba services that are available to us
so if you're on the marketing website
which is adab.
amazon.com what you'll see in the top
left corner is products and so these are
all the categories and for whatever we
want if it's like ec2 we can go into
here and we can read all about it so
usually we'll have our overview all
right and that's not very useful and
then we'll go over to features and so
this is can be kind of useful to get
some basic information and pricing which
is something you'll do a lot in adabs is
you're always going to be going to a
service looking up its price and so
you'll make your way over uh here every
single one is different a very important
page would be like getting started so
this will give you basic information but
what I do is I like to go all the way
down to the bottom here and find my way
over to the documentation so I'll go
here to documentation to get that deeper
knowledge about that service and as you
can see things get pretty deep with AWS
in terms of the information they have so
hopefully that gives you an idea of the
scope also when you're logged into
databus and this will be when we create
our account uh you can explore all the
services this way as well so these are
all the adus services uh but you just
notice that there's two ways to uh
explore them where this is actually you
just actually utilizing the services is
and then the marketing website is you
reading about them and learning all
about them
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the evolution
of computing your cloud service provider
has all of these offerings and the idea
is that you need to choose the one that
meets your use case a lot of times this
all has to come around the utilization
of space that's what we're trying to
illustrate here in this section here and
the trade-offs of why you might want to
use some of these offerings okay for
dedicated we're talking about a uh a
physically uh a physical server wholly
utilized by single customer that's
considered single tenant and uh for
Google Cloud we're talking about um
single node clusters and bare metal
machines where you have control of the
virtualization so you can install any
kind of hypervisor or virtualization you
want in the system the trade-off here
though is that you have to guess upfront
what your capacity is going to be and
you're never going to 100% utilize that
machine cuz it's going to have to be a
bit under in case the utilization goes
up that's you're choosing the CPUs and
the memories you're going to end up
overpaying because you're uh you'll have
under underutilized server uh it's not
going to be easy to vertically scale
it's not like you can just say resize it
because the machine you have is what you
have right you can't add more I mean I
suppose they can insert more memory for
you but that's a manual migration uh so
it's very difficult um and replacing the
server is also very difficult okay so
you're limited by the host operating
system it's not virtualized so whatever
is on there is is on there um and that's
what your apps are going to have access
to uh if you decide to run more than one
app which is not a good practice for
these kind of machines uh you're going
to end up with a resource sharing where
one machine might utilize more than the
others technically with a dedicated
machine you have a guarantee of security
privacy and full utility of the
underlying resources I put an aster
there because yes it's more secure but
uh but it's up to you to make sure that
it's more secure so you have that's up
to your skills of security right whereas
if you had a virtual machine or anything
above that there's more responsibility
on the cloud service provider to just
provide a secure machine and they can do
a better job than you so why would you
use a dedicated machine well maybe
you're doing high performance Computing
where you need these machines like very
close together and you have to choose
what kind of virtualization you need to
have okay so then we're looking at
virtual machines the idea here is you
can run a machine within a machine the
way that works is we have a hypervisor
this is a software layer that lets you
run the virtual machine
uh the idea here is now it's
multi-tenant you can share the cost with
multiple customers you're paying for a
fraction of the server uh you'll still
end up overpaying for the underutilized
virtual machine because a virtual
machine is just like you have to still
say how many V vcpus how much memory and
your app is you know you don't want an
app that uses 100% right you want to use
exactly the amount you need but you can
see here you know there's still going to
be some
underutilization uh you limited by the
guest operating system now but now it's
virtualized so at least it's very easy
to uh possibly migrate away if you
choose to run uh more than one app on a
virtual machine it it can still run into
resource sharing conflicts uh it's
easier to export or import images for
migration it's easier to vertically or
horizontally scale okay and virtual
machines are the most common and popular
offering for compute because people are
just very comfortable with those then
you have containers and the idea is you
have a virtual machine running these
things called containers the way they do
that is similar to a hypervisor but in
instead you have um like here is a
Docker demon so it's just a um a
container software layer okay to run
those containers there's different kinds
Docker is the most popular uh and the
great thing is you can maximize the uh
the the capacity because you can easily
add new containers resize those
containers use up the rest of the space
it's a lot more flexible okay uh your
containers will share the same
underlying OS but they are more
efficient than multiple VMS uh multiple
apps can run Side by without being
limited uh by the same OS requirements
and not cause conflicts during resource
sharing so containers are really good
but you know the tradeoff is there a lot
more work to maintain then you have
functions functions go even step further
and the idea is that you uh the the
containers where we where we talked
about that's a lot of work to maintain
now the cloud service provider is taking
care of those containers generally
sometimes not it depends if it's servers
or not but the idea is that you don't
even think about and this is called
servess compute but you don't even think
about uh the OS or anything you just
know that what your runtime is you run
Ruby or python or node and you just
upload your code and you just say uh I
want this to be able to run uh uh for
this long uh and use this amount of
memory okay you're only responsible for
your code and data nothing else it's
very cost effective you only pay for the
time the code is running uh and VMS only
run when there is code to be executed
but because of that there is this
concept of cold starts and this is uh
where the virtual machine has to spin up
and so sometimes requests can be a bit
slow so there's a bit of trade-off there
but functions or serverless compute is
generally one of the best offerings as
of today but most people are still
getting kind of comfortable with that
Paradigm
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the
types of cloud computing and the best
way to represent this is a stacked
pyramid and we'll start our way at the
top with SAS also known as software as a
service so this is a product that is run
and managed by the cloud service
provider you don't have to worry about
how the service is maintained it just
works and remains available so examples
of this and actually uh the first uh
company to coin this was actually
Salesforce um then there's things like
Gmail Office 365 so think Microsoft Word
Excel things like that and they run the
cloud okay and SAS is generally designed
for customers in mind then came along
platforms of service um also known as
and these focus on the development or
sorry the deployment and management of
your apps so you don't worry about
provisioning configuring or
understanding the hardware or operating
system and so here we' have things like
elastic beant stock Heroku which is very
popular among developers that just want
to launch their code or Google app
engine and that is the old logo but
that's the logo I like to use because I
think it looks cool and so these are
intended for developers the idea is that
you just deploy your code um and the
platform does the rest then there is
infrastructure as a service um there's
no way to say that like it's easy to say
SAS or pass but there's no easy way to
say IAS so this is the basic building
blocks for cloud it it provides access
to networking features computers and
data storage space and the idea here is
you don't worry about the IT staff data
centers and hardware and so that would
be like Microsoft Azure AWS Oracle Cloud
things like that and these are for admin
Traders okay so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at cloud
computing deployment models starting
with public cloud and the idea here is
that everything when I say everything
I'm talking about the workloads the
projects the code is built on the cloud
service provider so here is a diagram
where we have a ec2 instance a virtual
machine running her application and then
we have our database in RDS
and we have the internet coming into our
adus account and so everything is
contained all of our infrastructure is
within AWS all right uh and so this is
known as being Cloud native or Cloud
first and I put an aster beside Cloud
native because that was a term uh that
was uh used prior to Cloud Serv
providers to refer to Containers or
open- Source um uh models being deployed
and being mobile other places so just
understand that it has two meanings but
uh in the context of this cloud of just
being like native to the cloud like
using Cloud to begin with okay then we
have private Cloud so everything built
on a company's data center uh and being
built on a data center is known as being
on premise because that is where the
data center resides near where you work
and so here you could be using Cloud but
you'd be using openstack which would be
a private Cloud so here we have our on
premise Data Center and uh the
internet's coming into our data center
and we're running on open stack where we
can launch virtual machines and a
database
okay then there's the concept of a
hybrid Cloud so using both on premise
and a cloud service provider together
and so the idea here is we have our on
premise Data Center and then we have an
established connection maybe it's a VPN
connection maybe it is a direct
connection um but the idea is that we're
bridging that connection and uh
utilizing both our private and our
public uh stuff to uh create a cloud
workload then there is a fourth one
called cross Cloud um sometimes it's
known as multicloud and sometimes it's
erroneously referred to as hybrid Cloud
but it generally is not uh hybrid Cloud
okay the idea here is when you're using
multiple Cloud providers and so one
example here could be using services
like Azure Arc so Azure Arc allows you
to extend your um control plane uh so
that you can deploy containers for
kubernetes in um Azure within Amazon eks
Within gcp
n's engine but you know being cross
Cloud doesn't necessarily mean that
you're running a using a service that
use Works across the cloud and manages
it it could just mean using multiple
providers at the same time another
service that is similar to Azure Arch
but is for Google Cloud uh platform is
also known as anthos um adab us has
traditionally not been um cross Cloud uh
friendly and so we haven't seen any kind
of developments there where we see these
other services that are or CL Prov
behind AWS trying to promote it to uh
grab more of the market share
[Music]
okay so let's talk about the different
deployment models and what kind of
companies or organizations are still
utilizing uh for these particular
categories so for cloud again this is
where we're Fally utilizing cloud
computing hybrid is a combination of
public cloud and on Prem or private
cloud and then on Prem is deploying
resources on premise using
virtualization resource management tools
sometimes called private cloud or could
be utilizing something like open stack
so for companies that are starting out
today or are small enough to make the
leap from virtual private server to a
cloud service provider this is where
we're looking at Cloud so we're looking
at startups SAS offerings new projects
and companies um so maybe this would be
like base camp Dropbox Squarespace then
for hybrid these are organizations that
started with their own data center but
can't fully move to Cloud due to the
effort or migration or security
compliance so we're talking about Banks
fintech investment management large
professional service providers Legacy on
Prem so maybe CIBC which is a bank deoe
uh the CCP or CPP investment board and
then for on premise these are
organizations that cannot run on cloud
due to strict Regulatory Compliance or
the sheer size of the organization or
they just have like an outdated uh idea
of what cloud is so they just have a lot
of uh difficulties in terms of politics
adopting Cloud um so this would be
public sector like government super sens
of data like hospitals large Enterprise
with heavy regulation insurance
companies um so again hospitals maybe
AIG the government of Canada and so I
shouldn't say that they aren't using
Cloud but um you know because uh adabs
and all the cloud service providers have
um uh public sector offering so um you
know I'm just trying to Stage as an
example of things that could be still
using on premise so you know I know the
government of Canada definitely uses uh
cloud in a lot of ways same with AIG and
hospitals but you know generally these
are the the last holdouts of on Prem
because there really isn't a a good
reason to be fully on premise anymore uh
but again there are some things that are
still doing that
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are at the start of our
journey creating ourselves an adus
account so what you need to do is go to
ads. amazon.com if you don't have a lot
of confidence how to get there just type
in adabs into Google and then click here
on the L link where it says adus
amazon.com it'll take you to the same
place now notice we have a big orange
button in the top right corner so this
says sign into the adus console um it's
the if it's the first time you've ever
been to this website so if I go to adab.
amazon.com Incognito it will have the
create an Abus Account button um I don't
know why they don't keep this consistent
across the board but I wish they did but
if you are on the screen you can click
here or there um but if you do see
something that doesn't say uh you know
create an account account or or Etc you
can just sign
in okay and then down below you can hit
create a new a account so that's the way
you're going to get in there and so
you're going to put an email a password
and create an adist account name um I've
created this so many times and it's so
hard to set up new emails I'm not going
to do this again it's not complicated
but one thing I need to tell you is that
you do need to have a credit card you
cannot create an account without a
credit card um and for those who are in
places where maybe you don't have a
traditional credit card card maybe you
can get a prepaid one so up here in
Canada we have a company called coo and
so coo is um a Visa debit card and so
it's basically a virtual prepaid credit
card and so these do work on the
platform as well so if you have a
traditional credit card or possibly
could find one of these uh you still
have to load up with money but it does
give you a bit more flexibility to
create that account so what I want you
to do is go through that process
yourself it's not complicated and I'll
see you on the other end
okay
so once you finished creating your
account you should be within the adus
Management console and this is the page
you're always going to see when you log
in it's always going to show the most
recent Services here um and you'll
notice in the top right corner that I
have my account called exam Pro if
you're wondering how do you change that
name what you do is to go to my accounts
here and once there you'll have your
account settings up here if you go to
edit uh you can change that name here
okay so you know sometimes when you
create your account you don't like the
account name that you gave it and so
that's your opportunity to fix it um but
once we're in our account what I want
you to do is immediately log out because
I want you to get familiar with the way
you log into AWS because it is a bit um
different than other providers and so I
don't want you to uh get hung up later
on with your account so I've logged out
I'm going to go ahead and log back in so
you can click the orange button or what
I like to do is drop down my account and
go to itus Management console
it's a lot more clear and you notice
we're going to have two options root
user and I am user so this is what I'm
talking about for the confusion so when
you log into your root user account you
all are always using an email and when
you're logging as an IM user you're
actually going to be entering the
account ID or account Alias but what
we'll do is go to the root user and this
is the email you use to sign up with the
account so for me uh I called this one
Andrew plus sandbox exampro . Co I'm
going to go to next sometimes you get
this character box it's very annoying
but it happens time to time and so what
I'm going to do is just go ahead and
type that in
okay and hopefully it likes it and then
I'm just going to enter in my
password all right and I'll be back into
my account and so notice it takes me
back to ABS Management console so the
root account is not something we want to
be generally using uh except for um very
particular use cases and we do cover
that in the course uh but what I want
you to do is go set yourself up with a
proper account and so what we'll do is
go to the top here and type in am and
this stands for identity and access
management and we'll click on am
here and on the left hand side we're
going to see a bunch of options here um
and so notice right away we get to the I
IM dashboard where it's going to start
to make some recommendations for us the
first one is always to add MFA
multiactor
authentication another thing you can do
is set an account account Alias so you
can see that I've set one here prior so
if I just go ahead and remove it the way
we'd have to log in is via the account
Alias uh which is the same as the
account ID and so I don't really like
that so I'm going to just rename it to
Deep Space 9 and uh these are unique so
you have to pick something that is
unique to you so it could be your
company name or things like that it's
going to make it a lot easier to log in
uh when we create our additional user
here so we'll come back to MFA at some
point here what I want you to do is go
over to users and go ahead and make
yourself a new user and so I'm going to
call this one Andrew
Brown and I'm going to enable
programmatic access I'm going to enable
ads Management console so this one's
going to allow me to use the apis to
programmatically work with ads and this
one here is going to allow me to just
log into the console which is uh pretty
fair here so now that I have this we can
autogenerate or give it a custom
password I'm just going to autogenerate
for the time being and here it says You
must create a new password at the next
sign in which sounds fair to me and we
go ahead and create ourselves a new
group so it's pretty common to create a
group called admin and notice here this
is where we're going to have a bunch of
different policies so the first one here
which is admin and access provides full
access to a services and resources and
this pretty much gives you almost nearly
almost the same capabilities as the um
AWS root user account uh and so that's
going to be okay because we are an admin
in our account so I'll checkbox that on
but I just want to show you here if you
drop down filter policies and you went
to adus manage job functions these are a
bunch of uh pre-made uh adus uh policies
that you could apply uh to different
users so what's really popular after the
administrator access is to usually give
the power user access and so this one
allows um a user to do basically
anything they want with the exception of
management of users and groups so you
know it could be that that's something
that you'd want to do for some of your
users I just don't want to have any
trouble so I'm going to give us um admin
access here and we're going to go ahead
and create this
group and so here is the group that we
are creating we're going to go next we
can apply our tags if we want I'm not
going to bother we're going hit next
review and then hit create
user all right and so now what it's
doing is it's showing us the access ID
and the access uh key secret that we can
use to programmatically access AWS and
then there's a password here so I'm
going to go ahead and show it and what
I'm going to do is just copy this into a
clipboard
anywhere
and so I'm just copying that off screen
here because I'm going to need it to log
in and I'm just going to remember my
username as well all right and so what
we'll do is go ahead and hit
close so what I'll do is go back to my
dashboard here and remember I set my
account Alias as Deep Space 9 but we
could also use the account ID to log in
I'm just going to grab my account ID off
screen here and what I want to do now is
go ahead and log out and now log into
this I user and this is the one that you
should always be using within your 's
account you shouldn't be using your root
user account so what I'll do is go over
to I am user here and notice now that it
says account ID so 12 digits or the
account Alias so here I can enter in uh
these numbers here or I can enter in my
Alias which is Deep Space 9 and again
you'll have to come up with your own
creative uh one there for yourself and
we'll go ahead and hit next and so
notice what it's going to do is now ask
me what my IM username is so I Define
mine as Andrew Brown and then uh we had
an autogenerated a password there so
that we had saw and so I'm going to
place that in there we'll go ahead and
hit sign in and so now right away it's
going to ask me to reset the password so
I'm going to put the old password in
there and so now I need a new password I
strongly recommend that you generate out
uh your passwords to be very strong I
like to go to password generator and
I'll drop this down and I'll do
something really long like 48 characters
and um if you don't like weird
characters you can take those out there
sometimes it loads here so you got to
try it twice um and I'm going to go down
to whoops
48 there we go and so that's pretty darn
long so I'm going to copy that off
screen here so I do not
forget and you probably would want to
put this in a password manager something
like Dashlane or some sort of thing like
that and we'll go ahead and we will
paste that in and we'll see whoops I
don't want uh Google to save it uh and
we'll see if it takes it and so there we
go so what I'll do is now log out and
I'll make sure my new password works
because you really don't want to have
problems later so we'll type in Deep
Space 9 Andrew Brown again this is going
to be based on what your uh what you
have set and we'll go ahead and log in
and there I am and so now notice there
doesn't say um exam Pro or whatever it
says Andrew Brown at Deep Space 9 so
it's using the county alias and showing
the name and that's how I'm going to
know whether I'm the root account user
or whether I'm logged in as an I am user
all right so there we
[Music]
go okay so now that we have the proper
user account to log in I just want to
point out uh about regions so in the top
right corner you'll notice it says North
Virginia here it possibly will say
something completely else for you but
what you'll do is you'll click and drop
that down and you you'll see a big list
of regions and so sometimes when I log
in ads it likes to default me to U East
uh Us East Ohio but I honestly like to
launch all my stuff in Us East North
Virginia even though I'm in Canada I
probably should be using the Canada
central region down here um but the
default region is going to be based on
your locality okay so just understand
that it might be different I strongly
recommend for um all of our follow
alongs you run in Us East one because Us
East one is the original
um the original region and it also has
the most access to Ada services and some
Ada Services um such as like billing and
and cost and things like that are only
going to show up in Us East uh North
Virginia so just to make our lives a lot
easier we're going to set it there but I
want you to understand that some
services are Global Services meaning
that it doesn't matter what region
you're in it's going to default to
Global and one example could be
cloudfront so if I jump over to
cloudfront here for a moment
and uh we do seem to have uh some CLR
distributions here from a prior uh
follow along but notice up here that it
now says Global so CLR does not require
a region selection let's make our way
over to
S3 all right and this one's also Global
so again this one does not require a
region selection but if you go over to
something like
ec2 okay this has a a region dependency
so just be really careful about that
because a lot of times you'll be doing a
follow along and you'll be like why
aren't these resources here or whatever
and it's because this got switched on
you and it can happen at any time so
just be uh cautious or aware of that
[Music]
okay so one of the major advantages of
using ads or any cloud service provider
is that it utilizes metered billing so
that is different from a fixed cost
where you'd say Okay I want a server for
x amount of dollars every month but the
way us works is that it's going to bill
you on the hour on the second based on a
bunch of factors and so you're going to
be able to get services at a lower cost
however if you choose an expensive
service and you forget about it or
there's misconfiguration where you
thought you were launching something
that was cost effective but turned out
to be very expensive you could end up
with a very large Bill very very quickly
and so uh that is a major concern for a
lot of people utilizing Cloud but
there's a lot of great toolings built
into adabs to allow you to catch
yourself if you happen to make that
mistake and before we go ahead and learn
how to do that I want to show you uh
some place where you could end up having
excessive spend without knowing it so
one example and this is actually
happened to me when I first started
using AWS uh before I even knew about
all the billing tools is I wanted to
launch a reddis instance and so you you
just have to watch you don't have to do
this but um elasticache is a service
that allow you to launch either a mcash
or reddis uh database and I just wanted
to store a single value and so I went
here and I scrolled down it looked all
good and I hit create but I wasn't
paying attention because apparently itus
likes to default the no type here to the
cash
r6g dolar all right and you know you
might think that Abus has your best
interest in play and most services are
pretty good they they make sure that
they're either free or very low spend
but some of these and elastic cash is an
older service where they just have these
weird defaults so um you know if we were
to go look up this the
RG6 uh
large all right and look at it
spend all right and we would go over
here whoops I think I went to the China
One but if we were to go over here and
look for that instance I'm just trying
to find it here for cost this
one down below
um this doesn't say pricing does it say
our pricing
here here it is so this one cost
um this one costs about 2 cents per hour
it doesn't sound like a lot but if we go
here and we do the math we say 730 730
is the amount of hours in a month that
is
$150 okay so if you don't know about
that and forget about that that's going
to be $150 and I'm going to tell you
that it used to be a lot higher I'm
pretty sure they used to have it
defaulted to something like
like this or that because I remember I
did this and I had a bill that came in
that was like $3,000 USD and I'm in
Canada so like $3,000 USD is like a
million dollars up here and so I
remember um it was a big concern and I
freaked out but that was okay because
all I had to do was go to support and
what I had done is I went to the support
center and I had opened a support case
and I just said hey I had this really
big bill so you go here right and you
look for billing and uh you look for
something like charging query or
misspend and you say you know um you
know like help my bill's too
high and you just say like you explain
the problem saying hey you know I was
using elastic cash and it was set to a
large default and I wasn't aware about
it can you please give me back the money
and the great thing is that ads is going
to to give you a free pass if it's your
first time where you've had a
misspending they generally will say Okay
um you know don't do it again and if it
happens again you will get build but go
ahead and learn how to set up building
alerts or things like that okay so just
so you know don't freak out if you do
have a really high Bill you're going to
get a single free pass but now that we
know that let's go learn uh how to set
up a budget
[Music]
okay all right so now that we've had a
bit of a story about um over spend for
misconfiguration let's learn how to
protect ourselves against it and we're
going to go ahead and set up a budget so
go to the top here and type in budget
and what that will do is bring us over
to the billing dashboard another way to
get here is to go click at the top here
and go to my billing dashboard and then
you'll see the leftand menu here and so
the great thing about budgets is that
the first two are free it says there is
no additional charge for any those
budgets you pay for configured us us
Mage but I'm pretty sure that that's not
true because it used to be ABS budget
reports okay so that cost
something it used to be that Abus
budgets um after success enabled will Ur
10 cents daily so in addition to budget
monitor you can add actions to your
budgets the first two action enable
budgets are free okay so just be aware
that just because it says there's no
additional charge read into it because
sometimes the the Fine Line will tell
you it does something but I know that
the first two are free what we'll do is
go ahead and create a budget just going
to close these other tabs here since we
have no need for them and we're going to
be presented with a bunch of budget
types uh we're considered about cost
today so we're going to go with a cost
budget and notice we can change the
period from monthly to daily to
quarterly to annually if you change it
to daily um you won't get forecasting so
I don't want that today but a monthly is
pretty good you can have a reoccurring
which is strongly recommended and then
you can put a fixed cost notice that I
already have some spend on this account
so it was like 25 bucks last month I'm
going to set my uh budget here to
$100 and you can add filters here to um
uh filter that cost out so if you want
to say only for this region or things
like that you could do that uh notice
that this is my spend over here um so
this is my budget and that's the actual
cost notice my cost has been going up
the last few months because I've been
doing things with this account and so
what I'll do is say simple budget here
we'll hit next
and so now it's asking us if we want to
configure alerts we probably do so you'd
hit ADD alert and then you'd set a
threshold like 80% or you could say an
absolute value and then You' put in your
emails like Andrew exampro
doco and I want to point out that this
is using um itus
SNS or it should be anyway so Amazon SNS
has no upfront cost based on your stuff
here so even though you're filling out
an email you know and maybe it doesn't
show it but I'm pretty sure that this
would create an
SNS topic but what we'll do is hit next
here we have an alert so we're just uh
reviewing actually this is for attaching
any action so maybe we want some kind of
follow-up thing to happen here so we say
add
action and uh requires specific I in
permissions on your
behalf okay sure so I guess you could
follow up actions that's no different
than um a building alarm but we're not
really worried about that right now now
I'm not going to bother with an action
and we'll go ahead and create a
budget and so here it's going to say
that our budget is $100 it's going to
show us the amount used forecast amount
current budget sometimes this takes time
to uh show up so I'm going to hit
refresh and see if it shows up
yet there we go so notice we have
forecast amount $23 current budget Etc
forecasted budget uh forecasted versus
budget so it's pretty straightforward on
how that works um I'm just curious if it
actually created an SNS event so I'm
going to go over here because a lot of
services utilize SNS so if I go over
here default Cloud watch alarm um so I
think this is something I had created
before so I'm going to go ahead and just
delete it says default Cloud watch
alarms I'm going to just click into here
and see what I
have
confirmed so I think it might have used
this when we created it but um the
reason I'm bringing up SNS is that
there's a lot of services that allow you
to uh email yourself for alerts and it
always integrates with this service and
so I just want kind of want to point
that out so that you remember what SNS
is for um but yeah so setting up a
budget is not too hard so there you
[Music]
go all right so now that we've set a
budget what I want to talk to you about
is the free tier and the free tier is
something that available to you uh for
the first 12 months of a new adus
account and allows you to utilize adus
services without incurring any cost to
you and so it's in your advantage to
utilize this free tier um as you are
experimenting and learning cloud so if
you want to learn about all the
offerings what you do is go to Google
type in adus free tier and you'll get
this page that explains all the sorts of
things here so you can get uh 750 hours
on ec2 RDS things like that there are
stipulations in terms of what it would
be so here this is a T2 or T3 micel mic
uh micro running Linux Red Hat um or
other type of os's okay so there are uh
details you have to read the fine print
some services are only available for the
first two months things like that so
it's going to highly vary based on
service but it's worth giving this a
read in areas that you are interested in
now the thing is is how do you know that
you are still in the free tier or you go
outside of it and that's what I want to
talk to you about right now so I am
actually in another adist account so
notice in the top right corner it says
brown. laap or hyphen laptop exampro
doco sometimes I will switch into
different AIS accounts during these
follow alongs so I can best show you um
you know the settings so if you make
your way over to
billing and actually I should show you
up here if we go to my dealing B
dashboard just trying to be consistent
here and you go to the left- hand side
to billing preferences what you can do
is enable receive free tier usage alerts
and then put your email in there and
save that and so turn on this feature to
receive email alerts when your adus
service usage is approaching or deleted
data was free tier usage limits if you
wish to receive these alerts etc etc etc
right and while you're there I want you
to also checkbox receive billing alerts
so I can show you how to set a bing uh a
billing alert and ITA says you know
budgets are a new thing but billing
alerts are still something that we use
as of today so if you checkbox that on
we'll be able to see your cost if we go
back here uh it should show you um it's
because I'm out of the free tier on this
account but but it would show you in the
alerts you know your usage there so
example here is if we scroll down this
is the documentation tracking your a
free tier usage you would see like a box
like this and would say hey your free
tier usage limit is here and you're over
it okay so that generally would show up
on this panel here but again I'm outside
of the free tier so I'm not seeing it
here um today
okay so you know hopefully that is clear
um but yeah there you go
[Music]
all right so we created ourselves a
budget we're monitoring our free tier
but there's another way that we can
monitor our spend and that is through
building alerts or alarms and it is the
old way before uh we had abis budgets
this was the only way you could do it
but I still recommend it because there
is a bit more flexibility here with this
service and so I wanted to teach you
early on so that you know it's available
to you or if you want to play around
with it in the future so what you'll do
is go to the top here and type in
cloudwatch and cloudwatch is one of
those Services where it's actually a
collection of services so there's
cloudwatch alarms cloudwatch logs
cloudwatch metrics those are all
Individual Services and aabus loves to
update their interface so sometimes
you'll be presented with this option to
uh change the latest interface I'm going
to try out the new interface here um and
that is one challenge with datab is you
always have to expect that they're going
to change the UI on you and you're going
have to work through it so just
understand that I try to keep my videos
up toate as best I can but part of the
challenge is getting used to that so
this is what they have today I don't
know if they're going to stick with this
but this is what it looks like but what
I want you to do is make your way over
to alarms on the left hand
side and notice that we actually have a
section just for billing which is
interesting I don't remember them having
that before so it's new so uh here it
says it was cloudwatch help can help you
monitor the charges of Bill remember
that we had to turn that on get 10 free
alarms with 1,000 free email
notifications each month as part of the
free tier so understand that if you
create billing LS they do cost money um
as well if you go over that limit but
you sure get a lot 10 free alarms is
quite a bit what we'll do is go ahead
here and create ourselves alarm we are
going to go and choose a metric and so
here are the options we could choose
from and so we I think would like um
billing and see we can do buy service or
total estimated charge we're going to do
a total estimated charge we can only
select USD I've never seen any other
currency ever there and so here we kind
of get this little graph where we can
see stuff um but this is a lot more
powerful than budgets because you can do
anomaly detection uh so like here it
will actually check base between a range
as opposed to just going through a
particular value but what I'll do is
just set a value here like uh $50 right
so notice that it sets the line up here
and this is my current spend here right
and so back to anomaly detection this is
a lot smarter so so uh the idea is that
if something is outside this band of a
certain amounts um then it would alert
okay but I'm going to go back here I'm
just going to set this to
$50 and that looks okay to me you can
change the period 6 hours is fine um and
there's additional configuration that's
fine as well we're going to go ahead and
hit next uh and so the idea is that um
you know if it passes that red line it
will go to an in alarm State and then
what it will do is uh we want to
uh have it to trigger an SNS topic so I
would generally just create a new one
here we'll just say my billing
alarm Okay and then here we'll just set
the email Andre exam
pro. and we'll go ahead and create that
topic and so that is now set I don't
know if it would uh confirm it we might
have to go to our email to confirm it so
notice it says pending confirmation so
what it has done is it sent me out an
email and it wants me to click that link
to confirm term um that I want to
subscribe to it so I might just do that
off screen to show you here
okay so I'm just going to pull up my
email here just give me a
moment okay and so if I come back here
this is the email that came in so I'm
just going to confirm that subscription
says I'm confirmed good and if I refresh
this page we can now see that that that
is confirmed all right so we'll scroll
down here so we can uh trigger an auto
scaling AC so maybe you know if you have
too many servers you say hey the cost is
too much shut down those servers there's
ec2 actions things like that so these
are kind of similar to um budgets right
there's system manager actions I imagine
all these things are available in
budgets as well but budgets just makes
it a little bit easier to look at so I'm
going just say my simple building alarm
here we'll hit
next all right we'll hit create alarm
and there you go so bilding alarms don't
have like four forecasting and things
like that um but you know they are they
do have their own kind of special
utility and so I utilize both okay so
there we go we'll just go back to our
Management console and move on to the
next
[Music]
one so one of the strongest
recommendations that adus gives you is
to say to set MFA on your adus root user
account so that's something we're going
to do right now so make sure you're
logged into the root user account so I'm
going to go log out as my IM user I'm
going to go back and log in and I'm
going to log in as my uh root user here
so to do that no sometimes it will be
expanded as the I am user click and sign
into root user here we'll have root user
I'm going to go ahead and enter my email
that I used and if you do switch
accounts frequently they will ask you
these silly captures which drive me
crazy but uh you know it happens you
probably won't encounter it as much as I
do and so I'm going to go ahead and grab
my password here and paste it on in
and so now that I'm in what I want to do
is make my way over to
am and I'm going to go and look for
users actually sorry just right here add
an MFA root user we're going to go ahead
and hit add
MFA all right and so that's going to
bring us to this screen and so here we
can activate our MFA and so we have a
few options here so we have virtual MFA
device u2f security key other Hardware
like a uh
J galto token so you know I generally
use this because I have a security key
and I want to show you what I'm talking
about so this is how I log into my
machine or my ad account this is a
security key an UB key that sits on my
desk I tape it so it doesn't fall fall
off the cord but the idea is that when I
log in I have to press this little
button here to double confirm before I
get into my account uh but if you don't
have a security key you can just use a
virtual MFA and all that means is you're
going to um use something on your phone
to log in so we'll click continue here
and so it says install a compatible app
on your mobile phone or device and so if
you click and open this what it will do
is tell you about some things that you
can use um so if we scroll down to
Virtual here they suggest uh if you have
Android iPhone so aie dual mobile last
path Microsoft authenticator Google
Authenticator so Google Authenticator
Microsoft authenticator and a here I
have all those three installed um
honestly aie has the the nicest simplest
um UI but I'm using Microsoft authentic
authenticator quite a bit so anyway
whichever you want to do it's fine but
what we'll have to do is go back here
and then it says use your virtual MFA
app on your device camera to scan your
QR code so once you have one of those
apps installed like aie or whatever one
you want what you're going to do is open
up the application and I can't tell you
exactly where it is but you'll have to
hit add account in your in your app and
then from there it will ask you to scan
your QR code and so uh once you're ready
you hit show The QR code you hit scan
the QR code on your phone I'm holding my
phone up to my my um uh my computer
screen here and it's going to find it
and I'm just going to take a moment here
to rename the account so I can tell what
it is so I'm just naming it a
WS sandbox because that's what I call
this account
and I'm going to go ahead and save that
and so now what I can do is enter uh two
consecutive MFA codes now this always
confuses me what they wanted here but
the idea is that you're going to see one
code right whatever is on the screen
right now so I'm going to type in it it
says
051 and I'm going to wait until the new
code shows up so there's like a timer in
all these apps and they go across the
screen or they countdown and so you have
to wait for that to happen and so I'm
just going to wait here a little bit
and once I get the new number here this
one is
07153 0 I'm going to hit assign MFA and
there we go and I can't tell you how
many times I like mess that up because I
didn't understand the consecutive
numbers but you're just waiting for uh
the number that's on the screen to
entered in and then enter the next one
in to turn on MFA and so now your
account is protected and every time you
log in you're going to have to enter in
MFA so let's log out and see what that
looks
like so we'll go ahead and sign
in and uh again we'll put in our root
user account here we'll type in 74m
32t
submit and I need to go grab my password
so that's in my password manager just
give me a moment
here and now it wants the MFA code so
this is in my phone and so I'm going to
go enter it in so this one says
841 all right we'll hit
submit okay and there we go so that's
going to happen every single time we
want to log in uh I'm going to tell you
that if you get one of these they're so
much easier to use because you just
press the button okay so that's why I
have this because I cannot stand
entering the code in time and time again
um but you know those are your options
there
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're looking at the concept of
innovation waves so when we're talking
about Innovation waves we're talking
about contracta or k waves which are
hypothesized cyclik phenomena in the
global World economy and the phenomenon
is closely connected with technology
life cycles so here is an example where
each wave is irreversibly changes the
society on a global scale and if you
look across the top we can kind of see
what they're talking about so we have
steam engine cotton uh rail way in steel
electric engineering chemistry petrol
chemicals automobiles information
technology and so the idea is that uh
Cloud technology is the latest wave and
I'm not sure if you'd fit web 3 in there
as well ml AI but maybe they're all part
of the same wave or they're separate
waves but generally they're broken up
based on this
prde here where it says perspective
recession depression and movement uh
Improvement sorry and so this is the
common pattern of wave we see a change
of supply and demand and so if we're
seeing this we know that we are in a
wave and where we are in a wave
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the concept of
a burning platform so burning platform
is a term used when a company abandons
old technology for new technology with
the uncertainty of success and can be
motivated by fear that the
organization's future surv uh survival
hinges on digital transformation and
just to kind of give you visualization
here is a Lal burning platform so
imagine you have to jump to it jump from
it to make a change so um you know
burning platform could be you know stop
using on-prem and start using cloud or
maybe it going from Cloud to web 3 um
and that's generally the idea when we
talk about a burning
[Music]
platform so I just want to quickly show
you that digital transformation
checklist that I mentioned and the way
you can get to it is by typing in
digital transformation AWS and so it
should bring you to the public sector
page and here it is so we click there
and all it is is a PDF uh so it's not
new it's from 2017 but that doesn't mean
that it's not uh valid anymore uh it's
just that that's when it was made so we
scroll on down and we can see
transforming vision and so we have a
checklist there so if we click into this
uh we can see things like communicate a
vision of what success looks like Define
a clear governance strategy including
the framework of achieving goals uh
build a cross functional team identify
Tech technical uh Partners they talk
about Shifting the culture and then down
below I assume that this one is related
to that one it's unusual because you
know they just have a checklist here but
then they have a sub checklist which
must be clear to that so reorganize
staff into smaller teams things like
that so it's not super complicated
you'll see each category go go Cloud
native they'll have a
checklist um you know and if you are at
at the executive level or the sales
level or trying to convince your VPS or
stuff like that give this a it might
give you something uh useful in the end
uh to help better communicate that
transformation for you
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the evolution
of computing power so what is computing
power it's the throughput measured at
which a computer complete computational
tasks and so uh what we're pretty much
used to right as of these days is
general computing so a good example here
would be a zeeon CPU processor that's
more of a high-end processor not
something you'd find your home computer
but when we're talking about data
centers specifically uh um you know
inabus data centers Zeon CPU processors
or what you're going to come across uh
then came along a new type of compute
which is GPU Computing um when we're
talking about Google uh Cloud they have
tensor Computing and so this is where I
get the 50 times faster based on that
metric and so I didn't have an exact
metric here for AWS uh um solution for
this mid-tier of computing power so I
just that 50 times there but the idea is
that GPU Computing or tensor Computing
uh is is 50 times faster than
traditional CPU and generally that's
going to be used for uh very specialized
tasks when you're doing machine learning
or AI so it's not something you're going
to uh be doing for your regular uh web
workloads but just understand that all
of these uh fits so we're not getting
rid of general computing we're just
adding uh new levels to compute then
there's the latest which is uh Quantum
computing and so here we have an example
of the
rig retti 16q Aspen 4 and so it
literally looks like it's out of um
science fiction and this thing is like a
100 million times faster it is super
Cutting Edge and we don't even know
exactly how it works and there's not
even anything that's very applicable
that we can use this for but the idea is
that we're not done with the evolution
of of computing power things are going
to get a lot faster once we solve this
last one here
and so ad service offering here would be
for general computing you're looking
elastic compute Cloud You2 so we have a
variety of different uh instance types
and they're all going to have different
types of Hardware with different types
of general computing um for GPU
Computing this is a specialized chip
that adus has produced called the adus
um and I don't know how to say it but
we'll just abbreviate it to infer so
adus infer chip um and this was designed
as a direct competitor to uh gcps uh
tensor computing uh unit the T TPU um
and so this is intended for AI ml
workloads but it works with not just um
tensor flow but it works with any
machine learning framework so that is
one advantage it has over uh tpus um and
then the last one here is adus bracket
so you can actually use quantum
Computing as a service on adus you uh as
of even today um the way adus is able to
do this is they work with Caltech so
that's the California
technology um University or Institute
I'm sure the name of it there um so it's
not exactly adus producing this but adus
is doing this as a partnership to give
Quantum Computing accessible to you
okay so I'm here in the Abus console
because I just want to prove to you that
you can use quantum Computing on AWS
it's that accessible so all you'd have
to do is go to the top here type in
bracket uh and then you make it over to
Amazon bracket and so here uh you can
like set up Quantum tasks the first time
you set it up you got to go through this
process here um and I think I have to go
through this onboarding to be able to
show you the next steps so I'm going to
go ahead and enable bracket in this Abus
account okay and I'm not going to launch
anything I'm just going to try just kind
of show you a little bit of what is
accessible to you because it's not super
exciting but the fact that you can do it
is kind of interesting so here I am on
the inside here and we have all these
different types of quantum Computing so
d-wave I know I I NQ
retti things like that and then down
below these are the quantum processing
units the qpu and then down below you
have the simulator so you can kind of
simulate uh these things here um so I
think that's kind of
interesting uh but in terms of the cost
like if you scroll on down here um so AB
bracket is part of the was free tier it
gives you one free hour of quantum
circuit simulation time per month during
the first 12 months so it's free to do
uh a circuit simulation
but if you actually want to run it on
the actual Hardware you can see the cost
there's the per task price the per shot
price things like that uh what could you
do with this I don't know there's things
called like quad bits or something like
that and I can't imagine that you're
going to be doing anything useful but I
think it's just more so like you are
sending out quad bits or whatever they
are and you're observing them um but
what you could do with them I have no
idea but it's just exciting that you can
do that I didn't have any spend just by
activating that I'm just kind of just
showing you there okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the benefits of
cloud and this is a summary of reasons
why an organization would uh consider
adopting or migrating to utilizing
public cloud and so we'll quickly go
through the list here uh because in the
followup slides we actually go into them
a bit more detailed so we have agility
page a go economy of scale Global reach
security reliability High availability
scalability um um and elasticity so the
thing is is that eight of us had this
before it was called the six advantages
of cloud but they have reworked it to
include additional items um and so where
you see these uh sub bullets here those
are the original six as you see 1 2 3 4
five six and so I kind of just put them
where they kind of uh fall under the new
categories there and you'll notice that
aist has included High availability
elasticity reliability and security as
uh new ones here okay
and so the thing is is that um I have
always always even in my original uh I
think in my original cloud practitioner
had Cloud architecture as a separate
section and included all these things in
here so it's a great thing to see that
abis has included it um but in terms of
how I organized this course we're not
going to cover them in this section
because I have the cloud architecture
section so just understand that we will
come to those eventually and I would
just say that adus is still missing
something on this list which is fault
tolerance so you know my list looks like
this except I would add fault tolerance
to it so you have everything there um
and Disaster Recovery okay so the
benefits of cloud is a reworking
expansion of the six advantages of the
cloud and we will look at the original
six advantages um and then look at
another one that is more of a
generalized one that I I've used across
my courses so that we fully understand
the benefits
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look here at
these six advantages to Cloud defined by
AWS and so these are still uh part of
aws's marketing Pages um but you know
it's interesting because you can't find
the benefits of the cloud in a single
page on any at least at the time of
making this so there's a bit of
Disconnect between the um exam guide and
the actual marketing material but that's
okay I fill it all in for you so you
know I'm just again noting that the six
advantage of cloud was the original
description for cloud benefits and we'll
go through them okay so the first is
trade Capital expense for variable
variable expense so you can pay on
demand meaning that there is no upfront
cost and you pay for only what you
consume or you pay by the hour minutes
or second so instead of paying for
upfront costs of data centers and
servers the next is benefit from uh
massive Eon uh uh economies of scale so
you are sharing the cost with other
customers to get unbeatable savings
hundreds of thousands of customers
utilizing a fraction of a server stop
guessing capacity so scale up or down to
meet the current needs launch and
Destroy Services whenever so instead of
of paying for idle or underutilized
servers we have increased Speed and
Agility so launch resources within a few
clicks and minutes instead of waiting
days or weeks of your it to implement
the solution on premise we have stopped
spending money on running and
maintaining data centers so focus on
your customers developing and
configuring applications so instead of
operations such as racking stacking and
powering servers the last is Go Global
in minutes so deploy your app in
multiple regions around the world with a
few clicks provide load latency and a
better experience for your customers at
minimal cost the six advantage of cloud
still apply and um I like to include
them here because they just have a
different kind of a lens or or or angle
when you're looking at this stuff and so
we've looked at the six advantages of
cloud and now let's take a look at the
next slide my reworking of the six
advantage of the cloud to be more
generalized
[Music]
okay all right I just wanted to show you
where that six advantages of cloud
computing comes from it's part of IIs
documentation so I typed it in here and
you can see that it is still around uh
and so it's unusual because this used to
be part of the marketing website it had
those nice little Graphics um but for
whatever reason it's over here now in
the overview of Amazon web services and
by the way if you're starting starting
out with ads this is a very light read
but it is a good read uh to get started
with we obviously cover all this stuff
in the course um but you know maybe
you'll get something different here but
the idea is that IUS has definitely
expanded on this but for whatever reason
this documentation hasn't changed so
just understand that I've polyfilled
that for you in this course
[Music]
okay all right so this is the seven
advantages to Cloud I said six but I
meant to say seven and so um you know
since I've created fundamental courses
for all the clouds providers I started
to notice kind of a trend and so what I
did is I normalized it into my own seven
advantages and this actually Maps up
really well to the new benefits of the
cloud so it looks like itus was thinking
the same as I was um with the exception
of those Cloud architect stuff which I
keep in a separate section but let's go
through it and see what is here so the
first is cost effective you pay for what
you consume no upfront cost on demand
pricing so pay as you go PA YG with
thousands of customers sharing the on uh
sharing the cost of resources adus used
to refer to this always as on demand
pricing and Azure always said pay as you
go and so it looks like adus now uses
both on demand and page you go to
describe them which is great um but
there you go then we have Global so
launch workloads anywhere in the world
just choose a region it's secure so
cloud provider takes care of physical
security cloud services can be secured
by default or you have the ability to
configure access down to a granular
level uh it's reliable so data backup
Disaster Recovery data replication fault
tolerance it's scalable increase or
decrease resources and services based on
demand uh elastic so automate scaling
during spikes and drop in demand current
so the underlying hardware and and
managed uh software is patched upgraded
and replaced by the cloud provider
without interruption to you so I think
this is one that isn't on the benefits
of the cloud which is a really good one
um but uh yeah that's the
[Music]
seven hey this is Angie Brown and we're
taking a look at adus Global
infrastructure so what is it well the
adus global infrastructure is a globally
distributed hardware and data centers
that are physically networked together
to act as one large resource for the end
customers so what does that mean well if
you look at the globe on the right hand
side and that Globe is really cool
because adab us used to have a website
where you could uh see a 3D uh globe and
see where all their resources are for
whatever reason they took it down but I
still have the screenshot of it but the
idea is that um the global
infrastructure represents all that
hardware and the connectivity between
that Hardware around the world so what
kind of resources are we talking about
we're talking about regions we're
talking about availability zones direct
connections uh pops also known as point
of presence local zones wavelength zones
uh and we should point out that Abus has
millions of active users uh or customers
and tens of thousands of Partners
globally so they really are uh kind of
everywhere um and if you're wondering
well what are all these resources that's
what we're going to get into next we're
going to break down uh what all these
particular resources are because you
definitely need to know what they are
but hopefully that gives you at a high
level that adus has this thing called
Global infrastructure
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and we are
on the marketing website for adabs under
Global infrastructure and this is a
great way if you want to explore more
and make sense of that Global
infrastructure so we scroll on down here
we have a nice map and it's kind of
indicating as to where those regions are
notice that there is uh ones in red
which are coming soon the Canada West
they've been talking about that for I
think a couple years now so still
waiting for those but you know just like
every CL provider they're always
expanding looks like we can get a full
list here um and it should indicate
where uh when they launched and if
they're launching more things so you
know that is a nice little list uh that
we can get access to but if we go all
the way to the top across the top we can
go to Regions and azs uh and this is
where we should get better information
this is definitely different from before
and I don't think the top of candidate
is supposed to look like that but uh I
guess it's the best that they can do so
uh what I want to point out on these
pages is uh the terms of uh the number
of resources so I'm just going to bump
up the font because it's a little bit
small even for me if we go on down below
here you can see that it's describing um
let's say a particular region so here in
Canada we can see uh we have three
availability zones and when it launched
sometimes they have these Asters on here
so it says located in the Montreal uh
metropolian area so that's a good
indicator because central Canada could
mean Toronto could mean Winnipeg so
that's why they put the asterisk on
there um but just notice that what
you'll usually see for availability
zones you'll never see anything beyond
six I'm not sure why but that seems to
be the max usually when a region
launches it should have three availab
availability zones I think in the past
there might have been some that did not
have um at least three and the reason
why it's important to have three in a
zone is that is how we get high
availability uh the way you do that is
you should have um let's say we're
talking about compute that compute
should be um running redundantly into
other data centers in your region to
ensure um that you have up time in case
the other two go out so just make note
of that if you're coming from Azure
Azure uh will launch things without
having all of their uh zones uh gcp is
really good where they'll always at
least have three so uh each provider
Works a little bit differently there um
but yeah you can see here for North
America we just scroll through here you
can find your particular area and look
at the map uh and wonder why it's so
distorted but yeah hopefully that gives
you kind of an idea there and if you
want to explore any of these other uh
particular offerings you absolutely can
of course we do cover in the course so
it's not really necessary to do that but
I thought uh it'd be nice to show you
this page okay
[Music]
ciao hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at a
regions and regions are geographically
distinct locations consisting of one or
more availability Zone and so here is a
world map showing you all the regions
that AOS has in the world and the blue
ones represent regions that are already
available to you and the orange ones
represent ones that adus is planning to
open so adus is always expanding their
infrastructure uh in the world so always
expect there to be uh more upcoming ones
every region is physically isolated from
independent of every other region in
terms of location Power and Water Supply
and the most important region that you
should give attention to Is Us East one
uh in particular so this is Northern
Virginia it was in's first region where
we saw the launch of sqs and S3 uh and
there are a lot of special use cases
where things only work in Us East ones
and we'll find that out here in a moment
what I do want to show you is what it
looks like for an architectural diagram
when you are seeing a region so notice
that we have this um uh little flag here
it says Us East one US West one and
inside of it we have an E2 instance so
that is going to represent a region in
our architectural diagrams uh but let's
look at some of the facts here and under
understand why Us East or Us East one is
so important so each region generally
has three availability zones and that is
by intention and we will talk about that
when we get to the availability Zone
section some new users are limited to
two or uh to two uh but generally
there's always three okay new Services
almost always become available first in
Us East and specifically Us East one not
all services are available in all
regions all your billing information
appears in us east1 so that's a US east1
particular thing uh the cost of AD
services vary per region and so if you
were on the marketing website or uh for
Global infrastructure you can see uh
here in North America they will say like
when it launched how many availability
zones and there might be some conditions
so you'll notice there's like Aster uh
beside these things here or um in this
one particular there's an aster saying
hey there are three zones but generally
you're limited to two Okay when you
choose a region there are four factors
you need to consider uh what are the
Regulatory Compliance does this region
meet what is the cost of this Ina
service in this region what Ina services
are available in this region and what is
the dist distance or latency to my end
users and those are those four factors
that you should remember
[Music]
okay all right so we just talked about
adus regions now let's talk about uh how
that affects our services versus
regional and Global Services so Regional
services are scoped based on what is set
in the adus Management console on the
selected region so you have this drop
down and that's what you'll do you'll
say Okay I want to have resources in
Canada or in Europe uh so this will
determine where an ad service will be
launched and what will be seen within
the ad Services console you generally
don't explicitly set the region for a
service at the time of creation I
explicitly mentioned this because when
you use something like gcp or Azure when
you create the resource that's when you
select the region but ads is it has this
kind of global thing which is unique to
their platform um then there's the
concept of Global Services so some a
Services operate across multiple regions
and the region will be fixed to the word
Global and for these that's services
like S3 cloudfront R 53 I am so the idea
is if you were to go over to cloudfront
and go into the cloudfront console
you'll notice that it will just say
Global and you can't switch out of that
uh for these Global Services um at the
time of creation it's a bit different so
we were saying up here for regional ones
that you don't select the region but
when you are clearing Global Services if
you're using something like I there is
no concept of region because they're
just globally available so you don't
have to determine a subset of regions if
you're using S3 bucket that has to be in
one region so you actually do have to
select a region at time of creation um
and then there's something like Cloud
distributions where you were choosing a
group of regions so you either say all
of the world or only North America which
is more like geographic distribution so
you don't say the region in particular
but you know hopefully that gives you a
distinction between Regional services
and Global
Services
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at availability
zones so availability zones commonly
abbreviated as AZ and I'll frequently
use be using the term AZ is physical
locations made up of one or more data
centers so a data center is a secured
building that contains hundreds or
thousands of computers uh and this is
one of my favorite Graphics I like to
show of course uh you know ads would
never have a dog um in their data center
but I just thought that would be fun a
region will generally contain three
availability zones and I say generally
because there are some cases where we
will see uh less than three so there
might be two um data centers within a
region will be isolated from each other
um so there will be in different
buildings but they will be close enough
to provide low latency and that is
within the uh 10 milliseconds or less so
it's very very low uh it's common
practice to run workloads in at least
three azs to ensure Services remain
available in case one or two data
centers fail and this is known as high
availability and this generally is
driven based on Regulatory Compliance so
a lot of companies uh you know they have
to at least be running in three azs and
that's why iTab us tries to always have
at least three azs within a region uh
azs are represented by a region code
followed by a letter so here you know
you'd have us east1 which would be the
region and then the a would represent
the particular availability Zone in that
region um so a subnet which is related
to a a ability zones is associated with
uh two availability zones so you never
choose an a when launching resources you
always choose a subnet which is then
Associated to an AZ a lot of services um
you know don't even require you to
choose a subnet because they're fully
managed by AWS but in the case of like
virtual machines you're always choosing
a subnet okay so here is a graphical uh
representation or a diagram that's
representing two availability zones so
here we have the region Us East one and
Us West 2 and then we have our two azs
so here is 1 a and one b and so these
are effectively the subnets okay and so
within those subnets then you can see or
availability zones you will see that we
have uh two virtual machines okay so the
US east1 region has six azs and I
thought that's just kind of like a fun
fact because it is the most out of every
single one um I don't think any one
comes close to us East one but of course
it is the most popular it is the uh
first uh um region or so it's not a
surprise that that one has that many
[Music]
a okay so we just covered regions and
availability zones but I really want to
make it clear uh what they look like so
I kind of have a visual representation
so let's say we have our adus region and
in this particular one we have Canada
Central which in particular is Montreal
so CA Central one uh and the idea here
is that a region has multiple
availability zones so here you can see
that we have uh 1 a 1 B and 1 D for some
reason adus decided to uh not launch 1 C
maybe it's haunted who knows you know um
and then within your um availability
zones they are made up of one or more
data center so just understand that an a
is not a single data center but could be
a collection of buildings and that these
azs um are interconnected with high
bandwidth low latency networking they're
fully redundant dedicated to metrof
fiber providing High throughput latency
networking between so just very fast
Connections in between and all traffic
between azs is encrypted and these azs
are within 100 km so about 60 miles uh
of each other
[Music]
okay so what I want to do here is just
show you uh how regions and availability
zones work with some different adus
services so you have a general idea when
you are selecting a region or a and when
you're not so Within when you want to
select a region you're going to go up
here and change it and this is going to
apply to Regional Services a very famous
example of a regional service would be
ec2 so we go over to ec2 which is
elastic uh cloud computing or compute
whatever always forget the name of it
and what we can do is go over to
instances I'm going to launch an
instance I'm not going to complete the
process I just want to show you what
would happen when you go select some
things here so I'm going to go with
Amazon LX 2 um we're going to just go to
uh next here and so here is where we're
going to select um our availability zone
so up here we have North Virginia that's
our region and when I say we're
selecting availability Zone we're
actually selecting the subnet so so here
we are choosing a subnet and a subnet is
associated to a availability Zone and
every single um region has a default VPC
and that VPC has uh subnets set up and
the subnets are defaulted to each of the
availability zones available so us east1
has six of them so this server is going
to launch in Us East 1B so this is a
regional service okay uh then we have
Global Services like S3 so we go over to
S3 and it says it's Global right and so
we're going to go ahead and create our
bucket and so here we choose the region
so we go down we're going to say the
region we want to be in but we don't
choose the availability Zone because
there's nothing to um uh choose because
adabs is going to run these in a
multiple A's and it doesn't matter to
you what it's doing there okay um so
there's that and then there's something
like cloudfront so cloudfronts a little
bit uh different here so we go over to
cloudfront and we create ourselves a
distribution um and so yeah if if you
don't have that option there because
sometimes databus has like a splash
screen just click on the left hand side
then go to distributions okay okay and
so here well they changed it again on me
they're always changing this UI but if
we scroll on down it should allow us to
change um change where this is going to
launch it's like Global stuff like that
literally they just recently changed
this and that's why I'm
confused uh we'll scroll on down
here it used to
be maybe it's under
Legacy
additional customized
oh it's here sorry okay so notice here
the price class that says use the edge
locations for best performance North
America and Europe North America Europe
Asia middle uh Middle East and Africa so
we're not choosing a particular region
we're picking a geographical area and so
those are pretty much the major um uh uh
examples of that uh then there's of
course things like an IM am where you
don't even say where it is so you go
into IM am you know and if I create
something like a group uh over here a
user group
whoops here I say create group you know
I'm not saying oh this is for this
particular region or something like that
okay so yeah hopefully that makes
[Music]
sense hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and let's take a look here at fault
tolerance specifically for Global
infrastructure and so before we jump
into that let's just Define some fault
terminology here so let's describe what
a fault domain is so a fault domain is a
section of a network that is vulnerable
to damage if a critical device or system
fails and the purpose of a fault domain
is that if a failure occurs it will not
Cascade outside that domain limiting the
possible damage and so uh there's this
very popular meme called This is fine
where uh there's obviously a serious
problem but uh the person's not freaking
out and I gave it some context to say
well the reason they're not freaking out
because they know that is a fault domain
and nothing outside of this room is
going to be affected okay so you can
have fault domains nested inside of
other fault domains uh but generally
they're grouped in something called
fault level so a fault level is a
collection of fault domains um and the
scoping of a fault domain could be
something like a specific specific
servers in a rack an entire Rack in a
data center an entire room in a data
center the entire Data Center building
and it's really up to the cloud service
provider to define those boundaries of a
domain adus abstracts it all way so you
don't have to think about it but just to
compare it against something else when
you're using azure you actually Define
your fault domain so you might say like
okay uh make sure that this workload is
never running on the same VM on the same
rack for these things uh and you know
you might like to have that level of
control but I really like the fact that
Abus just abstracts it away I'm not sure
how they segment their uh their their
fault domains but they they definitely
are some broader ones which we'll
describe right now so when we're looking
at an abis region this would be
considered a fault level and then within
that fault level you would have your uh
availability zones and these would be
considered fault domains and of course
those data centers can have uh fault
domains within them okay like maybe you
know they have everything in a
particular room and that room is secure
so like if there's a fire in that room
it's not going to affect the other room
things like that um so each Amazon
region is designed to be completely
isolated from the other Amazon region
they uh they achieve this with the
greatest possible fault tolerance and
stability uh each availab availability
zone is also isolated but the
availability Zone in a region are
connected through low latency links each
availability zone is designed as an
independent failure Zone and so here we
have uh some kind of different language
that adus is using um I've never
experienced this terminology in other
any other cloud service provider so I
kind of feel like it's something that ad
made up but basically a failure Zone
they're just basically saying a fault
domain but let's kind of expand on their
fault uh failure Zone terminology so
availability zones are physically
separated within a typical Metropolitan
region and are located in lower risk uh
flood planes discreet uninterruptible
power supply so UPS and an on-site
backup uh generation facilities uh Data
Centers located in different azs are uh
designed to be supplied by independent
substations to reduce the risk of an
event on the power grid impacting more
than one availability Zone availability
zones are all redundantly connected to
multiple tier one Transit providers and
we'll talk about what those are uh in an
upcoming slide and just one thing I want
to note here is that when you adopt
multi-az you get high availability so if
an application is partitioned across A's
companies are better isolated and
protected from issues such as power
outages lightning strikes tornadoes
earthquakes and more so that's the idea
behind you know why we want to run in
multi-az okay because of these fault
[Music]
domains hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we're talking about the ad
Global Network so the global Network
represents interconnections between a
global infrastructure and and it's
commonly referred to as the backbone of
AWS so is ec2 so just understand that
that could be used in more than one way
but think of it as a private Expressway
where things can move fast between data
centers and uh one thing that is
utilized a lot to get data in and out of
AWS very quickly is Edge locations they
can act as on and off ramps uh to the
AWS Global Network of course you can uh
get to the network through pops which
we'll talk about um you know in the
upcoming slides here but let's just talk
about Edge locations and what services
use them so uh when we're talking about
things that are getting on to the adus
network we're looking at things like
Abus Global accelerator adus S3 transfer
acceleration and so uh these use agile
locations as an on-ramp to quickly reach
a resources in other regions by
traversing the fast adus Global Network
notice that the names in it say
accelerator acceleration so the idea is
that they are moving really fast okay on
the other side when we talk about like
an offramp we're looking at Amazon
cloudfront which is a Content
distribution Network
this uses Edge locations to uh as an
offramp to provide at the edge storage
and compute near the end user uh and one
other thing that is kind of always
utilized in the global Network are VPC
endpoints now these aren't using Edge
locations but the idea here is that this
ensures your resources stay within the
Aus Network and do not Traverse over the
public internet so you know if you have
uh you know a resource running in Us
East one and one in uh EU it would and
they never have to go to the Internet it
would make sense to always enforce it to
stay within Theus Network cuz it's going
to be a lot faster so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at point of
presence also known as Pop and this is
an intermediate location between an ads
region and the end user and this
location could be a data center or a
collection of Hardware so for AWS a
point of presence is a data center owned
by AWS or trusted partner that is
utilized by AWS Services related for
content delivery or expediated upload so
a pop resource could be something like
an edge location or Regional Edge cache
so as an example over here we see an S3
bucket and it has to go through Regional
Edge cache and then get to an edge
location let's go Define what those are
so an edge location are data centers
that hold cach copies on the most
popular files so web pages images and
videos so that the delivery of the
distance to the end users are reduced
then you have Regional Edge locations
and these are data centers that hold
much larger caches of less popular files
to reduce a full round trip and also to
reduce the cost of transfer
[Music]
fees so to kind of help put pops more in
presence just in the general sense here
is a diagram I got from Wikipedia that
kind of just shows a bunch of different
networks and notice where the pop is
it's on the edge or the intersection of
uh two networks so here you know we have
um you know tier three and then this
tier two and there's this pop that is in
between them okay so tier one networks
is a network that can reach every other
network on the internet without
purchasing IP transit or paying for
peering and so the anabis availability
zones or azs are all redundantly
connected to multiple tier one Transit
providers
[Music]
okay all right so let's take a look at
somea services that are utilizing pops
or Edge locations for Content delivery
or expediated upload so Amazon on
cloudfront is a Content delivery network
service and the idea here is you point
your website to cloudfront so that it
will route requests to the nearest Edge
location cache it's going to allow you
to choose an origin so that could be a
web server or storage that'll be the
source of the cache and cach is the
content of what origin would return to
various Edge locations around the world
then you have Amazon S3 transfer
acceleration this allows you to generate
a special URL that can be used by the
end users to upload files to a nearby
Edge location once a file is uploaded to
an edge location it can move much faster
within the adus network to reach S3 then
at the end here you have adus Global
accelerator you can find the optimal
path from the end user to your web
servers so Global accelerators are
deployed within Edge location so you
send user traffic to an edge location
instead of directly to your web
application this service is really
really great for if let's say you are
running a web server in Us East one and
you just don't have the time uh to set
up infrastructure in other regions you
turn this on and you basically get a
booster
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and let's take a look at it was
direct connect so this is a private or
dedicated connection between your data
center office collocation and AWS and so
the idea here is imagine if you had a
fiber optic cable running from your uh
data center all the way to your ads so
that it feels like uh when you're using
your stuff on your data center like your
local virtual machines that uh there's
like next tendo latency okay so Direct
Connect has two very fast network
connection options we have the lower
bandwidth which is at 50 to 500
megabytes per second and then you have
the higher bandwidth which is 1 GB to 10
GB per second so using Direct Connect
helps reduce Network cost increase
bandwidth throughput so great for hight
trffic networks provides a more
consistent Network experience than a
typical internet based connection so
reliable and secure um I do want to
point out the term collocation if you
never heard of that before a collocation
or a carrier hotel is a data center
where equipment space and bandwidth are
available for rental uh to retail
customers and I do want to also point
out that even though it says private up
here and this is the language that AWS
used I usually just say dedicated but
the connection is private but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's secure
okay so uh we'll talk about that when we
reach ads vpns and how we can use that
with direct connect to make sure our
connections are secure
[Music]
okay all right so let's take a look at
what a direct connect location is so a
direct connect location are trusted
partner data centers that you can
establish a dedicated highspeed low
latency connection from your on premise
to AWS so an example of a partner data
center would be one like here in Toronto
the Allied data center so you can tell
that's right down in uh the Toronto
Center and so you would use this uh uh
as part of direct connect service to
order and establish a connection
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at local zones
which are Data Centers located very
close to densely populated areas to
provide single-digit millisecond low
latency performance so think like 7even
milliseconds for that area so here is a
map of uh local zones that exist and
ones that are coming out I believe the
orange ones are probably ones that are
on their way and so to use a local Zone
you do need to opt in so you got to go
talk to AWS probably open a support
ticket to get access to it the first one
to ever be launched was uh the LA one uh
and so um you know when you want to see
it it looks just like a an availability
Zone it's going to show up under
whatever region that is because these
are always tied to existing regions so
the la1 is tied to us West uh region and
the a would look like us West 2 hyphen
LAX hyphen 1 a okay so only specific AA
Services have been made available so
there's particular ec2 types EBS Amazon
FSX application load balancer Amon VPC
they probably have extended it to more
services do you need to know that for
the exam no but you know the point is is
that there's a limited subset of things
that are available the purpose of local
zone is to support highly demanding
applications sensitive delcy so media
and entertainment electronic design and
automation adte machine learning so it
kind of makes sense like you look at La
they're in the media entertainment and
so they're dealing with lots of media
content so it has to be really low for
them
okay
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at Abus
wavelength zones and these allow for
Edge Computing on the 5G networks and
applications will have ultra low latency
being as close as possible to the users
so Abus has partnered with various
telecom companies to utilize their 5G
networks so we're looking at Verizon
vone kddi SK Telecom and so the idea
here is that you will create a subnet
tied to a wavelength Zone and then and
just think of it as an availability Zone
but it's a wavelength Zone and then you
can launch your VMS to the edge of the
targeted 5G Network so that's the
network you're using uh AWS to uh deploy
an ec2 instance and then when users uh
connect to you know those radio tower
those um the cell towers they're going
to be routed to um you know nearby
hardware that is running those virtual
machines okay and that's all it is it's
just it's just uh ec2 instances um but
you know the advantage here is that it's
like super super low Lane SE
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at data
residency so this is the physical or
geographical location of where an
organization or Cloud resources reside
and then you have the concept of comp uh
compliance boundaries so a Regulatory
Compliance so legal requirement by
government or organization that
describes where data and Cloud resources
are allowed to reside and then you have
the idea of data sovereignty so data
sovereignty is the jurisdictional
control or legal Authority that can be
asserted over data because its physical
location is within a uh jurisdictional
boundary and so the reason we care about
this stuff is that if we want to work
with the Canadian government or the US
government and they're like hey you got
to make sure that you know if you want
to work with us all the data has to stay
in Canada and you need to give them that
guarantee so data residency is not a
guarantee it just says where your data
is right and compliance boundaries are
those U controls that are in place to
say okay this this is going to make sure
that data stays where we want to be and
data of sovereignty is just like the
idea of the scope of the the legal the
legal stuff that ties in with compliance
boundaries so how do we do that on AWS
well there's a few different ways but um
let's just take a look at some ways that
we can meet those compliance boundaries
one uh which is very expensive but also
very cool is adus outposts so this is a
physical rack of servers that you can
put in your data center and you'll know
exactly where the data resides because
you know it's physical if it's in your
data center and you're in Canada that's
where it's going to be okay uh and I
believe that you know there is only a
subset of adus services that are
available here but you know that is one
option to you another is using like um
services for governance so like one
could be adus config this is a policy as
a code service so you can create rules
to continuously check adus resource
configuration so if they deviate from
your expectations you're alerted Oris
config can in some cases Auto remediate
so if you were expecting you know um you
know you had an account and you're
saying this account is only to be used
for candid resources and somebody
launches let's say something in another
region then you could get an alert or
tell it was config to go delete that
resource okay now if you want to prevent
people from doing it uh Al together
that's where IM am policies come into
play so these can be written explicitly
to deny access to specific adus regions
and you know this is great if you're
applying it to users or roles but if you
wanted to have it organizational wide
across all of your um your a accounts
you can use something called a service
control policy that is just an IM am
policy that is used within it
organizations that makes it
organizational wide
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at 8s for
government so to answer that we first
have to understand what is public sector
so public sector includes public goods
and government services such as military
law enforcement infrastructure public
transit public education Healthcare and
the government itself so AOS can be
utilized by the public sector or
organizations developing Cloud workloads
for the public sector and a achiev this
by meeting Regulatory Compliance
programs along with specific governance
and security controls so this could be
meeting the requirements with HIPPA
fedramp um cjis and fips okay so abis
has a special regions or special regions
for us regulation called gov Cloud which
we'll talk about next
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at govcloud and
to understand what govcloud is we need
to know what fedramp is so fedramp
stands for federal risk and
authorization Management program it's a
US government-wide program that provides
a standardized approach to security
assessment authorization continuous
monitoring for cloud products and
services so now that we know what fed
ramp is what is gocloud well uh and
again it's not particular to AWS because
Azure has gocloud as well but a cloud
service provider like ad or Azure J will
offer an isolated region to run fed ramp
workloads and so in ads it's called
govcloud and these are specialized
regions that allow customers to host
sensitive controlled unclassified
information and other types of regulated
workloads so govcloud regions are only
operated by you uh by US citizens on us
soil they are only accessible to us
entries and root account holders who
pass a screening process customers can
architect secure Cloud solutions that
comply with fed ramp uh do the doj's uh
criminal justice Information Systems uh
security policy the US International
traffic and arms regulation uh uh export
Administration regulations the
Department of Defense cloud computing
security requirements and guides so if
you want to work with the US government
you want to uh engineer and use govcloud
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at uh running
adus in China so adus China is the adus
cloud offering in mainland China adus
China is completely isolate
intentionally from adus Global to meet
Regulatory Compliance for mainland China
so that means that if you make a
workload on the adus global uh you can't
uh interact with it within the ads China
One okay it's basically treated like a a
completely separate service like ads has
its own Chinese version uh and so ad
China is on its own domain at Amazon
ads. CN and for everybody else that's
what's considered AB Global so when I'm
using adabs from Canada or use it from
the US or from India or from Europe or
wherever that is the adus global okay so
in order to operate in adus China
regions you need to have a Chinese
business license so ICP license not all
services are available in China so uh
you will not have the use of Route 53 uh
and you might say well why not just run
in Singapore ored was Global and you
could do that but the advantage of
running in mainland China means that you
would not have to Traverse the great
firewall okay so all your traffic is
already within China so you don't have
to uh deal with that Abus has two
regions in mainland China so uh there's
this one here which is the northwest
region operated by NS WCF and then you
have the one in Beijing North one
operated by uh sinnet so you know itus
just could not meet the the compliance
requirement so they had to partner with
local providers or data centers and so
that is how that works
[Music]
okay all right so I want to show you how
you get over to the um Chinese adus
Management console so this one is adab.
amazon.com that is the global one for
everyone outside of mainland China but
if you want to run resources uh on data
centers within mainland China this is at
amazon.cn and so it looks very similar
if you go to create a free account
you're going to fill in this stuff but
uh notice that you need to have your
business registration certificate uh and
additional information in order to run
these data centers down below that AWS
has partnered with also notice that the
logo doesn't say AWS in it and there's a
good reason for that if I type in adus
trademark
China uh adus is actually banned from
using the adus logo in China uh for
whatever reason it's a weird reason if
you ever want to read about it but
that's why you don't see AWS here all
right
um so yeah there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at sustainability
for adus Global infrastructure and
before we talk about that let's talk
about the climate pledge so Amazon
co-founded the climate pledge to achieve
Net Zero carbon emissions by 2040 across
all of Amazon's businesses which
includes AWS if youall want to find out
more information go to to
sustainability. amazon.com there's a a
lot of great information there and
you'll learn exactly how uh ads is
achieving this in particular like their
data centers it's very interesting okay
so adus Cloud sustainab goals are
composed of three parts the first is
renewable energy so adus is working
towards having their adus Global
infrastructure powered by 100% renewable
energy by
2025 and AAS purchases and retires
environmental attributes to cover the
nonrenewable energy for AIS Global
infrastructure so they would purchase
things like renewable energy credits
also known as Rec's guarantees of origin
so Go's the second Point here is cloud
efficiency so adus infrastructure is 3.6
times more energy efficient than the
medium of us Enterprises data centers
surveyed so that's going to really rely
on that survey surveys are not always
that great so you know take that with a
grain of salt okay then we have water uh
stewardship so uh direct evaporative
technology to cool our data centers use
of non portable uh water for cooling
purposes so they're recycling water
on-site water treatment allows us to
remove us them to remove scale forming
minerals and reuse Waters uh for more
Cycles water efficiency metrics to
determine and monitor optimal water use
for each aabus region and you'll find
that water plays a large part on uh
making these um uh these data centers
very efficient
[Music]
okay so I just wanted to show you where
you get to that sustainability
information so I just went to itus
Global infrastructure you click
sustainability and that's going to bring
us over to whoops I have my Twitter open
there to the sustainability in the cloud
so if you want to uh read a bunch of
stuff here about things that are going
on that itus is up to see uh how they
are progressing with renewable energy um
there's Cloud efficiency up here so you
know how are they being efficient it's
worth the read to really understand that
there's a lot of water involved like
reducing water in data centers I thought
that was really interesting um I mean
they have theis podcast but I don't
think there's really much to it a
bi-weekly podcast of bite side stories
about how Tech makes the world better
that's not necessarily A sustainability
podcast it's just the invis podcast in
general there's a download Center um
Amazon's 2020 sustainability reports so
I guess you can download the reports to
see what is going on there so we could
download the progress here and see what
they've been up
to okay so there's a bunch of numbers
things like that
okay very short reports but hey at least
you can download them okay so just in
case you're uh very interested in
sustainability all
[Music]
right hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at Abus
ground station so this is a fully
managed service that lets you control
satellite Communications process data
and scale your operations without having
to worry about building or managing your
own ground station infrastructure and so
when we're talking about ground station
a really good way to cement what the
service is is just think of a big anten
10 ey dish that's pointing into the sky
trying to communicate with satellites
because that's essentially what the
service is doing so the use cases here
could be for weather forecasting surface
Imaging communications video broadcasts
and to use ground station the idea is
that you would schedule a contact so
that's where you're selecting a
satellite a start and end time and the
ground location and then you use an a
ground station ec2 Ami and Amazon
machine image to launch e two instances
that will Uplink and downlink uh data
during the contact or receive downlink
data in an Amazon S3 bucket a use case
could be something like you are a
company you've reached an agreement with
a satellite image provider to use their
satellites to take photos for a specific
region or time or whatever and so the
idea is that you are using adus ground
station to communicate uh to that
company satellite and download that s uh
that image data to your S3 bucket
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown and we are
looking at Aus outposts and this is a
fully managed service that offers the
same aess infrastructure Services apis
tools to virtually any data center
cocation space or on premise facility
for a truly consistent hybrid experience
and just to kind of summarize it it's a
rack of servers running adaba stuff on
your physical location okay so before we
jump into the service or technology
itself uh let's talk about what is a
rack server or just a rack so it's a
frame designed to hold and organize it
equipment so here's an example of a 42 U
rack uh and there's the concept of rack
heights so the U stands for rack units
or U spaces uh with it equal to 1.75 in
and the industry standard rack is a 48 U
um so that is a 7 foot rack so a full
size rack cage is commonly the 4 to High
okay and uh in it you might have
equipment that is of different sizes so
there could be one u 2 U 3 U or 4 U high
so here's an example of you know of an
interior of a rack and notice that like
one u 2 U 4 U they're all a little bit
shaped differently uh but they give you
kind of an idea of um you know what
those are so it Outpost comes in three
form factors the four2 U the one U and
the 2 U so the the first one here the 42
U this is basic basically a full rack of
servers provided by adus so you're not
just getting the frame it actually comes
with you know servers uh and so adus
delivers it to your Preferred Physical
site fully assembled and ready to be
rolled into the final position it is
installed by adus and the rack needs to
be simply plugged in to the power and
network and there's a lot of details
about um the specs on this on the adus
website so you know I'm not going to go
through them all here um then there are
servers that you can just Place into
your existing racks so we have the oneu
so this is suitable for 19 in wide 24 in
deep cabinets it's using Idis uh
Gravitron 2 um CPUs and you can have up
to 64 uh virtual CPUs we have 128 gabt
uh 4 terabytes of local
NVM storage um and then you have the U
or sorry the 2 U so suitable for 19in
wide 36 in deep Intel processors up to
128 virtual CPUs 256 GB of memory 8 tab
of local nvme storage so there you
[Music]
go let's take a look at Cloud
architecture terminologies before we do
let's talk about some of the roles that
are around uh doing Cloud architecture
so the first is Solutions architect this
is a role in a technical organization
that Architects a technical solution
using multiple systems via researching
documentation and experimentation and
then you have the cloud architect this
is a Solutions architect that is focused
solely on architecting Technical
Solutions using cloud services
understand that in the uh actual
Marketplace a lot of times Solutions
architect is used to describe both a
cloud architect and a Solutions
architect and you know these are going
to highly vary based on your locality
and how companies want to use these
terms but this is just me broadly
defining them here so just don't take
them as a perfect word in terms of what
they're representing so a cloud
architect needs to understand the
following terms and factors uh and
Factor them into their designed
architect based on the business
requirements so we have the idea of
availability your ability to ensure
service remains available scalability
your ability to grow rapidly or
unimpeded elasticity your ability to
shrink and grow to meet the demand fault
tolerance your ability to prevent a
failure Disaster Recovery your ability
to recover from a failure and there are
a couple other things that uh that
should be considered they're not
terminologies but they're definitely
important to a Solutions architect or
Cloud architect and uh these are things
you always need to consider uh as as
well and this is just me talking to my
Solutions architect friends where
they'll always ask me these two
questions after presentation they'll say
how secure is the solution and how much
is this going to cost all right and so
for the terminologies up here we're
going to Define these right away and
we're going to figure these out
throughout the course we have two giant
sections just on cost and security alone
uh so there we
[Music]
go the first term we're looking at is
high availability and this is your
ability for your service to remain
available by ensuring there is no single
point of failure and or you ensure a
certain level of performance so the way
we're going to do that on ews is you'd
want to run your workload across
multiple availability zones to ensure
that if one or two availability zones
became unavailable your servers or
applications remain available because
those other um those other servers are
going to be there and the way we would
accomplish that is via elastic load
balancer so a load balancer allows you
to evenly distribute traffic to multiple
servers in one or more data center if a
data center or server becomes
unavailable or unhealthy the load
bouncer will route the traffic to only
the available data centers within the
server and understand that just because
you have additional servers doesn't mean
that you are uh you're available you
have to you might need to meet a
particular threshold of availability so
you might need to have at least two
servers always running to meet the
demand so it's based on the the demand
of traffic
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at high
scalability so this is your ability to
increase your capacity based on the
increasing demand of traffic memory and
computing power and we have the terms
vertical scaling so scaling up um this
is where you upgrade to a bigger server
and then there's horizontal scaling
scaling out this is where you add more
servers of the same size and the great
thing about scaling out or adding
additional servers is that you're also
going to get um High availability so if
you do need two servers it's always
better to you know add an additional
server as opposed to having a larger
server but it's going to be very
dependent on a lot of factors
[Music]
okay so scalability and elasticity seem
very similar but there is a crucial
difference and this is your ability to
automatically increase or decrease Your
Capacity based on the current demand of
traffic memory and computing power again
it's the it's the fact that it happens
automatically and you can go both ways
increase or decrease so for horizontal
scaling we have the concept of scaling
out so add more servers of the same size
and then scaling in removing
underutilized servers of the same size
and vertical scaling is generally hard
for traditional architectures so you'll
usually only see horizontal scaling
described with elasticity um and the way
we would accomplish uh being highly
elastic is using autoscaling groups asgs
and this is aabus feature that will
automatically add or remove servers
based on scaling rules you define based
on those metrics
okay
let's talk about being highly fault
tolerant so this is your ability for
your service to ensure there is no
single point of failure preventing the
chance of failure and the way we could
do that is with fail overs so this is
when you have a plan to shift traffic to
a redundant system in case the primary
system fails a very common example is
having a copy or secondary uh uh uh of
your database where all ongoing changes
are synced the secondary system is not
in use until a fail over occurs and it
becomes the primary database so when
we're talking about databases on ABS
this is the concept of RDS multi-az so
this is when you run a duplicate standby
database in another availability Zone in
the case your primary database
[Music]
fails and last here is high durability
so this is your ability to recover from
a disaster and to prevent the loss of
data so solutions that recover a
disaster uh from a disaster is known as
disaster recovery so do you have a
backup how fast can you restore the
backup does your backup still work how
do you ensure current live data is not
corrupt and so maybe a solution ads
would be using Cloud endurer which is a
disaster recovery uh service which
continuously replicates your machines in
a lowcost staging area in your target AB
account and preferred region enabling
fast and reliable recovery in the case
of an IT data center fails
[Music]
okay so to understand Disaster Recovery
we need to know more about uh things
around it like business continuity plans
BCPS and RTO and rpos so uh a BCP is a
document that outlines how a business
will continue operating during an
unplanned disruption in services so it's
basically the plan that you're going to
execute uh if that happens and so here
we have a disaster and you can see that
there's a chance of data loss and
downtime and these two um uh factors as
RPO and RTO are going to define the
length of these durations so recovery
Point objective is the maximum
acceptable amount of data loss after an
unplanned data loss incident Express
this amount of time so how much data are
you willing to lose and then recovery
time objective so the maximum amount of
downtime your business can tolerate
without inuring a significant financial
loss so how much time you're willing to
go down okay so those are the two there
and now let's go take a look at the
disaster recovery options that we can
use to define in our our
BCP
so now let's take a look at our disaster
recovery options uh and based on what
you choose they're going to be a trade
of cost versus time to recover based on
the rpos your RTO of course and so
sometimes this is rep represented
vertically like a a thermostat or you
can do it horizontally here um both are
valid ways of displaying this
information but I just have it
horizontally here today and so we have
low or high or you could say um even
though I don't have it written here this
could be cold or this could be hot okay
so um on the left hand side we got
backup and restore pilot light warm
standby multiactive sight notice we're
using the like the words like pilot
light warm things that are relating to
temperature so again cold and hot all
right so let's just walk through what
each of these things conceptually do uh
in terms of architecture so when you're
doing a backup and restore you're back
you basically back up your data and uh
at the time of Disaster Recovery you're
just going to restore it to New
infrastructure uh for a pilot light the
data is replicated to another region
with the minimal Services running to
keep on replicating that data and so you
might have some core Services running a
warm standby is a scale down copy of
your infrastructure so you basically
have everything that you would
absolutely need to run an application
but the idea is it's not at scale and so
at any time when there's an incident
you're going to scale up to the capacity
that you need and then you have multi
sight active active where you you have a
scaled up copy of your infrastructure in
another region so basically everything
you have identically in another region
and so in terms of the rpos and the RTO
for back and restore you're looking at
hours uh with the pilot light you're
looking at 10 minutes with a warm
standby you're looking at minutes and
multi sight uh active active you're
looking at uh real time so you know
hopefully that gives you an idea of you
know the difference in terms of scale
but let's just look at more detail so
for a backup and restore this is for low
priority use cases restore data after
event deploy resources after an event
and it's very cost effective uh for
light this is where you have less
stringent RTO and rpos so you're going
to be just running your core Services uh
you're going to start and scale
resources after the event and this is a
little bit more expensive this is uh
very good for warm standby is good for
business critical services so you scale
resources after the event uh and it's uh
almost very it's very it's costly but
it's not as expensive as a multi-site
active active so you get zero downtime
near zero loss uh you have it's great
for mission critical services and it's
just as expensive as your original
infrastructure so you're basically
doubling the cost there
[Music]
okay so we already defined RTO but let's
redefine it again based on what adus
describes in their white paper and just
look at how it Maps against um the
disaster recovery option so re recovery
time objective is the maximum acceptable
delay between the interruption of
service and restoration of service this
objective determines the what is
considered an acceptable time window
when service is unavailable and is
defined by the organization and so this
is the diagram found in the white paper
and so on the left hand side we have
cost and complexity here and then
lengths of serice interruption and what
you can see here is that the cost and
complexity for a multi-site active
active is very high but the length of
service Interruption is zero and then as
we go down we have warm standby so it's
significantly like at least half uh the
complexity of that one
then we have our pilot light down here
and backup and restore but notice backup
restore takes the longest amount of time
and notice here we have a recovery time
objective so in your BCP you kind of
Define where that is based on the cost
of business impact so you might have to
calculate that saying okay what is our
cost over time based on the length of
service Interruption where do we want
our RTO to be what is the acceptable
recovery cost and this is where you're
going to decide what you want to do so
here we have pilot light and backup and
restore and so this company
you has to decide whether they want to
do a pilot light or they're going to do
a backup restore but it sounds like this
is where they're going to be which is at
the pilot uh light for what is
acceptable in their business use case
[Music]
okay let's do the same for RPO so
recovery Point objective is the maximum
acceptable amount of time since the last
data recovery point the objective
determines what is considered an
acceptable loss of data between the last
recovery point and the interruption of
service and it's defined by the
organization again we pulled this from
the a white paper for disaster recovery
and uh we have cost and complexity but
this time it's replaced with data loss
before service Interruption so uh for
multisite again it's going to be very
expensive and high up here as you
noticed it's not like a perfect um uh
curve it's just it's a bit different in
terms of what it looks like so here we
have warm St standby pilot light um and
so you'll see that the data loss is um
not a big deal but for back up from
store it really juts out there so you
can see that you can get pretty good
results just with the pilot light and
the cost and complexity is very low
again we have to look at our cost and
business impact so we got to follow that
line and we need to see where our
acceptable uh recovery cost is and so uh
you're going to notice that uh we have a
bit of an intersection here okay and so
we need to determine you know like are
we going to be doing a warm standby
looks like we have the cost to do it um
uh but you know it just really depends
you know do we want to be down here or
down there okay so hopefully that helps
and visualize that information for
[Music]
you hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and what I want to show you here is
a real world architectural diagram I
created this a while ago this is a
previous version of the um exam Pro or
technically teacher seat platform uh
that powers The Learning Experience uh
for by class certifications and so I'm
hoping that by giving you some exposure
you'll absorb some information here uh
and that will carry through to really
help you cement what these services do
and how they work together now you might
be asking how did I make this well I'm
in Adobe XD it's by Photoshop or sorry
Adobe it's free to download but there's
a lot of options out there and but the
first thing you'll need is those Aus
architectural icons so these are free on
AWS you can download them in PowerPoint
download them as asset as svgs and pgs
which is what I have done and start
using them in your um uh whatever
software you like there's also third
party providers out there so like
there's Lucid charts I love lucid the
charts but I don't use it to make
architectural diagrams uh for AWS um but
you know you can drag drop and stuff and
they already have the library there and
there's a bunch of them that you can
choose from so uh you know that's
interesting but let's take a look at one
that we can download maybe everyone's
familiar with PowerPoint so here is the
adus architectural icons and the reason
I'm showing you this is not because it
just contains icons but it also suggests
how you should build them so if I go
through here they'll give you a
definition of those system elements uh
how they would look like here so we have
our group icons or layer group our
service icons resource icons where they
should go uh and then they have some
interesting guidelines of like dos and
don'ts so here's like a simple example
of a get to an S3 bucket um here's an
example of using VPC subnets and things
like that on the inside um and then you
can see kind of like all the groups that
we have and it show all like the uh the
um arrows it's a big faux PA to make U
diagonal arrows that's just something it
us Define but you'll see a lot of people
do them anyway and then you'll see all
the icons so do you have to make them
like ad suggests no but you know if you
like the way they look that is fine
everyone just does whatever they want
honestly so anyway now that we've seen
you know how we can go get the resources
to make our own I have Adobe XD open up
here and so I just kind of want to walk
you through what's going on here so
again I said this is a a
traditional um architecture meaning that
it's powered by virtual machines and so
what we need to look for uh is ec2
because that's where it's going to start
that's our virtual machine and you'll
notice we have one here so there's a T2
um uh that's running over here and then
over here we have a T2 okay so uh we
have a blue and a green environment so
this is our running environment so I'm
just going to zoom on in here okay so
the web app would be running on this and
um and then on the outside here we have
an autoscaling group and so autoscaling
groups allow us to um manage a group of
vc2 instances and they will
automatically scale if the demand
increases or or or declin so if this
machine can't handle it it will just
automatically provision a new one and so
I've contained it in this environment
here because I'm representing a blue
green deploy meaning that when I deploy
this will get this will be the
environment that replaces things and so
you can see I have a lot of lines being
drawn around here so um over here we
have uh um parameter store so parameter
store is a place where we can store our
environment variable
um or application configuration
variables and so I have this line going
here and it's just saying we're going to
take these environment variables and put
them into the application okay uh and
then there's also uh the database
credential so here we are using
postgress over here so and then we need
the database credentials so we're
grabbing those database credentials
those are stored in Secrets manager and
we're giving to the application so the
app knows how to connect to the database
and this one knows how to uh configure
it okay then we have um a bunch of uh
buckets here for different organizations
and so you know S3 is for storage so
this is a way we're going to um store a
variety of things so like user data
assets artifacts Cloud information
templates so some of this is for the app
some of them is for the infrastructure
so that's one thing there okay then over
here we have u a cicd pipeline so we
have code Pipeline and so code pipeline
is triggered by GitHub so we put our
code in GitHub and when that happens
it's going to do a code build so that's
going to build out a
server um and then from there it's going
to run another code build server and
then from there it's going to then um uh
uh use code deploy and so code deploy is
going to trigger a deploy what it will
do is create a new environment so it's
going to create a copy of this um sorry
it's going to create a cop this is
actually the environment that's running
so we'll copy that and that will be our
new environment right okay and so when
the deploy is done it will swap and then
that environment will become this new
one um and so you know again this is
actually really the the running server
it's just kind of easy to get hung up on
this one but the idea here is that um
you know that's how deployment works but
let's say uh you know we want to get uh
traffic to this actual instance this is
going to come through the internet and
the internet's going to probably go to
refy 3 so ref 3 is used for domain names
so this be like exam pro. c teacher
seat.com we pass that over to our
elastic load balcer which in this case
is an application load balcer that's why
it's called ALB and that's going to
distribute the traffic there if we
wanted to run the server in another um
in another availability zone so that we
make it highly available um you know ALB
the elastic load balancer application
load balancer is going to uh have some
traffic go here and some traffic go
there so this is just uh the blue
environment or whichever the current
environment is over here now when we
want to deploy new version we're going
to use launch templates and launch
templates um uh are necessary when using
Autos scaling groups so um you know you
do have to Define launch template it
just says like what is the shape of this
instance type like what's its family
what should it be and then we need an
Amazon machine image so our Amazon
machine image is custom built because we
are installing all the stuff that we
want on it and so in order to automate
that process we are using um SSM
automation documents so SSM stands for
system manager and automation allows you
to automate that step so what it's going
to do is launch an instance install Ruby
install postgress download the codebase
then it's going to create that Ami and
then um it will do a bunch of other
stuff here as well and this is going to
run weekly or actually at the time uh it
was running nightly so we're doing
nightly builds so that we would always
get the latest um updates to our server
um because it's a virtual machine there
could always be uh new updates for that
Linux version or Amazon machine Li Linux
version we using and then there's a
bunch of other stuff here so you know um
hopefully that kind of gives you an idea
like the complexity of it and you know
this is how I like to make my
architectural diagrams very in detailed
so that we can um look at them but yeah
if that was too much that's fine but you
know that's just the complexity of it if
you build your own you'll start to
really grasp this stuff pretty well
[Music]
okay so what I want to do is just show
you how high availability is built into
some ad Services where in other cases
say you have to explicitly choose that
you want something to be highly
available uh so what I'm going to do is
make my way over to S3 and so with S3
this is where you can create S3 buckets
and this allows you uh to store things
and so the great thing about S3 is that
it's basically serverless storage so the
idea is that you're just going to choose
your region and by default it's going to
replicate your data across multiple um
uh data centers or azs and so this one's
already highly available by default with
the standard tier and so that is
something that's really nice but other
services uh you know like ec2 the idea
is that you are going to launch yourself
an ec2 instance so we' launch that one
and the problem with this is that if you
launch a single
ec2 that is not highly available because
it's a single server running in a single
um a so here you know we would choose
our subnet our subnet is our
availability Zone but you'd have to
launch at least two additional servers
and then you'd have to Route um uh you'd
have to have something that would
balance uh the traffic to the to the
three which is a load balancer and so in
this case you have to construct your
high availability then you have services
like elastic beanock this is a platform
as a service um and we'll go to
environments here I'm not sure I wasn't
showing up there um and so the idea is
that with elastic beant stock I'm just
going to click on the main service here
you're going to go ahead and uh create
your application or create your
environment you probably want to create
an environment first here okay and so I
would choose a web server and then the
idea is I just name it so my application
here my uh environment and then down
below you go configure more options
whoops it wants me to choose everything
that's totally
fine and we say configure more options
we're not going to create it because um
we don't want to create one but the idea
is that uh you you could choose whether
you want this to be high highly
available or not so see it says single
instance so free tier uh and then if you
chose this what it's going to do it set
up a bunch of stuff for you so it's
going to set up an application load
balancer for you it's going to set up
Auto scaling groups for you to make it
highly available it's going to run at
least uh between one to four instances
so this does everything that uh ec2
you'd have to do manually setting up so
that's really
nice okay so you know some options have
that if we make it our way over to RDS
and again we're not creating anything
we're just looking at the options it
gives us when we uh start things these
up here
we'll make our way over to RDS when it
gives us a moment
here and if we go ahead and create
ourselves a new
database and we look at something like a
postgress database notice that we have a
production option and a Dev test option
and so I mean usually it shows us the
price down here so even test Dev is $118
which is not true can make it cheaper
than that but the idea is that when you
choose between these two options um it's
going to set up uh multi-az it's going
to that means that it's going to run an
additional um uh database and another
availability Zone replicate that data
over so that it stays highly available
um you know it's going to have
autoscaling uh uh part of it and so some
Services you just choose it abstractly
so you just have to understand what
highly availability is going to mean
underneath so hopefully that kind of
gives you a picture of high availability
on
AWS
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at adus application
programming interface also known as adus
API so before we talk about uh the API
let's describe what application
programming interface is so an API is
software that allows two applications or
services to talk to each other and the
most common type of API is via HTTP
requests and so the ads API is actually
an htttp API and you can interact with
it by sending HPS requests using an
application interacting with apis like
Postman and so here's kind of an example
of what a request would be that would be
sent out and so the way it works is that
each Ada service generally has a service
endpoint so see where it says monitoring
that's going to be cloudwatch so
sometimes they're named after the
services sometimes the name is a bit
obscure and of course you can't just
call uh call Api request without
authenticating or authorizing and so you
have to sign your request and so that's
a process of making a separate request
uh with your adus credentials to get
back a a temporary token in order to
authorize that and I don't have room to
show it but the thing is is that what
you'd be uh also going along with those
requests would be to provide an action
so when you look at um the adus API it
will show you a bunch of actions that
you can call they're basically the same
ones you'll see in the IM policies so it
could be like describe ec2 instances Or
List buckets um and they can also be
accompanied with parameters okay so you
know we're probably not going to show
you how to uh make an API request
directly because that's not something
that you would generally do um but what
you would do is you'd probably use the
abis Management console which is powered
by the API use the adus SDK which is
powered by the API or using the adus CLI
so we'll cover all those three
[Music]
okay all right so what I want to do is
just point you to where you'd find the
resources to use the API
programmatically uh we're not going to
actually use the API because there's a
lot more to it uh than what I'm going to
show you here but at least you'll be
familiar with how the API works so I'm
on the aws.amazon.com website if you
type in docs the type top there it's
going to bring you to the main
documentation and what we're looking for
if we scroll on down there should be a
general reference area where we have
service endpoints if we click into here
it's going to uh talk about um how a
service endpoint is structured and if we
go down to abis API we can see some
additional information of course to use
um the API you're going to have to sign
API requests first which is not a super
simple process but you have to use an
authorization header um and send along
uh some credentials and things like that
so if you want to know what service
endpoints uh are available to you if you
search service endpoints list for AWS
this is the big list and so if I was to
go down here and look for C2 U might be
a common example here it's going to tell
us what the end points are and as you
can see they are Regional based but the
idea here is that I could take something
like this okay I could grab that and
using something like
Postman I could go and create a new
request and it's probably a post I'm not
sure what it's supposed to be it's
probably a post and then you'd set your
authorization header there might even be
one in here for adab us see where it
says adab us signature so you can go
here and put your access key and secret
with in here um so that's something nice
about Postman so it's going to do the
signing requests for you so it makes
your life a lot easier and then from
there what you do is you go to your body
and you'd want to enter in Json so to do
Json would probably be raw you drop down
the format Json and then you'd send your
payload whatever it is so I again I
haven't done this in a while because
it's not a very common uh thing that I
have to do like describe ec2 instances
but there probably is like an action and
some additional information that you'd
send along um so you know hopefully that
gives you kind of an idea how the API
works but you know you should never Pro
uh in practice ever have to really work
with the API this way directly
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the itus
Management console so the itus
Management console is a web-based
unified console to build manage and
monitor everything from simple web apps
to complex Cloud deployments so when you
create your adus account and you log in
that is what you're using the adus
Management console and I would not be
surprised uh if you're watching this
video and they've already changed um the
default page here since abos loves to
change the UI on us all the time uh but
uh the way you would access this is via
console. ab. amazon.com when you click
sign in or go to the console that's the
link that it's going to uh and so the
idea here is that you can point and
click to manually launch and configure
adus Resources with limited programming
knowledge this is known as click Ops
since you can perform all your system
operations via clicks
[Music]
okay let's talk about the adus
Management console in brief here so you
know of course when you're on the
homepage you go to ads Management
console and you will end up logging in
and from there we will uh make our way
over to the ads Management console when
I say ads Management console I'm
referring to uh this homepage but I'm
also referring to anything that I'm
doing in this web UI whether it's a
subservice or not so you know a lot of
times people just call this the
dashboard uh or the homepage um but you
know it is technically the adus
Management console but everything is the
adabs Management console you can drop
down Services here if there's some that
you like you can favorite them on the
left hand side I don't find that
particularly useful you can see the most
recent ones here they'll also Show
recently up here as well we have the
search at the top notice that there's a
hotkey for alt S I don't think I ever
use it but if I was to type in a service
like ec2 it's going to get me the
services and then down below it's the
sub features of it so if I just click
into that there into this this is the
main this is a service console so I
would call this the ec2 console or the
ec2 service console so if you ever hear
me saying go to the ec2 console that's
what I'm saying and you'll notice here
like there is stuff on the left hand
side so I come back here ec2 image
Builder ec2 Global views these are
considered services but if you drop down
it says top features or you go down here
it says dashboard limits Amis you go
over here um the ec2 dash board limits
Amis are here and limits are somewhere
here right there so okay so those kind
of map over pretty well plls and
documentation knowledge based articles
Marketplace I don't think I've ever
touched those in my life uh this here is
the cloud shell so if you click it it
will launch a cloud shell will cover
that when we get to that section here we
have this little bell it tells us about
open issues I think this is for the
personal health dashboard yeah it says
PhD in the bottom left corner or left
corner so if I open that up it'll bring
up the PHD the personal Health dashboard
all right uh our region selector our
support so nothing super exciting here
but just kind of giving you a bit of a
tour so that you know there are some
things you can do um can you change the
look of this I don't think right now as
of yet um there is any way I'm sure Aus
is thinking about it because it's been a
high uh request that's in demand but uh
this is what it looks like as of today
okay all right so I just want to
describe what a service console is so an
an service each have their own
customized console and you can access
these consoles by searching the service
name so you would go ahead and type in
ec2 and then what we refer to this
screen as as the ec2 console the reason
I'm telling you this is that when you're
going through a lot of labs or follow
alongs you'll hear the instructor say go
to the ec2 console go to the stagemaker
console go to the RDS console what
they're telling you is to go type the
the name of the service and go to um
that particular Services console okay uh
some adus service consoles will act as
an umbrella console containing many adus
services so uh you know VPC console ec2
console systems manager console Sage
maker console uh cloudwatch console
these all contain multiple services so
you know for um for ec2 you might say
okay well I need a security group
there's no security group console it's
under the ec2 console okay uh so just be
aware of
that
[Music]
so now I want to show you some of the
service consoles to kind of distinguish
how they might vary per per service okay
so if we were to look up
ec2 um and we just did look at this but
the interesting thing is that some uh
consoles the ec2 console uh is the home
for other databus services and you just
have to learn this over time to know
that so for instance elastic Block store
is its own service but it's tightly uh
linked to ec2 instances so that's why
they always have have it here same thing
with Amis uh security groups same thing
with that so these are interesting
because these are basically part of
virtual networking and so you'd think
they'd be under the VPC console but they
are actually under here with ec2 and so
load balancing autoc scan groups tightly
coupled to um uh to ec2 if we make our
way over to
VPC um you know here it's going to
contain all the new stuff does it have a
new experience no I guess this is the
newest one
it looks a bit old and a little bit new
here but you know we have a lot of
different things here like firewalls
vpns Transit gateways traffic mirroring
we make our way over to
cloudwatch okay and cloudwatch has uh
very uh focused Services they're all
actually named and this is more like a s
feels more like a single service where
you have these very focused um Services
where you have alarms logs metrics
events insights right but you're going
to notice that like the UI highly VAR
so we had looked at cloudwatch and then
we had looked at U VPC and it looks like
this and then we looked at ec2 and it
looked like that and so there is
inconsistencies because each um Service
uh Team like that work on per service or
whatever they have full control over
their UI and so some of them are in um
uh different states of updating so some
people might have updated the left-and
column but this part is old or you might
click around like under something else
like ec2 dashboard um or maybe a better
example might be Amis I remember we're
in here and something looked old here
yeah see these are the old buttons and
that's just how it is so everything is
very uh modular and so they get updated
over time so that is the challenge that
you're dealing with you're always having
like three different versions that are
cobbled together in each uh um UI one
thing that I found really interesting is
that um VPC has its own console
Management console but if you were to
look up this in the uh the SDK so if I
was to look up um AB
SDK
ec2 okay I'm just looking up Ruby here
as an example because that's what I know
how to do um if you look under here
let's say you want to pragmatically work
with vpcs you think that it would have
its own top level VPC because it has in
the console its own uh its own
Management console but actually VPC is
tightly coupled ec2 and so when you want
to programmatically use VPC you're going
to be um using actually ec2 uh as as was
built so the the the what I'm trying to
get is the apis don't onetoone match
with this kind of stuff and so it's just
kind of interesting that there's those
kind of uh differences uh but again it's
not that big of a deal I'm just trying
to say like you know keep your mind open
when you're look at the stuff
[Music]
okay so every ad ofus account has a
unique account ID and the account ID can
be easily found by dropping down the
current user in the global navigation
so what I'm going to do is pull my pen
tool here and just show you it's right
there the ab account ID is composed of
12 digits and so it could look like this
or this or this account ID is used when
logging in uh with a nonroot user
account uh but generally a lot of people
like to set their own Alias because it's
tiring to remember your account uh ID
the uh you use it when you're creating
cross account rol so you'd have the
target account the source account ID to
gain access to resources in another a
account when you're uh dealing with a
support es a will commonly ask you what
your account ID is so they can identify
the account that they want to look at
and it is generally good to keep your
account ID private as it is one of the
many components used to identify an
account for an attack by malicious actor
uh so you don't have to be overly
sensitive with it but you know try to
hide it when you can when it's easy
[Music]
okay all right so let's talk about the
account ID which appears up here in the
top right corner uh where you can get
the account ID it also appears in IM am
so if we go over to IM am and you look
on the right hand side it should show
you the example here it keeps on trying
to take us to the old dashboard that's
fine um but you'll notice that it's over
here and I don't have MFA turned on
because I'm in my IM user account but it
should be turned on on everything that's
given but uh you know I just want to
show you where it is and also where you
might be using it so one example where
you would use you would need to know
your account ID would be something like
creating a cross account policy so I
went here and went to policy and went
create
policy um and we went to maybe it's a
roll I think we actually sorry we want a
cross account account rle it's not the
policy sorry we go here and we say I
want to access something in another A's
account what we have to do is specify
the account ID specify the accounts that
can use this role so you give I think
the the ID of the other account okay
okay and so that is one place where You'
use it another place would be when
you're creating policies so if I go back
to policies here I can create a policy
here and I can just choose something
like S3
okay and I'll just choose a list and
under the request
conditions I might specify I think the
account ID it should be in
here um I know I can limit based on
account
ID principal
account so you can do principal account
so if I just looked up this here ABS
principal
account and you just got to get used to
Googling things that's always what's
happening here and so we should be able
to specify an account ID yeah like that
so that would be the principle there so
if I just took that and doesn't matter
what it is we just put the value in here
uh um string equals this add I should be
able to go over here and now see the
full statement no sometimes that happens
because we don't have it fully filled
out but um yeah so that pretty much
that's pretty much how we use it like it
would normally show up as that so if I
just go ahead and go next the policy
contains an error you are required to
choose a
resource what do you mean the resource
is this right oh down here okay sorry uh
so we'll just say all resources then we
split over now it's valid and so here we
can see our condition saying only from
this account ID that it is allowed um
other places we're going to see account
IDs are in um ARS right so if we had an
ec2 instance we don't have one launched
right now but if I was to go ahead and
oh maybe we have some prior ones yeah so
if I was to checkbox this
here and you might not have any prior
ones so there might not be nothing for
you to see but if you look for the arm
AR where is our
AR sometimes it doesn't show the Arn in
the services sometimes it does I wish
that AB always showed the AR to make our
lives a bit easier but it could be
because of other reasons why but even
though we don't have the AR I think it
shows us shows us the owner ID and so
that's the account uh the account ID
number you can tell because it's 12
digits so hopefully that gives you kind
of a tour of the account ID and what its
purpose is in the out
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look at it
tools for Powershell so what is
Powershell Powershell is a task
Automation and configuration management
framework is a command like shell and a
scripting language so here it is over
here uh if you are a Windows user you're
used to seeing this because it has a big
blue window so unlike most shells which
accept and return text Powershell is
built on top of the net common language
runtime CLR accepts and returns the net
objects so uh adus has a thing called
the itus tools for Powershell and this
lets you interact with the itus API via
Powershell commandlets commandlets is a
special type of command in Powershell in
the form of the capitalized verb and
noun so in this case it'd be new hyphen
S3 bucket so you know we looked at the a
CLI and that is generally for bash um uh
you know shells and so power shell is
just another type of shell that's very
popular and I just wanted to highlight
it for those people that are uh you know
used to using Microsoft workloads or
Azure workloads uh that this actually
exists
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look at the
Powershell tools um I actually haven't
used this one yet so I'm kind of curious
I am out a Windows machine so if I was
to um open CM or
Powershell and you probably can't see
this but if I just bring this over here
if I type in Powershell on my
computer you'll notice that I have it um
so that's how You' launch it looks like
a blue screen here okay um if you're on
a Mac you're not going to have that but
that's totally fine we don't need to
have a Windows machine to use Powershell
because we can go ahead and use cloud
shell so make sure you're in a region
that supports Cloud shell so I switch
back to North Virginia uh this is not
important for the exam but it's just
kind of fun for me to go through this
with you and if you just like want to
watch uh here and so I want to change
this over to power shell so I imagine
that it must be over
here um so how do we change change to
poers Shell so we'll type in ads power
or ads Cloud
shell Powers shell like how do we do
it okay and so I'm just going to scroll
down
here so the following shells are
pre-installed uh The Bash the power
shell the Z shell you can identify them
by that yeah of course to switch to New
Shell enter the Shell's program name in
the command line prompt oh wow that's
easy so um if we want
pwsh do we just just type pwsh let's
find
out give it a moment to think oh there
we go okay so now we're using Powershell
and so I would think that ads would give
this pre-installed for us so if we go
over here to the instructions and we
scroll on down there's probably like oh
wait like I don't use Powershell a lot
it's very easy to install modules um
I've done it before but I never remember
how to do it but let's just see what we
can find here so I want the
documentation for Powershell here and
I'm going to go to the um the maybe the
reference here because I just want to
see some examples for the commandlets
and so we'll look for S3 again never
done this before but I'm always great at
jumping uh into these things and all I
want to do is just list out the buckets
so I'm going to just search for the word
list um and just see if I can find
something very simple
here and calls to get the list buckets
API operation so I think that is what
we're going to to be doing here so I'm
going to click into that
okay and then from there what I'm going
to do is just see if I can copy this
command so we will go ahead and copy
this and paste it in here and I like how
we got this little shell here so we can
tweak it so we need the bucket name but
I don't want to return a list of all the
buckets owned by the author so we don't
have a bucket name that we want to
explicitly set here so it's required
false so we can remove that
okay we'll look at the next one select
required fals use the select command to
control the command L output the default
is bucket specifying selectable result
in returning all the whole
buckets for that specifying the name uh
but it says it's not required so let's
just take that out as well I don't think
we need any of these actually let's just
go and put that in there and I think
that there must be something we need to
put in front of that right let's just
see what happens
uh the term is not recognized as the
name of the commandlet function script
is operable so I think we're missing
something in front of
here we'll go to the user guide here
quickly and we'll get to the getting
started I just want a super simple
example
here new bucket get bucket well let's
try this one here because they have it
here and so it should work
right I'm change this to us East
one the term new bucket is not
recognized as the name of the commandlet
function so I'm guessing that the
commandlet is not installed I would have
thought that they would have installed
it by default so I guess what we'll do
is look at how to install it so
installing
on Linux I
suppose
so you can install the modulized version
of the Powershell on computers to
install adus tools on Linux pwsh to
start Powershell core session so I guess
that's how you must start it on Linux
and then install the module this way so
yeah I said it's easy to install these
things we'll hit
enter cross your fingers hope this works
hope this is
fast I'm just going to take a look here
peek forward here if you are not uh if
you're notified the repository is UN
trusted you're asked if you want to
trust anyway just hit Y so we're waiting
for that here um you're installing this
module from untrusted repository it's
funny that it's untrusted by but it's by
AWS maybe that's some kind of drama
between Microsoft not letting AWS have
an official module there but it looks
like it should be installed now so if I
type in get S3 bucket
here um unless I typed it wrong that
still doesn't seem to be working if I go
up here and try to create a new bucket
still does not recom recognize the
command command lit here so there must
be more going on
here
um if you are notified you can now
install the module for each
service okay well what did we
do you're installing the the the modules
from unrusted if you trust it change the
uh change it installation policy value
by running set policy command are you
sure you want to install this module
from the PS Gallery so I said yes and I
gave it a capital Y and it didn't do
anything else
so oh hold on here so this is the
installer and then here is the actual
tool that we want to install so it
install to oh so we just installed this
thing and now we use this thing to
install S3 okay great not hard
okay and so we'll just say yes to
all and so that's going to install I
guess everything oh we said ec2 and S3
three well we didn't need both but
that's fine and so what I'm going to do
is go get bucket and so now recognize it
it lists out the items here we can go
and create ourselves a new bucket so
we'll do that okay we'll make our way
back over the databas Management console
we'll go to S3 just because I don't need
all these buckets lying around here and
I'm going to go ahead and delete some of
these buckets here so we'll say
delete my bucket great and we'll go to
this one here and say delete
my bucket
excellent all right and so we have an
idea how to use Powershell so Powershell
is just really popular because of it's
the way you do inputs it's very
standardized and the outputs that come
so it's very popular um and a very
powerful scripting tool that's or CLI
tool as well so uh you know hopefully
that's that was interesting for you but
what we'll do is just close these off
here and go back to our our homepage
always just clicking that logo there and
there we
go
[Music]
so Amazon resource names uniquely
identify itus resources and orangs are
required to specify resource and
Ambiguously across all a of all of AWS
so the AR has the following format
variations so there's a few different
things here but just notice here that
sometimes it has a resource ID or it has
a path so with a resource type or could
be separated by a colon so the partition
um could either be ads China or gov
Cloud because this is basically the ads
uh portal or URL that are completely
separated from each other uh as we
talked about those earlier in the course
uh then there's the service identifier
so ec2 S3 IM am pretty much every
service has their own uh service that uh
name here that would be identified then
the region would be pretty obvious Us
East one CA Central 1 you'd have a
account ID which would be 12 digits uh
the resource ID uh could be a name or a
pass so like for um IM IM users we have
user Bob the this is an E2 instance and
most of the IRS are accessible via the
Aus Management console and you can
usually click the Arn to copy to your
clipboard so here is it is for um an S3
bucket and notice that it's a little bit
different because it is a global Service
AWS there's no reason to specify the
region or the account ID or uh anything
else there like the resource type so
straight away we already know it's a
bucket so we can just say my bucket so
that one's really short but in other
cases it's really long so here it is for
a load balcer and it has all the
information there and notice that like
this has a pass load balcer app my
server will be and then it has the ID
okay for paths and IRS they can also
include uh a wild card Aster and we'll
see these like with IM policies or or
paths these are really useful when you
are doing um uh policies where you have
to specify n you want to say a group of
things and things like that so there you
[Music]
go all right so now let's take a look at
Amazon resource name or also known as AR
um and so ARS are used to reference
objects they're very commonly used when
you're using the CLI or the SDK to
reference to something um the easiest
example is S3 right so we go over to S3
here and we create ourselves a new
bucket um so I'll go ahead and create
ourselves a new one here we say my new
bucket I'm just going to put a bunch of
numbers in here doesn't matter we'll hit
create bucket and what we will see if we
click into this is the AR should be
under
properties and there it is okay so there
are many cases where you might want to
use the AR and a lot of times you'll
just copy it and uh a very common
example would be again with I am
policies so we go over to I am policies
right and I want to get to policies here
just save myself some trouble and we
create a
policy you know I might want to restrict
someone to use only that bucket so I say
S3 okay and then I'm going to say um I
want to be able to read and write from a
particular bucket we go drop down these
resources here and so here we have a lot
of
options um maybe I'll just get rid of
the read
option and I'm going to actually expand
right because it's just creating too
much work for me here and I just want to
have um put put object that's that's the
what we use to put something into a
bucket so we expand the resource here
and notice this says add the irn so we
go here
and we could type the bucket name so do
that or we just paste it on in here at
the top so it's probably easier just to
grab it
sometimes but if you don't know an AR a
lot of times you can just expand this
and then fill it in and that's how you
get an Arn so put that there let's list
oh you can also do it that way which is
easier too and so now if I go to Json is
it valid there we go so here it's saying
um this policy allows somebody to put an
object into this particular bucket and
so that would be an example where we
would use um an AR okay or if you're
doing uh if you're using uh ad support
you might have to use an AR to um to get
help from support saying hey look at
this particular resource exactly here
and then the the cloud support engineer
can help you
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the itus
command light interface but before we do
that we got to Define some terms so what
is a CLI so a command line interface
processes commands to a computer program
in the form of lines of text operating
system Implement a command line
interface in a shell okay so then we
have a terminal so a terminal is a text
only interface so it has input output
environment then you have a console this
is the physical computer to physically
input information into a terminal then
you have the shell a shell is the
command line program that users interact
uh with uh to input commands popular
shell programs are bash uh zsh
Powershell and you might remember this
one MS DOS prompt so
this has been around for obviously a
very long time so maybe this kind of
primes your mind for what is a shell and
just so you know people commonly
erroneously use terminal shell or
console to generally describe
interacting with a shell so if we say
shell or console or terminal we're just
talking about the same thing but there
is technically a difference between
these three things but most people do
not care and I wouldn't worry about it
too much okay so now let's take a look
at the itus command line interface which
allows you to pratically interact with
the itus API via entering single or
multi line commands into a shell and
then here I say or terminal but really
it's just the shell okay so uh here is
an example of one so we're trying to
describe uh ec2 instances and then we're
getting the output because we asked to
have it back in this table like view so
the ab is a python executable program so
python is required to install the aw CLI
the a CLI can be installed on Windows
Mac Linux Unix the name of the ca
program is AWS you'll notice that up
here in the top left corner there's a
lot more to this but this is all we need
for now
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the abis
CLI and the easiest way to get started
with this is actually via the cloud
shell so you'll notice this little icon
here in the top right corner that is
cloud shell and it's going to allow us
to um uh programmatically do things
without having to set up our own
environments so if I just click that
there okay uh and I say do not show
again close and by the way if you don't
see Cloud shell here it could be your
region so like if I go to Canada Central
it doesn't have it there and so if I was
to search Cloud shell
here okay it's going to say it's only
supported in those regions so that's a
bit annoying but once Cloud shell loads
it already has our uh credentials loaded
within our account and so this is going
to save us a lot of time in terms of uh
you know trying to get set up with the
exception that you have to wait for this
environment to create so it takes a
little bit of time time but it's not
that bad um and while that is waiting
what I'll do is show you actually how
you install the CLI yourself so if we
typed in Abus CLI
install all right and uh we went here
the way you would install I believe it's
a python library but if we went to
version two and we just said Linux uh
you go down here they have instructions
so you just curl it unzip it and do
that um so you know if it's this and
then once it's installed you'll have the
of the CLI commands this is still go so
you know maybe I can show you what it
would be like to install the CLI by hand
so if we wanted to do that one easy way
to do this is if we just go to GitHub
doesn't matter what repository I'm just
looking for anything here and if I open
up git pod so if we go on the top here
and type in git pod
uh. maybe
that I just want to see
whoops maybe just get
pods
that oh get pod you're not giving me oh
you know what it's doio that's why okay
so if we go back here sorry and we type
in
doio what this will do is launch me a
temporary environment and so this is
outside of AWS so I'd actually have to
install the CLI so this would be a great
opportunity to show you how to install
the CLI I'm just doing it this way
because git pod is free to use and um
you know it's going to set up an
environment and how let us simulate
installing the CLI so here is the CLI
here I'm going to see if I can bump up
the font
um let's make the font as large as we
can go light or dark dark sounds good to
me and so if we type in
AWS I give it a moment we can see that
we have uh the command here so if I say
ABS S3 LS whoops it should be able to
list things out in a bucket so this is
what's currently in the bucket if you're
wondering how do I know what these
commands are I can just type in a CLI
commands Okay and if we go here um and
we go to the CLI reference reference
then we have um anything we want here
right so we go down here and I just want
to see what's running in S3 and I go
here and I scroll on down it's going to
show me commands like copy move remove
sync uh MB RB uh list
right and if you're looking for a
particular command you go down and say
okay I'll look at LS here and it will
explain to me all the little options
that we can do with it and then it will
always give me examples right so I can
see examples like that so if I wanted to
move something into an S3 bucket so
let's say I want to create a new S3
bucket um we'll type in a ss3 and just
hit enter and it should tell
us um the sub commands may if I do like
help like
this and if we scroll on down so I guess
it just pulls up documentation let's
hoping it would give us like a tiny
summary okay so what we can do here
because I want to create a
bucket type in like
buckets if you don't know something you
just go a S3 C create bucket we'll go
here um and then what I do is I always
just go to examples here so we have a S3
API create bucket and I know it's
unusual there's an S3 and there's an S3
API I don't know why that is but it's
always been that way and I I just don't
question it anymore and so here I can go
ahead and create a new bucket so I'll
just go ahead and paste that command in
I do want to change it up a bit here
because this name could be that has to
be unique so just to make sure I get
what I want I'm putting random numbers
in here we're going to choose the region
as us East one if I wanted to do other
things here I could scroll up and look
at some Flags here
so uh it looks all fine to me so I think
I'll go back here and just
hit uh
paste okay and so it created that bucket
for me if I go over to S3
and we'll wait here a moment we can see
that bucket now exists if I wanted to
place something in that bucket what I
can do is just like touch a file so I'll
just say um touch touch is a Linux
command to make just an empty file so
we'll say um
hello.txt and then it would be a S3
um it would be SP to copy it and I'm
going to give it the local path
hello.txt and then I need to give it the
bucket address so would be
S3 slth bucket name so we named it this
I'm not going to try to type that in by
hand because it's too hard and then I
want to say where I want to put this
file so I'm going to say hello.txt and
if I'm right that should work as
expected and so it says I uploaded that
file I make my way back over to S3 I
refresh there is the file if I want to
copy this file back locally um all I
have to do I'm just going to remove I'm
going to delete the original hello txt
file LS to show you that there's nothing
there and what I need to do oops is just
revert this so instead of saying the
address
here we can go and type in
hello.txt and if I do LS there's the
file if you don't know what the address
is of the bucket um a lot of times you
can go here and find it so it should be
because they're always changing this UI
on me but we'll go to properties here
and there that's the
AR
uh usually a good way to find it is if
you go into an actual object so if you
go here it'll give you the full URL so I
could have grabbed that and I could have
just pasted that in there um but you
know you learn after time it's not hard
to remember this S3 Co SL the unique
name I do want to show you how to
install it by hand so here I'm in git
pods um I'm not sure how I can change
this to a dark theme so I really don't
like this on my eyes we'll go down below
here to color
theme and we'll say get dark there we go
and so this is a temporary workspace so
when I close it it'll be gone so that'll
be totally fine and so I'm going to type
in AWS to see that it's not installed
we're going to go over here this runs
Linux by default so I already know that
I'm going to use Linux we want to use
version two here um
so for the latest version use this
command for a specific version no we
just want the generic one so I'm going
to go ahead and copy this whoops yes
allow we'll paste that in we'll hit
enter okay then we'll take the next
command paste that in hit enter we'll go
take the next command
here we'll hit
enter you can now run uh AWS so we type
AWS and there's the command so uh the
only thing is that if we do ads S3 LS
it's not going to work because we don't
have any credentials set so we'll give
it a moment to think so it says unable
to locate credentials you can configure
credentials by running ads configure so
we type in ad
configure and by the way if this font is
too small I believe I can bump it up
like
this not a great way to do it but um it
works and so it says ads access key ID
so what we can do is go over to IM
am and what I'm looking for is my
particular user over
here and if you remember when we first
created our account it generated out
access keys I go to security credentials
and so we have a key here but I need the
secret so this key is useless to me so
I'm going to go ahead and deactivate
it just because I don't even want this
key and I'm going to create myself a new
key so I'm going to have an access ID in
secret when ever you generate these out
never ever ever ever ever show anyone
what these are these are your yours and
yours alone okay so this is cloud shell
we're fine we're just going to close
that for now and I'm going to go back
over to get pods here and hit enter so
that's the ID I'm going to go grab the
secret hit enter paste and I want it to
go to us East one to save myself some
trouble uh you can change the output
from Json to tables I'm going to leave
it as the default here and so now if I
type ABS S3
LS I get a list and so if I want to grab
that file there I'm going to grab that
S3 U and we type in a S3 API or sorry
it's just LS sorry or sorry C
and we're going to paste that link in
and we're going to say
hello.txt and I must have done the
command wrong it's because we're missing
S3 here I just hit up on the keyboard to
get that command back and so I type in
LS for list and I mean I have some other
code here so you know again any repo you
want on GitHub it doesn't really matter
uh but you'll see there is that file
probably shouldn't have used this one
because it makes a bit of a
mess um but yeah it's pretty
straightforward just to one thing to
show you is where those credal are
stored so by default they're going to be
stored in um it's going to be in the
hidden directory in your root or your
home directory called ad. credentials so
if I just do like LS here you can see
there's a config file and a credentials
file cat lets me print out the contents
of that file so I go here and it's
saying the default region is Us East one
this is a tomble file even though it
doesn't have a do toml on the end of it
I just know by looking at it that's what
it is config lets you set uh defaults
that are going to apply to all of your
credentials and then uh within the
credential file here is the actual
credentials so if you wanted to just set
them you could go in here and just set
them in here you can also set multiple
credentials so if I go here and I'm
going to open up and buy because I'm not
sure how to open it up here in the main
one but if you wanted multiple accounts
you do like exam Pro and then you just
repeat these with different keys right
and then when you wanted to use an a CLI
command actually I'm going to go back
here for a
second
okay and if you want to um and by the
way I'm using VI never use Vim it's it's
a bit tricky to use uh you might want to
use Nano instead if you're if you're
kind of new to this um because this will
use like regular key key cuts and then
down below it shows you what it is so
this is like control X or alt X alt X
NOP control X there we go um but anyway
so if I go into this file and I delete
the original one right and now I try to
do
um this command here even though we
already have that file it should either
hang or complain I Could Just Kill that
by doing control C if I do ads S3
LS notice that it's hanging so unable to
locate credentials because there's no
default one but if I go and I put
profile and I say exam
Pro all right it it'll now use that
profile so that's the way we do it um
but hopefully that gives you kind of a a
crash course into the CLI um so yeah
there you go okay so I'm just going to
go ahead and close these off you can
delete this bucket if you don't want it
it's probably a good idea to delete this
here and I'm just going to say
permanently delete
okay very very good okay close that off
and yeah that's the introduction to the
CL so yeah there you
go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at software
development kits uh so a software
development kit or SDK is a collection
of software development tools and one
installable package so you can use the
AWS SDK to programmatically create
modify delete or interact with aabus
resources so the aabus SDK is offered in
a variety of programming languages so we
have Java python node.js Ruby go.net PHP
JavaScript C++ and so here would be an
example of some Ruby code where we are
creating ourselves um an S3 bucket so
we're just uploading a file there
[Music]
okay okay so now what I'm going to do is
show you how to use the itus SDK and so
uh to do that uh we're going to need
some kind of IDE um a a basically code
editor and so we had looked at get pods
which is a third party service and
that's fine but let's take a look at
Cloud9 because that is built into AWS so
if I just type in Cloud9 here and go
over to IDE I'm going to launch myself a
new environment so I'll hit create I'm
going just say my SDK
environment EnV if you if you have our
time typing environment like me and we
have some options so create a new C2
instance for direct access create it via
assistance manager run a remote with SSH
I'm going to leave it as the default
then we have the option to choose what
size I want to leave it on T2 micro
because that is the free tier then we're
going to scroll on down we have Amazon
Linux 2 Linux Ami I'm going to stick
with Amazon Linux 2 and we can have it
turn off after 30 minutes a great option
for us here and we'll go ahead and hit
next and we'll hit create
environment and so we're going to have
to wait a little bit for this to launch
it'll take a few minutes as that is
going let's go to Google type in adus
SDK um to get to the main page and so
the idea here is that there are a bunch
of different languages you can use C++
go Java javascript. net node.js PHP
Python and Ruby uh and so I'm a really
big fan of Ruby I've been using Ruby
since 2005 and so that's what we're
going to do it in it's also really easy
to use and it's a really great language
so um you know down below it's just
showing you that there's all these
different things but if we go down to
the SDK here and we click on
Ruby we we have examples where we have
the developer guide the API reference
and so this tells you how to get started
even here it's saying like hey go get
started with Cloud9 which is great as
well I suppose um and so here it might
show you how to install it um and when
we open up the API references this is
what it looks like so a lot of times
when I want to do something I know it's
like I want to do something with S3 so I
scroll on down here and I look for
S3
right and then I just kind of like uh
scroll around and look you know what I
mean sometimes you have to expand it go
into the client every API is a slight
different so you do have to kind of
figure out how to navigate that I'm
actually under S3 right now so I'm
looking for the client and I just know
this for memory that this is where it is
so first you create yourself a client
and then you can do API operations so if
I wanted to like list
buckets I just search the word list and
I just scroll on down and there it is I
click into that and I have an example of
how to list a bucket so I'm going to go
back to Cloud9 and it is ready and it
started in dark mode um if yours is not
in dark mode which really honestly why
wouldn't you want dark mode mode um if
we go up to I think it's like file where
is it preferences here got to C the
Cloud9 option and I'm just seeing if it
like remembers my settings I really like
two two soft tabs here but uh there
should be something for themes down
below and
so
um that doesn't seem like that's it used
to be like a oh here it is if you go
here and just choose like whatever you
want I'm on jet dark here and so if it's
on classic light or something you don't
like you can fix that there um but I'm
just going to go here and just fiddle
with my
settings because I really like to use
Vim uh keys I don't recommend this if
you are uh to change this if you are not
a programmer but I'm just going to
change it so that I can type here
efficiently so I'm just looking for the
option
here and they moved it on me where did
they move
it probably be like key
bindings ah bin mode there we go again
don't do that this is just for me so I
can uh move around in a different way so
what I want to do and by the way it
looks like this default screen we could
have just changed it here I just clicked
through all that for nothing was here
the entire time but um what we need is
we need to make sure that we have our
credentials so if we type in OS um S3 LS
that's like my sanity check that I
always like to do to make sure I have
credentials notice that we didn't have
to set up any credentials it was already
on this machine which was really nice
and so I'm going to create a new file
here and it's okay if you don't know
anything about Ruby we're just going to
have fun here and just follow along so
I'm going to do example. RB I'm going to
make sure Ruby's install by doing Ruby
Hy and V so it is install which is great
uh you need a gem file so say new gem
file
here and if we go back to the
installation guide uh we need the gem
SDK
here actually I'm going to look at how
to generate a gem file gem file because
there's some stuff that goes to the top
of those files like this
here I think we just need this line here
so I'm just going to grab that whoops
paste that in allow
good and uh I you can do gem ads SDK
that will install everything but uh we
only want to work
with S3 and so this is going to vary
based on each language but I know that
if we type in S3 we'll just get S3 and
that's all we really need and so once we
have that what we'll need to do is use a
bundle install so we're going to make
sure we're in the correct directory I'm
going to type in LS down below notice
the gem file is there and by the way if
the fonts are too small I should
probably bump those up let's see how we
can do
that uh editor size font user
settings good luck trying to find a
day um project
no you think it'd have to be under user
settings right
ah here it is okay so um this is
for probably the editor so we'll go to
18 here Co code editor
here I'm I'm trying to find the one for
the terminal probably over
here there we
go much easier okay so notice we have
example. RB and Gem file so we're in the
correct directory make sure I save that
I'm going to type in bundle
install that's going to install the gems
give it a moment there it's going to
fetch notice that installed um the ads
sdks S3 and everything that it was
dependent on and so now if we go over to
our example. RB file really when you're
coding for the cloud you can pretty much
copy paste everything so over here we
found this code here for S3 list buckets
um so I'm going to go ahead and paste
that on in okay and I know it looks
really complicated but we can quickly
simplify this so I know that this is
just the output so I don't need that
okay and in Ruby you don't need
parentheses or curlies if uh if you
don't have any things there and so all I
need to do is Define a client so if I
click uh if I go to the top here of this
file I think we're in the client right
now all the way to the top all the way
to the top
here that's what we need
okay and so I'm going to paste that in
now uh we can set the region here so I'm
going to say Us East
one right and then you'd have your cred
um because the credentials are on the
machine in the um uh credentials file
they're going to autoload here I believe
so I don't think I need to set them so
I'm just going to take that out here for
a
second okay and I can do this if I want
this is just slightly different syntax
it might be easier to read if I do it
this way for
you okay and I don't need double client
there so we have the client I like to
name this like S3 so I know what it is
and I put puts for the response FS I'm
going to do
inspect and so puts is like print okay
and so now if I type in bundle exact
let's just make sure that it's in the
context of our bundler file Ruby
example. RB um we have a syntax error on
this line here unexpected thing
here oh it's because of this it's
because I commented out so I'm just
going to do curly parentheses comment
out
here
okay actually to make it a bit easier
I'm just going to bring this down like
this okay and we'll paste that
there okay and we'll try this
again un initialized constants ad to oh
yeah we have to require it so we have to
require ABS SDK S3 I think we'll hit
up and uh we got a struck back so it is
working we are getting an object back if
we want to play around with this a bit
more I'm just going toall another gem
called pry pry allows us to um inspect
code so we're going to do bundle install
and I'm going to go back to Ruby here
I'm going to put a binding pry in
here and then if I hit up and I do
bundle EXA Ruby example.
RB um I installed it right B install
yes undefine method
pry oh because I have to require it
again bad habit here
okay we'll hit up and so now I have an
interactive shell and I can kind of
analyze that object so we have a
response so if I type in RSP here I have
the structure object I can type in
buckets here okay and it's showing me a
bucket I can give it get its
name
um oh I think it's an array so I think
I'd say like I'd say like zero here or I
could say first this is just the how the
Ruby language works we say name I get
the name creation date okay so you get
the idea whatever you want to do you
know you search for it you just say I
want to delete a bucket I want to create
a bucket right and you look for it so I
say create bucket here I click on this
and I can see the options and they are
always really good about giving me an
example and then down below they always
tell you all the parameters that you
have there so that's how the SDK Works
uh but yeah the credentials were uh soft
loaded here but you could easily provide
them yourself I should just show you
that before anything else just cuz
there's some variations there
um and I'm just trying to look for it
because it is separate
code so you could do this this is one
way of doing it so you could do it
separate from the code so if you only
wanted to configure it
once right because you could you could
have a lot of clients you wouldn't want
to keep on like for each client you
wouldn't want to put region in every
time so I could take this and put this
right here
okay and this this is the file here
where we have the credentials so this
would be our um our access key and our
ID and so you never want to put your
code directly just in here so if I open
up if you go cat you would never want to
do this but I'm just going to show as an
example
here uh
credentials oops I got to get out of
this
exits
credentials oh do they not even show it
on this machine which would be smart we
wouldn't really want to see our
credentials here uh hit up say
LS oh no it's there
okay cat
whoops
credentials there it is okay so you know
if we look here we can see that there
are credentials set it's a little bit
different we have this like session
token I guess it's to make sure that
this expires over time but if I was to
take these okay and I was just to paste
them in
here
that's one way you would do it um you
never ever want to do this ever ever
ever ever you never want to do this
because you'll end up committing that to
your code um so this is really dirty to
do so I don't ever recommend to do it um
if you wanted to have this apply to
everything you could put it up here and
so now when we call the client we don't
have to do it um of course if the
they're loaded on the machine you don't
have to do it the other thing is like if
you if you want you could load them in
Via environment variables that's usually
what you want to do so you say adabs uh
access
key right and then we say environment
databus access
secret and so you'd set those by doing I
think it's like an
export um environment
variables set in Linux you think I know
after like 15 years of doing this but I
never remember so you type in export so
you go down into oops here you type in
export and you just say something like
I'm going to just show an example to see
if it works so I'm going to say hello
world okay and if I do uh hello like
that Echo see it prints it out so that's
how you would set it you'd set those
there but there's actually very specific
ones that aabus uses for um the API and
it's these ones here so you always want
to use
those okay so you put that in
there and that in there but of course
you know like if they're already set in
your machine you don't have to even
specify those cuz it would autoload
those environment variables I don't
think they're set right now if we type
in Echo just take a look here is are
they going to get autoloaded
here no so but anyway so we could go
here just as an
example and well actually they just show
them right here so you see your access
key but we go and we type in um
export and I'm going to paste the key in
there and I'm going to go to the the
front of it we're typee adus access key
ID
equals enter and so now if I did echo on
this ads access key ID okay shows up but
I just want to show you how it can kind
of vary and those conditions around it
so yeah that is the adus SDK um and yeah
a lot of times you're just copying
pasting code and just kind of tweaking
it you're not really writing uh real
programming okay so hopefully that is
less intimidating so I'm just going to
close these off and I want to close down
this Cloud9 environment
um I might have to reopen this up in
another
Tab and go to the Management console
here and then go over to Cloud9 and just
close this tab and then while go ahead
as and delete this environment oops I'll
just type delete here even if you didn't
it would turn off after 30 minutes and
you have that free tier so it's not that
big of a deal it's up to you whether you
want to use Cloud9 or git pods Cloud9 is
really good because it allows you to um
uh it allows you to uh use it runs on a
virtual machine right so you have a a
container runtime there and so it's very
easy to run containers on it um whereas
in like I've had some issues with G pods
but um yeah those are the two
[Music]
okay let's take a look at adus Cloud
shell which is a browser based Shell
built into the adus Management console
and so Cloud shell is scoped per region
it has the same credentials as the loged
in user and it's a free server so this
is what it looks like and the great
thing about this is that you know if you
have a hard time setting up uh your own
shell or terminal on your computer um or
maybe you just don't have access or
privilege to do so it's just great that
Abus makes this uh available to you and
so what you can do is click the shell
icon up at the top and that will expand
this here some things to note about
Cloud shell is that it has some
pre-installed tools so it has the CLI
python nodejs git make pip pseudo tar
t-x Vim W get vim and more it includes 1
gab of storage free per adus region it
will save your files in a home directory
available for future sessions for the
same Aus region uh and it can support
more than a single shell environment so
it has bash Powers shell and
zsh um and so Adis Cloud shell is
available in select regions so when I
was in my Canada region I was like
where's the little shell icon but I
realize it's limited for some areas
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at
infrastructure as code also known as IAC
and this allows you to write a
configuration script to automate
creating updating or destroying your
Cloud infrastructure the way you can
think of I it's a blueprint of your
infrastructure and it allows you to
easily share version or inventory your
Cloud
infrastructure so adus has two different
offerings for IAC the first is cloud
formation uh a com commonly abbreviated
to CFN and this is a declarative IC tool
and then you have a cloud development
kit commonly known as cdk which is an
imperative IAC tool so let's just talk
about the difference between declarative
and imperative and then we'll look at
these tools a little bit closer uh each
okay so declarative means what you see
is what you get it's explicit it's more
verose but uh there is zero chance of
misconfiguration unless the file so big
that you're missing something uh
commonly declarative files are written
things like Json yaml X ml so for cloud
formation it's just Json and yaml uh and
so that's that side there so for
imperative you say what you want and the
rest is filled in so it's implicit uh
it's less forbose you could end up with
some misconfiguration that's totally
possible uh but it does more than
declarative and you get to use your
favorite programming language maybe
python JavaScript actually cdk does not
support Ruby right now but I just have
that in there just as a general
description of what imperative is
okay
all right so just a quick look at cloud
formation so cloud formation allows you
to write infrastructures code as either
Json or yaml the reason why was adus
started with Json and then everybody got
sick of writing Json and so they
introduced jaml which is a lot more
concise which you see on the right hand
side so cloud formation is simple but it
can lead to large files or is limited in
some regards to creating dynamic or
repeal infrastructure compared to cdk
Cloud information can be easier for
devops engineers who do not have a
background in web programming languages
a lot of times they just know scripting
and this basically is scripting since
cdk generates out Cloud information it's
still important to be able to read and
understand Cloud information in order to
debug IAC Stacks knowing cloud formation
is kind of a cloud essential when you go
into the other tiers of AWS um like
Solutions architect associate
professional or any of the associates
you need to know Cloud information
inside and out
[Music]
okay okay so what I want to do now is
introduce you to infrastructure as code
and so we're going to take a look at
cloud formation and so we were just
using Cloud9 for the STK so we're going
to go back and create ourselves a new
Cloud9 environment because we do have to
write uh some code so I'll go ahead and
hit create here and I'm going to just
say uh CFN that's sort for cloud
formation example and we'll hit next
step and we'll create ourselves a new
environment T2 micro Amazon X2 is
totally fine we'll hit next it'll delete
after 30 minutes we'll be fine we're
within the free tier we're going to give
this a moment to load up um and remember
you can set your theme your your
keyboard mode whatever you want as that
loads and as that's going we're going to
look up cloud formation and so cloud
formation is very intimidating at first
but once you get through the motions of
it it's not too bad um so we'll go to
the user guide here as we always do if
you go to the getting
started it's going to just tell us some
things it's going to read about yaml
files um I don't think I really need to
read much about this here here so I
think we'll just go start looking up
some codes so something that might be
interesting to launch as an ec2 instance
Cloud information so that's what I'll do
is I'll type in what I want so in ec2
instance and I'll just start pasting in
code so if we scroll on down below
here going to go to examples because I
want a small example here this is
something that I might want to do and
we're going to give that a moment here
it's almost
done you can do it ad come on as that is
going I'm going to open a new tab
I'm going to make my way over to cloud
formation
okay and um you can see I have some
older Stacks here notice Cloud9 when we
create an environment actually creates a
cloud formation stack which is kind of
interesting um but if we go here we can
create a stack and we can create a file
and uploaded here
so okay this is good I'm going to go
ahead and make a new file we're going to
call it
template. yaml um just so you know yaml
can be yml or Y ml there's a big debate
as to which one you use um I think that
adabs likes it when you use the full
version so I just stick with
yl I'm going to double click into that
and so in the cc2 example I'm just going
to copy this okay and I'm going to paste
this in
here and I'm going to type in resources
oops
capital okay so that's a resource I want
to create um when you create Cloud
information you always have a template
version so I just
need a basic example here at the
top I guess that's a simple one is like
a Hello World
Bucket maybe we should do a bucket
because it'll be a lot
easier we don't have to make our life
super hard here okay um but what I'm
looking for is the version because
that's the first thing that you
specify I'm just trying to find it
within an example
here oh for freak's sakes cloud
formation
version if I don't have the format
version it's going to complain there it
is okay so we'll copy that we'll go back
over
here we'll paste that in there it might
be fun to do like an output here so I'm
going to do like an out put
outputs and uh maybe instead of doing
this we'll type in ads
S3 C
formation because what I'm looking for
is what we can set as output so we'll
say return values
here
um maybe we just
want Returns the domain
name so we'll just say
um
value ref that that's going to get the
reference for it and we have to say
hello
bucket uh type
string say outputs cloud formation
example and even though I've written
tons of cloud formation it's just like
if you're not doing it on day and day
out you start to forget what it is so
here for outputs we need a logical ID
description value and export
so um that is what I want so I'm going
to go ahead and copy that back
here this is just so that when we run it
we're going to be able to observe an
output from the cloud formation file
okay so the logical ID is whatever we
want so hello bucket
domain it's funny because this is how
you do do um kind of that would be the
format for terraform I was getting the
mixed up so the
domain of the bucket the value here is
going to be ref
hello
bucket domain
name that's the
output export value to
export uh can I get an example
here B
name oh you know what export is for uh
cross Stacks we don't need to do that
okay so that's fine so what we'll do is
set that and we'll take out our old one
and so this should create us an S3
bucket so with Cloud information you can
uh provide a template here by providing
a URL or you can upload a file directly
so um I'm just trying to decide here how
I want to do this you can also use a
sample file or create a template in the
designer I'm going to go over to the
designer because then we can just like
paste in what we want so if I go over to
yes enel here and we go back over here I
copy
this I'm just going to paste this in
here and we're going to hit the refresh
button nobody ever uses the designer but
this is just kind of a easy example for
me to uh place this in
here it's not really working maybe I got
to go to template dude here
refresh there we go so there's our
bucket it's nice to have a little
visualization and I believe this is
going to work as expected so now that we
have our designer template I think if we
hit close what's this button say
validate template probably a good idea
validating the template template
contains errors unresolved resource
dependency uh in the output block of the
template
hello domain
seems like it should be
fine let's go
whoops let's go back over
here that's what I did I said reference
that
value oh uh maybe it's get a trib
okay it's get ATT
sorry get a tri cloud formation can't
remember there's an r on the end of it
oh it's just ATT this is if you're
trying to get a return intrinsic value
so a reference is like what the default
one is but when every time we do like a
logical name and attribute that's how we
get that there so uh what I'm going to
do here is just hit refresh and I'm
going to validate that one more time now
it's valid if I hover over this is going
to upload it create the
stack we could save this save
it oh we can save it an S3 bucket so
we'll say
hello bucket and so now we have this URL
so I'm going to copy it honestly I never
use this editor so it's kind of
interesting I'm going to leave
and we probably could have hit create
stack but I just find it a bit easier if
we just kind of do it through uh this
here so go back create the stack we're
going to paste in the URL we're going to
say
next and we're going to say uh my new
stack and I didn't see what the name of
the bucket was oh there's no name so
it's going to randomize that's perfect
so we'll go next we have a bunch of
options here we'll H hit
next we'll give it a moment here I guess
we have to review it create the stack
and this the part where we watch so it
says create in progress and we wait and
we hit
refresh and we can see what's happening
trying to create a
bucket and if we go to resources this is
this is a lot easier to track because
you can see all the resources that are
being
created if you notice that when you use
the C uh when you're using database
management cons and create S3 bucket
it's instantaneous but like with cloud
there's a bit of delay because there's
some communication going on board but
here it is and notice if we go to our
outputs this is the the value of the
bucket domain name if we were to make it
with uh self-hosting which is not what
we're doing with it we could also have
an export name which would be used for
cross referencing Stacks which is not
something we uh care to do um but yeah
that's how you create a stack that way
um but you know we can also do it via
the SDK here so what I can do um is look
up what is the Adis uh CLI cloud
formation CU they have their own
commands here if I go
here there's a new one and there's an
old one
so if we go create
stack yeah there's things like this like
create stack
update um so if we wanted to do it this
way okay and I copied this here just
going to put this in my read me here for
a second
uh so here what you do is you say my new
stack and you can provide the template
URL or you could specify the local path
here so we have like a template body so
I'm going to go ahead and grab
that okay this would be like
yaml and um I need to specify this file
here so template.
yaml and I'm just going to go PWD here
to get the full path
okay and I'm going just paste that in
there
whoops okay I'm going to do LS okay so
that gives us the full path to the file
we can also specify the template URL um
and so this should work as well if I
take this and paste that on as a
command unable to locate parameter file
oh there's three three triple slashes
there we'll just fix that
there
paste unable to load pram file no such
file directory and there's a t
missing okay be like don't be like me
and make sure you don't have spelly
mistakes okay I can type clear down here
so I can see what I'm doing we'll hit
enter
whoops unable to load the parameter file
no such file or
directory home well I you didn't want
the for slash so another we can try to
do I think it will take it relative so
if I do this it should
work I don't ever remember having to
specify the entire path and error
occurred while calling the create stack
my stack name already exists if I go
back over here give this a refresh oh
that's what we named our stack the the
one that we did so I'm going to say
stack
two
okay template format unsupported
structure when calling the create stack
operation
are you kidding me I do this all the
time template body yaml file cloud
formation unsupported structure take a
look
here oh you know what I think uh this
one's out of date that's why so what we
can do is go to our old stack here and
we can actually see the temp I can go
ahead and copy this whoops and we can go
ahead and paste that in there and then
now what I can
do so you know that's that's the reason
why it wasn't working okay so we'll hit
enter um unsupported
structure it should be
supported let's see if Cloud information
can help us
out um apparently there was very
unhelpful error message formatting so
try the validate template option I
wonder if if we could just do
this maybe if that would help
here I'm just hitting up to try to run
it
again nope I guess we can try to
validate it here it's like I'm not
having much luck here
today so we'll just say this here maybe
it's not even loading that file where it
is so there's no
errors
just going to make this one
line okay created so for whatever reason
I must have had a a bug there and so
putting sometimes putting on one line
helps that out because I must have had
an obvious mistake there and now we can
see the stack is creating it's doing the
exact same thing it's creating a
different bucket though if we go over to
our S3
here again you know you don't need need
to be able to do this yourself to pass
the exam it's just so I'm just trying to
show you like what it is so you kind of
absorb any kind of knowledge about
what's going on here notes down below it
uses the stack name followed by uh the
re The Logical name of the resource
there okay um and what we'll do is wait
for that to create once that's created
we can go ahead and delete these Stacks
we could also use the a cloud
information to say like delete stack but
I don't want to uh bore you with that
today and so we'll hit refresh here wait
for those to
vanish okay those are gone uh what I'm
going to do is kill this Cloud9
environment uh if there's a way to do it
from here I have never known how to do
it go back to your dashboard well that's
nice to know we'll go ahead and just
delete
this okay we'll close that Tab and so
now we are all in good shape and so that
was our introduction to Cloud
information
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at cdk so
cdk allows you to use your favorite
programming language to write
infrastructure as code and technically
that's not true because they don't have
Ruby and that's my favorite but anyway
uh some of the languages include NOS
typescript Python
java.net and so here's an example of
typescript typescript was the first
language that was um introduced for cdk
It's usually the most upto-date so not
always does cdk reflect exactly what's
in cloud formation but I think they're
getting better at that okay so cdk is
powered by cloud formation it generates
out cloud formation templates so there
is an intermediate step it does
sometimes feel a bit slow so I don't
really like that but you know it's up to
you uh cdk has a large library of
reusable Cloud components called cdk
constructs at constructs dodev this is
kind of the concept of terraform modules
and is really really useful uh and
they're really well ridden um and they
can just reduce a lot of your effort
there CD cdk comes with its own CLI um
and I didn't mention this before but
cloud formation also has its own uh uh
CLI okay cdk pipelines uh are are allow
you to quickly set up cicd pipelines for
cdk projects that has a big pain point
for cloud formation where you have to
write a lot of code to do this whereas
um this cdk has that off the bat makes
it really easy for you cdk also has a
testing framework for unit and
integration testing I think this might
be only limited to typescript because I
didn't see any for the rest of the
languages but um you know I wasn't 100%
sure there uh this one thing about cdk
is that it can be easily uh confused
with SDK because they both allow you to
programmatically work with AWS uh using
your favorite language but the key
difference is that cdk ensures uh itap
poent of your infrastructure so what
that means that's such a hard word to
say but what that means is that um you
know if you use this cdk to say give me
an a virtual machine you'll always have
a single virtual machine uh because it's
trying to manage the state of the file
whereas
uh when you use SDK if you run it every
time you'll end up with more and more
servers uh and it's not really managing
States so hopefully that is clear
between the difference
[Music]
there okay so we looked at cloud
formation but now let's take a look at
cdk cloud formation or cloud formation
Cloud development kit it's just like
cloud formation but you use a a
programming language in order to uh
Implement your infrastructure as a code
I don't use it very often I don't
particularly like it but um you know if
you are developer and you don't like
writing Cloud information files and you
want to have something that's more
programmatic you might be used to that
um this I think should be deleting cuz
we were deleting the last one here and
notice how it's grayed out I can't
select it so don't worry about that
create a new one we'll say cdk example
we'll hit next T2 micro ec2 instance
Amazon X2 you know the drill it's all
fine here we're going go ahead and
create ourselves a new environment we're
going to let that spin up there and as
that's going we're going to look up uh
adus
cdk so it was cdk um and we probably
want to go to GitHub for
this okay because it is open source and
so I want to go to getting
started and I have used this before but
I never can remember how to use it
probably the easiest way to uh use this
is by using
typescript
so here's an example initialize a
project make directory cdk oh first we
got to install it right so we give that
a moment so this is you know how we did
like bundle install this is like the
same thing but for uh typescript install
or update the itus cdk CLI from npm we
recommend using this version etc etc so
again we're just waiting for that to
launch but uh as we wait for that it's
very simple we're just going to install
it create a directory um go into that
directory initialize the example here
it's setting up an
sqsq which is um that's quite a complex
example um but you can see it's code
right and then we run cdk deploy and
we'll deploy it and then hopefully we'll
have that
resource so again we're just waiting for
Cloud9 there we go so Cloud9 is more or
less ready a terminal seems like it's
still
thinking and we have a JavaScript one
which I do not care about there we go
there's our environment we're going to
make sure we have mpm so we can type in
mpm great it says version
8.1.0 and so this is asking for
10 okay I don't know if this gives us
like MVM installed MVM it does so what
we can do is do MVM list that stands for
node version manager Ruby has one as
well and so it's telling us what version
we're on I want to update um looks like
we have a pretty uh pretty new version
but what I want is the latest version of
oh but that's node version that's not
necessarily mpm so we'll do node version
Oh 17 okay we're well well in the uh
range of the new stuff so what I'm going
to do is scroll on down we're going to
grab this link here or this uh code here
hit enter and that's going to install
the adus cdk so it
says uh file already exists oh so maybe
it's already installed in the
machine um cdk we'll type in
cdk because of course adus wants to make
it very easy for us this soft has not
been tested with what was that warning
uh with node 1701 you may encounter
runtime issues great AWS you're like the
one that installed this stuff here so we
get a bunch of the commands which is
great and so what we'll do is follow
their simple instructions we'll say
hello
cdk we will CD into
this and um now what we can do is run
cdk andit and this language
here and so that's going to do a bunch
of stuff creates tons of files it's
going to vary based on what you're using
like which language because cdk comes
available in a variety of languages so
if we type in ads
cdk um documentation
here notice up here python java.net so I
think it has more than just those three
languages but um you know I wish it
supported more like yeah see here is C
Java but I I really wish there was a
ruby so we'll give this a moment here to
get installed and I will see you back
here when it is done
okay okay uh it turns out I only had to
wait like a second there but it says
there's a newer version of the cdk you
probably should install it but I just
want to get going here so as long as I
don't run into any issues I do not care
um but anyway so looking at this and I
again rarely ever look at this but I'm a
developer so it's not too hard for me to
figure out but under the lib this is our
stack that we're creating and here is it
is loading in sqs it's loading in SNS
and then the core Library it's creating
an sqs q and it's setting the visibility
of that timeout it's also creating an
SNS topic so those are two resources
that we expect to be created if we
scroll on down to the getting started it
just says cdk deploy so what we'll do is
go ahead and hit enter
and let that do whatever it wants to
do and it is thinking there we go so
here we have IM statement changes so
it's saying this deployment will
potentially make potential sensitive
changes according to your current
security approval options there is there
may be security related changes not in
this list do you want to deploy sure
we'll hit
Y deploying creating Cloud information
change set so cdk is using cloud
confirmation underneath it's not
complicated um and as that is going what
we'll do is we'll make our way over to
our itus amazon.com
console and if we go over to cloud
formation we'll see if we see anything
yet so it's creating a stack here we can
click into it we can go over to our
events see that things are being created
this is always a confusing so I always
go to resources to see what is
individually being created and they're
all done so we go over here and they
exist so here it says that we have a
queue called this right sometimes they
have links you can link through it so
notice here I can click on the topic and
get to that resource in SNS which is
nice for sqs I'm just going to type in
sqs
enter uh and there it is okay so we
don't really understand what those are
we could delete the stack this way
there's probably a cdk way to delete the
stack so uh cdk
destroy I assume that's what it
is destroy okay so we'll type in cdk
Destroy give it a moment we're going to
say
yes okay it's deleting in progress we
can even go back here and double
check
still
thinking and again you know if we
deleted these for real it would take
like a second but uh you know sometimes
they're just
slow sometimes it's because a resource
can get hung as well um but uh I don't
think anything is problem so here we can
see what the problem is not not
necessarily a problem but it's just the
sqs is taking a long longer time to
delete where the SNS subscription is a
lot
faster so I'll just see you back here in
a moment okay okay so after a short
little wait there it finally finished uh
I just kept on refresh until I saw it
deleted and so it's out of there and so
we'll get rid of our Cloud9 environment
since we are done with it so type in
Cloud9 up at the
top and we'll go ahead and delete and we
will go ahead and delete this here thank
you and we will go back to our adabs
amazon. console here just so we can get
our bearing straight here and there we
[Music]
go all right let's take a look here at
the adus toolkit for vs code so adus
toolkit is an open source plugin for vs
code to create debug deploy itus
resources since vs code is such a
popular uh editor uh these days I use
Vim but it's very popular um I figured I
should make sure you're aware of this um
plugin so it can do four things you get
the Abus Explorer this allows you to
explore a wide range of adus resources
linked to your adus account uh and
sometimes you can view them sometimes
you can delete them it's going to vary
per service and what's available there
then you have the adabs cdk Explorer
this allows you to explore your Stacks
defined by cdk uh then you have Amazon
elastic uh container service ECS this
provides intellisense for ECS task
definition files intell sense means that
when you type uh and you uh you'll get
like autoc completion but you'll also
get a description as to what it is that
you're typing out then there is servess
applications and this is pretty much the
main reason to have Theus toolkit allows
you to create debug deploy Serv
applications via S and CFN and so uh
there you can see the command pallet and
you can kind of access stuff there okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at access key so
an access key is a key and secret
required to have programmatic access to
adus resources when interacting with the
adus API outside of the adus Management
console so uh access key is commonly
referred to as adus credentials so if
someone says adab credentials generally
you're talking about the access key not
necessarily your um username and
password to log in so a user must be
granted access to use access key so when
you're creating a user you can just
checkbox access key um you can always do
this after the fact but it's good to do
that as you're creating the user and
then you can generate an access key and
secret so you should never share your
access keys with anyone they are yours
if you give them to someone else is like
giving them the keys to your house it's
dangerous uh never commit access keys to
a codebase uh because that is a good
place uh for it to get leaked at some
point you can have uh two active keys at
any given time you can deactivate access
Keys obviously delete them as well
access Keys have whatever access a user
has to Aus resources so uh you know if
you can do it in databus Management
console so can the key so access keys
are to be stored in the ads. adabs
credentials uh file so um and if you're
not familiar with Linux this Tilda here
this actually represents your home
folder so whether you're on Windows or
Linux that's going to be your home
folder and then you have this period AWS
that means it's hidden folder but you
can obviously access it and so in it
it's just a toml like file I think it's
toml um but I never 100% verified that
it's toml it looks just like toml uh and
so what you'll have here is your uh
default profile and so this is what you
would use um or this is what uh any of
your tools you use like the CLI or
anything else would automatically use if
um if you did not specify a profile you
can of course store multiple access keys
and then give it a profile name um so if
you are doing this for the first time
you might just want to type in ad config
and it'll prompt you and you'll just
enter them in there as well I think
that's set the default one when you're
using the
SDK uh you would rather probably use
environment variables because this is
the safest way to access them when you
are writing code all right um so there
you
[Music]
go all right let's talk about access
Keys access keys are are very important
to your
um and so what we'll do is go to IM if
you are the root user you can go in and
you can uh generate access keys for
people um but generally you're doing it
yourself for your own account so I go to
users I'm going to click into mine here
and we'll go over to Security
credentials and here you're going to
notice access keys and one thing that is
interesting is that you can only ever
have two access keys at a time so if I
hit create I'm just going to close that
notice that the button is gray out I can
uh uh deactivate them if I feel that I
haven't used them in a while and I can
make them active again so I can bring
them back into access or what I can do
is um make them
inactive right and then I can delete
them and so what I recommend right even
if you do not want to programmatically
be using your account for anything you
always want to fill up both these and
the reason why and this is for security
reasons is that if somebody wanted to
come in and uh uh get into your account
what they would do is they would try to
find find a user um where they have
access to them and then they would try
to generate out a key so if both these
keys are taken up so if you generate up
both these
Keys okay and this is the one you want
to use you deactivate the other one okay
we're not going to use that one and so
now there's no way for them to fill up
that other slot okay and so that is my
strong recommendation to you but there's
again only ever two here I'm just going
to uh Delete both of these so that when
we want to uh do what whatever next in a
tutorial we'll go generate that out okay
go ahead and clear that
out so hopefully that is enough for you
to understand what to do with these
access Keys okay so I'm going to go back
here there you
[Music]
go let's take a look here at adus
documentation which is a large
collection of technical documentation on
how to use adus Services which we can
find at doc. adab. amazon.com uh and so
this is kind of like the landing page
where you can see all the guides and API
references if you expand them in there
uh into ec2 and you click on the user
guide you can see HTML in PDF format
Kindle and you'll notice there's a link
to GitHub and that's because all of
these docks are open source and you can
contribute to them if you choose to do
so I've done so multiple times in the
past it's quite fun so adus is very good
about providing detailed information
about every ad service and the basis of
this course and any AD certification
will derive mostly from
uh the adus documentation so I like to
say that I'm not really coming up with
new information I'm just taking what's
in the docs and trying to make it more
digestible and I think that's the thing
is like the docks are really good you
can read them end to end but they are
very dense um and so it can be a bit
hard to figure out what you should read
and what you should not um but uh they
are a really great resource and you
should spend some time in there
[Music]
okay so I just want to quickly show you
the ads documentation like give you a
bit of a tour of it so if we go to ab.
amazon.com and type in docs and I'm sure
you might have seen this through other
tutorials but the idea is that you have
basically documentation for basically
any possible service that you want and a
lot of times you'll click into it and
what you'll get are these little boxes
and they'll show you different guides
and it's going to vary based on service
but a lot of times there's a user guide
there's an API reference those are the
two that you'll see there maybe we go to
something simpler like
S3 that might be a simple example yeah
user guide API API reference and so all
of these are on GitHub right if you open
these up the documentation is here if
you find something you don't like you
can submit issues and uh and correct
things you can even submit your own
examples I have um I have uh committed
uh example code to the uh docs
specifically for AI services so you
might be looking examples that I
implemented or even Ruby examples since
I really like to promote Ruby on AWS you
can as a PDF or you can take it as an
HTML a lot of times you're going to the
user guide and the way I build the
courses here is I actually go through
and I read these end to end so you know
if you wanted to do that and you wanted
to be like me uh you can do that or you
can just watch my courses and save
yourself the trouble and not worry about
everything that is here but generally
the documentation is extremely extremely
good there are some exceptions like
Amazon Cognito where the content is good
but it's just not well organized so I
would say it best out of every other
provider they they have the most
complete documentation uh they generally
don't keep their examples or like
tutorials within here it's usually
pretty light they'll have some examples
um but like they like they have adus
Labs separately so you type Aus Labs
GitHub right you go here and a lot of
stuff is in here instead so you have a
lot of great tutorials and examples over
there okay um but yeah pretty much
that's all there is to it is there
consistency between documentations no
they kind of vary um you know but uh
it's all there is my point and they're
always keeping up to date so yeah that's
all you need to know about the inabus
[Music]
documentation hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam Pro and we are taking a look
at the Shared responsibility model which
is a cloud security framework that
defines the security obligations of the
customer versus the cloud service
provider in this case we're talking
about AWS and they have their own shared
responsibility model it's this big ugly
blob here um and the thing is is that
every single CSP has their own variant
on the model uh so they're generally all
the same but some visualizations make it
a little bit uh easier to understand or
they kind of uh include a little bit
more information at different parts of
it and so just to get make sure that you
have well rounded knowledge I'm going to
go beyond the aws's shared
responsibility model and just show you
some variants uh there's also variants
not just per uh CSP but also the type of
cloud deployment model and sometimes
these are also scoped uh based on a
cloud service category like compute or
machine learning and these can result in
specialized share responsibility models
so that's what we'll look at in this
section
[Music]
okay all right so let's take a look at
the ad shared responsibility model and
so I've reworked the graphic because it
is a bit hard to uh digest and so I'm
hoping that this way will be a little
bit easier for you I cannot include the
in and of here just because we're
limited for space but don't worry we'll
follow that up with the next slide here
so there are two people that are
responsible or two um organizations that
are responsible the customer and AWS and
on aws's side they're going to be
responsible for anything that is
physical so we're talking about Hardware
Global infrastructure so the regions the
availability zones The Edge locations
the physical security so think of all
that Hardware that's there those data
centers um everything like that then
there's also software the services that
they're offering and so um you know this
extends to all their services but
generally it breaks down to the four
core and so we're talking about Compu
storage database and networking okay and
when we say networking we're talking
about like physically setting up the
wires and also you know the software to
set up the routing and all that kind of
stuff there uh now looking at the
customer side of it they're responsible
for configuration of managed services or
thirdparty software so the platforms
they use so whether they choose to use a
particular type of os uh the
applications so if they want to use like
Ruby on Rails uh am so identity and
access management so if you uh create a
user and you grant them permissions if
you give them things they're not
supposed to have access to that's on you
right then there's configuration of
virtual infrastructure and systems so
that would be choosing your OS that
would be uh the networking so there
could be networking on the um uh the
virtual machines themselves or we could
be talking about Cloud networking in
this case then there are firewalls so
we're talking about virtual firewalls
again they could be on the virtual
machine or it could be configuring like
knackles or security groups on AWS then
there's security config ation of data uh
and so there is client side data
encryption so if you're moving something
from S3 from your local machine to S3
you might need to encrypt that first
before you send it over then there's
server side encryption so that might be
turning on server side encryption within
S3 or turning it encryption on your EBS
volume then there's networking traffic
protection so you know that's turning on
VPC flow log so you can monitor them
turning on it was guard Duty so that it
can detect anomalies with your traffic
or or activities within your um adus
account and then there's customer data
so that's the data that you upload on
the behalf of your customers or yourself
and what you decide to um you know like
what levels of sensitivity that you want
to lock it down do you want to use
Amazon Macy to see if there's any public
facing uh personally identifi
information that's up to you so there's
a lot here and honestly it's a lot
easier than you think um instead of
thinking about this big diagram what I
do is I break it down into this and so
we have the in and the of and that's
what I said I could not fit on the um
previous slide there the idea is
customers are responsible for the
security in the cloud so that's your
data and configuration so if it's data
that's resigning on there or there
something you can configure you are
responsible for it on the ad side they
are responsible for the security of the
cloud so if it's anything physical or
Hardware the operation of managed
services or Global infrastructure that's
going to be on them and this in and of
thing is very important for the exam so
you should absolutely know the
difference between the two this is kind
of an adist concept I don't see any
other cloud service provider talking
about in and of uh so you definitely
need to know it
[Music]
okay so one variant we might see for the
uh shared responsibility model would be
on the types of cloud computing this
could also be applicable to the types of
uh deployment models but we're doing
types of cloud computing here and so we
have the customers responsibility and
then the cloud service provid
responsibility so we're seeing on
premise infrastructure as a service
platform as a service and software as a
service and so when you are on Prem
you're basically responsible for
everything apps data runtime middleware
OS virtualization servers storage
networking basically everything and just
by adopting the cloud you're almost
cutting your responsibilities in half
here so now the cloud service provider
is going to be responsible for the
physical networking uh the physical
storage those physical servers and
because they're offering virtual
machines to you they're setting up a
hypervisor uh on your behalf so
virtualization is taking care for you
and so um you know if you launch an ec2
instance you know you're going to have
to choose the OS so that's why you're
responsible whatever middleware there
the runtime so whatever kind of programs
you install on it uh the data that
resides on it and any kind of like major
applications okay then we have platform
as a service uh and so you know the
cloud service provider is going to take
even more responsibility there so when
we're talking about this we're thinking
like a elastic beant stock right so you
know the you just choose what you want
and it's all managed so you might say I
want a ruby on rail server but you're
not saying what OS you need um you're
not uh saying exact you might say what
version of Ruby you want but you don't
have to manage it if it breaks uh or it
might be managed updates and things like
that the last thing here is like
software as a service and this is
something where the CSP is responsible
for everything so if you're thinking of
a of a software as a service think of
like Microsoft Word where uh you're just
writing uh you know writing stuff in
there and you know you you are
responsible for where you might choose
to store your data but the data is like
still handled by the cloud service fider
because you know it's on the cloud so on
their servers right um so yeah hopefully
that gives you kind of an idea across
types of cloud U Computing
responsibilities
[Music]
all right so what I want to do here is
just shift the lens a bit and look at
the share responsibility model if we
were just uh observing a subset of cloud
services such as compute and so we're
going to see infrastructures of service
platform as a service software as a
service and now we have function as a
service and so that's what I mean when
we shift the lens we get new information
uh and so you can just see that you
really don't want to look at this uh
from one perspective okay so starting at
the top here we have bare metal uh and
so ad's offering is called the ec2 bare
metal instance and this is where you
basically get the whole machine uh you
can configure the entire machine with
with the exception of the physical
machine itself so as the customer you
can install the host OS um uh the host
OS so the operating system that runs on
the physical machine and then you can
install your own hypervisor um and then
Aus is going to be responsible for the
rest the physical machine now normally
The Next Step Up would be dedicated but
dedicated doesn't exactly give you more
responsibility it gives you more
Assurance because it's a single tenant
uh virtual machine and that's why I kind
of left it out here um but we'll see it
in the next slide that it is kind of on
the model and shares the same spot as uh
ec2 um but ec2 is a virtual machine and
so um here the customer is responsible
for the guest OS so that means that you
can choose what OS you want whether it
is Ubuntu or Debian or Windows but
that's not the actual OS that is running
on the the physical machine and so
you're not going to have control of that
ads is going to take care of that then
there's the container runtime so you
know you you can install Docker on this
or any kind of container layer that you
want um so that's another thing that you
can do so ads is going to be responsible
for the hypervisor uh the physical
machine and the host OS all right then
looking at containers it has more than
one offering for containers but we'll
just look at ECS here and so um this is
where you are going to uh have uh you
don't you don't install the guest OS
right the guest OS is already there for
you what you are going to do is choose
your configuration of containers you're
going to uh deploy your containers
you're going to determine where you need
to access storage for your containers or
attach storage to your containers and
databus is going to be responsible for
the guest OS it it the and there might
not even be a guest OS but there the
host OS the guest OS the hypervisor the
container runtime uh and you're just
responsible for your containers okay
then going to the next level here we
have platform as a service and so this
one also is a little bit odd where it
fits um because the thing is is that
this could be using anything underneath
it could be using containers it could be
using virtual machines um and so that's
where it doesn't exactly fit well on a
linear graph but let's just take a look
at some things here so this is where
you're just uploading your code uh you
have some configuration of the
environment you have options of
deployment strategies um the
configuration of the associated services
and then Abus is going to be responsible
for the servers the OS the networking
the storage the security so it is taking
on more responsibility than
infrastructures a service um uh whereas
you know itus is just going to be
responsible for that so if it's a
virtual machine that it's being under uh
under the use the is going to be
responsible for this customer stuff okay
you're not if it's containers then AIS
is going to be responsible for this but
it just depends on how that platform as
a service is set up actually the way
elastic beanock is set up is that you
actually have access to all that
infrastructure and you can fiddle with
it and so in that case um whereas like
if you were to use Heroku which is a a
third party provider um you know they
would take care of all this stuff up
here um and so you would not have to
worry about it but on AWS you actually
are responsible for uh the underlying
infrastructure because you can you can
configure it you can touch it so that's
where you know again these do not fit
perfectly you can't look at platform as
a service meaning that um you're not
responsible for certain things it really
comes down to the service offering okay
then we're taking a look at software of
service so on AWS um this is going to be
something like um Amazon workdocs which
is I believe a competitor uh not a very
popular competitor but a competitor to
Microsoft SharePoint and this is for
Content collaboration so as the customer
you're responsible for the contents of
the document management of the files
configuration of sharing access controls
and the databas is responsible for the
servers the OS networking the the
storage the security and everything else
so you know if you use a Microsoft Word
Doc and you type stuff in it you say
where to save it that's what you're
responsible for okay the last one here
on the list is our uh functions here and
so ad's offer is itus Lambda and so as
the customer all you're doing is you're
uploading your code and itus is going to
take care of the rest so deployment
container runtime networking Storage
security physical machine basically
everything um and so you're really just
left to uh develop okay so you know
hopefully that gives you kind of an idea
and again you know we could have thrown
in a a few other services like what we
could not fit on this slide here was um
uh adus fargate which is a serverless
container as a function or sorry
serverless uh serverless container as a
service or container as a service so uh
you know that has its own unique
properties in the model as well okay so
let's just have kind of a visualization
on a linear graph here so we have the
customers's responsibility on the Le
hand side and adus is responsibility on
the right and we'll look at our broad
category so we got bare metal dedicated
virtual machine Mach containers and
functions and so no matter uh which uh
type of compute you're using you're
always responsible for your code for um
containers you know if uh you know like
uh the functions when you're using
functions there are pre-built containers
so you say I want to use Ruby and
there's a ruby container and you don't
have to configure it but obviously um
you know when you are using container
service you are configuring that
container you are responsible for it for
um virtual machine you know you're
responsible for the runtime so you can
install a container runtime on there or
install a bunch of different packages
like Ruby and stuff like that uh the
operating system you have control over
in the virtual machines for the
dedicated and we saw with bare metal you
have both uh controls of the host OS and
the guest OS and then only bare metal
allows you to have control of the
virtualization where you can install
that hypervisor so hopefully that gives
you an idea of compute and A's offering
there and also kind of how there's a lot
of little caveats when we're looking at
the Shared responsibility model
[Music]
okay all right so I have one more
variant of the share responsibility
model and this one is actually what is
used by Google so um we're going to
apply to AWS and uh see how it works so
let's just kind of redefine share
responsibility model or just in a
slightly different way so we fully
understand it so the share
responsibility model is a simple
visualization that helps determine what
the customer is responsible for and what
the CSP is responsible for related to
AWS and so across the top we have
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service software as a service but
remember there's other ones out there
like functions and service it's just not
going to fit on here um okay so and then
uh along the side here we have content
access policies usage deployment web
application security identity operations
access and authentication network
security remember that's Cloud
networking security the guest OS data
and content audit logging now we have
the the actual traditional networking or
physical networking storage and
encryption and here we're probably
talking about the physical storage
hardened kernel IPC uh the boot the
hardware and so then here we have our
bars so we have the csp's responsibility
and the customer responsibility so when
we're looking at a SAS software as a
service uh the customer is going to be
responsible for the content remember
like think of like a word processor
you're writing the content the access
policies like say I want to share this
document with someone the usage like how
you UTI it can you upgrade your plan
things like that then next on our list
here is platform as a service so
generally uh you know platform is a
services for developers to De develop
and deploy applications and so they will
generally have more than one deploy
strategy and uh you know there might be
some cost-saving measures to choose like
uh you might have to pay additional for
security uh or you it's up to you to
configure in a particular way or you
might have to integrate it with other
services uh and you know we saw that
pass is not a perfect uh definition or
fit because you know when we look at
elastic bean stock if you have access to
those resources and you can change them
underneath then you might have more
responsibility there than you think that
you would okay the next one here is
infrastructure the service and so this
is extending to Identity so who's
allowed to uh you know log into your
adabs account uh operations the things
that they're allowed to do in the
account access and authentication do
they have to use MFA uh things like that
networ security obviously you can
configure the security of your uh Cloud
infrastructure or Cloud Network um you
know so you know do you isolate
everything a single VPC how do you set
up your security groups things like that
uh we know with virtual machines you can
set up the guest OS there's data and
content but remember that bare metal is
part of the uh infrastructure service
offering and so that's where we'd see
Hardware or not Hardware but you'd have
the host o the host Os or virtualization
and so this again is not a perfect
representation uh but it generally works
okay and then last and list there um or
just looking at what the ads is
responsible for auto logging so of
course adus has cloud trail which is for
uh uh logging uh API um events but Auto
logging could be things that are uh
internally happening with those physical
servers then the networking the physical
storage uh Harding the kernel ad of us
has I think what's called the Nitro
system where they have like a security
chip that's uh installed on all their
servers then it's the the boot OS uh and
then the hardware itself okay so just
remember the customer is responsible for
the data and configuration of access
controls that reside in AWS so if you
can configure it or you can put data on
it you're responsible for it okay the
customer is responsible for the
configuration of cloud services and
granting access to users via permissions
right so if you give uh one of your
employees access to do it um you know
even if it's their fault it's your fault
so remember that um and again the CSP is
generally responsible for the underlying
infrastructure we say generally because
you know there's edge cases like bare
metal and coming back to adses in the
cloud and of the cloud so in the cloud
so if you configure it or store it then
you the customer are responsible for it
and of the cloud if you cannot configure
it then the CSP is probably responsible
for it
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the share
responsibility model from the
perspective of architecture and if
you're getting sick of share
responsibility model don't worry I think
this will be the last uh slide in this
section but let's take a look here so uh
we have uh less responsibility more
responsibility at the bottom so what we
have down here is traditional or virtual
machine architecture so Global Workforce
is most familiar with this kind of
architecture and there's lots of
documentation Frameworks and support so
maybe this would be using elastic
beanock with platform as a service or
using ec2 instances alongside with Auto
scaling groups uh code deploy uh load
balancers things like that the next
level here is microservices or
containers this is where you mix and
match languages better utilization of
resources so maybe you're using fargate
which is seress containers or elastic
container service or elastic kubernetes
service for containers and at the top
here we have serverless or commonly with
functions as a service so there are no
more servers you just worry about the
data or uh and the code right so
literally just functions of code and so
you could be using the amplify serus
framework or maybe aess Lambda for
creating servess architecture so there
you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Computing
Services and before we jump into uh the
entire Suite of Computing Services they
us have let's just talk about ec2 for a
moment which allows you to launch
virtual machines so what is a virtual
machine while a virtual machine or VM is
an emulation of a physical computer
using software server virtualization
allows you to easily create copy resize
or migrate your server multiple VMS can
run on the same physical server so you
can share the cost with other customers
so imagine if your server or computer
was an executable file on your computer
okay so that's the kind of way you want
to think about it when we launch a VM uh
we call it an instance and so ec2 is
highly configurable server where you can
choose the Ami so the Amazon machine
image that affects options such as
amount of CPUs or vcpus virtual CPUs the
ount of memory so Ram the amount of
network bandwidth the operating system
so whether it's Windows Ubuntu Amazon L
2 uh the ability to attach multiple
virtual hard drives for storage so
elastic Block store um and so the Amazon
machine image is a predefined
configuration for AVM so just remember
that and so ec2 is also considered the
backbone of ads because the majority of
AD services are using uc2 as the
underlying servers whether it's S3 RDS
10B or lambdas that is what it's using
so um what I say also it's just because
when we talk about the it Network that
is the backbone for uh Global
infrastructure uh and the networking at
large and so ec2 is for the services
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro so we just looked at what ec2 is
well let's look at more of the broader
services for computing and these are the
more uh common ones that you'll come
across there's definitely more than just
what we're going to see on this single
slide here so we'll break this down with
virtual machines containers and then
serverless for for virtual machines
remember that's an emulation of a
physical computer using software and ec2
is the main one uh but for our VM
category we have Amazon light sale this
is a manage virtual server service it is
the friendly version of ec2 virtual
machines so when you need to launch a
Linux or Windows server but you don't
have much Aus knowledge you could launch
a WordPress here and uh you could hook
up your domain and stuff like that um so
this is a very good option for beginners
we have containers so virtualizing an
operating system or Os to run multiple
workloads on a single OS instance so
containers are generally used in
microservice architecture when you
divide your application into smaller
applications that talk to each other so
here we would have ECS elastic container
service this is a container
orchestration service that supports
Docker containers launches a cluster of
servers on these two2 instances with
Docker installed so when you need
Dockers a service or you need to run
containers we have elastic container
registry ECR this is a repository of
container images so in order to launch a
container you need an image an image
just means a save copy a repository just
means a storage that has Version Control
we have ECS fargate or just fargate now
people are kind of forgetting that it's
it runs on ECS these days that's why I
have it in there it is a serverless
orchestration container service is the
same as ECS ex except you pay pay on
demand per running container so with ECS
you have to keep a ec2 server running
even if you have no containers running
so it manages the underlying server so
you don't have to scale or upgrade the
ec2 server so there's the advantage over
ECS okay then we have elastic kubernetes
service eks this is a fully managed
kubernetes service kuber or so
kubernetes commonly abbreviated to K8 is
an open-source orchestration software
that was created by Google is generally
the standard for managing microservices
so when you need to run kubernetes as a
service then we have serverless category
so when the underlying servers are
managed by Deus you don't worry or
configure servers cus Lambda is a
serverless function service you can run
code without provisioning or managing
servers you upload small pieces of code
choose much uh how much memory how how
long you want the function to run is
allowed to run before timing out and you
are charged based on the runtime of the
Serv function rounded to the nearest 100
milliseconds so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and what I want to do is just show you a
variety of different Computing Services
on AWS so I'm going to try to launch
them and uh we're not going to do
anything with them just going to Simply
launch them okay so the first I want to
show you is ec2 and by the way we will
go more in depth in ec2 later on in this
course here um but what I'm going to do
is go ahead and launch the instance
don't worry about all this stuff but
just choose the Amazon Linux 2 so it's
in the free tier all right we're going
to choose an instance type of a T2 m so
that's part of the free tier it's going
to be set as one all these options are
fine I want you to go ahead and review
and launch we're going to launch and I
don't want to generate any key pair I'm
going to proceed without a key pair I'm
going to acknowledge that because I
don't want it and that's all there is to
launching an ec2 instance and so I can
go here and view my instances and what
you'll see is it's pending okay and
usually it has like a little spinning
icon maybe they've updated it since then
so I go here it's hard to see because
there's all these terminated ones but I
don't need to do anything with it I just
wanted to show you the actions that
you'd have to do to launch it actually
we'll leave it alone maybe we'll see it
when it's launched the next one I want
to show you is e elastic container
service um and wow this this is old
let's go let's get the new experience
please so old okay checkbox that
on and we'll hit get started and we'll
say create a
cluster and we have some options here
networking only ec2 Linux plus
networking uh for use with either ads
fargate or external Windows
um uh this is if you're doing fargate
which we're not doing right now fargate
is part of elastic container service it
used it well used to be it is called ECS
fargate but it us markets it as a
separate service we'll go to next and
say my ECS
cluster um we can create an empty
cluster but that would make it a fargate
cluster which we don't want there's an
ond demand server look it's M6 I large
if you're very afraid of a lot of spend
here you don't have to do this you can
just watch me do it and just learn well
what I'm going to do is try to find
something super cheap so I want a T2
micro or a T3 micro T2 micro is part of
the uh free tier I don't know if we get
to choose T2 anymore in here they might
not let
you there it is you know T3 mro is great
too I just whatever says it's free
that's what I'm going to go for number
of instances one the Amazon version is
fine I don't care about a key pair uh
use the existing VPC I don't want to
have to make a new one select the
existing ones
okay uh let it create a new security
group that's totally fine allow those to
be fine create a new role that's fine
create okay and so that's going to
create ourselves a
cluster um I'm going to just make a new
tab here let's just check on our ec2
instance
and so if we look at our ec2 instance it
is running okay great so it has a
private IP address it has a public IP
address all right um there's not much we
can do with it I can't even log into it
because we didn't generate out a key
pair times you want to name these things
so I just go here and name it my server
okay go back to our ECS instance and the
cluster is ready so we'll go here and oh
nice we got a new UI and so if we wanted
to deploy something as a service or a
task
um we would need to create a template
like a task definition
file uh they don't have a new UI for
this you're being redirected to the
previous version console because this
isn't available in the new experience
yet of course it isn't so we can create
a new task definition file that's what's
used to run it it's basically like a
Docker file composed file whatever you
want um we have fargate or ec2 we are
doing ECS so we're going to have to do
ec2 so we'll say my ECS yes uh task def
file um task roll opt optional IM roll I
don't need one network mode I don't
care um and then this is the idea is
that because a container allows you to
use up a particular amount of the um
thing we don't have to use all of the
memory so we should look up what a T2
micro is because I don't even remember
what size it is okay T2 micro AWS so we
go here we look at the instance types
and we're going to flip over to T2 and
it says that it's one
vcpu one gigabyte of memory so what I'll
do one yeah one okay that's fine so what
we want and this is in megabytes so
we'll say 500 megabytes and um I don't
know if we can do less than one but I'm
going to do one
here
um the task CPU must be an integer
greater than or equal to 128 okay fine
128 oh I guess it's 1024 would utilize
the whole thing so I could say
512 okay and this is where we would add
our
container so I don't do this every day
so I don't remember how to do this we'll
say my
container um and I need a repository
here so I need like dockerhub Hello
World okay I don't care what it is I
just need a image that's
simple and I'm looking for the address
here
um I'm hoping that's just
this dockerhub
URL so it' be something like this right
docker.io probably Docker IO Docker
image um Docker Hub URL in
ECS okay it goes to show how often I'm
laun launching these things so
repository URL Docker image so I think
that what we're going to do
here I would really just like the URL
please
reviews
tags where is
it where is it it's somewhere here
right uh uhuh
uh well let's just try it we'll go and
we'll type in says image and tag so
docker.io
hello world I really need an image ID
image URL hello
world dockerhub
they're not making my life easy here
today anything I just want to see like a
single example
docker.io
Docker
iio URL
examples
ECS this is what it's like you know this
is what you're going to be doing if you
are um you know a cloud engineer you're
going to be Googling a lot and just
trying to find examples
here so here it says docker.io the name
the host name okay so we'll just try it
okay so I think that the the the name
here is underscore and then it's hello
world and that's what's throwing me off
here right docker.io
just hold on
here repositor URL and then there's the
tag I don't know if like is the tag
going to be like latest view available
tags latest okay so what I'll do
here and that's the thing you got to
have a lot of confidence to too so hard
limit soft limit um do I have to set
it do I have to set any of these things
can I just go to the bottom and hit
add looks like I
can okay so we'll scroll on down
create we create our task definition
file which is fine we're going to go
back to our cluster it's going to bring
us back to the new experience we're
going to click into this
cluster holy smokes uh we're going to
hit
deploy and and we are going to choose
service that means it's going to
continuously run task means that when
it's done running it ends we're going to
choose our family our version that's the
task definition file there is not
compatible with the selected compute
strategy my task
file what if I just choose task take
that okay some maybe some you have to
like code it so that it continuously
runs I don't care we don't need to run a
service here the selected task
definition is not compatible with the
selected compute
strategy okay let's see
why uh can you double check if you're
using fargate strategy instead of the
ec2 uh blog designed for the ec2
strategy so probably what it's
suggesting is that the the strategy file
I made is not for the right one here
task
definitions go back over
here well what's wrong with
it task roll none my container so what
I'm going to do because I don't trust
this just going to go ahead and delete
this can I delete this how do I delete
this oh boy
actions deregister
deregister we'll create a new one and so
it has tools like it was co-pilot um CLI
to make this a lot easier because you
can see this is very frustrating but I
chose
this so my task
def requires compatibility of
ec2
default 512
512 add
container we're going
to uh was it docker.io
uncore what's it called hello
world
latest I we'll just say hello world
here and we'll just say uh 512 which is
fine I don't care about any port
mappings I'm just reading it carefully
here to see what it wants we'll say 512
maybe because I didn't specify them it's
complaining
this looks fine we'll hit
add
okay constraints type this all looks
fine so we'll try this
again and so we now have our file let's
see if we can just run this task from
here you
see2 this is just another way to do it
so we just choose the cluster this is
actually a lot easier to do it this is
old old old Eh this is ugly and so now
it launches so you know if you have
trouble one way then just do it another
way and uh sometimes it'll work here so
I don't expect this task to really work
in any particular way if it's pending
that's fine if it fails that's fine if
it's successful that's fine I don't
care I just want to go through the
motion so it was successful it it ran
and then it stopped I don't know if we
could see like the output anywhere
probably what it would do is it would
log out something like into somewhere
and so I don't know if like there's logs
turned on for this if I go over to like
cloud watch logs maybe I could see
something a lot of these services will
automatically create cloudwatch logs so
sometimes you can just go look at them
there so we'll drop down we'll go to log
groups
here there is some stuff here um there's
a couple that I created from before just
go ahead delete
those and so what I'm looking for is
like ECS so no there's no logging
happening here which is totally fine so
that is ECS um for fargate it's pretty
much uh the the same the difference is
that fargate is like it has to start up
and run so it's a lot slower to
watch okay and now let's go take a look
at a
Lambda okay so this is our serverless
compute so we go ahead and create
ourselves a function uh we can start
from a blueprint that doesn't sound too
bad and I personally like Ruby so no not
getting much here but we can do is look
for something that do we have like a
hello
world there we go hello world and we'll
click that we'll say my hello
world uh it's going to create those
permissions that's fine it's showing us
the code it's very simple okay it's
going to console log out these values
not a very good hello world function
doesn't even say hello world how can you
call it a hello world function if it
doesn't say hello world I don't
understand so we're going to go ahead
and create this function usually doesn't
take this long
okay so uh here is our function here is
our code notice that this is
cloud9ine okay and you can even move
that over to Cloud9 they didn't have
this button here before that's kind of
cool I hit test they used to have it up
here but I guess they wanted to make it
more obvious so they moved it down here
which is nice so what I can do is hit
this oops my test it's going to send a
payload here to the actual function uh
and it's going to tell us if it works
okay so can I run my test go over here
to
test they changed it a bit so I guess I
created there it succeeded so I have my
logs okay so it's it's going to Output
those values there so there are the
three values which basically is
nothing maybe you were supposed to set
those an environment variable but you
can see you're just uploading uh some
code right it's just a bit of code it's
not like a full app or anything so we
launched an E2 container we did a a um
sorry ec2 instance a container we did a
seress function there's other things
like eks but that is really really hard
to set up okay because uh you'd have to
use like kubernetes commands and stuff
like that and my kubernetes knowledge is
always very poor um I'm just taking a
peek here to see if they've updated it
so yeah you create the cluster but like
deploying it is forget it I'm just
trying to think if there's anything else
I kind of want to show you um no those
are the main three I would say so I'm
pretty happy with that um what I'm going
to do is go and kill all these things so
we're going to go over to Lambda
okay and I'm going to go ahead and
delete
this as you saw ECS was the hardest and
no matter how many times I've built
things on ECS and I've deployed full
things on ECS I can't remember I always
have so much trouble with task
definition files it's unbelievable we'll
go over to our cluster
here and
ECS cluster up here make sure you're not
in the fargate cluster I know I'm
clicking really fast but there's just so
many things to click and I'm going to
click into this cluster we're going to
go hit edit because this is running an
ec2 instance right I need to destroy it
um it just took me back to the old one
here um I want to delete no I want to
delete the cluster click back
here where do I delete it up
here here
I can't checkbox
anything uh how do I delete this do I
have to delete the task first maybe so
we'll go here I mean it's already
stopped there's nothing to
do
edit uh huh account
settings wow this is
confusing
okay how to delete ECS
cluster got to be kidding me I have to
actually look this up so open the SS
console from navigation in the
navigation choose clusters and the new
turn off the E uh turn off new ECS
experience and choose the old console
the delete cluster workflow is not
supported in the EC ECS console are you
serious then
why why do you have it like why even let
people use the new experience if that
you don't have all the functionality
there um oh I was going to give it
feedback but it didn't let me here it
says uh I need to delete an ECS
cluster
no okay so I'm
here there's my big ugly
cluster delete
cluster okay so yeah it it's a struggle
okay like things are always changing on
me but uh you just have to have
confidence and if you've done it a few
times you know that can do it right um
and that's one of the biggest Hang-Ups
to Cloud I would say so it's going to
take a few minutes apparently to delete
the cluster as that is going let's go
over to ec2 I didn't close it I kept
this tab
open and uh there's our ec2
instance we can go ahead and terminate
that instance terminate
okay and if this says it's terminating
then we're in good shape Terminator
shutting down that's fine and notice
here that's the ECS instance just make
sure you shut down the my server not the
um the ECS instance cuz that's going to
stop and so this is already terminated
but if we go back here notice that it
says that it's not done but it
clearly clearly has shut
down okay so I'm going to wait here for
a bit even though I know it's been
deleted maybe it's deleting things like
the auto scaling group so we go down
below
here right so that's probably what it's
doing it's probably trying destroy the
Autos scaling
group but it doesn't show any here so it
must have already destroyed
it yeah so task Services delete so I'll
be back here in a bit but I know it's
safe it's already deleted but I'll see
you back here in a bit okay so I waited
literally a second and it's now deleted
so we deleted our Lambda we deleted our
oh did we delete our
Lambda good
question now I'm not really worried
about the Lambda because I guess we did
but I'm not really worried about it
because um you know at when it rests at
idle it's not costing us anything where
the ECS and the ec2 are backed by ec2
instances so we do have to shut those
down okay and again remember make sure
you're in the correct region sometimes
that gets flipped over and then you
think those resources are gone but
they're actually not they're just
running in another region so uh there
you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're taking a look at higher
performance Computing Services ons so
before we do we got to talk about the
Nitro system so this is a combination of
dedicated hardware and lightweight
hypervisor enabling faster Innovation
and enhanced security all new ec2
instant types use the nitro system and
the Nitro system is designed uh by AWS
okay so this is made up of a few things
we have Nitro cards these are
specialized cards for vpcs EBS instant
storage and uh controller cards you have
Nitro security chips these are
integrated into the mother board
protects Hardware resources and we have
the Nitro hypervisor this is the
lightweight hyper visor memory and CPU
allocation bare metal like performance
there's also uh Nitro enclaves but you
know that's a bit out of scope here but
that's has to do with like ec2 isolation
Okay uh then we have bare metal
instances so you can launch ec2
instances that have no hypervisor so you
can run workloads directly on the
hardware for maximum performance and
control we have the M5 the R5 um E2
instances that can run bare metal
there's other ones I believe I've seen
as well but um you know if you are
running bare metal you can just go
investigate at the time of okay we have
bottle rocket this is a Linux based open
source operating system that is purpose
built by adus for running containers on
VMS or bare metal hosts then uh let's
just Define what HBC is so it's a
cluster of aund of thousands of servers
with fast connections between each of
them with the purpose of boosting
Computing capacity so when you need a
supercomputer to perform computational
problems too large to run on a standard
computer or computers or would take too
long this is where you know HBC comes
into play one solution here is adus
parallel cluster which is uh an ad
supported open source cluster management
tool that makes it easy for you to
deploy and manage high performance
Computing HBC clusters and AWS so
hopefully that gives you an idea of this
stuff
[Music]
okay all right so let's take a look at
HPC or high performance computer
Computing on AWS so HPC is for running
large complex simulations and deep
learning workloads in the cloud with a
complete Suite of high performance
Computing product Services gains Insight
faster and quickly move uh from idea to
Market blah blah blah blah blah it's for
ML or very complex scientific Computing
stuff these run at least on C5 NS okay
and the way it works is that you use
this um CLI called P cluster or aess
parallel compute U or aess parallel
cluster stuff and so let's see if we can
get get this installed very easily um so
what I'm going to
do is see how hard it is to install now
I don't recommend you running this
because I don't know what it's going to
cost me and if I make a misconfiguration
I don't want you to have that spend here
but I don't think it's that dangerous so
I'm going to go back over to us East one
here I'm going to open up
cloudshell and I'm going to give it a
moment to load and so as that is loading
let's take a look at how we would go
ahead and install this so install the
current parallel um it was parallel I
think we just copy that line
okay and so we have to wait for our
environment to spin up all right so once
it has spun up we will install it and
then we will jump over to this tutorial
here okay so we'll give this a
moment and after waiting a little while
here it looks like our shell is ready it
looks like it's in bash um I'm just
going to type in S3 LS that's a sanity
check okay and it works that's great so
we go back over here and I'm going to go
back up to install for
Linux and what I need is that single
command where is
it so I'm certain that we already have
Linux or python installed but I just
want the command to install
it you saw it a moment go here I'm just
going to back out till I can find
it uh one more there it is so it's under
oh it's this link here and that's what I
talk about the documentations being
tricky sometimes you have to click these
uh headings here to find stuff so this
is the first time installing it so we'll
grab that usually you're supposed to
create in Virtual environments with
python I don't care this is my cloud
shell it doesn't matter to me so we're
going to go ahead and download that and
hopefully it is fast and it was super
fast which was really nice
and so what we'll do is go check out the
P cluster
version okay and that looks fine to me
I'm going to go down below here to run
our first job um the returns the it
gives outputs I don't think we need to
configure it because we already have our
CLI so what I'm going to do is go ahead
and create ourselves a new cluster um
beginning cluster creation configuration
file config not found so I guess we do
have to configure
this
configure and it's asking what region do
we want to be in um if I have us East
one I would choose it for some reason
it's all the way for number 13 that is
not a lucky number but I'm going to
choose it anyway anyway no key pair
found in Us East one region please
create one of the following um so create
an ec2 key
pairs uh no options found for ec2 key
pairs that's fine so what what I'll do
is go over
here and we'll go over to ec2
and we will go over to key pairs key
pairs key pairs key pairs we'll create
ourselves a new one here so say um HPC
key pair or just my
HPC so we know what it is for we have
putty or PM we're going to do pem
because we're on Linux we'll create that
and notice that it downloaded the pem
down down here and we're going to need
that for later um and so what I'll
do is I'll type in P cluster here again
configure we'll choose 13 we'll choose
number one here uh allowed values for
the scheduler I have no idea what these
are uh let's choose the number one
allowed values for the operating system
Amazon L 2 I know what that is minimum
cluster size one maximum cluster size
two head notice instance oh T2 micro you
can do that yeah let's do it I didn't
know we could do that enter compute type
uh T2 micro sure so I thought that we'd
have to use a c5n but I guess apparently
not automate VPN uh VPC creation yes of
course network configuration so allow
values for the network configuration uh
head node in a public subnet and and
compute Fleet in a private subnet uh
head node and compute yeah we'll do it
in the both just to make our lives
easier I don't care first one sounds
more secure of course and so oh it's
creting Cloud information sack wow this
is easy I thought this was going to be
super painful okay so we'll go over here
we'll go take a look at what cloud
formation's doing all
right now I don't care if we actually
run a task on here but it was just
interesting to go through the process to
see how hard it was and we will go look
at what resources are being created so
it's creating an internet gateway so
it's literally creating a isolate VPC
for it which is totally fine I guess um
it's creating a subnet creating a route
table refresh
here um I'm not sure how much it wants
to create here it just looks like VPC
that's all it's creating I thought maybe
the ec2 instances would show up here but
maybe it's going to launch that on a
need B
basis okay so that's all created oh now
it's doing a VPC
Gateway I think VPC gateways cost money
let's go take a look here VPC
pricing
yeah there's a uh transfer fee so just
be careful about that you know again you
can just watch along here you don't have
to do
it default route depends on public so
now it's creating ec2
route I don't know what an ads ec2 route
is I've never seen that before sometimes
what we can do is go into ec2 and then
take a look on the left hand side you
see anything in here we don't know what
it is we just type in ec2 route cloud
formation sometimes cloud formation is
great for figuring out what a component
is not all components are represented in
the um inabus um Management console so
specify route in the route table oh it's
just a route
okay and we'll go back here we'll
refresh so that is done is the stack
done created complete good we'll go back
to our Cloud shell it says you can edit
your configuration file or simply do Etc
so now let's see if we can create the
cluster I assume this would create ec2
instances so the job schedule you using
is sge this is deprecated in future use
parallel cluster well should have told
me okay there is a new version of 301
parallel available I don't understand
because I just installed it right we'll
go back to cloud formation just going to
probably create nested Stacks which
that's what I thought it would do Nest
Stacks means that it's Reliant so
there's one main one and then there's uh
children stack
so go here see what resources it's
creating oh whole bunch of stuff wow so
many things at sqsq
SNS uh network interface a Dynamo DB
table Yeah you you probably don't want
to run this you just want to watch me do
it and then we go into here it's
creating uh an ec2 volume so that's
going to be
EBS and then here we
have uh a log group I don't know why
they separated those out do seem very
necessary we are waiting on the elastic
IP that always takes forever creating
elastic IP root instance profile that is
the IM Ru for
it that didn't take too long these these
take a long time I I never know why
create a rooll it's really easy but
attaching an I am policy you're always
waiting for
those um so I'm going to just stop it
here I'll be back in a second because I
don't want to have to make you watch me
stare at the screen here okay all right
so after a really really long wait um
and it always takes some time there it
finally created I'm not sure what it's
made I mean we generally saw over here
in the outputs but usually the cost that
I'm worried about is whatever it's
launching under uc2 it might not even
have launched any servers here we're
going to take a look here see if there's
anything so we have a master and a
compute and they're T2 micros so seems
pretty safe here um this compute is not
running yet so I'm assuming that this is
like the machine that does the Computing
and maybe if you had multiple machines
here like that would be the cluster like
could manage multiple computes um I'm
not particularly sure but let's just
keep going through the tutorial and see
what we can do the next step is we need
to get this PM key in our Cloud shell
here so this I don't know where this is
but what I'm going to do is I'm going to
move it to my desktop I'm doing this off
screen by the the way so I'm moving it
to my desktop and then I'm just going to
go and upload the file okay and there it
is so we'll say open and we'll say
upload and it's going to upload it here
onto this machine and I believe this is
on like uh I think this used as an e EFS
instance like if you're wondering where
the storage for cloud shell is if we go
over here I think it's
EFS is
it h i don't know where it is okay maybe
it's just a maybe it's some else okay I
can't remember where it is but anyway um
so
now it's created the cluster can I hit
enter
here okay can I create a
tab like if I quit this is it going to
kill it it exited it which is I think
it's fine I don't think it stopped
running and so now if I do an LS there's
my key and so we can go back to our
instructions just have too many tabs
open here drag this all the way to the
left here and so we can try to use our
key here to log in so what I'm going to
do
is go here and we'll say my HPC pm and
see if that works we'll say
yes and permission denied it is required
your private key is not accessible
that's because we have to chamod
it
um I never remember the command anymore
CU I rarely ssh in the machine
but if we go to connect and we go to SSH
client it'll tell us what we need to
run chamad 400 okay so that's what we
need to do is we need to do a chamad 400
just wanted to grab that code
there okay and now if we hit up we
should SSH into the machine there we
are we are in the instance we'll type in
exit and so now we want to run our job
on this
machine and if we go back over to here I
guess we can go create our first job so
I'm just doing this in
v and I'm going to paste that in
yep and I don't want the first line oh
okay that's perfect
great right
quit oh there's no file name hold on
here so I need to name this file
something so I'm going to say job.
sh and we're going to paste that again
here we'll say
paste and I don't know if that's cut off
yeah it is okay great is that one
okay I don't trust that the first line
is
there so what I'm going to
do is go back to our tutorial here it's
shebang
forbin
bash
uh this then that for SL bin
SL bash just double check it looks good
to me we're going to quit that I'm just
going to make sure that it is what it we
said it is so job. sh looks correct to
me good and so we'll try to run our job
here so I'm going to say
Q um job.
sh
LS and I guess it really depends on what
we decided to use when we set up that
thing I can't remember what we choose as
our Q we do
qat
oh okay okay okay so I think the thing
is like you see how we have sge I think
that that's what we use to queue up jobs
and so we have to have that installed
probably so
install configure surid
engine SG install um
Linux oh boy that looks like a lot of
work so I don't think we need to to do
anything further here but as far as I
understand the idea is that you're
choosing uh some kind of way to manage
these and so I'm not sure what q q sub
is let's just go look up what that is
what is Q sub oh that is the sun grid
engine okay so how do we install
that um I'm just going to see if we can
install it so I'm going to do I think
this is using
yum so if I do clear here clear yum
install Q sub let's see if I can do
it pseudo yum install qm no package
available Amazon Linux 2 Q sub because
that's probably what we're running in
cloudshell Q sub doesn't tell us how to
install
it that's great
so that's probably what it is and so in
order to use this we would have to
install that sun whatever whatever and
then we go through we do Q sub it would
queue it up um we could do qat cat hello
destroy it that's pretty much all we
really need to know to understand this
um it would have been nice to queue up a
job and see it work but you know we're
getting kind of into a hairy territory
here and I think that we fundamentally
understand how this does work so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go here
I'm going to remove the job Dosh here
and and I want to destroy this
cluster um so I'm going to do pcluster
commands to figure out what all the
commands are and there's probably a
delete command so we'll go back up
here B
cluster where is our crate so we'll say
delete okay and so what that's going to
do is just tear down all the stuff
now so if we go over to cloud
formation okay and it looks like it's
destroying so yeah I'll see you here uh
back in a bit when it's all destroyed
okay all right so after a short little
wait there it has destroyed it been so
long that I uh my connection vanished
but just make sure if you did follow
along for whatever reason uh you know
make sure that the stuff is deleted and
it looks like it did not destroy uh this
so I'm going to go ahead and delete that
that's just VPC stuff so I'm not too
worried about it I know that's going to
roll back no problem and so I'm going to
consider this done so going to make my
way back to the Management console close
this stuff up and we are good to go uh
for our next
[Music]
thing hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're taking a look at Edge and
hybrid Computing Services so what is
Edge Computing when you push your
Computing workloads outside of your
network to run close to the destination
location uh so an example would be
pushing Computing to run on phones iot
devices external servers not within your
Cloud Network what is hyber Computing
when you're able to run workloads on
both your on premise Data Center and the
a uh VPC okay so we have a few Services
here starting with ad Outpost this is a
physical rack of servers that you can
put into your data center ads output
allows you to use ads API and services
uh such as ec2 WR in your data center
then we have AIS wavelength this allows
you to build and launch your
applications in a telecom data center by
doing this your applications will have
ultra low latency since they will be
pushed over the 5G Network and be
closest as possible to the end user um
so they've partnered with things like
Verizon vone uh business and a few
others but those are the two noticeable
ones okay we have VMware Cloud on AWS so
this allows you to manage on premise
virtual machines using VMware uh within
ec2 instances the data center must uh be
using uh VMware for virtualization for
this to work okay then we have Aus local
zones which are Edge uh Data Centers
located outside of the adus region so
you can use adus closer to the edge
destination when you need faster
Computing storage databases in populated
areas that are outside of AWS region you
could do this there's some other Edge
offerings on AWS that aren't listed here
like sag maker has what's called like
Neo stage maker um let you do Edge
Computing with um ml but I mean this is
good enough
[Music]
okay all right so I wanted just to show
an example of edge Computing uh because
we didn't cover it in our generic uh
compute and so there's a variety of
services that allow you to do Edge
Computing like wavelength and so um I've
never actually launched wavelength
before and I think that uh you have to
request it so if I go over to support
here again I've never done this before
but I'm sure we can figure it out pretty
easily I feel that if we create a case
um maybe it's like service
limit we type in wavelength here nope
not
there so how do we get wavelength
wavelength AB us
request so that's what I'm looking for
here okay how do I use wavelength
AWS
whoops and sometimes what I'll do is go
to the doc here opt into wavelength
zones before you specify wavelength zone
for resource or service you must opt
into it to opt in go to the AIS console
okay so we'll go to
ec2 and then it's going to say use the
region selector in the navigation bar to
select the region which supports your
wavelength
l so I know that there's stuff
in uh Us West because of Las Vegas right
or not Las Vegas but Los Angeles right
so if we go over here there's definitely
that over there on the navigation pain
on the ec2 dashboard under account
attributes select
zones okay do we see zones
here
zones oh ec2
dashboard zones let's go check here
again on the navigation pane choose ec2
dashboard we are there
right and under account attributes uh
settings account
attributes oh over here okay oh it's
here
zones and so there we have two zones and
we see switch regions to make uh zones a
different region
okay so under Zone groups turn on
wavelengths Zone
groups okay nothing there so I'm just
going to switch over to another one
here maybe
Oregon maybe it's usw 2 oh look at all
the stuff we have here I've never seen
these before okay so here is the
wavelength one so that is the Los
Angeles
one we can go ahead and enable this
before disabling The Zone group I'm not
sure what zone groups cost so wavelength
Zone pricing again you might just want
to watch me do this because it might
cost
money um and so you might not want to
have to spend for
that
pricing uh provides mobile networks wave
lengths are available across whatever
learn about the data transfers in price
about ec2 instances okay so what's the
price we go into
here all right so what I'm going to
suggest to you is don't do this but I'm
going to do it and we're just going to
see what the experience is like okay so
I'm going to update my zone so now I
have this one so we'll say enable I'm
going to assume that it has to do with
like data transfer
costs okay and uh we're going to go over
to
ec2 and we're going to go over to
instances here
here we're going to launch an instance
and we're going to see if we we have
that available now I don't know if we're
restricted to to particular uh instances
I'm assume we can launch a Linux machine
it'd be really weird if we couldn't you
know we'll go over to configuration and
what we want to do is
choose uh the zone so how do we do it so
once it's turned
on confirmation and confirm it configure
your network so create a VPC create a
carrier Gateway so you can connect your
resources into the the VPC to the
telecommunication Network holy smokes
This is
complicated but it's just kind of
interesting to see like the process
right you know it's not for our use case
but uh carrier Gateway
right and as I do this I always check up
all the costs here so I say carrier
Gateway pricing AWS because maybe that's
where the price
is okay if you don't get a pricing page
then usually that's hard to say
logically isolated virtual Network
again it's not telling me
what um to use carrier you need to opt
into at least one wavelength Zone but I
did
right and sometimes what happens is that
it just takes time for the optin to to
go so go here manage the Zone settings
that was a lot easier way so we have one
it's we're opted in right here
okay
and
okay we'll we'll go here again if that
one didn't work
um we can try so the I guess these are
all the regions Denver things like
that can I opt opt into this one op
in it's not super exciting like all
we're going to do is launch an ec2
instance but you know we'll go through
the process here a
bit and I don't know why I can't create
one so we'll go back over to the
instructions
here create so you can connect so create
a route table using the VPC to the route
table so I think that's as far as we're
going to get here because I'm not seeing
any options here but the idea was that
we would have to create a carrier
Gateway we'd update our route tables and
all we would be doing is launching an
ec2 instance so you know it's no
different than launching it you just
choose a different subnet so I think
you'd have to create a subnet for that
zone and launch it in there and that
would be Edge Computing another example
of edge Computing would be something
like via cloudfront which we have uh
these um Edge functions or not Edge
functions yeah functions here and so
these are functions that are deployed to
cloudfront so my cloudfront
function and these would be deployed to
um Edge locations right and all you can
use here is Javascript so here's an
example of one and um I'm fine with this
development live this function is not
published we'll go to
test test the function it's
good publish publish that function and
so the advantage of this is that you
know if you have functions that are in
it was Lambda there's a chance of cold
start um whereas if they're deployed on
the edge here there's still probably a
cold start but it's going to be a lot
faster because it's a lot closer to the
edge location so um you know it's just a
different uh different cases but yeah
there was one where we're launching ec2
workload into wavelengths which we
couldn't complete which is totally fine
and then we have these functions on the
edge there's other uh Edge Computing
Services like within Sage maker you can
deploy I think it's called like Neo sag
maker and then for iot devices those are
obviously on the edge so you can deploy
those as well uh but generally that
gives you an idea of edge Computing
[Music]
okay hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at cost and capacity
management Computing Services so before
we talk about them let's define what is
cost management so this is how do we
save money and we have capacity
management how do we meet the demand of
traffic and usages through adding or
upgrading servers so let's get to it the
first are the different types of EC
pricing models so you got spot instances
reserved instances saving plans these
are ways to save on Computing by paying
up in full or partially or by committing
to a yearly contract or multi-year
contract uh or by being flexible about
the availability Interruption to
Computing Services we have adus batch
this plans schedules and executes your
batch computer workloads across the full
range of adus Computing Services which
can utilize spot instances to save money
we have aabus compute Optimizer so
suggest how to reduce cost and improve
performance by using machine learning to
analyze uh you uh your previous usage
history we have ec2 autoc Scan groups so
asgs these automatically add or remove
ec2 servers to meet the current demand
all of traffic they will save you money
and meet capacity since you only run the
amount of servers you need then we have
elb so elastic load balcer so this
distributes traffic to multiple
instances we can reroute traffic from
unhealthy instances to healthy instances
and can Route traffic to ec2 instances
running in different availability zones
and then we have elastic beant stock
here which is easy for deploying web
applications without developers having
to worry about setting up and
understanding the underlying ad services
similar to Heroku it's a platform as a
service so not all of these are about
cost some of them are about capacity
management like elb um but yeah there
you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the types of
storage services and no matter what
cloud service provider using they're
usually broken down into these three
where we have blocks file and um uh
object okay so let's take a look at the
first so this is going to be for Block
storage so for AWS this is called
elastic Block store data is split into
evenly split blocks directly accessed by
the operating system and supports only a
single right volume so imagine you have
an application uh over here and that
application is using a virtual machine
that has a specific operating system and
then it has a drive mounted to it uh
could be using FC or uh scuzzy here um
but the idea here is when you need a
virtual Drive attached to your VM is
when you're going to be using block okay
the next one here is for um file or it's
just basically a file system so this is
Abus elastic file storage so the file is
stored with data and metadata multiple
connections via a network share supports
multiple reads writes locks the file so
over here uh we could have an
application but it doesn't necessarily
have to be an application and so it's
using NASA exports as the means to uh
communicate and so the protocols here
can be NFS or SMB which are very common
uh file system protocols
and so the idea here is when you need a
file share where multiple users or VMS
need to access the same drive so this is
pretty common where you might have
multiple virtual machines and you just
want to act as like one uh Drive uh one
example that could be like let's say
you're running a Minecraft server you're
only allowed to have one world on a
particular single drive but you want to
be able to have multiple virtual
machines to maximize that compute that'
be a case for that um so there you go
then the last one here is like object
storage and so for ads this is called
Amazon simple storage service or also
known as S3 so object is stored with
data metadata and a unique ID scales
with limited uh with limited no file
limit or storage limit so there's really
very there's very little limit to this
it's just basically scales up supports
multiple reads and wrs so there are no
locks and so the protocol here we're
going to be using htps and API so when
you just want to upload files and not
have to worry about the underlying
infrastructure not intended for high uh
IOP so input and outputs per seconds
okay so depending on how fast you have
to do your read and wrs are going to
determine you know whether you're going
uh this direction or the other way um or
you know how many need to actually
connect at at the same time and whether
it has to be connected as a mount drive
to the virtual machine
[Music]
okay hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're going to do a short
introduction into S3 because on the
certified Cloud practitioner they ask
you a little bit more than they used to
and so we need to be a bit familiar with
S3 because it is um at least I think
that abis considers its Flagship uh
storage uh service and it really is one
of the earliest Services it was the
second one ever launched okay so what is
object storage or object based storage
so data storage architecture that
manages data as objects as opposed to
other storage architectures so file
systems where uh these are others right
so which manages data as files and a
hierarchy and block storage which
manages data as blocks with with ins
sectors and tracks that get stored on an
actual uh drive and so uh the idea here
is we have S3 which provides basically
unlimited storage you don't need to
think about the underlying
infrastructure the S3 console provides
interface for you to upload and access
your data okay so we have the concept of
S3 objects so objects contain your data
they are like files but objects may
consist of a key this is the name of the
object a value the data itself made up
of a sequence of bytes the version ID
when versioning enabled the version of
the object metadata additional
information attached to the object and
then you have your S3 buckets so buckets
hold objects buckets can also have
folders which in turn hold objects S3 is
a universal name space so bucket names
must be unique it's like having a domain
name okay and one other interesting
thing is an individual object can be
between zero bytes and up to 5 terabytes
so you have unlimited storage but you
can't have uh files of uh incredible
size uh I mean 5 terab is a lot but
nothing beyond that for a single file
but just understand that you can
actually have a zerob byte file uh and
for like associate certifications that
can be a an actual question so that's
why it's
[Music]
there all right let's take a look at S3
storage classes um and so for the
certified Cloud practitioner we need to
know generally what these are for
associate levels we need more detail
than we have here but let's get through
it so adus offers a range of S3 storage
classes that trade retrieval time
accessibility durability for for cheaper
storage and so the farther down we go
here the more cost effective uh it
should get uh pending uh you know
certain conditions okay so when you put
something into S3 it's going to go into
the standard uh tier the default tier
here and this is uh incredibly fast it
has
99.99% availability 119 durability and
it's replicated across 3 azs and so uh
you know we have this cheaper meter here
here on the left hand side and that
would apply this is very expensive and
it's not actually expensive but it is
expensive at scale when you can uh
better optimize it with these other
tiers so just understand that um then
you have the S3 intelligent tiering so
this uses ml to analyze objects and
usage and determine the appropriate
storage class it is moved to the most
cost effective access tier without any
performance impact or added overhead
then you have S3 standard IIA which
stands for infrequent access this is
just as fast as S3 standard but it's
cheaper if you access the files less
than once a month there's going to be an
additional retrieval fee applied so if
you do try to retrieve data as
frequently as S3 standard it's going to
actually end up costing you more so you
don't want to do that okay then you have
S3 one zone IIA so as it says it's
running in a single zone so it's as fast
as S3 standard but it's going to have
lowered availability but you're going to
save money okay there is one caveat
though your data could get destroyed
because it's remaining in a single uh AZ
so if that a or data centers um suffer a
catastrophe you're not going to have uh
a duplicate of your data to retrieve it
okay um and then you have S3 Glacier so
for long-term clothed storage retrieval
of data can take minutes to hours but
it's very very very cheap and then you
have S3 Glacier uh deep archive which is
the lowest cost storage class but the
data retrieval is 12 hours and so you
know um all of these here to here these
are all going to be in the same uh ads
S3 console or Amazon S3 console S3
Glacier is basically like its own
service but it's part of S3 so kind of
lives in this weird State there's one
here that we didn't have on the list
here which is S3 outputs because it has
its own storage class and doesn't
exactly fit well into um this kind of
linear cheaper uh thing here
[Music]
okay hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at the a snow
family so this is storage and compute
devices used to physically move data in
or out of the cloud when moving data
over the Internet or Prov private
connection that is too slow difficult or
costly so we have snow cone snowball
Edge and snow mobile and so there
originally was just snowball and then
they came out with snowball Edge uh and
Edge introduced Edge Computing that's
why there's Edge in the name uh but
pretty much all of these devices have
Edge Computing uh and they do
individually come with some variance so
with the snowball snow cone it comes in
two sizes where it has 8 terabytes of
usable storage and then there's one with
14 tabt of usable storage for snowball
Edge technically Ally has like four
versions but I'm going to break it down
to two for you we have storage optimized
where we have 80 terab of use um uh of
usable storage there and then compute
optimize
3.9.5 terabytes and even though it's not
here you get a lot of vcpus and
increased memory which could be very
important if you need to do Edge
Computing before you send that over to
AWS and then last here we have
snowmobile which can store up to 100
pedabytes of storage um in the
Associates I cover these in a lot more
detail because there's so much more
about these like the security of them
how they're tamperproof like how they
have networking built in the the
connection to them but you know for this
exam that's just too much information um
you just need to know that there are
three uh three ones in the family and
generally what the sizes are and that
they're going to be all placed into
Amazon S3 what's interesting is that you
know snowmobile only does 100 pedabytes
but adus markets it as you can move
exabytes of of um content because you
can order more than one of these devices
so uh they'll mark it it saying like
snowball Edge is when you want to move
pedabytes of data and snowball Mobil is
when you want to move exabytes but you
can see that a single thing isn't in the
exib it's just in the petabyte
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at all the
itaba storage services in brief here so
let's get to it so the first is simple
storage service S3 this is a servess
object storage service you can upload
very large files and an unlimited amount
of files you pay for what you store you
don't worry about the UN file system or
upgrading the dis size you have S3
Glacier this is a cold storage service
it's designed as a lowcost storage
solution for archiving and long-term
backup it uses previous generation uh
HDD drives to get that low cost and it's
highly secure and durable we have
elastic Block store EBS this is a
persistent block storage service it is a
virtual hard drive in the cloud and you
attach to ec2 instances you can choose
different kinds of hard drives so SSD
iops SSD throughput HDD and um cold hhd
okay we have elastic file storage so EFS
it is a cloud native NFS file system
service so file storage uh you can mount
to multiple ec2 instances at the same
time when you need to share files
between multiple servers we have storage
Gateway this is a hybrid cloud storage
service that extends your on premise
storage to the cloud we got three
offerings to your file Gateway so extend
your local storage to Amazon S3 volume
Gateway caches your local drive to s
three so you have a continuous backup of
the local files in the cloud tape
Gateway so stores files onto virtual
tapes for backing up your files on very
cost effective long-term storage we got
one more page here because there's a lot
of services here we have adab us snow
family so these are storage devices used
to physically migrate large amounts of
data to the cloud and so we have
snowball and snowball Edge these are
briefcase size data storage devices
between 50 to 80 terab I don't believe
snowball is available anymore it's just
snowball Edge but it's good to have all
of them in here so we can see what's
going on we have snowmobile this is a
cargo container filled with racks of
storage and compute that is transported
via a semi trailer tractor truck to
transfer up to 100 pedabytes of data per
trailer I don't think we're going to be
ordering that anytime soon cuz that's
pretty darn expensive but that's cool we
have snow cone this is a very small
version of snowball that can transfer 8
terabytes of data we have adab us backup
a fully managed backup service that
makes it easy to centralize and automate
the backup of data across multiple a
services so ec2 EBS RDS DB EFS storage
Gateway you create the backup plans we
have Cloud endure disaster recovery so
continuously replicates your machine in
a lowcost staging area in your target
abl account and preferred region
enabling fast and reliable recovery in
case of it data center failures we have
Amazon FSX this is a feature Rich and
highly performant fall system that can
be used for uh windows so that would be
using SMB or Linux which uses luster and
so there we have the Amazon FS FSX for
Windows file server so use SMB protocol
and allow you to mount FSX to Windows
servers and then the luster one which
uses uh Linux luster file system it
allows you to mount F FSX Linux servers
are there any storage Services missing
here not really I mean you could count
elastic container repository as one but
um that's kind of something else or you
could also count maybe um uh code commit
but you know I kind of put those in a
separate category where we where those
are in our develop tools or our
containers
[Music]
okay all right so what I want to do is
show you around S3 so we'll make our way
up here and type in
S3 and we'll let it load here and what
we're going to do is create a new bucket
if you do not see the screen just click
on the side here go to buckets and we'll
create ourselves a new bucket so bucket
names are unique so let's say my
bucket and we'll just pound in a bunch
of numbers I'm sure you're getting used
to making buckets in this um in this
course so
far um so if we scroll on down notice
that it says block public access
settings for this bucket and this is
turned on uh like the blocking is turned
on by default because S3 buckets are the
number one thing that are a point of
entry for malicious actors where people
leave their buckets open so if we want
to uh Grant access to this bucket for
people to see this publicly we'd have to
turn this off okay but for now we're
going to leave that on you can version
things in buckets which is pretty cool
you can turn on encryption which you
should turn on by default and use the
Amazon S3 key on the certified Cloud
preder it's going to ask you about
client side encryption and server side
encryption so you definitely want to
know what these are I'm going to turn it
off for the time being so we can kind of
explore uh here by oursel here um then
there's object lock so we can lock files
so that um you know there you know
people aren't writing to the multiple
times so we'll go ahead and create a
bucket and it's very quick so here is
the new bucket we made and you'll notice
we have nothing here which is totally
fine if I go to
properties um you know we can see that
uh we can turn on bucket versioning turn
on encryption what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go grab some files I
remember I saved uh some files recently
here I'm just going to make a new folder
called Star Trek I just have some
graphics you can pull anything off the
internet you want to do this
yourself um but I'm just going to
prepare a folder here it'll take me a
moment
okay just a
moment okay great so now I have my
folder prepared and so what I want to do
is upload my first file so I can go here
and upload and actually I can upload
multiple files you can add a folder
which is nice and so in here if I want
to upload these files here whoops I'll
just select multiples I'll hit open
it'll cue them up which is really nice
we can see the destination details here
if we want to turn it uh versioning on
we could there uh we could apply
permissions for outside access but we
have uh things turned on but what's
really important is the properties where
we have these different tiers and So
based on the tier that you use the lower
you go at least it should be the cheaper
it's going to get uh but it's going to
have some trade-offs and we cover that
through the course then there's that
server side encryption um and I'm going
to hit upload we'll just individually
turn it on so you're going to see this
progress go across the top these have
all been uploaded I'm going to cck click
on my destination bucket and so what we
can do is we can uh open these if
they're images they'll show us right
here in the browser we can download them
so if we need to get them again all
right we can create a folder here and
just say Star Trek or Enterprise
D Enterprise D
here okay but it's not really easy it's
not like I can drag this into there um I
might be able there's no move option so
you'd actually have to copy it into the
destination and then delete the old one
it's not like using a file system you
know um there's a lot more work involved
but you know it's a great storage
solution um so let's look at encryption
so I have this selected here if I click
into it I can go to permissions I can go
to versions see that I'm looking for H
encryption here we go so if I turn it on
I can enable encryption and I can choose
whether I want to use an Amazon S3 key
so SS S3 so an encryption key that
Amazon S3 creates man uses for you then
you have
IUS SS KMS and I believe this uses AES
up here which is totally fine then you
have KMS down here and it's interesting
because they're like ads will manage the
key for you and then this one ads will
manage the key for you it's just
slightly different this one of course is
a lot simpler there's not many reasons
not to turn on encryption but U I'm
going to go turn this one so that it is
encrypted
here and just because it's encrypted
doesn't mean we can't access the file I
can still download it I can still view
it because ads is going going to decrypt
it right so if I go and click on this
one and I say open okay even though it's
encrypted I can still view it right it
just means that it's encrypted on the
storage right so if somebody were to
steal that hard drive whatever hard
drive it's sitting on on ads they could
even figure it out it's encrypted
they're not going to be able to open up
the file right so that is the logic
there but through here um I can get it
something that's really interesting with
um um S3 is the ability to um uh have
cycle events so I'm just kind of looking
where that is it's usually in the bucket
so if I go to management up here I can
set up a life cycle rule and what I can
do is say like move this to deep
storage okay and then I can say what it
is that I want to filter so maybe it's
like data.jpg
I can say apply to all objects in the
bucket I acknowledge that and we say
move current versions of objects between
storage classes and I checkbox that on
and I can say move them to Glacier after
30 days I think if I go lower it'll
complain probably when I save there and
so the idea is that we can move things
into storage so maybe you have files
coming in down below it's showing you
here right so a file is uploaded and
then after 30 days then move them in the
glacier so we save money okay that's a
big advantage of S3 there's a lot of
things going on in S3 here like you can
turn on
um uh wherever it is you can turn
on web hosting so you can turn this into
like a website down below here there's a
whole uh whole bunch of things that you
can do okay so uh we're not going to get
into that because that's just too much
work but uh you know we learned the
basics of S3 so what I want to do to
delete this I have to empty it first
watch it'll be like you cannot delete it
you need to empty the bucket first so go
ahead and empty it and I'll say my
bucket
empty or sorry I guess I have to type in
permanently
delete
Perma
net we delete no they used to oh yeah I
can copy it okay great and so once the
bucket is emptied I can go back to the
bucket and I'll go back one layer and
then I'll go ahead and delete my
bucket and you can only have so many
buckets I think it's like a 100 you have
like 100
buckets how many buckets can you have in
a WS
100 buckets yeah I was
right and I think if you wanted to know
how many you Pro there's probably like a
service limits page service limits
service
quotas so you go here you say a Services
S3 how many buckets 100 right there okay
so you know that gives you kind of an
idea what's going on there but there you
go that's
S3 all right so let's go take a look at
elastic Block store which is uh virtual
hard drives for ec2 so what I'm going to
do is make my way over to the ec2
console because that is where it's at
and on the Le hand side if we scroll on
down you'll see elastic block volumes or
elastic Block store volumes and so we
can go here and the idea is we can go
ahead and create ourselves a volume and
what you'll notice is that we have a few
different options here we have general
purpose provisioned iops cold HDD
throughput optimized magnetic magnetic
being um basically like uh physical tape
that you can use to back up like the old
school stuff and so you have all these
options here and you can choose the size
so when you change these options you're
going to notice that some things are
going to change like the through uh
throughput or iops so notice that
general purpose is fixed at between 300
to 3,000 and notice that it goes from 1
Gigabyte to how many ever that is that's
a lot there and so it's not too
complicated but in practicality I don't
really create volumes this way what I do
is I'll just go launch an ec2 instance
so I'll say launch ec2 instance and
we'll choose Amazon alytic 2 and again
you know if we haven't done the ec2
follow along we'll cover all this stuff
in more detail don't worry about it um
we go to configure instance then we go
to add storage and this is what you're
going to be doing when adding EBS
volumes um to your ec2 instances and
you'll notice we always have a root
volume that's attached to the ec2
instance that we cannot remove we can
change the size up here I believe the oh
it shows us right here that we have up
to 30 gigabytes so sometimes you might
want to Max that out to take advantage
of the free tier you notice we can also
change uh this there might be some
limitations in terms of the root volume
so notice that we have a few more
options here we can't have a cold HDD or
HDD as our root volume uh notice we have
a delete on termination so EBS volume
persists independently from the running
life so you can choose to automatically
delete uh EBS volume when the associated
instance is terminated so if you take
this off if the ec2 instance is deleted
the volume still remain which could be
something that's important to you uh for
encryption here um you might want to
turn it on and so generally adus always
has a KMS manage key which is free so
you checkbox that on it will be
encrypted uh you can turn it on later um
but you can never turn encryption off
but you should always uh turn the
encryption on and so just be aware to
turn that on you can also add file
systems down below here but maybe we'll
talk about that later because I think
that gets
into um e EFS okay so that is a
different type of file storage there but
that's pretty much all there is to it uh
you just go ahead and create uh your
volume there and then it would show up
under EBS we could take snapshots of
them to back them up that goes to S3 but
that's all we really need to know here
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look at
elastic file uh system or EFS uh storage
manage file storage what does EFS stand
for EFS system elastic file system okay
sorry and so what we can do is go ahead
and create a file system here so I'm
going to say my EFS and the great thing
is that it's basically a serverless so
it's only going to be what you consume
right so what you store and what you
consume um and I think that's what it's
going to be based on we have to choose a
VPC I want to launch it in my default
VPC and we have the choice of regional
or one zone um I guess this is going to
be based on what gets backed up to S3
possibly so one zone probably is more
cost effective but I'm going to choose
Regional and that's a new Option I never
noticed before I just opened it up to
see a few more things here we have
General Max iio bursting provision
things like that we'll hit
next we'll choose our
azs and uh then you might have to set up
a policy so I'm going to hit next here
you'll go ahead and hit create so you
know this is really interesting but the
trick to it is really mounting it to a
dc2 instance and that's kind of the pain
okay so if we go into this um you you
have to mount it and there are commands
for it so like EFS mounting Linux
commands okay I've done this in my
Solutions architect associate uh but you
know again I'm not doing on a regular
basis so I don't remember and so if we
go here I'm just trying to see if we can
see some code that tells us how to mount
it so mounting on an E2 uh uh uc2 Linux
instance with the EFS Mount helper um so
I don't know if they had that before but
that sounds interesting so pseudo Mount
hyphen T the file system the EFS
mounting
Point yeah this looks a lot easier than
what we had before okay so before I had
to enter a bunch of weird commands but
now it looks like they've boiled it down
to single command but once you have your
EFS
instance
um I'm going to assume that there is an
entry point here just clicking around
here seeing what we can see I would
imagine we have to create an access
point so my access
point sure I don't know if it's going to
let me just do that it did and so I
would imagine that you'd probably use an
access point let's go back here ifs
Mount point I think that's the same
thing I think the mount point and the
access point you create access points
and that's what you use uh we can go
here we can attach it so oh yeah here's
the command
so um Mount via DNS or Mount via IP
address
so it doesn't look too hard
we can try to give it a go I haven't
done it in a while it looks like they've
made it easier so maybe we'll try it out
okay so we go to ec2
here and I'm going to launch an instance
I'm going to choose Amazon L
2 okay we're going to go and choose that
and then we want to choose a file
system and
so it's going to mount to here
okay and storage is fine all this is
fine and I'm going to go ahead and
launch
this and I need a new key pair so create
a new key pair um this will be for EFS
example
okay we're going to download that key
pair there we're going to launch this
instance okay and then we're going to go
view this and as that is launching what
I'm going to do is open up my cloud
shell and I'm going to want to upload
this pen so again like before I'm going
to drag it to my desktop off screen and
then what I'm going to do is upload this
file so I have
it EFS
example okay we're going to upload
it because I just want to see if we can
access that EFS volume and so if I do
LS that's our old one one which I can
delete by the way I'm never going to use
that anytime soon
yes LS and I'm going just delete the
hello text there so it's a bit cleaner
for what we're doing and so we need to
chod that
400 uh EFS
example and we saw that's how like if
you want to try to connect to a server
remotely that's what you do right so I
believe that the drive is
mounted if I go to storage does it show
up
here doesn't show up under
here but
um what we're waiting for are these two
status checks to pass and then we can
SSH into this
machine and I'm just going to go back
here and take a look here so using the
EFS Mount helper so pseudo Mount hyphen
T EFS TLS this volume to EFS and so I
imagine it's going to mount it to EFS
here using the NFS client so I guess it
just depends on what we're going to have
available to us even if the status
checks haven't passed I'm going to try
to get into this
anyway um so what we can do is click on
this grab the public IP address we'll
type in
SSH um ec2 hyphen user at sign paste
this in hyphen I EFS example pem I
usually don't log in Via
SSH um but you know just for this
example I will and so I want to see if
this drive
exists usually be under mount right
there it is okay so it already mounted
for us so I can do touch hello
world.
text say pseudo
here I can say pseudo VI I'm going to
open up the file and say hello from
another computer
okay and so I've saved that file and
what I want to do
now
oops oh okay sorry I'm in the cloud
shell here but what what I want to do
now is I want to kill this
machine okay and what I'm going to do is
spin up another ec2 instance I'm going
to see if I when I mount that if that
file is there if it actually worked but
wow that is so much easier than before I
can't tell you how hard it was to attach
an EFS volume the last time I did it um
so we'll go ahead We'll add that and the
storage is fine we're going to go to
review here we're going to say launch
and I'm just going to stick with the
same key pair
there we're going to give that moment to
to launch and we're going to go to view
instances and so now this one is
launching as it's launching let's just
go peek around and see what we can see
so you know I imagine if we didn't add
that file system during the the boot um
and we were we're adding it after the
fact we probably could just ran that
line and added it really easily um I'm
not going to bother testing that because
I just don't want to go through that
trouble to do that um I still can't
remember what these access points are
for um but uh it's okay it's that's kind
of out of the scope for the certified
Cloud
partitioner and then so I'm just curious
so we get some nice monitoring here
right so that's kind of
nice um I guess they're trying to
suggest here like inabus backup data
sync
transfer so that would just be backing
up simplify uh automates accelerates
moving data okay that's pretty
straightforward transfer family fully
managed F SFTP okay so nothing exciting
there
and we're going to refresh that there
and this is initializing so let's go see
if we can connect to this one so I'm
going to go ahead grab that public IP
address I'm going to hit up okay I'm
going to swap out that IP address and
we're going to see if we can connect to
that machine yet so we'll say yes and we
got into it so that's great and so what
I'm going to do is go again into the
mount directory EFS FS1 LS and there it
is I'm going to do cat hello world and
so it works and so that's the cool thing
about DFS is that you have a file system
that you can share among other um uh ec2
instances I'm sure users could connect
to it using the NFS protocol I'm not the
best at like networking or storage
networking so I'm not going to show that
here to you today but that gives you a
general idea how EFS works again you
only pay for what you store it is
serverless so we'll go here and type
delete because I'm done with this I'll
probably uh destroy the instance first
so it doesn't get mixed
up and just so we clean up a little bit
better here I'm going to delete these
Keys
here uh
Delete okay and we'll go ahead and
delete this one as
well delete I'm done with
that uh we'll make sure that that is
tearing down that is good and we'll make
our way back over here and it says enter
probably the ID's name in so we'll enter
that in and we hit
confirm and we'll see is it deleting I'm
not confident with it I'm going to do it
one more time confirm that by entering
the the file systems ID so we'll put it
in
again is it destroying I cannot tell
there we go so it's destroying we are in
good shape it is gone our data is gone
um but yeah that is
[Music]
EFS all right let's take a look at um
the snow family in ads so if we type in
snow up here and we click into Adis snow
family this is where we can probably
order ourselves a device um I might not
be able to order them at least when I
originally looked at this like way back
in the day uh it wasn't available in
Canada so I'm kind of curious to see
what there is but the idea is that
you're going to go here and Order and
you have some options so you can import
into S3 or export from S3 and then down
below we have local compute storage so
perform local compute storage workloads
without transferring data you can order
multiple devices and clusters for
increased durability and storage Capac
so it sounds like you're not you're not
um transferring data you're just using
it uh locally on to um it's like
basically buying renting temporary
computers which just kind of interesting
I never saw that option before but we're
going to choose import into a ss3 and
we're just going to read through this
stuff and it's not my expectation that
we're going to even be able to submit a
job here and you probably don't want to
because it's going to cost money but I
just want to show you the process so we
can see what there is here so snow job
assistance if you're new to snow family
run a pilot of one to two devices so
batch file smaller than 1 Megabyte
Benchmark and optimize deploy St uh
staging
workstations discover and remediate
environmental uh issues early files and
folders name must conform to Amazon S3
prepare your Ami once the pilot is
completed confirm the number of snow
family devices that you can copy devices
to simultaneously follow the best
practices use the following resources to
manage your snow devices so we have adab
US Open Hub and then there's the edge
client CLI
so open Hub is a graphical user
interface you can use to manage snow
devices so that's kind of cool and then
we have the CLI which I imagine is is
something that's very useful to use so
just close those off here and then we
have other things so I can say I
acknowledge I know what I'm doing which
I don't really but that's okay and then
here we are going to enter in our
address so we say Andrew Brown and I'm
not going to I'm not going to enter this
in for real just whatever so it would be
Toronto exam Pro um Canada oh see so
there's there's the thing you can only
ship it to the US and so that's as far
as I can get okay um and that's the
thing is like if you really want to know
any of us inside or not you got to be in
the US but let's pretend that we do have
an address in the states what's a very
famous address so what is the address of
the White House
okay there it
is so I'm just going to copy that
in because again we're not going to
submit this for real I just want to see
what's farther down the line here
okay uh what's
NW is that the state it's in Washington
right is is this part of it NW Northwest
is that a thing I'm from Canada so I
couldn't tell you um so we'll go down
here and we have Washington do we have a
second address line it doesn't look like
it
um we have a zip code I believe this is
the zip code
and do we need a phone number looks like
we do
416 uh 111 11111 okay we have one day or
two day shipping why not just have one
right and so then we can choose our type
of device so we have snow cone snow cone
SSD snow cone optimized I'm surprised I
never took a screenshot of this earlier
um compute optimize things like that so
you can choose which one you want it
looks like we're gonna see some
different options but we'll go with snow
cone
my snow
cone and snow cones do not ship with a
power supply or ethernet cable snow cone
devices are powered by 45 watt CB C uh
USBC power supply I'll provide my own
power supply and cable do not ship with
a power supply res cable that's fine uh
snow con Wireless snow con connect your
wireless connection connect the buckets
you want there's the bucket we created
earlier Computing use compute using E2
instance is use a device as a mobile
data center by loading ec2 Ami so here's
an Ami that I might want to
use uh ad iot green grass validated Ami
not interested in Remote device
management you can use Ops Hub or Etc to
monitor reboot your device that's fine
and so then we need to choose our
security
key I don't know if we have to set the
service roll we'll see what happens here
and uh we'll let it update that's fine
and and so then I guess we just hit
create job and so I don't really want to
order one um so I'm not going to hit
that button and also it's going to go to
the White House and they're going to be
like Andrew Brown why did you do that so
that's not something I feel like doing
today but at least that gives you an
idea of that process there and I imagine
that uh if you go the other way it's
going to be pretty similar yeah it's
just like same stuff I think uh so you
it Sav that address it's not a real
address and the the options are a little
bit uh limited here and it's like NFS
Bas S3 Bas so it's slightly different
but it's basically the same process just
curious we'll take a look at the last
one
there since there are three options just
curious okay Sim similar thing okay so
yeah that's pretty much all I want you
to know about um the snow family and
that's about it
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at what is
a database so a database is a data store
that stores semi-structured and
structured data and just to emphasize a
bit more a database stores more complex
data stores because it requires using
formal design and modeling techniques so
databases can generally be categorized
as either being relational so structured
data that strongly represents tabular
data so we're talking about tables rows
and columns so there's a concept of row
oriented or column oriented and then we
have non relational databases so these
are semi-structured that may or may not
distinctly resemble tabular data so here
is a very uh simple example the idea is
that you might use some kind of language
like SQL put in your database and you'll
get back out tables for relational
databases let's just talk about some of
the functionality that these databases
have so they can be uh using a special
specialized language to uh query so
retrieve data so in this case SQL
specialized modeling strategies to
optimize retrieval for different use
cases uh more fine tune control over the
transformation of the data into useful
data structures or reports and normally
a database infers uh someone is using
using a a relational row oriented data
store so um you know just understand
that when people say database that's
usually what they're talking about like
postgress MySQL relational row store is
usually the default but obviously
there's a lot more broader terms there
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at what is
a data Warehouse so it's a relational
data store designed for analytical
workloads which is generally column
oriented data store okay so companies
will have terabytes and millions of rows
of data and they'll need a fast way to
be able to produce analytics reports so
data warehouses generally perform
aggregation so aggregation is the idea
of grouping data together so find a
total or an average uh and data
warehouses are optimized around columns
since they need to quickly aggregate
column data and so here is kind of a
diagram
of um a data warehouse and so the idea
is that it could be ingesting data uh
from a regular database here I'm just
getting out my pen tool so it could be a
regular database or it be coming from a
different data source that isn't
compatible in terms of the schema and
you use like ETL or elt uh or ETL to get
that data into that data warehouse so
data warehouses are generally designed
uh to be hot so hot means that they can
return queries very fast even though
they have vast amounts of data data
warehouses are in free quently access
meaning they aren't intended for
real-time reporting but maybe once or
twice a day uh or once a week to
generate business and uh user reports of
course it's going to vary based on the
um the service that is offering the data
warehouse a data warehouse needs to
consume data from a relational database
on a regular basis and again it can
consume it from other places but you'll
have to transform it to get it in there
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're taking a look at a key
value store so a key Value store or
database is a type of non-relational
database or nosql that uses a simple key
Value method to store data and so key
value stores are dumb and fast uh but
they generally lack features like
relationships indexes aggregation of
course there are going to be providers
out there have managed solutions that
might uh po fill some of those uh issues
there but I want to show you the
underlying way that key value stores
work to kind to kind of distinguish them
between document stores so a key value
stores literally a unique key alongside
a value
and the reason I'm representing that as
zeros and ones is because I want you to
understand that that's what it is it's
basically just some kind of of data
there and how the key value uh store
interprets it is going to determine what
it is so when you look at a document
database that is just a key value store
that uh uh interprets the value as being
documents right and so key value stores
can and do commonly store um uh multiple
uh like associate array that's pretty
common so even for Dynamo DB that's how
it does it and so that's why when you
look at a key Value Store it looks like
it uh a a table but it's not actually a
table it's schema list because
underneath it's really just um you know
that associative array and so that's why
you can have uh columns or sorry rows
that have uh different amounts of
columns okay so due to the design they
are able to scale very well beyond a
relational database and they can kind of
work like a relational database without
all the bells and whistles so hopefully
you know that makes sense
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look at
document stores so a document store is a
nosql database that stores documents as
its primary data structure and a
document could be an XML uh type of uh
structure but it also could be something
like Json or Json like document stores
are sub classes of key value stores uh
and the components of of a document
store are very uh comparable to
relational databases so just kind of an
example here where in a relational
database they'd be called tables now you
have collections they were called rows
now they're called documents you had
columns they had Fields they may have
indexes and then joins might be called
embedding and linking so you can
translate that knowledge over uh you
know they they're not as um they don't
have the same kind of feature set as a
relational database but you have better
scalability and honestly document stores
are just key value stories with some
additional features built on top of it
[Music]
okay hey it's Andie Brown from exam Pro
and we're going to take a look at the
nosql database services that are
available on AWS so we have Dynamo DB
which is a serverless no skill key value
and document database it is designed to
scale to billions of records with
guaranteed consistent data returned in
at least a second you do not have to
worry about managing shards and Dynamo
DB is 's Flagship database service
meaning whenever we think of a database
service that just scales is cost
effective and very fast we should think
of Dynamo DB and in 2019 Amazon the
online shopping retail uh shut down
their last Oracle database and completed
their migration to Dynamo DB so they had
7,500 Oracle databases with 75 pedabytes
of data and with Dynamo DB they reduced
that cost by 60% and reduce the latency
by 40% so that's kind of to be like a
testimonial between relational and a no
escol database so when we want a
massively scalable database that is what
we want Dynamo db4 and I really just
want to put that there because it if you
remember that you're going to always be
able to pass uh or get those questions
right on the exam okay then we have
document DB so this is a Noll document
database that is mongod DB compatible uh
so mongodb is very popular noo among
developers there were open source
licensing issues around using open
source mongodb so ad got around it by
just building their own mongodb database
basically so when you want a mongod DB
like database you're going to be using
document DB we have Amazon key spaces
this is a fully managed Apachi Cassandra
database so Cassandra is an open source
no esql key value database similar to
Dynamo DB that is column or store
database but has some additional
functionality so when you want to use
apachi Cassandra you're using Amazon
keyspaces
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at relational
database Services starting with
relational database service RDS and this
is a relational database service that
supports multiple SQL engines so
relational is synomous with SQL and
online transactional processing
oltp and relational databases are the
most commonly used type of database
among tech companies and startups just
because they're so easy to use I use
them I love them um RDS supports the
following SQL engines we first have
MySQL so this is the most popular open
source SQ database uh and it was
purchased and is now owned by Oracle uh
and there's an interesting story there
because when Oracle purchased it they
weren't supposed to have it um Mario DB
was or sorry myell was sold to Oracle
Sun systems and then within the year um
uh Oracle purchased it from them and the
original creators never wanted it to go
to Oracle um just because of their uh
the way they do licensing and things
like that and so um the original
creators came back and they decided to
Fork my
and then maintain it as Mario DB just so
that uh you know oracle never kind of
pushed away the most popular database so
that everyone had to go to a paid
solution then you have postest so psql
as it's commonly known is the most
popular open source SQL database among
developers this is the one I like to use
because it has so many Rich features
over my school uh but but it does come
with added complexity then Oracle has
its own SQL proprietary database which
is well used by Enterprise companies but
you have to buy a license to use it then
you have Microsoft SQL so Microsoft's
proprietary SQL database and with this
one you have to buy a license to use it
uh then you have Aurora so this is a
fully managed database uh and there's a
lot more to uh going on here with Aurora
so we'll talk about it it almost acts as
a separate service but it is powered by
RDS so Aurora is a fully managed
database of either myql so five times
faster or postgress SQL three times
faster database so when you want a high
available durable and scalable and
secure relational database for post
custom isqu you want to use Aurora uh
then you have Aurora serverless so this
is a serverless ond demand version of
Aurora so when you want the most of the
benefits of Aurora but you can trade uh
off to have cold starts or you don't
have lots of traffic or demand uh this
is a way you can use Aurora in a
serverless way then you have RDS on
VMware so this allows you to deploy RDS
supported engines to on premise data
centers uh the data center must be using
VMware for Server virtualization so when
you want databases managed by RDS on
your own database Center uh and yeah I
realize that this is a small spelling
mistake should say just on here but yeah
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're looking at the other
database services that abos has because
there's just a few loose ones here so
let's talk about red shift so it is a
petabyte siiz data warehouse and data
warehouses uh are for online analytical
process procing oap and data warehouses
can be expensive because they are
keeping data hot meaning that they can
run a very complex query and a large
amount of data and get that data back
very fast so when you need to quickly
generate analytics or reports from a
large amount of data you're going to be
using red shift then you have elastic
cache so this is a managed database of
an inmemory and caching open source
databases such as reddis or memcache so
when you need to improve the performance
of an application by adding a caching
layer in front of your web servers or
database you're going to be using
elastic cash then you have Neptune this
is a managed graph database the data is
represented as interconnected nodes I
believe that it uses Gremlin as the way
to interface with it which is no
surprise because that's what it looks
like most class providers are using so
when you need to understand the
connections between data so mapping
fraud Rings or social media
relationships uh very relational
database heavy information you're going
to want to use Neptune we have Amazon
time streams it's a fully managed time
series database so think of devices that
send lots of data that are
time-sensitive such as iot devices so
when you need to measure how things
change over time we have Amazon Quantum
Ledger database this is a fully managed
uh Ledger database that provides
transparent immutable cryptographically
variable transaction logs so when you
need to record a history of financial
activities that can be trusted and the
last one here is database migration
service DMS it's not a database per se
but it's a migration service so you can
uh migrate from on premise database to
adabs from two databases in different or
same adabs accounts using different SQL
engines and from an SQL to a nosql
database and I'm pretty sure we cover
this in a bit uh greater detail in this
course
[Music]
okay all right let's go take a look at
Dynamo DB uh which is ad's nosql
database so we'll go over to Dynamo
DB and what we'll do is create ourselves
a new table to say my Dynamo DB table
and you always have to choose a
partition key you don't necessarily have
to have a sort key but it could be
something
like um like you want it to be really
unique so it could be like email and
this one could be uh created at
right and so we have string binary
notice that the the types are very
simple then for settings we have default
settings or customized settings so the
default is use provision capacity mode
rewrite five rules Etc custom no
secondary indexes use KMS so I'm going
to just expand that to see what I'm
looking at we have two options here on
demand uh so simplify billing by paying
the actual reads and rights you use or
provisioned which is this is where you
get a guarantee of performance so if you
want to be able to do you know whatever
it is a thousand I don't know what it
goes up to but like a thousand read
writs per second then that's what you're
paying for okay you're paying for being
a having a guarantee of that um of that
capacity okay I'm not going to create
any secondary indexes but that's just
like another way to uh look at data
notice down below that we have a cost of
$2.9 uh then we have encryption at rest
so you can do owned by Amazon Dynamo DB
that's pretty much the same as like adab
us has or S3
has ssse S3 there you could use uh C
actually I guess both of these are
probably KMS I would imagine we'll go
ahead and create the table here
and that's going to create the table
this is usually really really
fast we'll go here and what we can do is
insert some data so as it's just
starting up here we can go over
to our tables they recently changed its
UI so that's why I look a bit
confused U view items up here okay and
then from here we can create an item so
I can add something say so Andrew
exampro doco and
uh well we'll just do the future so
we'll say 20
25 055 I don't want to have to think too
hard here but we can add additional
information so I can say like uh today
true we could say
um make like a
list uh you know food and then I could
go here here and then add a
string it is not working oh there we go
there we are so we could say like um
banana and then we could say pizza right
we can go ahead and create that
item and so now that item is in our
database uh we can do a scan that will
return all items we can query we can
actually have uh some limitations of
what we're choosing there's the party Q
editor so we can use SQL to select it um
I have not used this
before party Q um AWS or party Q Dynamo
DB
examples I'm hoping I can just find like
an example of some of the language
getting started here I don't need to I
don't need an explanation I just show me
an example query here and I will I'll
get to it
here okay so here's some examples right
so maybe we can give this a go uh um so
we have our table here so my
Dynamo DB
table and I just want the email
back we don't need a
wear we'll run this see if it
works there we go I'm not sure if we
could select additional data there so I
know that we had some other things like
uh
food
there it is okay so that's really nice
um addition to it dynb can stream things
into a Dynamo DB stream to go to Kinesis
and do a lot of fun things so there all
sorts of things you can do with Dynamo
DB but um I'm pretty much done with this
so I'm going to go ahead and delete this
table and notice that it also creat some
cloudwatch alarm so we want to delete
this as well create a backup no we do
not care go ahead and delete
that and that is Dynamo DB
[Music]
okay so now I want to show you uh RDS or
relational database service so go to the
top here type in RDS and we'll make our
way over there and so RDS is great
because it allows us to launch
relational databases um sometimes the UI
is slow I'm not sure why it's taking so
long to load today but every day is a
bit different and so what we're going to
do is go ahead and create a new database
uh you're going to notice that we're
going to have the op between creating a
standard or easy I stick with standard
just because I don't like how easy hides
a lot of stuff from us even here like it
says two cents per hour but it's not
giving us the full cost so I really
don't trust it because if you go down
here and you chose their Dev test here
look it's like $100 it's not showing the
the the cost preview right now maybe
because we didn't choose the database
type sorry I wanted to chose postgress
but before we do that let's look at the
engine types we have Amazon Aurora so we
have between myell and post postgress
MySQL Marb postgress Oracle Microsoft
SQL no for Microsoft SQL it comes with a
license you don't have to do anything
with that it might change based on the
addition
here uh nope comes with a license for
all them which is great uh if you want
to bring your own license that's where
you need a dedicated host right running
uh Microsoft SQL for Oracle uh you have
to bring your own license that's going
to be based on um importing with the Aus
license manager over go over to postest
which is what I like to use uh we're
going to set it to Dev test to try to
get the cheapest cost scroll down look
$118 we can get it cheaper we get super
cheap so here the password is going to
be testing one two three capital on the
T so and an exclanation mark on the end
okay because it has a bunch of
requirements of what it wants here I
want a T2 micro so I'm just going to
scroll down
here what is going on here standard oh
look M classes I don't want an m class
class I want a burstable class that's
the cheap ones and so we go here can we
still do a T2 micro or is it now
T3 so I don't see
T2 so I imagine a T3 micro must be the
new it free tier so we go it fre tier
here right and if I go
to
databases um RDS on the t2 micro 750
hours but I can't select
it
so I'm going to assume that the T3 micro
must be the new tier if it's not there
right unless it's saying include
previous
generations and then maybe I can see it
then okay so I don't see it
there I really don't like how they've
changed this on
me okay so the oldest I can choose is a
T3 micro which is fine I just I just
know T2 being the free tier that's all
uh this is fine we don't want Auto
scaling turned on for our example here
we do not want a multi-az so do not
create a standby that's going to really
jump up our cost we don't need Public
Access it will create a VPC that is fine
password authentication is fine we have
to go in here which I don't know why
they just don't keep that expanded
because you always have to come in here
name your database so my database we
choose your postest version here I'm
going to turn backups off
uh because if we don't if we don't it's
going to take forever to launch this
thing encryption is turned on you can
turn it off but generally it's not
recommended we can have performance
insights turned on I'm going to turn the
retention oh we'll leave it to seven
days because we can't turn that off we
don't need enhanced monitoring so I'm
just going to turn that
off and uh that's fine we're not going
to enable delete protection here and so
we are good we can now go ahead and
create our dat
database and what we'll do here is wait
for that database to be created so the
thing is is like if we're doing the
solutions architect or the developer
social stuff I'd actually show you how
to connect to the database um it's not
that hard to do like you just have to
connect uh grab all the database
information so it's going to have an
endpoint a port stuff like that and you
use something like table Plus or
something to connect to the database but
that's out of scope of the certified
Cloud partitioner I'm just going through
the motions to show you that you can
create an RDS database very easily but
not how to connect to it and actually
utilize it okay and so that would spin
up and we would have a server and after
that we can just go ahead and delete the
server here so to say delete me
okay and that's all there really is to
it there is the special type of um
database like Aurora doesn't have its
own like console page it's part of RDS
so if you want to spend up Aurora you
just choose the compatibility you want
you can choose between provisioned or
serverless um and serverless is supposed
to be really good for um scaling to zero
cost so that's something there so you
fill that all out but the initial cost
is a lot more expensive you can't choose
a T2 micro here um unless it lets you
now it is
for provision it's
uh oh T2 T3 medium is the smallest you
can go Okay so if you reach to the point
where using a a medium-sized database
then you might consider moving over to
Aurora just because it's going to be
highly scalable Etc like that um so
that's a consideration there there's
also something called Babble fish um
that it was announced last year when I
when I shot this um or when I'm shooting
this as of now and the idea was to make
it compatible with MyQ SQL Server to
migrate over to Aurora post SQL which is
kind of interesting um but that's about
it so if our database is destroying I
think it is just going to go back over
over here to
RDS it's taking a long time to load
today and uh I think it's already
deleted maybe we go to databases here
it's deleting so I'm confident it's
going to delete so there we
[Music]
go all right let's take a look at Red
shift so red shift is a data warehouse
and it's generally really expensive so
it's not something that you're going to
want to launch uh day to-day here but
let's see how far we can get with it um
just by running through it so what we'll
do is go ahead and create a cluster and
again you can just watch me do this you
don't have to create uh you don't have
to create one yourself uh so free trial
configure for learning that sounds good
to me uh is free for limited time if
your organization has never created a
cluster why rarely ever create these so
when the trial ends delete your cluster
to avoid the charges of on demand okay
that sounds fair um so here we're going
to have two vpcu it's going to launch a
d a DC to
large so let's look that up for
pricing show me prices please please
please
um I think it's loading right here okay
so I don't know how much it is but I
know it is not cheap and down below we
have sample data is loaded into your red
shift cluster that sounds good to me
ticket is the sample data
okay ticket sample
data red shift I just imagine they
probably have like a tutorial for it
here they do right
here and so because I want to know what
we need to do to query it right if we
can even query it via the interface here
so the admin user is adus user um and
the password is going to be capital T
testing 123 4 5 6 exclamation and we'll
hit create
cluster oh cool we can query the data
right in here so that's what I wasn't
sure about whether we would be able to
just query it in line because before
you'd have to use Java with j jdbc or an
odbc driver and download the jar and
it's not as fun as it sounds of course
but it looks like we can query data once
the data is
loaded so that looks really good I guess
we can pull data in from um the
marketplace so that's looks pretty nice
too and I guess we could probably integr
into other things like quick site
because you probably want to adjust your
data over
there again I usually don't spend a lot
of time in red shift um but it looks
like it's a lot easier to use I'm very
impressed with this so I don't know how
long it takes to uh launch a red shift
cluster I mean it is 160 gigabytes uh of
of of storage there it's uh even at the
smallest it's pretty large so what I'm
going to do is to stop the video and
I'll be back when this is done
okay okay so after a short little wait
here um it was lot lot faster than I was
expecting but uh it's available and so
looks like here it says to query the
sample data use red shift version two so
I'm going to click that and I'm sure
there's tons of buttons to get here and
it'd be great if it just populated the
query for me um it doesn't but this
looks really nice really nice UI I
wonder if it has like some existing
queries no that's okay so what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to go ahead and
pull out this query and see if we can
get this to work here never found out
what those prices were
though okay and what we'll do is hit run
I like how there's like a limit of 100
but here it has that so we'll go ahead
and hit run and see what data we get so
relation sales does not exist okay
so what's going on
here um we'll go up here so most of the
examples in the red shift documentation
uses uh a sample database call ticket
this sample uh this small database
consists of seven tables you can load
the ticket data set by following the
this
here okay so to load the sample data
from Amazon
S3 okay
so I would have thought it already had
the data in there I could have swore it
would
have
Dev
public
tables zero
tables okay so I don't think there's any
data in here and so we're going to have
to load it
ourselves I really thought it would have
added it for us uh let's go ahead and
create these tables and see if this is
as easy as we think so run that create
that
table cool okay we got it down
here we'll run that we just run each at
a
time I think there's seven of them
so date already exists okay that's fine
event already exists saying all these
tables
exist maybe I just wasn't
patient
okay um
interesting all right so maybe we'll go
back and uh run that query maybe we just
had to wait a little while for that data
to
load
run okay so you know what I think it was
doing this for us like if if the if it
did not create it for us we would have
to go through all these steps which is
fine because we're learning a little bit
about um uh red shift but um uh looks
like we just had to wait there so it
looks like you would run those you
download that you use the copy command
to bring it over there um it looks like
you can do all of this via the uh this
interface here and we've done a query so
that's kind of
cool um I imagine you probably could
like save it or export it what if we
chart it what happens okay you can chart
it that's kind of
fun can we export it out to oh just we
can save it I thought maybe it could
export out to Quick site but I I suppose
you'd rebuild it in quick site a but
yeah I guess that's it right there so
that's pretty darn simple so so what I'm
going to do is make my way back over to
Red shift because we are done for this
example and we will go over to clusters
here and I'm going to go ahead
and delete my
cluster
delete create file snapshot
nope
delete delete the cluster there we go so
I'm pretty sure that will succeed no
problem there and we are done with red
shift and red shift is super expensive
so just make sure that thing deletes
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look here at
Cloud native networking Services um and
so I have this architectural diagram I
created which has a lot of networking
components uh when people create
networking diagrams for adws they don't
always include all these things here
even though they're there so we're just
being a little bit verbo so you can see
okay the first thing is our VPC our
virtual private Cloud this is a
logically isolated section of the adus
cloud where you can launch adus
resources that's where your uh resources
are going to reside not all services uh
require you to select a VPC um because
they're managed by AWS but I wouldn't be
surprised if under the hood they are in
their own VPC Okay then if you want uh
the internet to reach your services
you're going to need an internet gateway
um then you need to figure out a way to
Route things to your various subnets and
that's where route tables uh come in
then we need to Def Define a region that
it's going to be which is a geographical
location on your network then you have
your availability zones which are
basically your data centers where your a
resources are going to reside then you
have subnets which is a logical
partition of an IP network into multiple
smaller Network segments um and these
pretty much map to your uh availability
zones if you're making one per a and
then we have knackles these act as a
firewall at the subnet level then we we
have security groups that act as a
firewall at the instance level so
hopefully that gives you a good overview
[Music]
okay all right so now let's take a look
at Enterprise or hybrid networking so we
have our on premise uh environment or
your private cloud and then we have our
ads account or our public Cloud so
there's a couple Services here that we
can Bridge them together the first is
ADS virtual private Network VPN it's a
secure connection between on premise
remote offices and mobile employees then
you have direct connect this is a
dedicated gigabit connection from on
premise data center to ads so it's a
very fast connection a lot of times the
direct connect we say it's a a private
connection but that doesn't necessarily
mean secure it's not encrypting uh the
data in transit so very commonly these
services are used together not just
singular okay um and then uh we have
private links and so this is where you
already uh are using ads but you want to
keep it all within ads never going out
to the internet okay so these are
generally called VPC interface endpoints
and then the marketing Pages call them
private links which is a bit confusing
but you know it just keeps traffic
within the aabus network so it does not
transverse out to the internet
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at vpcs and
subnets so a VPC is a logically isolated
section of the adus network where you
launch your adus resources and you
choose a range of ips using a cider
range so a cider range is an IP address
followed by this uh net mask or sub
submask and that's going to determine
how many IP addresses there are um and
there's a bunch of math behind that
which we're not going to get into um but
anyway so here is an architectural
diagram just showing a VPC with a couple
subnets so subnets is a logical
partition of an IP network into multiple
uh smaller Network segments and so
you're essentially breaking up your IP
ranges for vpcs into smaller networks so
just thinking about cutting up a pie
okay so subnets need to have a smaller
cider range uh to uh the vpcs represent
for their portion so uh 4/24 is actually
smaller which is interesting the the
higher the number gets the smaller it
gets and so this would allocate 256 IP
addresses and so that's well smaller
than 16 okay we have the concept of a
public subnet so this is one that can
reach the internet and a private subnet
the one that cannot reach the internet
and um these are not uh strictly
enforced by AWS so the idea is that when
you have a subnet you can just say don't
by default assign publicly assignable IP
addresses but it's totally possible to
launch an ec2 instance into your private
subnet and then turn on um uh the IP
address so you got to do other things to
ensure that they stay private or public
[Music]
okay hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are comparing security groups
versus knackles so I have this nice
architectural diagram that has both
knackles and security groups in them and
we'll just kind of talk about these two
so knackles stand for network access
control lists and they act as a virtual
firewall at the subnet level and so here
you can create an allow uh and deny
rules and this is really useful if you
want to block a specific IP address
known for abuse and and I'm going to
just kind of um compare that against
security groups because that's going to
be a very important difference okay so
security security groups act as a
firewall at the instance level and they
implicitly deny all traffic so you
create only allow rules so you can allow
an ec2 instance to access port on uh
Port 22 for SSH but you cannot block a
single IP address and the reason I say
that is because in order for you to
block a single IP address in Security
Group you would literally have to block
or you literally have to allow
everything but that IP address and
that's just not feasible okay so if you
can remember that one particular example
you'll always be able to remember the
difference between these two one other
thing that um any of us likes to do is
is ask which which ones are stateless
which ones are stateful but at the uh
Cloud partitioner level they're not
going to be asking you that
[Music]
okay all right let's learn a bit about U
networking with AWS so what I want you
to do is go to the top and type in VPC
which stands for virtual private cloud
and what we'll do is set up our own VPC
it's not so important that you remember
all the little bit of details but you
get through this so that you can
remember the major components so what
I'll do is create a new VPC I'm going to
call this my VPC
uh tutorial and here I'm going to say
10.0.0.0
sl16 the reason you're wondering why I'm
doing that if we go to
xyxy Z here um this tells you the size
of it so I go here and I put 16 so you
can see we have a lot of room if we do
24 it takes up it it it's smaller see so
this is basically the size of it right
the empty blocks over here so we're
going to have a lot of room so we do 10
00 16 we don't need IPv6 we're going to
go ahead and create that and once we
have that we can go ahead and create a
subnet which we will need so we're going
to choose our VPC we'll go down here and
say my Subnet
tutorial and we'll choose the first a z
you can leave it blank and it'll choose
it random and then we need to choose a
block that is smaller than the current
one so 16 would be definitely um uh well
16 is the size that we have now so we
can match that size but
10.0.0.0 sl24 would be absolutely small
okay so we go ahead and create that
subnet and so that is all set up now um
let's see if our route table is hooked
up so our route table says where it
links to and it says to local so it's
not going anywhere and that's because we
need to attach a u internet gateway that
allows us to reach the internet so if we
go over here and create a new internet
gateway we'll say my
igw and we'll go ahead and create that
and what we'll do is associate that with
our VPC we created here okay and so now
that we have the internet gateway
attached we want that subnet to make its
way out to the Internet so if we go to
the route table we can edit the uh route
table Association here I like how it
keeps on showing me this as if I don't
know what I'm doing um but I do and
so this would change that particular
Association but I want to add to that
route table so I thought when I click
that it would allow me to add more but
apparently I got to go to Route tables
over
here and I'm looking for the one that is
ours we can see that it's over here we
could even name it if we wanted to like
my rote
table notice then we apply uh uh uh
names it's actually just applying a tag
see over here it's always what that
is so we'll go over to routes and we
want to edit the routes and we want to
add a route and we want this to go to
and we're going to choose the internet
gateway
okay we're going to say save
changes and what that's going to allow
us to do is to reach the
internet um and so what I want to do is
go back to subnet I was just curious
about this I've never used this
before um so looks like we can just
choose some options here I'm not too
concerned about that but I assume like
that's used for debugging azers had
those kind of services for a long time
and so it has been starting to add those
so you can easily debug your network
which is nice so we have a subnet the
subnet uh can reach the internet because
there's a there's
um uh an internet gateway and it's
hooked up via the route table one thing
that matters is will it assign a public
IP address um so that is something that
we might want to look into it's not the
default subnet which is totally fine so
it says Auto assign is no so that might
be something that you might want to
change
so here we go to edit the r table
Association no it's not there they
changed it on me used to be part of the
uh setup instructions us to just
checkbox it now they moved it modify the
auto assign so we'll say enable so that
means it's always going to give it a
public IP address on
launch and while we're here I'm just
going to double check if I have any
elastic IPS I did not release okay just
double checking here and
so this is all set up and we should be
able to launch a um ec2 now within our
our new VPC so I'll go over here to
ec2
okay and I'm going to launch a new
instance say Amazon El
2 we're going to choose this tier
Here and Now what we should be able to
do is Select
that and that is our subnet there
okay go ahead and launch that I don't
care if we use a key whatsoever so I'm
going to go ahead and launch that there
okay we'll go
back and so there you go it is launching
so we created our VPC and we launched uh
in it no problem
whatsoever so hopefully that is pretty
darn
clear um so yeah uh what I'm going to do
is I'm going to let that launch because
I want to show you security groups So
within AWS you can set security groups
and knackles and that's going to allow
or deny access based on stuff and when
we launched this ECU instance it has a
default security group that was assigned
we could have created a new one but what
I might want to do is create myself a
new Security Group
here okay and you can end up with a lot
really fast like here's a bunch and I
can't even tell what's what so like
there's Bunch for load balancers and
things like that and so I might just go
ahead and delete a bunch of these
because I cannot tell what is going on
here and um we'll delete these security
groups and sometimes they won't let you
delete them because they're associated
with something like a network interface
or
something all right but um we need to
find out which one we're using right now
so the one that we are using is the
launch wizard 4 so we'll go into
here and I don't know if you can rename
them after they've been created I don't
think so which is kind of frustrating
because if you want to rename it it's
like I don't want that to be the name so
what's interesting is you can go here
and you can edit the
routes uh the rules sorry the inbound
rules and the outbound rules and so here
it's open on Port 22 so that allows us
to ssh in we could drop this down and
choose different things so if we want
people to access a website we go Port 80
and we say from anywhere ipv 46 so now
anyone can access it um you might want
to do something like give it access to
postgress that runs on Port 5432 things
like that um could be something else
like maybe you need to connect to Red
shift that's on that Port you can go
ahead and save those rules we're just
going to say uh from anywhere you can
even say my IP so maybe only I'm allowed
to connect to it right so you added
inbound rules you don't really ever have
to touch outbound rules it's set for all
traffic so it's stuff that's
leaving uh the that there one
interesting thing to note about uh
security groups is
that you don't have a deny option right
so let's say you only wanted a
particular IP address you only wanted um
let's say what's my IP my IP
address so that is my IP address and
let's
say I wanted to block it right so I go
here and I say okay I want to
block on all TCP I want to block this
number right but I can't do that all I
can say is I allow this number so in
order to do it I would have to enter
everything but this number in here and
you can enter ranges in with like these
forward slashes and stuff like that but
you would imagine that'd be really hard
because you have to start and go like
you'd have to start and go through every
single IP address in the world to get it
out of here and that's almost impossible
and that's the key thing I want to
remember about security
groups um so that's security groups and
there's also
knackles knackles um they're associated
with subnet so they probably show up
under VPC I rarely touch knackles rarely
ever have
to um I mean they're great tools but you
know for me I I just don't ever need
them so knackles are associated with
subnets so we can go here and try to see
my Subnet tutorial so we created our
subnet we got a knle for free and we can
set inbound and outbound rules and so
here here is where we could say Okay I
want to add a new
rule and I want to and I want to make
the rule number
150 you always do these in hundreds okay
or the power of 10 so that you can move
them around easily and I can say all
traffic that comes from this IP address
I'm going to put the for/ Z that just
means a single IP address and I say deny
right and so
now uh this my address I can't access
that ec2 instance okay if I try to go
there's nothing running on the server
but if I was to try to use it I wouldn't
be able to do it and and this applies to
anything for that subnet it's not for a
particular instance it's for anything in
that subnet so hopefully that is is
pretty clear there um but that's pretty
much all you really need to know I mean
there's lots of other stuff like Network
firewalls all these other things it gets
pretty
complicated um it's well beyond what we
need to learn here but uh what we'll do
is tear down that ec2
instance okay we'll terminate
that and once that instance is destroyed
we can get rid of our security group and
a bunch of other
stuff and there's always a bunch of
these darn
things so we'll say
delete
One Security Group
Associated so we go here this is the one
we are using but I want to get rid of
all these other
ones okay if I go here it could be
because like of inbound
rules so see this one because you can
reference another Security Group within
a security group so I'm just going to go
save that there say any my IP there
whoops
it's set to n uh NFS so that might have
been set up for our access
point or I could just delete it that'
probably be
easier okay so that's one that's kind of
of a
pain so I'm just looking for rules that
might be referencing other security
groups to get rid of
them okay let's try this again
we'll go ahead and delete I'm leaving
the
um I'm leaving the uh the defaults alone
because those come with your vpcs and
you don't want to get rid of
those so it won't let me delete this one
so I'm going to go edit that
rule delete it save it you might not
have this kind of clean up to do it's
just might be me here you
know um outbound
inbound let's try this again
here
delete and I'll open this one
up must be this one that is referencing
the other
one
I'm just going to delete the
rule and this is something that's just
kind of frustrating with AWS but it's
just how it is where sometimes it's hard
to get rid of resources because you have
to click through stuff so it's not
always a clean you might have like
lingering resources and this isn't going
to cost us anything but it's just the
fact that
um that it just makes things harder to
see what you're doing you
know
this last one really doesn't want to go
away so I'm just trying to delete all
the rules out of here get rid of
it can I delete this one
now one group associate it will not show
me what it's talking about okay here it
is
um okay this is referencing
it I think it was the one there was an
old one I don't know what this is
we'll go down
here and we'll go here and delete that
and while I've been cleaning all these
up now we can go over to our inst
instance make sure that it's terminated
it is good because if our instance is
not terminated we cannot destroy the VPC
uh prior the VPC could not be destroyed
unless you detach the internet gateway I
wonder if it's going to still complain
about
that we'll say yes it actually looks
like it includes it in the
cleanup typ delete
here there we go so we're all good we're
all cleaned up there you
[Music]
are hey this is angre Brown from exam
Pro and in this video I just want to
show you cloudfront so let's make our
way over to cloudfront cloudfront is a
Content delivery Network and it's used
to cash your data all over the place as
you can see I have some older ones here
if you have a splash screen what you can
do is just look for the left hand side
there might be a hamburger menu open
that up and then click on distributions
and what we're going to do is create a
new distribution if you don't want to
create one because these do take forever
to create um you can just kind of watch
along I don't even feel like I'm going
to hit the um the create distribution
button because I just hate waiting for
so long but the idea is that you have to
choose an origin and so the origin could
be something like an S3 bucket load
balancer media store this is where um
the the content distribution network is
going to Source its content right so if
I say this bucket here um and I just it
probably default to the root path the
idea is that it's going to be able to
pull content from there and then cach it
everywhere and then down below you can
say okay set the type of protocol
redirect to here you can set up uh
caching rules or like how often do you
want it to uh cash like cash a lot don't
cash a lot the great thing is like you
have these Edge or these um l Edge
function so you can uh read and modify
the request and response to the CDN
which is very powerful but what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to go look
at what we already have because again I
said they take forever to spin up and
we're not going to see too much if we do
so once it's spun up um this is what it
looks like so you'll have an origin it
says where it's poting to you can create
multiple Origins group them uh you can
modify your behavior so that was
basically what we were looking at before
as you can see we have our Behavior
there nothing super exciting
we can set up error Pages you can
restrict based on geographical locations
so if you're for whatever reason if you
if you're not allowed to serve content
in UK you could say exclude this
geographical region right so you have an
allow list or a block list saying like
Okay we can't do UK because like let's
say you just don't want to do um let say
England you don't want to do um uh gdpr
for whatever reason you could block out
I don't know why I'm having a hard time
here Britain England it's England right
United Kingdom there we go so you just
say okay forget United Kingdom I don't
have to do gdpr now uh for invalidations
the idea is that you know it is a cache
so things can get stale or just persist
and so here you can just type in say I
want to get rid of image.jpg and then
you create that invalidation and then it
will go delete it out of the cache and
so the next time someone requests
they'll get the the fresh content this
usually doesn't take that long but
that's pretty much cloudfront in a
nutshell
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at ec2 also
known as elastic compute cloud and so
this is a highly uh configurable virtual
server or it's also known as a virtual
machine and that's what we're going to
generally refer to it uh ec2 is
resizable compute capacity it takes
minutes to launch new instances and
anything and everything on adabas uses
ec2 instances underneath that's why we
generally call it the backbone to all
the adab services and uh you're going to
just have to choose a few options here
so the first thing you'll need to do is
choose your OS via your Amazon machine
image so that's where you get red hat
Ubuntu Windows Amazon Linux Seuss it
might also come with pre-installed
libraries and things like that then
you're going to choose your instance
type that's going to determine things
like your vcpus your memory so here you
can see how many there are and you'll
have like a monthly cost and that's the
name of the instance type then you have
to add storage so very commonly you're
attaching elastic block storage or
elastic files system system or service
uh and so you know if you do choose your
EBS uh you are going to have to
determine what type it is so whether
it's a solid state drive a hard disk
drive a virtual Magnetic Tape or even
attaching multiple volumes not just a
single one and the last thing is
configuring your instance so this is
configuring the security groups the key
pairs user data IM roles placement
groups all sorts of things so we will
experience in that because we will show
you how to launch it an ec2 instance and
it'll make a lot of sense if it does not
make sense right now okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at ec2
instance fames so what are instance
families well instance families are
different combinations of CPU memory
storage and networking capacity and
instance families allow you to choose
the appropriate combination of capacity
to meet your application's unique
requirements different instance families
are different because of the varying
Hardware used to give them their unique
properties and we do talk about this
thing about uh capacity reservation
where adus can actually run out of a
particular type of instance family
because they just don't have enough
Hardware in that data center and so you
have to reserve it but let's go through
the different types of instance families
the first is general purpose and these
are the names of the different families
uh very popular ones is the t2 um the t2
and one that's really interesting is the
Mac which actually allows you to run um
a a Mac server so these are great
balance of compute memory and network
resources so you're going to be using
these most of the time the use cases
here would be web servers code
repositories things like that then you
have compute optimize so um they all
start with C uh no surprise there
they're ideal for compute bound
applications that benefit from high
performance processor their edge cases
here are scientific modeling dedicated
gaming servers ad server engines things
like that then you have memory optimized
um and so there's a variety here these
are fast performance for workloads that
process large data sets in memory um
they're great for in-memory caches
inmemory databases real time big data
analytics then you have accelerated
optimize so this is your P2 P3 P4 things
like that these are Hardware
accelerators or co-processors these are
great for machine learning computational
Finance seismic analysis speech
recognition if you're doing um uh ML on
AWS you you'll start coming across these
types AWS technically has a separate
page on sagemaker ML machines but
they're all pulling from these instance
families okay then you have storage
optimize so I3 i3n things like that
these are highly High sequential read
and write access to very large data sets
on local storage the use cases here
would be no SQL in memory or
transactional databases data warehousing
for the certified Cloud practitioner you
just need to generally know these five
categories not the names of the instance
families if you're doing um Associates
or above you definitely want to know
these things in a bit more detail and I
want to say that commonly instance
families are called instance types but
an instance type is a combination of
size and family but even aws's do
mentation doesn't make this family
distinction clear but I know this
because you know in Azure they make that
very clear and and gcp and so I'm
bringing that language over here to just
kind of normalize it for you
[Music]
okay let's take a look at what ec2
instance types are so an instance type
is a particular instance size and
instance family and a common pattern for
instance sizes you'll see is things like
Nano micro small uh medium large xlarge
2x large 4X large 8X large and you know
generally they're to the power of twos
but sometimes it'll be like 12 14 16 or
it's even uh and so when you go to
launcher ec2 instance you're going to
have to choose that instance type and so
here you can see you know here is our T2
micro and then we have um the small the
medium the large the x large okay but
there are exceptions to this pattern for
sizes so you know there is one
particular one called uh Dot metal and
so that's going to indicate that this is
a bare metal machine and then sometimes
you get these Oddball ones like 9x large
so you know the rule of power of two or
even numbers is not always the case uh
but generally it'll be pretty even for
you know the start here okay uh just
talking about instance sizes so the easy
to instance sizes generally double in
price and attribute so uh just bringing
up these numbers a little bit closer
starting at the small here you're going
to notice one two doesn't maybe double
there but four and here we see 12 2 4 uh
almost doubles there almost doubles
there but I want to show you that the
price is generally almost double so 16
33 67 135 and so a lot of times like you
always have the option to say okay do I
want to go to the next instance size up
or have uh an additional instance of the
same size and sometimes it's a better
approach to get an additional instance
because then you can distribute it
across another a uh but then you also
meet additional capacity so there you
go
[Music]
so we talked about dedicated instances
and hosts a little bit but let's just
make that distinction very clear so
dedicated hosts are single tenant ec2
instances designed to let you bring your
own license so Bol based on machine
characteristics and so we'll compare the
dedicated instance to the dedicated host
across isolation billing uh physical
characteristics visibility Affinity
between a host and instance targeted
instance placement automatic instance
placement and add Capac using allocation
request so for isolation for dedicated
instance you're going to get instance
isolation so you can have the same
customer on the same physical machine
but there is virtualization there for
them and there's a guarantee of that um
for a dedicated host you have physical
server isolation so you get the whole
server for billing uh on a dedicated
instance it's per instance billing and
it's going to have an additional fee of
$2 per region and for dedicated host
it's per host billing so it's a lot more
expensive but you get the whole machine
uh for visibility of physical
characteristics you're not going to get
any of that information for a dedicated
instance for dedicated host you are such
as sockets core host host ID and this is
really important when you have a bring
your own license and they're saying this
license is for x amount of corers or x
amount of sockets then we have Affinity
so there's no affinity for dedicated
instance for dedicated hosts you'll have
consistency with deoy to the same
instance to the same physical server uh
there's no control of Target instance
placement for dedicated instance you do
have control on a dedicated host for
auto automatic instance placements you
have it for both and to add capacity
using allocation requests it's a no for
dedicated instance and it's a yes for
dedicated host so I want to come back to
the main point that's what's highlighted
here is that on a dedicated host you
have visibility of sockets core host ID
and this is really really important when
you're bringing your own licens byol
such as um you know Microsoft SQL
servers where you have to specify the
menac cores and things like that
[Music]
okay so we've been talking about uh
tendency and I just wanted to make it
very clear uh the difference between the
different levels of tendency on AWS so
we have three okay so we got dedicated
host so your server lives here and you
have control of the physical attribute
so basically the whole server okay uh
then we have dedicated instances so your
server is on the same uh a physical
machine as other customers but the
actual slot that you have the dedicated
instance will always be the same uh and
then we have uh the default so your
instance will live somewhere on the
server uh and when you reboot it it's
going to be somewhere else so there's no
guarantee that it's going to be in the
same place every single time
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and in this follow along we're going
to be looking at ec2 and also um
services that are adjacent to it so like
Auto scaling groups load balancers
elastic IPS things like that so we fully
understand ec2 um you don't have to know
tons for the exam but you should be able
to go through the motions of this with
me so that you can cement that knowledge
um for some of those deeper Concepts
like working with key Pairs and things
like that so let's make our way over to
the ec2 console and learn what we can
learn um and generally when you go to
the ec2 console it'll bring you to the
dashboard for whatever reason it didn't
bring me there and then the idea here is
that on left hand side we can make our
way over to
instances okay and this is where we can
launch our first instance so if we go
here and launch our instance the first
thing we're going to be presented with
is to choose our am or Amazon machine
image and so that is a template that
contains the software configuration so
the operating system applications and
other binaries that would be installed
on that OS by default all right and so
we have a variety that we can choose
from in the quick starts and generally
the ones that you're going to see first
are the ones that ad support so there
are uh um Amis or operating systems that
ads will support when you contact them
and then there's ones that are outside
that where uh they'll still help you
with but they might not have the
knowledge on so just understand that if
you pick from these core ones you're
going to be in good shape uh the most
popular is the Amazon Linux 2 because
it's part of the free tier and it is is
very minimal and well hardened by AWS so
it's a very good choice there but you
can see you can install a bunch of
things so like if you want to launch a
Mac OS server you can absolutely do that
a red hat uh Suzie Ubuntu a Windows
Server you name it they have it um if
you wanted something more farther out
there you can go to the marketplace and
uh subscribe to one that is managed by
company basically everything exists
Under the Sun here or you could get a
community Ami so these are ones that are
contributed by the community for free
but we're going to go back to quick
start here and what I want you to notice
is that there is this Ami ID that's how
we can uniquely identify what we are
using IF if we were to change region
even with the same Amazon L 2 instance
this thing will change so just
understand that it is regional based and
it comes in a 64bit variant and a arm
variant and so we're going to be using
the x86 here you can notice here you can
change it on the right hand side we're
going to stick with x86 I'm going to go
ahead and hit next so now we're going to
choose our instance type and so this is
going to decide um uh greatly how much
we're going to be spending because the
larger it is the more we're going to
spend so see this T2 micro if we
wandered into the pricing for that we go
to
ec2 pricing
AWS and once we get to ec2
pricing we want to go to on
demand and from here this will
load and so down below we can kind of go
find our price it should show us it
should show us the list ah here it is
okay so I can say a T2
micro and we can see the On Demand is
this so it seems really cheap what you
got to do is do the math so so if you do
time 7:30 that's how many hours there
are in a month if we launch a T2 micro
and let's say we didn't have the free
tier we you do if you first made your
account you're going to have 700 750
hours for free with the free tier but if
you didn't it would only cost you $8 and
and 46 USD okay so just be aware of that
if you ever need to figure something out
go there copy it do the math 7:30 it's
pretty easy so here we have a T2 micro
and the t2 family it's going to have one
V VC CPU notice that it has a V for
virtual so there could be more than a
single CPU on the underlying Hardware
but we're only going to have access to
one virtual CPU we have one gigabyte of
memory it's for low to moderate Network
performance so that's a factor that can
change if you need like uh uh gigabit
stuff like really fast connections for
on Prem hybrid connections and you have
specialized servers for that but for
this this is fine the TT micro is great
uh if you want you can also search uh
this way to see all the instance
families and things like that you can
filter for current Generations all
generations so this is fine okay so from
there we're going to go to configure our
instance type you can say let's launch
multiples of these instances let's turn
on spot to uh save money and try to bid
for a particular price we can change our
VPC it's going to default to the default
VPC um if you have no subnets just going
to pick one at random here which is fine
um whether to Auto assign a public IP
address if you do not have an IP address
you cannot reach the internet so
generally you want this to be enabled
this is dependent on the subnet whether
it will default to enabled but doesn't
matter if you have an ec2 instance in a
private or public subnet you can always
override this and give it a public IP
address you have placement groups which
allows you to play servers together
closely not something for the certified
Cloud partitioner there's capacity
reservations so if you're worried about
any us running out of this you can
reserve capacity so that's kind of
interesting domain join directory this
isn't something that I've done much with
but I imagine that has something to do
with um a direct active directory or
something like that to join information
then you need to uh have an IM roll and
we absolutely do need an IM roll here so
what I want you to do is create a new Ro
just going to close off these other tabs
here and we will go wait a moment create
a new role here and we want to do this
for ec2 so we say ec2 is what we're
creating the rule for we'll hit next and
um I don't know if I have a policy but
I'm going to go ahead and um well I
don't need to make a new policy but I
just want SSM and the reason I want SSM
is so that I can um uh use sessions
manager to log in so we don't have to
use key pairs we will use key pairs but
if we didn't want to use it that's what
we could do and this used to be the old
Ro and'll tell you hey go use this new
one here so I just want to make sure I
know which one it is and so we'll just
checkbox that on we'll hit next we can
add tags right here it' be uh well
actually we don't need to add any tags
here so that's fine we'll hit next and
then I'll just say uh my SSM ec2 roll
okay and we'll create that
rooll and now that we have created that
Ro we can go back to our first tab here
and give this a refresh and then drop
down and it should show up
here if we go down here a little bit we
could turn on extra monitoring there is
monitoring built in but if you wanted to
uh monitor it to a lower uh like it more
frequently you could do that as well we
want share tendency right this is where
you change the dedicated instance or
dedicated host obviously these class
more but we're going to stick with
shared elastic inference so this is for
um uh attaching a a fractional GPU great
for ML not something that we want
there's credit specification I don't
remember seeing this before selecting
unlimited for credit specification
allows for to burst beyond the Baseline
so it's for bursting here you can attach
an uh EFS uh so if you need a file
system that you want to mount or attach
um then there's the Enclave option so
Nitro Enclave enables you to create is
compute environments to further protect
your uh and securely processed highly
sensitive data so it might be something
you might want to checkbox on um based
on your use case and then down below our
we have our ability to enter our user
data and this is something we want to do
because we want to install aachi so that
we have something to work with here so
what I'm going to do is make a shebang
so that is a pound and an exclamation
mark I know that's really small so I'll
try to bump up my font here so you can
see what I'm doing and we're going to do
a forward SL bin and a for bash on the
next line here we're going to do yum
install hyphen y
httpd um that's going to install Apachi
and why it's not called Apache I don't
know why but they call it
httpd there's no Apachi in the name
there and so we'll say system CTL start
httpd system CTL enable httpd so we're
saying start up Apachi and then make
sure that it stays running if we restart
our machine very simple so from there we
will go to our our storage we'll say add
our storage and this is at 8 gbes by
default we could uh uh turn that up to
30 if we like so you can go all the way
up to 30 if you like um and you might
want to do that but I'm going to leave
it at 8 we could change our volume type
I'm fine with gp2 because it's very cost
effective and if we want to turn on
encryption and you should always turn on
encryption there's no reason not to and
so we'll turn that on it's not like it's
going to cost you more it's going to be
the same clost it's just your choice
there if do want to add a tag yes we're
going to add a name and we're going to
say my ec2 instance
okay and so that's going to give us a
name which is something we would really
like to have then we have a security
group I'm going to just create a new
security group called my um ec2 SG here
and just say my ec2 SG something you
cannot do is rename a security group
once you've made it so make sure you
don't make a spelling mistake up here
and we want to be uh accessing that httt
HTT or it's going to launch a website so
in order to do that we need to make sure
we have HTTP as a type with the port ad
open and we want it from anywhere so
we'll say anywhere and that will be
0.0.0.0 for size0 and that's for the
ipv4 this is for the IPv6 okay so we'll
just say
internet and this is for SSH right and
for this um I would probably suggest to
say my IP but since we might be using a
cloud shell to do that we're going to
leave it as anywhere so that we don't
have any issues connecting so from here
we'll r and launch and you can review
what it is that's going on here it's
going to say here hey you have an open
port that's okay we we want the internet
to see our website because that's the
whole point there and we'll go ahead and
launch it it's going to ask for a key
pair we can go down and say proceed
without key pair but what I'm going to
do is I'm going to create a new key pair
because I want to show you how those
work and I'm sure we've already done in
this course once but we'll do it again
and so I'm going to just name this as my
ec2 instance here and then we're going
to go download that key pair it's going
to download a pem file there and so now
we can go ahead and launch that
instance and while that is launching so
I'm going to just close this other tab
here we're going to click on The View
instances and so here is that instance
that's how we put the tag so we could
have a name there we're going to wait
for that to start but as that's going
I'm going to make a new tab by just
right clicking here on the logo click
anywhere pretty much to do that and uh
once we do that we'll click on cloud
shell
and as that is going what I want to do
is take this pen down below I'm going to
move it to my desktop to make it easier
for me to upload I'm doing this off
screen
okay and uh once this environment is
running I'm going to go ahead and upload
that okay so we'll just give it a moment
to do that we're also waiting for the
server to spin up as you'll notice there
is a public IP address here it says it's
running so if we want we can copy it
we're looking for those two checks to
pass so the server could be available
but generally you want to wait for those
two system checks because one says Hey
the hardware is fine the Network's fine
things like that okay but if I take that
IP address paste it on it up here we
have the web page so that is working uh
no problem there so that's great and
we'll go over to Cloud shell and that is
still starting uh it's not the fastest
but that's just how it is and um you
know we'll get going here in a second as
soon as this decides to
load there we go so it's loaded I can
type clear here just to clear that
screen out and so what I want to do is
upload that PM file so I'm going to go
and upload that file we're going to go
ahead and select it I'm going to go to
my desktop here whoops my desktop and we
are going to choose my ec2 instance pem
all right and from there we'll hit
upload and that's going to upload that
pem
file once that is uploaded we're going
to do
LS okay and so uh this is from a
previous tutorial so I'm going to go
ahead and just delete that other one
there we'll say remove EFS example pem
yes okay we'll type
clear and then what we can do here is
Type in chamod and um I believe it's 400
and what do we call this my ec2 instance
PM if you hit tab it will autocomplete
which is nice and if you do lsen la we
can take a look at that file and see it
should look like this should have only
one R here here so the idea is you're
locking it down so it's not writable or
executable it's just readable because
that's what you have to have it if you
want to SSH and so if we want to ssh
what we'll do is hit the connect button
here and we have four options they just
give you too many options it's going to
be a fifth one for sure soon but right
now we're talking about SSH so for SSH
um we had to chamod our file which we
did and then we need to use this DNS to
connect to it and so this is the full
line here if you click on this copy that
over and paste it in
that should be everything and notice
we're doing ec2 user followed by this
you could put the IP address in here
instead if you preferred so if you were
over
here you could go and take that IP
address which is I think shorter nicer
but um you know if you just click that
one button it works that's fine you
always have to accept the uh the
fingerprint then you'll be inside the
instance you can type who I to see which
user you are you're the ec2 user that's
the user that ads creates for their
Amazon Linux instances um it's going to
vary per um Ami so not all Amis have an
ec2 user it might be something else but
that's generally the ones that a US uses
for their supported ones and so if we do
um an LS again we're in the server right
now we can tell because it says right
here or we do a PWD we can kind of just
kind of look around so I think it's
going to be at VAR ww that's where HT
httpd or Apache always uh puts their
files here so if I go in here whoops I'm
just looking looking for um the index
file so I thought the index file was
in cdar
WW
HTML well where the heck is it so I'm G
to just touch a file here and see if it
overrides
it oh I don't care I'll just type
Pudo and what we can do is just try to
restart this system CTL um there's a
very similar command that's like uh
service and so I always forget the order
of it so I think it'd be I'm just
checking um probably uh restart
httpd and so failed to restart the
policy was not provided as the name
service um
Service uh maybe
pseudo there we go and so if we go back
here I'm going to see if it changed
because it will take whatever is in the
index HTML file so if there's no file
there it's going to uh show that there
and so what I can do is I can edit this
file I'm going to type VI index HTML and
um I'm going to hit I for insert mode oh
says it's readon so what we have to do Q
uh colon Q
quit oops uh clear LS and so what we
need to do is do pseudo VI index HTML
and so Vim every single key is a hotkey
okay um and I'm not teaching Vim here
but I'm going to teach you the basics
but the idea is that when you're here
notice that the cursor is blinking when
I hit I it enters insert mode now I can
type normally so I'd say hello uh hello
Cloud okay and I'm going to hit escape
to go back to um navigation mode
whatever you want to call it I'm going
to hit colon so it brings up the command
I'm going to type in uh write and quit
Okay and hit enter and so I'll type
clear and so whoops clear and so we'll
hit up till we get that command pseudo
system CTL restart hbd we'll hit that
hit
enter okay and it should restart pretty
fast there it is it says hello Cloud I
probably didn't even have to restart it
to do that but anyway so now that
instance uh you can see how we're
updating that so what I want to do is
just do a sanity check and make sure
that if we restart this instance that
we're going to be able to um have a poy
running that's something you should
always do if you have an app and you or
anything and you install it restart your
server make sure that everything works
so what I'm going to do is uh just hit
exit here so we go back to the top level
cloud shell type clear I'm going to go
back over to my ec2
instance might have to click around to
find it here and what I want to do is
reboot it okay and if I reboot the
machine the IP address is going to stay
the same okay so if I reboot it the IP
address is going to to stay the same and
the reboot is going to happen really
fast if we want to observe that reboot
we could go over to um here on the right
hand side go to the system log and it
would show us that it it had
rebooted I think so yeah it does cloud
in knit there I think it
rebooted not sure um but anyway if it's
rebooted then we can go ahead and
connect and make sure everything's fine
so let's just go here and hit enter and
let's see if the what the web page is
here
notice that it's hanging right so it's
probably because it's still
restarting even though it doesn't look
like it is and that's something that you
have to understand about the cloud is
that you have to think about what you're
doing and have confidence that it is
happening and also just double check it
but uh that's something that can be kind
of frustrating because these are
globally available Services uh uh
they're massively scalable and so one of
the trade-offs is that you don't always
have the most uh responsive uh uis ads
has one of the most responsive uis out
of all the major providers but even
still like sometimes I have to second
guess myself but the page uh right now
is not working now it is so it's fine so
it just took time for that to reboot and
so um what I want to do is connect a
different way so we're going to go here
and we're going to hit um we're going to
checkbox that on we're going to hit
connect and instead of using SSH client
we're just going to go to sessions
manager and hit
connect and this is the preferred way of
connecting because you don't have to
have this this SSH key and that's a lot
more secure because if someone has that
key and you you know you hand it to
someone they could hand it to somebody
else and then you have a big problem on
your hands so here this looks very
similar but if you type who am I it
actually logs in as the SSM user which
is kind of annoying so I type in sudo Su
I have to do this hyphen here and then
I'm going to say the user I want to be
which is E2 user and then if I type who
am I we are the correct user you can't
do anything in that SSM hyphen user or
or SSM user so you got to switch that
over and I can bump this up to make it a
bit larger so this is obviously not as
nice as working over here or even in
your own terminal but it's a lot more
secure and it's tracked and all these
other things so we really should be
using it
okay and um I really don't like having
to bump this up with my HTML I'm going
just go back to zero there there's
probably like a way to configure that
but anyway uh let's just go and take a
look at our
file I'm going to type VI again and
we're going to do VAR www HTML index
HTML I'm going to put pseudo in front of
there and again remember you have to hit
I to go into insert
mode and uh what I'm going to do is just
take capitalize that hello Cloud give
that exclamation mark colon WQ to quit
WR quit going to go back here refresh
okay so we don't have to restart our
server which is nice all right so um
that's that that's pretty clear so I'll
hit terminate
here and I don't think we need Cloud
shell for anything so I'm just going to
close that and so that's pretty much it
when it when it comes to working with an
an ec2 instance and so the next thing I
want to show you is elastic IP
[Music]
okay okay so now I want to show you
elastic IP uh commonly abbreviated to
EIP and so all that is it's just a um a
static IP and IP that does not change
because this ec2 instance here notice
that it's 54 163
4104 and what would happen if we were to
stop this instance not reboot it but
stop it because for whatever reason we
had to or
or um for whatever reason and if we were
to stop this instance and we were to
restart
it
okay uh and we have to wait for it to
stop but that IP address is going to
change
okay so 54 1634 104 hopefully we can
observe that I'm just going to write
that down so we do not forget so I can
prove to you that it does
change and now that it it's still
stopping here so as that's stopping
we're just going to go ahead and get our
elastic IP and I will'll prove that as
we go here so I'm going to go over to
here and so what I want to do is Reserve
or allocate an elastic IP address and so
I'm going to say us
east1 and it's going to say from the
Amazon Pool of ipv4 addresses so ads has
a bunch of IP addresses they're holding
on to and so you can just allocate one
and once you've allocated that's your IP
address so coming back to here okay this
is stopped notice there is no public IP
address we're going to start it
again okay and then we'll just checkbox
it on and we just have to wait a little
while to see what the IP address is
going to be I'm going to tell you it's
going to be something
else so if I go back here this is
54235 12 110 and our original one was 54
163 4 104 so the the reason why it's
important to have the same address is
that if uh you have a load balancer well
not a load balancer but if you have a
domain pointing to your uh your server
and you reboot then the rout you have a
dang a dangling um path or route where
uh Revenue 3 was going to be pointing to
nothing and so Aus does have things to
mitigate that like aliases and things
like that but um in general you know
there's cases where you just have to
have a static IP address and so we had
allocated one over here and if we want
to assign it we're going to associate
that elastic IP address we're going to
drop it down choose the cc2 instance um
I suppose the private IP as well and
then we're going to go ahead and hit
allocate or
associate and once it's Associated it
should now have 34 199 121 116 so we go
over
here and we're going to take a look here
and that's its IP address we can pull it
up okay and that's that so yeah that's
the lastic
[Music]
IP okay so now that we um have our
lastic IP we have our ec2 instance
running let's say um you know we lose
the server we terminate it so we would
lose all of our configuration so if we
wanted to bake this Ami to save it for
later what we'd have to do is go and
create an image so to do that we go to
the top here and we go to images and
templates and we can create an image or
we can create a a a template which is a
lot better but for the time being we're
going just go ahead and create an image
and when you create an image you're
basically creating an Ami and so here
I'm just going to say uh my
ec2 and I'm going to go 0 to just kind
of like number it so that's a very
common numbering just do three zeros and
then increment by one and so here I can
just say my Apachi server and so it's
going to save some settings like the
fact that there is a a volume you could
uh save some tags there and so I might
go ahead and add a tag and you'll say
name and we'll just say my ec2 server or
so that it remembers that
okay and then what we'll do is go ahead
and create our image and so this can
take a little bit of time if we go over
to uh images
here it's going to be spinning for a
while and uh we'll just wait until it's
done okay all right so after waiting a
little while here our Ami is ready so
we're just waiting for it to go
available if you do not see it just make
sure you hit the refresh um because
sometimes ads will just been forever um
and so that's just something you'll have
to do so you know hopefully that makes
sense what we'll do is is go make our
way back over to instances here and we
can launch one this way well actually we
can do it over from um the Ami page so
what I'm going to do is just terminate
this instance we're all done with it
okay and we'll hit terminate it's
totally fine and it had a message about
elastic IPS about releasing them so when
it does that the elastic IP is still
over here so it did not release it so
what we're going to do is go ahead and
disassociate the elastic
IP okay and then we're also going to
release the IP address because if we
don't we're going to have this IP
address that's sticking around that
we're not using it this is going to
charge us a dollar month over month so
just be aware of those because that's
just kind of like a hidden cost there
but what we're going to do is go over to
Ami and we're going to select it here
we're going to go to actions we're going
to go ahead and
launch and what it's going to do is make
us fill out all this other stuff again
so if you had made a launch template uh
we wouldn't have to fill out all this
stuff it'd be part of it but that's what
I'm trying to show you with this Ami
stuff so um instead of filling out all
this what I'm going to do is now go
create a launch template just to kind of
show you that that would be a much
easier way to
work so we go over to E2 instances and
then left- hand side we're looking for a
launch template launch launch
configurations is the old thing um
launch templates here we go so what
we'll do is create ourselves a launch
template we'll just say my apachi
server and then down below we need to
choose our Ami so we're going to go here
and we need to type it in so what would
we call it my
ec2 I really don't like this uh search
here it's very slow and frustrating but
once we find it whoops that's why I
don't like it because a lot of times
it'll be loading and you'll end up
clicking the wrong
thing okay
so I don't like this okay we'll type in
my give it a
second
there it is just wait because it will
keep loading and then once it's loaded
hit
enter and so it has that instance
selected and then from there uh don't
include in the launch template so here
we could be explicit I would say I want
this to be two T2 micro but we could
exclude it if we wanted to we could
specify the key pair here um not that we
really want to use key pairs we'll say
my ec2 instance then down down here for
the networking we can specify uh that
security group we created so we created
one here called my ec2
SG um storage is fine it's going to be
encrypted network interface is fine
Advanced details what I want to do is
set the IM instance profile that's
really important because we don't want
to have to figure out that roll every
single time so we'll put that there and
that should be everything and we could
put user data in there but it's already
baked into our Ami so we don't have to
worry about anything so what I'm going
to do here is go ahead and create this
launch template and then we're going to
view this launch template temp plate and
so now what we can do is then use it to
launch an instance okay and so we're
going to look here and it's very similar
to dc2 except it's vertical so we're
going to have one instance it's going to
use that Ami that instance type so you
can see how you can override them which
is nice we're going to check the
advanced details make sure that I am
profile is set and we'll go ahead and
launch this from a
template so from there we can go ahead
and click the instance value there and
just be aware that when you do click
through links like that you'll end up
with the search so I was just checkbox
that off so I can see what I'm doing and
so we're just waiting for this instance
to show up and the only thing I noticed
is it didn't said are darn tags so I
wanted the name in there and I think
it's because we said it in the Ami but
it didn't carry over to the launch
template so I'd have to go back to the
launch template and update it probably
so if I go into here into the launch
template um we can probably modify
create a new
version and then add tags there we say
name uh my uh Apachi
server I realize I'm changing it between
them and so that should allow us to have
a version two so we'll create that and
but anyway that will be for the next
time we launch it okay and so this
instance is running I'm going to go grab
the IP
address the server may or may not be
ready we'll take a look here and so it's
just spinning if it's spinning it's
either the server is not ready or um um
our ports not open so it was just
getting ready to work there so it is
working now so that is our launch
template so now you know we don't have
to worry about losing our stuff and if
we need to make new versions We can just
bake new Amis and increment them at uh
Inc and attach them as new versions of
that launch template
[Music]
okay all right so what I want to show
you in this follow along is to set up an
auto scaling group for our ec2 instance
and the idea behind this is that um
we'll be able to always ensure that a
single server is running or uh increase
the capacity if the demand requires it
so in order to create an Autos scaling
group we can go all the way down below
to here um and so you know I really
don't like the Autos scaling group form
but it's okay we'll work our way through
it so the first thing is we'll have to
create our or name our Autos scaling
group so we'll just say my ASG and then
we'll have to select a launch template
which is great because we already have
one and then we'll have to select the
version I'm going to select version
version two so that it applies that tag
name and we'll go to next and so here um
it's going to need to select a VPC and
then we need some subnets so we're going
to choose three just because to have
high availability you have to be running
in at least three different availability
zones so that's why we have three
different subnets and then down below we
have the instance type requirements so
uh T2 micro launch template looks good
to me so we'll go ahead and hit
next and then from here we can choose to
do a load balancer and so I want to do
the load balancer separate so we won't
do it as of yet but very often if you're
going to have an H group you're going to
usually have a load balancer but we'll
talk about that when we get to that
point there so we'll just go to the
bottom here and hit next and so this is
what's important so how many do you want
to be always running and so we always
want to have one and maybe the maximum
capacity is two and you want the desired
cast capacity be to be around a
particular number so if you had three
and you said the desired is two um there
are things that could try to work to
always make sure there's two but we just
want to have one for this example we can
set up uh scaling policy so I do Target
tracking scaling policy and so here we
could do it based on a bunch of
different things so if the CPU
utilization when were 50% it would
launch another server so that might be
something we might want to set so I'll
we're not going to uh try to trigger the
scaling policy but we might as well just
apply because it's not too hard then you
can also do a scaling uh scale in
protection policy so if you want to make
sure it does not um uh reduce the amount
of servers that's something you could do
we can add a notification to say hey
there's a scaling policy happening here
which is fine we don't have to worry
about that um and there's tags so add
tags to help you search filter Etc um so
I'm going to put a tag here I'm going to
say name I'm just wondering if this is
going to attach to the ec2 in or this is
for the auto scaling group you can
optionally choose to add tags to
instances by specifying tags in your
launch templates so we already did that
so I don't need to put a tag here and so
we can review our um Auto scaling group
and go ahead and create that auto
scaling
group okay and so that auto scaling
group expects there to be a single
instance so what it's going to do is
it's going to start launching an
instance and so what I'm going to do is
just get rid of this old server because
we don't need it anymore this old one
here
okay and you can already see okay that
the load balancer is launching this new
one here and remember we updated our
version two to have that name so that's
how we know that it is so if we go back
over to our autoscaling
group okay it's now saying there's an
instance we don't have a status as of
yet and so there are ways of doing a
status checks to for to determine
whether or not the server is
working um because if the server is
unhealthy what it would do is it would
actually kill it and then start up a new
one right so if I go down below it's
right now doing an ec2 health check and
the ec2 health check just means that is
the server working right um is it
running it doesn't necessarily mean like
hey can I load this web app um but you
know it's very simple so we'll give it a
moment here to start up and just make
sure that it's
working okay and I think it's ready so
if I take that public IP address here
and paste it in there it is okay so if
we were to tell it to increase the
capacity to three then what it would do
is it would launch three and then it
should probably launch it all evenly to
those other it should evenly launch it
to all those other uh availability zones
and then we'll have something that is
highly available okay so that's pretty
much it for this and then we'll move on
to Auto scaling
[Music]
groups all right so we have our uh ec2
instance now managed by an Autos scaling
group and the great thing is that if we
terminate this instance this Autos SC
group will launch another uh instance to
meet our particular capacity um the only
thing though is that if we were to have
multiple E2 instances running like three
of them um how would you distribute
traffic to the allall right so you know
you have an IP address coming in from
the internet uh but let's say you want
to evenly distribute it and that's where
a load balcer comes into play and even
if you have a single server you should
always have a load balancer because it
just makes it a lot easier for you to
scale when you need to and you it acts
as an intermediate layer where you can
attach a web application firewall you
can attach an SSL certificate for free
so there's a lot of reasons to have a
load balancer so what we'll do is go
down below on the left hand side and
we're going to make our way over to load
balancers and we're going to create
ourselves a new load balancer so I'm
going to hit create load balancer here
and you're going to see we have a lot of
options application load balcer Network
load balcer Gateway load balcer and then
the classic load balcer and so we are uh
running an application so I'm going to
create an application load Bouncer and
here I'm going to say my ALB um for an
application load balancer this is going
to be internet facing it's going to be
ipv4 um we're going to let it launch in
the default um subnet and we're going to
choose the same the same uh uh azs right
so that we get the same subnets as our
that are in our Autos scan group and
that's really important okay and then
here um you know we need to have a
security group and I just feel like
selecting the same one here because that
should work no problem there and we want
to make sure that we can listen on Port
80 and that it's going to forward it to
a a um a Target group it looks like I
might have a Target group there from
before so just to reduce that confusion
you won't have this problem I'm just
going to double check if that's true so
do I have a Target group from there from
before yes I do that came
from I'm not sure it might have been
created by um elastic bean stock and
wasn't deleted okay so I'll go back over
to here just so there's less confusion
and we were selecting our Target group
so we're going to have to create a new
Target group so we go over here and here
you can choose whether it's instance IP
Lambda application load balancer so you
could point it specifically to an IP
address and so if it was a static IP
address that would make sense uh
apparently you can Port uh point it
directly to instances I don't remember
seen that option before I guess that
makes sense yeah no sorry that makes
sense because that would go to uh vpcs
okay or sorry U asgs Autos scaling
groups it's just that you are pointing
them to Auto scaling groups you're not
pointing them to instances so that's why
that's confusing so I'm going to say my
um Target group it'll be for Port 80
here um protocol http1 is fine we want
to be in the same U VPC so that's fine
as well and down below we have our
health check and so the for slash means
that it's going to hit the index HTML
page and so if it gets back um something
healthy and that that something healthy
is going going to be um uh Port 80 then
it's going to be considered good and
then we can say the threshold of check
so I'm just going to reduce this so it's
not so crazy so we'll say three uh two
and then 10 okay and then it expects
back A200 which I think that's what
we'll get back so we'll go ahead and hit
next and so now we have our Target group
and it should register instances so it's
saying hey we detected this and this
fits the requirements for this so this
is now
uh this e two instance is now in this
target group okay so we can go back over
here and we can now drop down and choose
whoops hit the refresh
button and choose our Target
group so I'm not seeing it here so I'm
going to go back over here oh we didn't
create it
okay and now we can go back hit refresh
and there it
is and yeah that looks all good so we'll
go ahead and hit create load balcer
we can view the load balancers and these
create really fast if we scroll on up
what we can do is now access our server
through this DNS name okay so we copy
that paste that on in
there does it
work not as of yet so if it's not
working there because we did say look at
these instances another way is to
directly associate your Autos scaling
group with the load balancer so if I go
into here and we hit uh
edit there is a way aha load bouncer
so we want to associate this way and we
want to say this target group
here and also while we're here we might
as well set it to elb so it's going to
use the elb check so that makes it so
the Autos scaling group if it wants to
uh restart a server it's going to use
the elb's check which is a lot more
sophisticated and then what we'll do is
go hit
update okay
and now if we go back over to our load
balancer we just going to close some of
these tabs so it's less
confusing uh load balcer
here I think we should be able to see
through here whether it is seeing it
let's go down below listeners monitoring
integrated Services no it's going to be
through the target
group
okay
I mean it already had it there so maybe
it's just that it hasn't finished the
check so over here it has a health
status check oh now it's healthy okay so
if it's healthy in the Target group and
the load bouncer is pointing to it then
it should technically work so we're
going to go ahead
and uh copy the DNS again here make a
new tab paste it
in and there it is okay so that's how
you're going to access um all your all
your instances that are within your
autoc scaning groups you're going to
always go through the DNS and so if you
had a row 53 uh domain like you had your
domain managed by AWS you just point to
the load balancer and that's how you
hook it up so that's pretty much it so
yeah there you
[Music]
go all right so there you go we learned
everything we wanted to know about ec2
so the the last thing to do is to tear
everything down so we have a load balcer
we have an autoc scanner group um and
those are the two things we'll have to
pull on down so the first thing would be
to take down the autoscaling group and
when you delete an Autos scaling group
it's going to delete all the ec2
instances so we'll do it that way if you
tried to delete the ec2 it would just
keep on spinning up so you have to
delete that first and so as that's
deleting then we'll be able to delete
our load balancer I'm going to try
anyway to see if I can delete it at the
same
time and so I'll go up here I'm going to
go ahead and delete that uh load
balancer actually it did work no
problem going to make sure I don't have
any elastic
IPS I'm going to also make sure I don't
have any key pairs you can keep your key
pairs around but like I just want to
kind of clean this up
so
okay okay and that instance should be
terminating got to go back to the Autos
scan group
here
if we click into it we can check um its
activity
here so it's just saying successful so
it is waiting on elb connection draining
which is kind of annoying because we
deleted elb so there's nothing to
drain um draining is just to make sure
that uh you know there's no
interruptions when terminating services
so just trying to be smart about
it
and all I want to see is that it's just
saying terminating over here and then I
think we're
done okay so we'll just have to wait a
little while here okay and I'll see you
back in a moment okay all right so after
waiting a very long time it did destroy
so if I go down over to uh my load
balcer here you're going to see that it
does not exist so there was that
connection draining thing which was kind
of annoying it's probably because I
deleted the load balancer first and then
the um the uh the Autos scaling group
second and probably connection draining
was turned on but it's not a big deal we
just waited it and it did eventually
delete so we're pretty much all done
here so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at ec2
pricing models and there are five
different ways to pay with ec2 remember
ec2 are virtual machine so we have on
demand spot reserved dedicated and AD us
save savings plans so what we'll do is
look at these in summary here and then
we'll dive deep onto each of these
different pricing models so for on
demand you are paying the a low cost and
also you have a lot of flexibility with
this plan uh you are paying per hour so
this is a pay as you go model uh or you
could be paying uh down to the second
which we'll talk about uh the caveats
there when we get to the on demand
section this is suitable for workloads
that are going to be short-term spiky
unpredictable workloads uh that cannot
be interrupted and it's great for
firsttime application
and the on demand pricing model is great
when you need the least amount of
commitment for spot pricing you can see
we can save up to 90% which is the
greatest Savings of out of all these
models here uh the idea here is you're
requesting spare Computing capacity that
adus is not using and that's where
you're going to get that savings you
have flexible start and end times uh but
your workloads have to be able to handle
interruptions because these servers can
be stopped at any time to be giving to
more priority customers uh and this is
great for non-critical background jobs
very common for like scientific
computing
uh where jobs can be started and stopped
at any given time this has the greatest
amount of savings then you have Reserve
or reserved instances this allows you to
save up to 75% this is great for steady
state or predictable usage you're
committing uh with AWS uh for ec2 usage
over a period of one or threee terms you
can resell un uh unused reserved
instances so you not totally stuck with
this if you buy them this is great for
the best long-term savings then you have
dedicated so these are just dedicated
servers and technically not a pricing
model but more so that the fact that it
can be utilized with pricing models um
but the idea here is it can be used with
on demand reserved or even spot this is
great when you need to uh have a
guarantee of isolate hardware for
Enterprise requirements and this is
going to be the most expensive uh so
yeah there you go and we'll dive deep
here
[Music]
okay so the on demand pricing model is a
pay as you go model where you consume
compute and then you pay later so when
you launch an ec2 instance by default
you are using that on demand pricing and
On Demand has no upfront payment and no
long-term commitment you are charged by
the second up to a minimum of 60 seconds
so technically a minute or the hour so
let's just talk about the difference
between those uh per second billing and
those per hour billing so per second are
for Linux windows windows with SQL
Enterprise windows with SQL standard
windows with SQL web instances that do
not have a separate hourly charge and
then everything else is going to be um
per hour and so you know when I'm
launching ec2 instance I can't even tell
when something's per second or per hour
you just have to know that it has a
separate hourly charge but generally you
know if you're just launching things
it's going to probably be the per second
billing when you look up the hourly or
the uh the pricing it's always shown in
the hourly rate so even if it is using
uh per second billing when you look up
that pricing it's always going to show
it to you like that but on your bill
you'll see it down to the second okay up
to the first 60 seconds in on demand is
great for workloads that are short-term
spiky or unpredictable uh but when you
have a new app development this is where
you want to experiment and then when
you're ready to uh start saving because
you know exactly what that workload is
going to be over the span of a year or
three that's where we're going to get
into reserved instances which we'll
cover
next
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at reserved
instances also known as RI and this is
um a bit of a complex topic but uh you
know if we do get through it it's going
to serve you well through uh multiple
adaa certifications so let's give it a
bit of attention here so RI is designed
for applications that have a steady
state predictable usage or required
Reserve capacity so the idea is that you
are saying to ads I'm going to make a
guaranteed commitment uh saying this is
what I'm going to use and I'm going to
get savings uh because abos knows that
you're going to be spending that money
okay so the idea here is that the
reduced pricing is based on this kind of
formula where we have term class
offering the ra attributes and payment
options technically the ra attributes
don't exactly factor into it other the
fact that they an our attribute could be
like the instance type size uh but I'm
going to put that in the formula there
just because it is an important
component so let's take a look at each
of these components of the formula to
understand how we're going to save so
the first is the term so the term uh the
idea here is the longer the term the
greater the savings so you're committing
to a one-year or threeyear contract with
AWS um and one thing you need to know is
that these do not renew so at the end of
the year the idea is that you have to
purchase again and when they do expire
your instances are just going to flip
back over to On Demand with no
interruptions to service then you have
class offerings and so the idea here is
the less flexible the offering the
greater the savings so the first is
standard and this is up to a 75
reduction in the price compared to on
demand and the idea here is you can
modify some ra attributes which we'll
we'll talk about when we get to the um R
tribute section there then you have
convertible so you save up to 54%
reduced pricing compared to on demand
and you can exchange uh RIS based on the
r attributes if the value is greater or
equal in value and there used to be a
third class called schedule but this no
longer exists so if you do come across
it just know that ads is not planning on
offering this uh again for whatever
reason I'm not sure why uh then there
are the payment options so the greater
upfront the greater the savings so here
we have all upfront so full payment is
made at the start of the term partial
upfront so a portion of the cost must be
paid upfront and the remaining hours in
the terms are build at a discounted rate
and then there's no upfront so you are
build at a discounted hourly rate for
every hour within the term regardless of
whether the reserv is being used and
this is really great this last option
here because basically you're saying to
AWS you're saying like I'm just going to
pay my bill as usual but I'm going to
just tell you what it's going to be and
I'm going to save money so if you know
uh that you're going to be using a T2
medium for the next year uh you can do
that and you're just going to save money
okay so RIS can be shared between
multiple accounts within an organization
and unused RIS can be sold in the
reserved instance Marketplace but we'll
talk about the limitations around that
when we get a bit deeper in here just to
kind of show you what it would look like
in adus console and they updated it I
love this new uh UI here the idea here
is you're going to filter BAS on your
requirements and that's going to show
you RIS that are available and then
you'll just choose the desired quantity
you can see the pricing stuff there
you're going to add it to cart you're
going to check out and that's how you're
going to purchase it
[Music]
okay so another factor to that formula
were RI attributes and sometimes the
documentation calls them RI attributes
sometimes they call them instance
attributes but these are limited based
on class offering and can be uh uh can
affect the final price of the r instance
and there are four R attributes so the
first is the instance type so this could
be like an M4 large and this is composed
of an instance family so the M4 and then
the instance size so large okay then you
have the region so this is where the
reserved instance is purchased then you
have the tendency whether your instance
runs on shared so the default which uh
would be multi-tenant or a single tenant
which would be dedicated hardware and
then you have the platform whether
you're using Windows or Linux even if
you're using on demand of course this
would just affect your pricing but there
are some limitations around here which
we'll get into as we dive a bit deeper
here with RI
[Music]
okay all right let's compare Regional
and zonal Ri so when you purchase an RI
you have to determine the scope uh for
it okay so this is not going to affect
your price but it's going to affect the
flexibility of the instance uh so this
is something you have to decide so we're
going to talk about Regional RI which is
when you purchase it for a regional and
zonal RI when you purchase it for an
availability Zone so when you purchase
it for regional RI it does not Reserve
capacity meaning that there's no
guarantee that those servers will be
available so if ads runs out of those
servers uh you're just not going to have
them but when it's zonal uh you are
reserving capacity so there's a
guarantee that those will be there when
you need them um in terms of uh AZ
flexibility uh you can use the regional
RI for any AZ within that region but for
the zonal ri you can only use it for
that particular region we're talking but
instance flexibility um you can apply
the discount to uh any instance in the
family regardless of the size uh but
then when we're looking at a there is no
instance flexibility okay so you're just
going to use it for exactly what you
defined you can cue purchases for
regional RI you cannot cue purchases for
zonal Ri so there you
[Music]
go let's talk about some ra limits here
so there's a limit to the number of
reserved instances that you can purch
purchase per month and so uh the idea
here is that you can purchase 20
Regional reserved instances per region
and then 20 zonal reserved instances per
a so if you have a region that has three
azs you can have uh 60 um zonal reserved
instances in that region okay there are
some other limitations here so for
regional limits you cannot exceed the
running on demand instance limit by
purchasing Regional reserved instances
the default for on demand limit is 20 so
before for purchasing your RI ensure on
demand limit is equal to or greater than
your RI you intend to purchase you might
even want to open up a service uh limit
increase just to make sure you don't hit
that wall for zonal limits you can
exceed your running on demand uh
instance limit by purchasing zonal
reserved instances if you're already uh
have 20 on demand instances and you
purchase 20 zonal reserved instances you
can launch a further 20 on demand
instances that match the specification
of your zonal reserved instances so
there you go
[Music]
let's talk about capacity reservation so
ec2 instances are backed by different
kinds of hardware and so there is a
finite amount of servers available
within an availability Zone per instance
type of family remember an availability
zone is just a data center or a
collection of data centers and they only
have so many servers in there so if they
run out because the demand is too great
you just cannot spin anything up and so
that's what's happening you go to launch
specific ec2 instant type but Abus is
like sorry we don't have any right now
and so the solution to that is capacity
reservation so it is a service of ec2
that allows you to request uh a reserve
of VCU instance type for a specific
region and a so here you would see that
you just select the instance type
platform AZ tendency the quantity and
then here you might manually do it
specify time or you might say okay I
can't get exactly what I want but can
give me something generally around uh
that kind of stuff or that type that I
want so the reserve capacity is charged
at the selected instance type on demand
rate whether an instance is running in
it or not and you can also use Regional
reserved instances With Your Capacity
reservations to benefit from billing
discounts so there you
[Music]
go so there are some key differences
between standard and convertible Ri so
let's take a look at it here so the
first is that with standard RI you can
modify your tributes so you can change
the a within the same region you can
change the scope uh from a zonal RI to
original RI or vice versa you can change
the instance size uh as long as it's a
Linux and it has the default tendency
you can change the network from ec2
classic to VPC and vice versa but when
you're looking at convertible you you
don't modify R tributes you perform an
exchange okay and so standard RIS cannot
do exchanges where convertible RI you
can uh exchange during the term for
another convertible r with new R
attributes and this includes instance
family in in type platform scope and
tendency um in terms of the marketplace
you C uh they can be bought in standard
RI uh in the marketplace or you can sell
your RI if you uh don't need them
anymore uh but for convertible RI they
cannot be sold or bought in the
marketplace you're just dealing with ads
directly
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the
reserved instance Marketplace we had
mentioned a R so let's give it a little
more attention here so it allows you to
sell your unused standard RI to recoup
your spend for RI you do not intend or
cannot use so reserved instances can be
sold after they have been active for at
least 30 days and once databus has
received the upfront payment you must
have a US bank account to sell RI on the
ri Marketplace there must be at least
one month remaining in the term for the
ri you are listing you will retain the
pricing and capacity benefit of your
reservation until it's sold and the
transaction is complete your company
name and address upon requests will be
shared with the buyer for tax purposes a
seller can set Only The Upfront price of
an RI the usage price and other
configurations such as instance type
availability Zone platform will remain
the same as when the ri was initially
purchased the term length will be
rounded down to the nearest month for
example a reservation with 9 months and
15 days remaining will appear as 9
months on the R Market you can sell up
to 20,000 USD in reserved instances per
year if you need to sell more RI
reserved instances in the gov Cloud uh
region cannot be sold on the ra
Marketplace so there you
[Music]
go hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at spot
instances so adus has unused compute
capacity that they want to maximize the
utility of their idle servers all right
so the idea is just like when a hotel
offers booking discounts to fill vacant
Suites or planes offer discounts to fill
vacant seats all right so spot instances
provide a discount of 98% compared to On
Demand pricing spot instances can be
terminated if the Computing capacity is
needed by other on demand customers but
from what I hear rarely rarely does spot
instances ever get terminated um it's
designed for applications that have
flexible start and end times or
applications that are only feasible at
very low compute cost so you see some
options here like load balancing
workloads flexible workloads Big Data
workloads things like that um there is
another service called abis batch which
is for doing batch processing and this
is very common what you use um spot WID
and so you know if you find the spot
interface too complicated you're doing
batch processing you want to use this
service instead um there are some
termination conditions so instances can
be terminated by adus at any time if
your instance is terminated by ads you
don't get charged for a partial uh hour
of usage if you terminate an instance
you will be still charged for an hour uh
that it ran so there you
go
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look here at
dedicated instances so dedicated
instances is designed to help meet
regulatory requirements inabus also has
this concept called dedicated hosts and
this is more for when you have strict
server bound licensing that won't
support multi- tendency or cloud
deployments and we'll definitely
distinguish that in this course but just
not in this slide in particular um and
so to understand uh dedicated instances
or hosts we need to understand the
difference between multi- tendency and
single tendency so multi- tendency you
can think of like everyone living in the
same apartment and single tendency you
can think of it everyone having their
own house so the idea here is that you
have a server I'm just going to get my
uh cursor or my pen out here to say
server and you have multiple customers
running workloads on the same hardware
and the idea is that they are separated
via virtual isolation so they're using
the same server but it's just software
that might be separating them okay and
then we have the idea of single tency so
we have a single customer that has
dedicated Hardware so the physical
location is what separates customers um
and the idea here is that dedicated can
be offered via on demand reserved and
spot so that's why we're talking about
dedicated here in the pricing model just
so you know that you know even though
these are a lot more expensive than on
demand uh you can still save by using
reserved and also spot which I was very
surprised about um and when you want to
choose dedicated you're just going to
launch your ec2 and you'll have a drop
down where you have that shared so
that's the default dedicated so you have
dedicated and dedicated host again we'll
talk about dedicated host later when we
need to here um and so again the reason
why um you know Enterprises or large
organizations may want to use dedicated
instances is because they have a sec uh
a security concern or obligation about
uh against sharing the same Hardware
with other adus customers
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at adus
savings plans and this is similar to to
reserved instances but simplifies the
purchasing process so it's going to look
a lot like RI at the start here but I'll
tell you how it's a bit different okay
so there are three types of saving plans
you have compute Savings Plan ec2
instance saving plans and sagemaker
saving plans uh and so you just go ahead
and choose that you can choose two
different terms so one year threee so it
be simple as that and then you choose
the following payment options so you
have all upfront partial payment and no
upfront and then you're going to choose
that hour of the commitment you're not
having to think about standard versus
convertible uh Regional versus zonal RI
attributes it's a lot simpler uh and
let's just talk about the three
different saving plans or types in a bit
more detail so you have compute so
compute savings plans provides the most
flexibility and helps to reduce your
cost by 66% these plans automatically
apply to ec2 instances usage ads fargate
ads Lambda service usage regardless of
the instance family size AZ region Os or
tency then you have ec2 instances so
this provides the lowest prices offering
saving up to 72% in exchange for
commitment to usage of instance uh
individual instance families in a region
so automatically reduce uh your cost on
the selected instance family in the
region regardless of AZ size OS tendency
gives you the flexibility to change your
usage between instances with a within a
family in that region and the last is
Sag maker so helps you reduce Sage maker
cost by uh up to 64% automatically apply
to sagemaker usage regardless of
instance family size component adus
region if you don't know what sagemaker
is that's ad's ml service and it uses
ec2 instances or specifically ml ec2
instances so everything's basically
using ec2 here um but there you
[Music]
go all right let's take a look at the
zero trust model and the zero trust
model is a security uh model which
operates on the principle of trust no
one and verify everything so what I mean
by that is malicious actors being able
to bypass conventional access controls
demonstrates traditional security
measures are no longer sufficient and
that's where the zero trust model comes
into play so with the zero trust model
identity becomes the primary security
perimeter uh and so you might be asking
what do we mean by primary security
perimeter the primary or new security
perimeter defines the first line of
defense and its security controls that
protect a company's Cloud resources and
assets um if this still doesn't make
sense we do cover a part of the defense
and depth where you see the layers of
Defense from data all the way to
physical and so you can kind of see you
know what we're talking about in that
model there but the old way that we used
to do things is Network Centric so we
had traditional security focused on
firewalls and VPN since there were few
employees or workstations outside the
office or they were in a specific remote
office so we treated the network uh the
network as kind of like the the boundary
so if you're in in office there's
nothing to worry about but we don't
think like that anymore because
everything is identity Centric so this
is where we have bring your own device
remote workstations which are becoming
more common uh we can't always trust
that the employee is in a secure
location we have uh identity based
security controls like MFA we're
providing provisional access based on
the level risk from where when and what
a user wants to access and identity
Centric does not replace uh but it
augments Network Centric security so
it's just an additional layer of
consideration for uh security when we're
thinking about our Adas Cloud workloads
okay
all right so we just Loosely defined
what the zero trust model is so let's
talk about how we would do Zer Trust on
AWS and so zero trust has to do a lot
with identity security controls and so
let's talk about what is at our disposal
on AWS so on ads we have identity and
access management IM this is where we
create our users or groups or policies
so IM am policy is a set of permissions
that allow you to say okay this user is
allowed to use uh these services with
these particular action
uh then you have the concept of
permission boundaries and so these are
saying okay um these aren't the
permissions the user has currently but
these are the boundaries to which we
want them to have so they should never
have access to um uh ml services and if
someone's to uh apply them uh uh
permissions it'll always be within these
boundaries then you have service control
policies and these are organization-wide
policies so if you have a policy where
you don't want anyone to run anything in
the Canada region you can apply that
policy at the organiz level and it will
be enforced then within an policy there
are the concept of conditions and so
these are all the kind of like uh little
knobs you can uh tweak to say how do I
uh control based on a bunch of different
factors so there is Source IP so
restrict where the IP address is coming
from a requested region so a restrict
based on the region as we were just
mentioned as an example uh multiactor
off presence so restrict if MFA is
turned off uh current time so restrict
access based on time a day maybe your
your employees should never be really
using things at night and so that could
be an indicator that someone is doing
something malicious so you know only
give them access during a certain time a
day and so that's where we're going to
figure out you know based on all these
type of controls security controls uh to
our adus resources we can kind of
enforce the zero trust model adabs ads
does not have a ready to use identity
controls that are intelligent which is
why adus is considered not to have a
zero trust offering for customers and
third-party services need to be used so
what I'm saying is that technically you
know this checkbox is this thing saying
okay we can kind of do zero trust on AWS
but the there's a lot of manual work and
you know if I was to say okay um I don't
want anyone using this at nighttime it
doesn't really detect you know what I'm
saying it's not going to say oh I think
this time is suspicious andalicious so
then restrict access only to these core
services and anything outside of the
services can't be used it just can't
exactly do that without a lot of um work
yourself and that's what I'm talking
about here where we have a collection of
a services that can be set up in an
intelligence intelligent is detection
way for identity concerns but requires
expert knowledge so the way you might do
that AWS is that everything all the API
calls go through a cloud trail and so
what you could do is feed those into
Amazon guard Duty and guard duty is an
intrusion uh uh intrusion detection and
protection system so it could detect
suspicious or malicious activity on
those cloud trail logs and you could
follow that up with mediation or you
could pass that on to Amazon detective
that could analyze investigate and
quickly identify security issues uh that
it could ingest from guard duty but I'm
telling you that this stuff here is not
as easy um for the consumer and so you
of course you can do zero trust model
but it's going to take a lot of work
here and there are some limitations
which we'll talk about next
[Music]
here so now let's see how we would do
zero trust on adus with third parties so
adus does does technically Implement a
zero trust model but does not allow for
intelligent identity security controls
which you know you can do it but it's a
lot of work so uh let's kind of compare
it against kind of a third party where
we would get the controls that we would
not necessarily get with AWS so for
example Azure active directory has a
realtime and calculated risk detection
Based on data points than AWS and this
is based on device and application time
of day location whether MFA is turned on
what is being accessed and the security
controls verification or logic
restriction is much more robust so you
know just as one particular example like
device and application is not something
that ads factors in uh with the existing
controls or at least not in a way that
is consumer friendly and you know I
can't say on adus okay when you think
that this is the type of threat only
allow them access to these things or if
you think they're in a risky area or
risky uh location only give them access
to you know these things where there's
not sensitive data you can't exactly do
that adus very easily and so this is
where third party Solutions are going to
come into play so you have Azure active
directory Google Beyond Corp jump Cloud
uh all these have more intelligent
security controls for Real Time
detection um and so the way you would
use these is these would be your primary
directories uh for Google Beyond Corp is
just a zero trust framework so I guess
you'd use uh Google's uh Cloud directory
but the idea anyway here is that You'
use single sign on to connect those
directories to your adus account and
that's how you access access those uh
adus resources and you get this more
robust functionality
okay hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at identity now we
need to know a bunch of Concepts before
we talk about identity on AWS so let's
jump into it the first is a directory
service so what is directory service
well it's a service that Maps the names
of network resources to network
addresses and a directory servic is
shared uh infrastructure or information
in infrastructure for locating managing
administrating and organizing resources
such as volumes folders files printers
users groups devices telephone numbers
and other objects a directory service is
a critical component of a network
operating system and a directory server
or a name server is a server which
provides a directory service so each
resource on the network is considered an
object by the directory server
information about a particular resource
is stored as a collection of attributes
associated with that resource or op
project uh well-known directory Services
would be a domain name service um so the
directory service for the internet
Microsoft active directory and uh they
have a cloud hosted one called Azure
active directory we have aachi directory
service Oracle inter internet directory
so o ID uh open ldap uh Cloud end
identity and jump Cloud
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at active
directory now you might say well we're
doing adabs why are we looking at this
well no matter what cloud provider
you're using you should know what active
directory is uh especially when it comes
to identity because you can use it with
AWS um so let's talk about it so
Microsoft introduced active directory
domain services in Windows 2000 to give
organizations the ability to manage
multiple on- premise infrastructure
components and systems using a single
identity per user and since then it's uh
involved uh evolved obviously it's uh
running Beyond Windows 2000 as of today
and uh they even have a managed one
called Azure ad which is on Microsoft
Azure but just to kind of give you an
architectural diagram here the idea is
that you would have your domain servers
here uh and they might have child
domains and the idea is that you have
these running on multile machines so
that you have redundant ability to log
in from various places when you have a
bunch of domains it's called a forest
and then within a domain you actually
have organizational units and when then
within organizational units you have all
your objects look like your users your
printers your computers your servers uh
all things like that
[Music]
okay hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're talking about identity
providers or ipds
so
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are talking about identity
providers also known as
idps so an identity provider is a system
entity that creates maintains and
manages identity information for
principles and also provides
authentication services to Applications
with a federation or distributor Network
a trusted provider of your user identity
that lets you use authent uh lets you
authenticate to access other service
identity providers so this could be like
Facebook Amazon Google Twitter GitHub
LinkedIn uh Federate identity is a
method of linking a user's identity
across multiple separate identity
management systems and so some things
that uh we can use for that is like open
ID so this is an open standard and
decentralized Authentication Protocol
allows you to be able to log in to
different social media platforms using
Google or Facebook account open ideas
about providing who you are then we have
ooth 2.0 this is an industry standard
protocol for authorization oo doesn't
share password data but instead uses
authorization tokens to prove an
identity between consumers and service
providers o is about granting access to
functionality and then we have samles
security assertion markup language which
is an open standard for exchanging
authentication and authorization between
an identity provider and a service
provider and this is important use for
samle which we use for single sign on
via the web browser
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro we're looking at the concept of
single sign on so SSO is an
authentication scheme that allows a user
to log in with a single ID and password
to different systems and software as so
allows it departments to administer a
single identity that can access many
machines and cloud services so the idea
is you have as your active directory
this is just an example of a very
popular one You' use samle to do SSO and
you can connect to All Things slacks
Google workspaces Salesforce or your
computer uh the idea here is uh once you
uh log in um you don't have to log in
multiple times so you log into your
primary directory and then after that
you're not going to be presented with a
login screen some Services might show an
intermediate screen but the idea is
you're not entering your credentials in
multiple times so it's
[Music]
seamless all right let's talk about ldap
so lightweight directory access protocol
is an open vendor neutral industry
standard application protocol for
accessing and maintaining distributed
directory information Services over uh
IP network so a common use of ldap is to
provide a central place to store
usernames and passwords ldap enables for
same sign on so same sign on allows us
to uh use a single ID and password but
they have to enter it every single time
they want to log in so maybe you have
your on premise active directory and
then it's going to store it in that ldap
directory and so the idea is that um you
know all these services like Google
kubernetes um jenings is going to uh
deal with that ldap server so why would
you use ldap over SSO which is more
convenient or seamless so most SSO
systems are using ldap under the hood
but ldap was not designed aily to work
with web applications so some systems
only support integration with ldap and
not SSO so you got to take what you can
get
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at
multifactor authentication also known as
MFA and this is a security control where
after you fill in your user's name an
email password you have to use a second
device such as a phone to confirm that
it's you that is logging in so MFA
protects against people who have stolen
your password MFA is an option in most
Cloud providers and even social media
websites such as Facebook so the idea is
I have my uh username or email and
password I'm going to try to log in this
is the first factor and the second
factor or multiactor is I'm going to use
a secondary device so maybe my phone
we're going to enter in different codes
or maybe it's passwordless so I just
have to press a button to confirm that
it's me and then I'll get access so in
the context to AWS it's strongly
recommended that you turn on MFA for all
your accounts especially the adus root
account uh we'll see that when we do the
follow
[Music]
alongs let's take a look at security
keys so a security key is a second
device used as a second step in
authentication process to gain access to
a device workstation or application a
security key can resemble a memory stick
and when your finger makes contact with
a button of exposed metal on the device
it will generate an autofill a security
token a popular brand of security Keys
is the UB key and this is the one I use
and is looks exactly like the one that's
right beside my desk it works out of the
box with Gmail Facebook and hundreds
more supports PH2 web offn uh u2f it's
waterproof and Crush resistance it uh
has variations like usba us uh NFC dual
connectors on a single key can do a
variety of things so when you turn on
MFA on your adabs account you'll have
virtual MFA device so that's when you're
using something like a phone or using
software on your phone to do that then
there's the u2f security key ke so this
is what we're talking about right now
and there's even other kinds of Hardware
MFA devices um which we're not really
going to talk about but um you know just
security Keys tie into MFA and this is a
lot better way than using a phone
because you know you can have it on your
desk and press it um and you know you
don't have to worry about your phone
being not charged
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at itus
identity and access management also
known as I am and you can use this
service to create and manage adus users
groups uh use permissions to allow and
deny their access to adus resources so
there's quite a few components here
let's get to it so the first is I am
policies so these are Json documents
which Grant permissions for specific
users groups or a role to access
services and policies are attached to IM
identities then you have IM permissions
or a permission and this is an API
action that can or cannot be performed
and they represented in the IM policy
document
then there's the IM identities so we
have IM users these are end users who
log into the console or interact with ad
resources programmatically or via
clicking UI interfaces you have IM
groups so these these uh group up your
users so they all share the same
permission levels so maybe it's admins
developers or Auditors then you have IM
roles so these roles Grant ads resources
uh permissions to specific ads API
actions and Associate policies to a role
and then assign it to an adus resource
so just understand that roles are when
you're attaching these to uh resources
so like if you have an ec2 instance and
you say it has to access S3 you're going
to be attaching a a rooll not a policy
directly
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at IM policies a
little bit closer here and they are
written in Json and contain the
permissions which determine the API
actions that are allowed or denied um
and rarely do I write these out by hand
uh because they have a a little wizard
that you can use to write out the code
for you but if you want to you
absolutely can write it out by hand but
we should know the contents of it and
how these Json files work so the first
thing is the version uh which is the
policy language version and it's been
2012 for a very long time I don't see
that changing anytime soon if they
happen to change uh what or what the
structure of the Json is then you have
the statements and these are for policy
elements uh and you're allowed to have
multiples of them so the idea is that
this is the the policies or permissions
we should say uh that you uh plan on
applying then you have the Sid this is a
way of labeling your statements um this
is useful for like visualization or for
referencing it for later on but a lot of
times you don't have to have a sid um
then there's the effect it's either
allow or deny then you have the action
so here we're saying give access to S3
for all actions under it there's another
action down below where it's saying give
access I'm going get my pen tool out
here just to create a service link role
so that's a cross account role there
then there's the principal so this is
the account user role or Federated user
to which you would like to allow access
or deny so we're specifically saying uh
this IM am user named Barkley um in our
adus account there uh then there are the
resources so the resources to which the
action applies um so in this one up here
we are specifying a specific adus bucket
here we're saying all possible resources
in in adus account and then the
condition so so there's all sorts of
different kinds of conditions so this is
a string like one and it's saying look
at the service name and if it starts
with this or that then they'll have
access to that so this person even
though it says all resources they're
really only going to have access to RDS
[Music]
okay so in this follow along we're going
to take a closer look at I am policies
so go to the top and type in I and what
we'll do is make our way over here uh
all the way over to policies and what I
want to do is create a new policy that
only has access to uh um limited
resources so um let's say we want to
create an Amazon ec2 instance and that
E2 instance has access to a very
particular S3 bucket so what I want you
to do is make your way over to S3 and
we're going to create ourselves a new
bucket and I'm going to go ahead and
create a bucket here we're going to call
this
um policy
tutorial and I'm going to just put a
bunch of numbers here
you'll have to randomize it for your use
case and so now that we have our bucket
what we're going to do is go ahead and
create a
policy and the policy is going to choose
a service we're going to say S3 and what
I want to do is only be able to list out
actions I'm going to expand this so I
don't want everything so we're just
going to say list
buckets okay and then what we'll do is
uh expand this here and I want to save
for a particular bucket so we'll go back
back over here click into our
bucket and uh we're going to go ahead
and set those
permissions by finding that Arn we're
going to paste
that we're going to paste that Arn up
there sometimes it's a bit tricky it
vanishes on
you and we could set other conditions if
we wanted to but this is pretty simple
as it
is and so that's our rule here right so
we're saying this policy allows us to
list this bucket for that okay so what
we'll do is go ahead and hit next we'll
hit review and we'll just say my bucket
policy and we'll create that
policy okay so there's a few other
things I think that I'd like to do with
this policy I'm going to pull it back up
here so if we want to find it uh used to
be able to filter these based on the
ones that you
created but
um yeah they show like the little I so
these are ones that I've created up here
and so there's my bucket
policy and I feel like I want to update
this policy to have a bit of extra
information here so I'm going to go edit
this
policy no you know what I think this is
fine so what I want to do is now create
a
ro and we're going to create a new Ro
and I'm going to call this
um well before I do I need to choose
what it's for so it's going to be for
ec2 so we're going to go ahead and hit
next we're going to choose our policy so
my bucket policy there it is and I want
to add another one here because I want
to be able to use sessions manager
because I really don't want to use an
SSH key to check that this works and
so um for this I I need to use SSM so
I'm going to type in SSM
here and I'm just make sure this is the
new one so this policy will soon be
deprecated use Amazon SSM manag core
instance should always open these up and
read them and see what they do and so
that's the one that's going to allow us
to access uh Simpson manager so we can
use um sessions manager okay and so
we're going to say my ec2 roll for
S3 and we're going go ahead and create
ourselves a
roll so now that we have our roll I'm
going to go over to
ec2 and I'm going to go ahead and launch
myself a new
instance we're going to choose Amazon
ltic 2 we're going to stick with T2
micro I'm going to go over to
configuration here everything is fine
here um I'm fine with all that storage
is fine we'll go to Security Group and I
don't want any ports open because I'm
not going to be using
SSH we're going to launch this instance
I don't even want to keep
pair
okay and then we're going to go over
here and so what we're waiting for is
this instance to launch as that is going
what I want to do is go over to my S3
bucket and I want to place something in
this bucket so I do have some files here
um so what I'm going to
do let's create a new folder here whoops
I'm going to go back and I'm just going
to create a folder first create a folder
Enterprise
D and I'm going to click into this and
then I'm going to upload all my images
here so you'll have to find your own
images off the internet this is just the
ones I have and we'll go ahead and
upload
those give that a
moment okay and so we don't have access
to read those files we'll adjust our
policy as we go so that we can do that
okay so this instance should be running
um it has doesn't have the two status
checks pass we should be able to uh
connect to it so click on connect here
and so we have options like easy to
instance connect sessions manager SSH
client I want you to go to sessions
manager it says we weren't able to
connect to your instance common reasons
SSM agent wasn't installed we absolutely
have that installed the required I am
profile oh right so we were supposed to
attach I forgot to do we were supposed
to attach an I am profile right so an I
profile is the role uh it or the it
holds the role uh that's going to give
the permissions to that instance and
since we didn't add it we have to go
retroactively add it after the
fact and so I'm going to have to modify
the IM roll and we're going to choose my
ec2 roll for S3 and we're going to save
that and actually when that happens you
have to reboot the machine you only have
to do that if you have no Ro attached
like prior no profile attach and you're
attaching it for the first time but
after that you never have to reboot the
machine this is the only case where
you'd have to do
that that's why when I launch an ec2
instance I always at least have the SSM
R attached the managed one that gets
sessions manager so that I don't don't
ever have to do a reboot in case I have
to update the
policy and so we will give that a moment
there it says initializing so I'm going
to try again to connect to it
okay and we still don't have that option
there um so I'm going to go back to my
instances I'm going to check to see if
the role the rule or policy is
attached or profile I should
say
so I'm just looking for it
here there it
is and so if I click into this into the
r we can see that we have the Amazon SSM
managed instance core there so that's
set up and then my uh bucket policy so
this has everything that it should be
able to do it no
problem okay so I'm going to try that
again
okay so now the connect shows up ads is
finicky like that you just have to have
confidence in knowing what you're doing
is correct okay we'll go ahead and hit
connect and I didn't have to use SSH
keys or anything and this is a lot more
secure way to connect your instances
when it logs Us in it's going to set us
as the SSM user but we want to be
the um the ec2 user
okay that's uh ads always makes their am
like their Linux version as the ec2 user
and that's what you're supposed to use
but it's just you just that's how you
have to get to that you just have to
type that pseudo suyen ec2 user okay
just once and if you type who am I
that's who you are if you type exit
you'll go back to that user so I type
exit and I type who am I I'm now this
person so I'm going to go back hit up go
back in there type clear so now I want
to see if I have access to S3 so I have
to do OS S3 LS want's see if I can list
buckets it says access deny
so I mean that kind of makes sense
because if you have list buckets and
we're just saying only that bucket that
might not make a whole lot of
sense so I'm going to go back to my
policy I might just written a a crummy
policy but we'll say I am here if we
have that one open we should just go
here and click on this policy
here I'm going to edit that
policy so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to change it and we all
resources review the policy save changes
and we'll see how fast that
propagates
okay because I'm pretty sure I don't
have to do anything here it should just
now give me full access to
S3 just going to keep on hitting up
here so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to take like a three four minute
break going to get a drink I'm going to
come back here and see if this
propagates I'm pretty sure I don't have
to do anything for that to propagate and
I think that I've attached everything
correctly here
okay okay so I haven't had much luck
here it's still having the same issue so
if that is happening what I'm going to
do um is I'm just going to reboot it
because maybe I didn't give it a good
opportunity to reboot there again I
don't think we should have to reboot it
every time when we we're changing um uh
things there but we will give it another
go here and see if if that fixes that
problem there so no sessions matter is
going to time out here which is totally
fine it's going to kill that session
there um and so what we'll have to do is
close this out because there's not much
we can do with
that and we're going to go ahead and go
back to connect and so we're waiting for
this button to appear because it is
rebooting so if we want to monitor that
stuff usually there is an option here to
monitor where it'll show us the system
logs of what it's doing doing so here
it's just like restarting the
machine I'm not sure if we expect to see
something after
this so I can click that
there and uh yeah it's easy to get
turned around this so I can connect to
it again
now we'll type in pseudo Su hyphen ec2
user ads S3
LS and we still
have access deny for list buckets so if
that's the case it could be that um
sometimes you need other permissions
when doing list policy like uh list
buckets so if that's the case we're
going to do a sanity check I'm just
going to say all permissions here okay
and this way there's no way that I've
set this
incorrectly um it just has to work now
type this
in there we go okay so there has to be
something more to it so just because you
say list buckets you know like means
there must be more to it right so if I
go here to this right and I say
whoops and I say uh list buckets here
we'll say
copy paste
okay here it's saying maybe I need get
object as well so I just know from using
a long time that that's the case that it
could be more than one thing so you know
that was in the back of my mind that
that could be happening and I guess that
is but notice I didn't have to restart
my uh my server boot my server to get
those to work um uh but anyway let's go
lock that down and see if we can just
kind of make this uh more focused so
let's say um all resources I'm going to
specify the condition
so I might want to just say for
particular
buckets we say specific when you
checkbox everything then you have to do
this so for storage accounts these are
fine any for
objects that could be something we'll
say multi- region access bucket any
bucket but what I'm going to say is I
want to only allow them to access things
in a particular bucket and so if I go to
Arn
here um what is our bucket
name our bucket name is policy tutorial
3414 whatever right and so we can
actually give it a wild card or we can
say
Enterprise
D and we learned this in the course that
uh you can provide orangs with
randomize things there I don't know know
if I spelled it wrong over here so I
should really double check I should
probably just copy
it
oops I just don't want to type it wrong
and so
this
okay means that we should only be able
to get stuff from there I'm going to
review the policy see if it takes save
the
changes and if I just view the Json
here notice it says anything from here
right so allow S3 anything as long as
it's within here and then it also broke
it up into sub one4 here okay um so
anyway what I want to see is what
happens if I upload something into the
loose area here so I'm to say
upload and I'm going to just say add a
file we're just going to grab data here
and upload
it go back to our bucket there there's
our file we have that stuff in there and
so if I go back over to my ec2 instance
which I'm still connected
to uh who am I okay great clear um so
I'm going to say ads S3 LS see if that
works still it does good and so what I
want to do is see if I can copy a file
locally so I'm going to do Abus S3
copy I think it was S3 no it's just S3
copy polic uh S3 SL SL policy
tutorial
34 141 whoops
34 tutorial
hyphen
slash Enterprise
D data.jpg I think it's a JPG let's go
double check yeah it is okay and then I
just want to say data.jpg
and it downloaded it right so I'm going
to remove that one and so now what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to see if
my policy is working or maybe my
permissions aren't exactly what I think
they are and I was able to download it
so it's these policies can get kind of
tricky because like this one says allow
all actions for these but then these say
all actions and
so that makes it hard because I want get
object
so another thing we can
do and if that one doesn't work really
well I'm just going to write one by hand
it's not that scary to write these by
hand you just get used to it so I'm
going to say
effect um is it disallow or maybe it's
deny
action S3 get off object I believe
that's what it
is
resource and then I'm going to specify
exactly the resource I don't want it to
allow so we're going to say
R AWS S3 three
colons policy
tutorial
34141 uh and just say data.jpg
now if this is not valid it's going to
complain and say hey you didn't write
this right and it and it's fine okay
so we'll save those
changes and so that should deny access
to that
right hopefully I got the policy
right okay so that one doesn't work
which is
fine and that one's fine so that worked
we were able to deny that but you can
see there's a little bit of an art to
creating these policies uh as you make
more of them it becomes comes a lot
easier so hopefully it's not too scary
but uh that's all there really is uh to
it that I want to show you today so what
we're going to do is clear out this
bucket we're done with this bucket here
so we'll say delete whoops we got to
empty it
first and we'll just say permanently
delete
here okay and we will exit that out
we're going to go ahead and delete that
bucket grab its name
here
and uh we'll go back over
here I think I forgot to delete this
Bucket from earlier I'm just going to
delete that because I don't need that
bucket so that's okay with you just
going to go ahead and delete
that and we have that ec2 instance
running so we want to stop
that go ahead and we're going to
terminate that yes
please and then we'll go to IM and do
some clean
up
I have some custom roles I've been
creating um you know from prior things a
lot of those usually there's a way to uh
We've redesigned it okay where's the
redesign this is the redesign that can't
be it because there'll be like rolls
that ads makes I think these are all
rolls that I've
made um I don't want to delete service
roles but I want to get rid of some of
these CU I just have too many you know
it's getting out of hand for me and I'm
going to just see if it will let
me
delete all of these let's delete
those there we go just clean up a bit I
still have a lot here but there's like
service roles that adus crates once and
you really don't want to delete those
because you
don't um and then I have a bunch of
these like like I'm never going to use
these so I might as well detach them
delete
detach you really don't want to keep
like rolls that you're never going to
use
around things like that like gauze we
going to be using that
again
delete there's that bucket we just
created
but anyway you get the idea so uh yeah
that's uh that's I am
[Music]
okay principal of lease privilege PP is
the computer security concept of
providing a user roll or application the
least amount of permissions to perform
an operation or an action and the way we
can look at it is that we have just
enough axis so Jaa permitting only the
exact actions for the identity perform a
task and then we have just in time jit
permitting the smallest length of
duration an identity can use permission
so usually when we're talking about PLP
it's usually a focus on here uh but now
these days uh there's a larger focus on
jit as well and so jit is the difference
between having long lived um uh
permissions or access Keys versus
short-lived ones and the most
Progressive thing in PP is now
risk-based adaptive policies so each
attempt to access a resource generates a
risk score of How likely the request is
to be from a compromised source so the
risk score could be based on many
factors such as device user location IP
address what service is being accessed
and when did they use MFA did they use
Biometrics things like that and right
now as of this time it just does not
have a risk-based adaptive policies
built into I am you can roll your own um
what's interesting is Cognito has
risk-based adaptive policies they call
like um adaptive authentication but
that's for user pools and not identity
pools user pools is for getting access
to an app uh that you have built through
an ipd where identity pools in cognito
is about getting access to adus
resources so uh you know I'm sure abos
will get it eventually but they just
don't have it right now and you have to
rely on thirdparty um identity Solutions
uh to get risk-based adaptive policies
now talking about just enough access and
just in time just in time is like you
think how would you do that with ads you
just add and remove permissions manually
well one thing you could do is use
something like console me so this is an
open source Netflix project to selfer
short-lived I am policies so an end user
can access it of his resources while
enforcing Jaa and jit and so there's a
repo there as well um but the idea is
they have like this self- serve wizard
so you say I want these things and then
the machine decides okay you can have
them or you you don't need them and it
just freezes you up asking people and
worrying about the length and stuff like
that
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the IUS
route user uh and this gets confusing
because there's an account root user and
regular user so let's distinguish what
those three things are so here we have
an AB account and the account which
holds all the adus resources including
the different types of users then you
have the root user this is a special
account with full access that cannot be
deleted and then you have just a user
and this is a user for common tasks that
is assigned permissions so just
understand that sometimes people say it
was account they're actually referring
to the user and sometimes when they're
saying it was account they're actually
referring to the ads account that holds
the users I know it's confusing it just
it's based on what people decide the
context is when they're speaking so the
ads account user is a special user who's
created at the time of the ads account
creation and they can do uh they have a
lot of conditions around them so the re
user account uses an email and password
to log in as opposed to the regular user
who's going to provide their account ID
Alias username and password the root
user account cannot be deleted the root
user account has full permissions to the
the account and its permissions and
cannot be limited and when we say it
cannot be limited we're saying that if
you take an IM policy to explicitly deny
the user access to resources it's not
something you can do however you can do
it in the case of adus organizations
with service control policies because a
service control policy applies to a
bunch of accounts so it just it's one
level above and so that is a way of
limiting root users but generally you
can't limit them within their own
account uh there can only be one root
user uh per ad of us account the root
user is instead for very spec specific
and specialized tasks that are
infrequently or rarely performed and
there's a big list and we'll get into
that here in a moment and the root uh
account should uh not be used for daily
or common tasks it's strongly
recommended to never use the root users
access keys because you can generate
those and use them it's strongly
recommended to turn on MFA for the root
user and adus will bug you to no ends to
tell you to turn it on so let's talk
about the uh tasks that you should be
performing with a root user and only the
root user can perform so changing your
account settings this includes account
name email address root user password
root user access Keys other account
settings such as contact information
payment currency preference regions do
not require the root user credentials so
not everything um restore IM user
permissions so if there's an i IM admin
so just a user that has admin access who
actually revokes their own permissions
you can sign into the root user to edit
policies and restore those permissions
um so you can also activate IM access to
the billing and cost Management console
you can view certain tax invoices you
can close your ad's account you can
change or cancel your adus support plan
register as a seller in the reserved
instance Marketplace enable MFA uh
Delete on S3 buckets edit or delete an
Amazon S3 bucket policy that includes an
invalid VPC ID or VPC endpoint ID sign
up for govcloud and something that's not
in here which this I took this from the
documentation but uh you can use the
adus uh account user to create the
organization you can't create that with
any other user so um you know the ones I
highlighted in red are very likely to
show up your exam and that's uh why I
highlighted them there for you but there
you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at adus
single sign on also known as adus SSO
and so this is where you create or
connect your Workforce identities in ads
once and manage access centrally across
your ads organization
so the idea here is you're going to
choose your identity Source whether it's
it SSO itself active directory SLE 2.0
IDP you're going to man manage user
permission centrally to ads accounts
applications samle applications and it
uses uh it can you get single click
access to all these things so you know
just to kind of zoom in on this graphic
here uh you know you have your on
premise active directory it's
establishing a ad trust connection over
to Able single sign on you're going to
be able to apply permissions to access
resources within your adus account so
via adus organizations in your
organizational units down to your
resources you can also use ads SSO to
access custom samle based applications
so you know if I built a web app and I
uh like the exam Pro platform and I
wanted to use sample based uh
connections for single sign on there I
could do that as well and you can
connect out SSO access to your business
Cloud application so Office 365 Dropbox
slack things like that so there you
go well let's take a look here at
application integration so this is the
process of letting to Independent
applications to communicate and work
with each other commonly facilitated by
an intermediate system so Cloud
workloads uh strongly encourage systems
and services to be Loosely coupled and
so inabus has many services for the
specific purpose of application
integration and these are based around
common system systems or design patterns
that utilize application integration and
this would be things like queuing
streaming pubsub API gateways State
machines event buses and I'm sure there
are more but that's what I could uh
think about that are the most common
ones
[Music]
okay so to understand queuing we need to
know what is a messaging system so this
is used to provide asynchronous
communication and decouple processes via
messages and events from a sender
receiver or a producer and a consumer so
a queing system is a messaging system
that generally will delete messages once
they are consumed it's for simple
communication it's not real time you
have to pull the data it's not reactive
and uh a good analogy would be imagining
people that are queuing in a line to go
do something so for ads it's called
Simple queuing service sqs it's a fully
managed queing service that enables you
to decouple and scale microservices
distributed systems and serverless
applications so a very common use case
in a web application would be to queue
up transactional emails to be sent like
sign up reset password and the reason
why we have queing to decouple uh those
kind of actions is that if you had a
long running task um and you had too
many of them it could hang your
application so by decoupling them and
letting a separate compute uh service
take care of that um that would be
something that would be very useful
okay
let's take a look here at streaming and
so this is a different kind of messaging
system um but the idea here is you have
multiple cons consumers that can react
to events and so in streaming we call
messages events and then in a queing
system we just call them messages but
events live in the Stream for long
periods of time so complex operations
can be applied and generally streaming
is used for realtime stuff whereas
queing is not necessarily real time and
so ad's solution here is Amazon kinesis
you could also use Kafka but we'll focus
on Kinesis here so Amazon Kinesis is the
aist fully managed solution for
collecting processing and analyzing
streaming data in the cloud so the idea
is that you have these producers so that
are producing events could be ec2
instances mobile
devices could be a computer or
traditional server they're going to go
into the data stream there's a bunch of
shards that scale and there's consumers
on the other side so maybe red shift
wants that data Dynamo DB S3 or EMR okay
but the thing you have to remember is
that streaming Is For Real Time data and
as you can imagine because it's real
time and it's doing a lot more work than
um a queuing system it's going to cost
more
[Music]
okay so we have another type of
messaging system known as Pub sub so
this stands for publish subscribe
pattern commonly implemented in
messaging systems and a pub sub system
the sender of messages the Publishers do
not send their message directly to
receivers they instead send their
messages to an event bus the event bus
categorizes their messages into groups
then receivers of messages subscribers
subscribe to these groups whenever new
messages appear within their
subscriptions the messages are
immediately delivered to them so the
idea is you have Publishers event bus
subscribers and event buses appear more
than once so it actually appears in
streaming appears in this Pub sub model
and then it can appear in other
variations so you're going to hear it
more than once the word event bus um so
the idea here is the publisher has no
knowledge of who the subscribers are
subscribers do not pull for messages
messages are instead automatically
immediately pushed to the subscribers
and messages and events are
interchangeable terms in Pub sub all
right and so you know the idea here with
Publisher subscribers just imagine
getting like a um a magazine
subscription right if you think of that
you kind of think of the mechanisms that
are going here in terms of practicality
it's very common to use these as a
real-time chat system or a web hook
system so you know hopefully that gives
you an idea there in terms of aws's
solution we're using simple notification
service SNS this is a highly available
durable secure fully managed Pub sub
messaging service that enables you to
decouple microservices distributed
systems and serverless applications so
here we have a variety of Publishers
like the SDK the CLI cloudwatch Aid with
Services you'll have your SNS topic you
can uh filter things fan them out and
then you have your subscribers so Lambda
sqs emails PS looks very similar to
streaming but again you know um you know
there's not a lot of communication going
back between it it's just Publishers and
subscribers and it's limited to you know
these things here so it's a very managed
service right whereas uh Kinesis you can
do a lot more with it
[Music]
okay so what is API Gateway well it is a
program that sits between a single entry
point and a and multiple backends API
Gateway allows for throttling logging
routing logic or formatting of the
requests and response when we say
request and response we're talking about
https uh requests and responses and so
the service for ads is called Amazon API
Gateway so API Gateway is just a type of
pattern and this is the few cases where
ADS has named the thing after what it is
and so we have Amazon API Gateway which
is a solution for creating secure apis
in your Cloud environment at any scale
create apis that act as a front door for
applications to access data B is logic
or functionality from backend services
so the idea is that you have data coming
in from uh mobile apps web apps iot
devices and you actually Define the API
calls and then you say where do you want
them to go so maybe tasks are going to
go to your lambdas um and then other
routes are going to go to RDS Kinesis
ec2 uh or your web application and so
these are really great for having um
this uh being able to Define your API
routes and change them on the Fly and
then and always route them to the same
place
[Music]
okay so what is a state machine it is an
abstract model which decides how one
state moves to another based on a series
of conditions think of a state machine
like a flowchart and for AWS the
solution here is AWS step function so
coordinate multiple a Services into a
servess workflow a graphical console to
visualize the component of your
application as a series of steps
automatically trigger and track each
step and retries when there are errors
so your application executes in order as
expected every time logs the state of
each step so when things go wrong you
can diagnose and debug problems quickly
and so here's an example of using a
bunch of um uh steps together on the uh
the aabus step functions service and so
you know this is generally applied for
servess workflows but it is something
something that is very useful in
application integration
[Music]
okay so what is an event bus an event
bus receives events from a source and
routes events to a Target based on rules
so I'll get my pen tool out here so we
have an event it enters the event bus we
have a rules tell it to go to the Target
it's that simple and we have been seeing
event buses in other things like uh
streaming and uh Pub sub but Abus has
this kind of event offering uh that is
kind of high level it's called event
bridge and it's a service event bus
service that is used for application
integration by streaming real-time data
to your applications the service was
formerly known as event Amazon
cloudwatch events they gave it a
renaming to give it uh a better um
opportunity for users to know that it's
there to use uh and they also extended
its
capabilities and so the thing is that a
lot of AD services are always admitting
events and they're already going into
this bus and so if you utilize this
service um it's it's a lot easier than
having to roll your own thing uh with
other services so Amazon event bridge
will just Define an event bus so there
is an event bus holds event data defines
the rules on event bus to react to
events you always get a default event
for every single Aus account you can
create custom event buses scope to
multiple accounts or other adus accounts
you have a SAS event bus scope to
thirdparty SAS providers you have
producers these are adus services that
emit events you have events these are
data emitted by Services they're jent
objects that uh travel the stream Within
the event bus you have partnered sources
these are thirdparty apps that can emit
events to event buses you have rules
these determine what events to capture
and pass to targets and then targets
which are Ada services that consume
events so yeah it's all just this great
built-in um uh uh stuff that's going on
here and so you know there there might
be a case where you can use event bridge
and save your time uh a lot of time and
effort uh doing application integration
okay
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at application
integration services at a glance here so
let's get through them so the first is
simple notification service SNS this is
a pub sub messaging system sends
notifications via various formats such
as plain text email https web hooks SMS
text messages sqs and Lambda pushes
messages which are then sent to
subscribers you have sqs this is a
queuing messaging system or service that
sends a events to a queue other
applications pull the queue for messages
commonly used for background jobs we
have step functions this is a state
machine service it is it coordinates
multiple a Services into a servess
workflow easily share data among lambdas
have a group of lambdas wait for each
other create logical steps also works
with fargate tasks we have event Bridge
formerly known as cloudwatch events it
is a service event bus that makes it
easy to connect applications together
from your own application third party
services and adus services then there's
Kinesis a real realtime streaming data
service creates producers which send
data to a stream multiple consumers can
consume data within a stream used for
real-time analytics clickstreams
ingesting data from a fleet of iot
devices you have Amazon mq this is a
manage message broker service that uses
aachi active mq so if you want to use
aachi active mq there it is manage kofka
service and this gets me every time
because it says
msk and that is the proper
initialization but you'd think it'd be
MKS
it is a fully managed Apachi Kafka
service Kafka is an open source platform
for building realtime streaming data
pipelines and applications similar to
conis but more robust very popular by
the way we have API Gateway a fully
managed service for developers to create
publish maintain Monitor and secure apis
you can create API endpoints and rote
them to ad Services we have appsync this
is a fully managed graphql service
graphql is an open source agnostic query
adapter that allows you to query data
from many different data sources so
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are comparing virtual
machines to Containers so I know we
covered this prior but I just want to do
it one more time just to make sure that
we fundamentally understand the
difference before we jump into
containers so the idea is that if you
were to request an ec2 instance it has a
host operating system that we don't
really know much about but we don't
really need to know uh and then the idea
is you have a hypervisor which allows
you to deploy virtual
machines and so when you launch an ec2
instance you're actually launching a VM
on top of a hypervisor on a server uh
with on uh within the adabs uh data
centers servers there and you're going
to choose an operating system so like
Ubuntu and it might come with some
pre-installed packages or you're going
to install your own libraries packages
and binaries and then you're going to
decide what kind of workloads you want
to run on there so it could be D Jango
uh mongodb so your database and some
kind of queing system like rabit mq the
difficulties with virtual machines
you're always going to end up with some
unused space because you're going to
want to have some Headroom uh to make
sure that uh you know if you know Dango
needs more memory or or mongod DB needs
more storage that you have that room
that you can grow into but the idea is
that you're always paying for that even
when you're not utilizing it and so you
know that can be uh not as cost
effective as you'd like it to be so when
we're looking at um doing this again and
we are using containers um instead of
the provisor we have container
virtualization a very common one would
be called Docker Damon for Docker of
course and so now you're launching
containers and so maybe you have Alpine
and this is for your web app and then
you install exactly the libraries
packages and binaries you need for that
and then for uh mongodb you want to have
a different OS different packages and
same thing with Rabbid mq maybe you want
to run it on FreeBSD and the idea is
that uh you know you're not going to
have this waste because it it's kind of
changed the sense that these containers
are Flex ible so they can expand or
decrease based on the the use case of
what they need uh and you know if you
use particular services like ad fargate
you know you're paying like for running
the containers not necessarily uh for uh
over provisioning okay so VMS do not
make best use of space apps are not
isolated which could cause uh config
conflict security problems or resource
hogging containers allow you to run
multiple apps which are virtually
isolated from each other launch new
containers configure OS uh dependencies
per container
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the
concept of microservices and to
understand microservices we first need
to understand monoliths or monolithic
architecture and the idea here is that
we have one app which is responsible for
everything and the functionality is
tightly coupled so I'm going to get my
pen tool out here and just to highlight
notice that there is a server and
everything is running on a single server
whether it's load balancing caching the
database um maybe the marketing website
the front-end JavaScript framework the
back end with its API uh the uh
orm connected to background tasks things
like that and that's the idea of a
monolith and that's what um a lot of
people are used to doing but the idea
with microservice architecture is that
you have multiple apps which are
responsible for one uh one thing and the
functionality is isolate and stateless
and so just by uh leveraging um various
cloud services or bolting it onto your
service um you know you are technically
using microservice architecture so maybe
your web app is all hosted in containers
so you have your apis your or your orm
your reports maybe you've abstracted out
some particular functions into Lambda
functions you have your um marketing
website hosted on S3 you have your
frontend JavaScript hosted on S3 You're
Now using elastic load balancer uh
elasticache
RDS sqs and that's the idea between
monoliths and microservices
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at
kubernetes which is an open-source
container orchestration system for
automating deployment scaling and
management of containers it was
originally created by Google and now
maintained by the cloud native Computing
foundation so the
cncf kubernetes is commonly called K8
the 8 represents the remaining letters
for kuti which is odd because everyone
calls it kues with the S on there but
that's just what is the advantage of
kubernetes over Docker is the ability to
run containers distributed across
multiple VMS a unique component of
kubernetes are pods a pod is a group of
one or more containers with with shared
storage network resources and other
shared settings so here is kind of an
example where you have your kubernetes
master it has a schedule controller etcd
you might be using it uses an API server
to run nodes within the nodes we have
pods and within the pods we have
containers kubernetes is ideally for
microservice architectures where company
has tens to hundreds of services they
need to manage I need to really
emphasize that tens to hundreds of
services all right so you know crion is
great but just understand that it is
really designed uh to be used for
massive amounts of microservices if you
don't have that need you might want to
look at something just easier to use
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look here at
docker which is a set of platforms of
service products that use OS level
virtualization to deliver software in
packages called containers so Docker was
the earliest popularized open source
container platform meaning there's lots
of tutorials there's a lot of services
that uh integrate with Docker or make it
really easy to use and so when people
think of containers they generally think
of Docker there's of course a lot more
options out there than Docker to run
containers but this is what people think
of and so we said it's a suite of tools
so the idea is you have this Docker CLI
so these are C commands to download
upload build run and debug containers a
Docker file a configuration file on how
to provision a container Docker compose
uh which is a tool and configuration
file when working with multiple
containers Docker swarm an orchestration
tool for managing deployed
multicontainer architectures Docker Hub
a public online repository for
containers published by the community
for download and one really interesting
thing uh that came out of Docker was the
open container initiative oci which is
an open governance for creating open
industry standards around container
formats and runtimes so Docker
established the O oci and it is now
maintained by the Linux foundation and
so the idea is that you can write a
Docker file or or do things very
similarly and use different types of um
uh technologies that can use containers
as long as they're oci compatible you
can use them so Docker has been losing
favor with developers due to their
handling of introducing a paid open
source model and Alternatives like
podman are growing and that's why we're
going to talk about podman next
[Music]
okay so let's take a quick look here at
podman which is a container engine that
is oci compliant and is a drop in
replacement for Docker I just want to
get you exposure here because I want you
to know about this um and that you can
uh use it as opposed to using Docker um
there are a few differences or
advantages that podman has so podman is
Damon list where Docker uses a container
D Damon pman allows you to create pods
like crew brunetes where Docker does not
have pods podman only replaces one part
of Docker podman is is to be used
alongside builda and uh scopio so you
know Docker is an all-in-one kind of
tool uh everything is done via single
CLI and everything is there but you know
they just wanted to make it more module
and so uh these other tools anytime you
say podman it usually means we're
talking about podman builda and scopio
so builda is a tool used to build the
oci images and scopio is a tool for
moving container images between
different types of container storages p
is not going to show up in your exam but
you should practically know it um just
for your own benefit
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at the
container services offered on AWS so we
have primary services that actually run
containers provisioning and deployment
on you know tooling around provisioning
deployment and supporting services so
the first here is elastic container
service ECS um and the advantage of this
service is that it has no cold starts
but it is a manage dc2 so that means
that you're going to be always paying
for the resource as it is running all
right then you have ads fargate so this
is more robust than uh using adus Lambda
it can scale to zero cost um and it's uh
being managed by adus managed ec2
however it does have cold starts so you
know if you need containers launching
really fast you might be wanting to use
ECS then you have elastic kubernetes
service eks this is uh open source it
runs kubernetes um and this is really
useful if you want to avoid vendor
lockin um which is not really a problem
but uh that or it's just you want to run
kubernetes then you have itus Lambda so
you only think about the code uh it's
designed for short running tasks uh if
you need something that runs longer you
want to use that is serverless you'd use
adus fargate which is serverless
containers you can deploy custom
containers so prior adus Lambda just had
um pre-built run times which were
containers but now you can create any
kind of container and uh use that uh on
a was Lambda for provisioning deployment
you can use elastic Bean sock so um it
can uh deploy elastic container service
for you um which is very useful there
now there's app Runner which kind of
overlaps on what elastic beanock does
but it specializes it specializes for
containers um and I believe that it can
actually I don't know what it uses
underneath because it is a managed
service so elastic beanock is um open
you can see what is running underneath
an app Runner I don't believe you can
see what is running underneath it's just
taken care of by AWS then there's AWS
co-pilot CLI so this allows you to build
release operate production ready
containerize applications on app Runner
ECS and Abus fargate for supporting
services you have elastic container
registry this is reple for your
containers not necessarily just Docker
containers but containers in general
probably oci compliant containers x-ray
so analyze and debug between uh
microservices so you know it's
distributed tracing then you have step
functions so stitch together lambdas and
ECS tasks to to uh create um um a state
machine and the only thing I don't have
on here would be you know being able to
launch an ec2 instance from the
marketplace that has um a uh a container
runtime installed like Docker um I just
don't feel that that's very relevant for
the exam but it is another option for
containers not something that people do
very often but there you
[Music]
go hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look here at
organizations and accounts so adus
organizations allow the creation of new
adus accounts and allows you to
centrally manage billing control access
compliance security and share resources
across your adus accounts so here's kind
of a bit of a structure of um the
architecture of adus organizations and
we'll just kind of walk through the
components so the first thing you have
is a root account user this is a single
signin identity that has complete access
to all ad services and resources in an
account and each account has a root
account user so generally you will have
a master or root account and even within
that you'll have a root account user and
for every additional account that you
have you'll notice over here we have a
root account
user then there's the concept of
organizational units uh these are
commonly abbreviated to ous so they are
a group of adus accounts within an
organization which can contain other
organizational units creating a
hierarchy so here is one where we have
called Starfleet and here's one called
Federation planets and underneath we
have multiple
accounts it accounts within that
organizational unit and even though it
does not show it here you can create an
organizational unit within an
organizational unit then we have service
control policies scps and these give uh
central control over the allowed
permissions for all A's accounts in your
organization helping to ensure your
accounts stay within your organization's
guidelines what they're trying to say
here is that um there's this concept of
adus I am policies and all you're doing
is you're creating a policy that's going
to be uh organizational uniwide or
organizational wide or for select
accounts so it's just a way of applying
I am policies across multiple accounts
adus organizations must be turned on and
once it's turned on it cannot be turned
off it's generally recommended that you
do turn it on um because basically when
if you're going to run any kind of
serious workload you're going to be
using adus organizations to uh isolate
your adus accounts based on workloads
you can create as many adus accounts as
you like One account will be the master
or root account um and I say root
account here because this is the new
language here and some of the
documentation still calls it master
account so do understand this is the
root account not to be confused with the
root account user so another
clarification I want to make is an ads
account is not the same as a user
account which is another thing that is
confusing so when you sign up for AWS
you get um an adus account and then it
creates you a user account which happens
to be a root user account so hopefully
that is clear
[Music]
so adus control tower helps Enterprises
quickly set up a secure adus multic
count it provides you with a baseline
environment to get started with a
multi-count architecture so it does this
a few uh a few different ways the first
thing is it provides you a landing Zone
this is a baseline environment following
well architected and best practices to
start launching production ready
workload so imagine you wanted to go
have um you know the perfect environment
that you know sec cure um is correctly
configured and has good logging in place
that's what a landing zone is and so 's
Landing zone for control tower is going
to have SSO enabled by default so it's
very easy to move between it accounts it
will have centralized logging for adus
cloud trail so that you know they're
going to be tamper evident or tamper
proof away from your workloads where
they can't be affected it'll have cross
account security auditing um so yeah
Landing zones are really great to have
then there's the account Factory they
used to call this um uh a vending
machine but uh they changed it to
account Factory the idea is that it
automates provisioning of new accounts
in your organization it standardizes the
provisioning of new accounts with
pre-approved account configuration you
can configure account Factory with
pre-approved network configuration and
region selections uh enable sell service
for your Builders to configure and
provision to accounts using a service
catalog a service catalog is just
preapproved uh workloads uh via Cloud
information templates that you created
to say okay you're allowed to launch
This Server these resources
um and the third and most important
thing that a control tower comes with is
guard rails so these are prepackaged
governance rules for security operations
compliance the customers can select and
apply Enterprise wide or to specific
groups of accounts so adus control tower
is the replacement of the retired adus
Landing zone so if you remember adus
Landing zones which was never a self-
serve easy thing to sign for it required
a lot of money and uh stuff to go in
there they just don't really have it
anymore and it was control Tower is the
new offering um there
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at 's
config and to understand adus config we
need to know what compliance as code is
and to understand compliances code we
need to understand what change
management is so change management in
the context of cloud infrastructure is
when we have a formal process to monitor
changes enforce changes and remediate
changes and compliance is code also
known as CAC is when we utilize
programming to automate the monitoring
enforcing and remediating changes to
stay compliant with the compliance
program or expected configuration so
what is adus config well it's a
compliances code framework that allows
us to manage change in your adus
accounts on a per region basis meaning
that you have to turn this on for every
region that you need it for and so here
is a very simple example where let's say
we create a config rule and we have an
ec2 instance and we expect it to be in a
particular State and then in the other
case we have a an RDS instance and it's
in a state that we do not like so the
idea is that we try to remediate it to
put it in the state that we want it to
be and those config rules are just
powered by lambdas as you can see based
on the Lambda icon there so when should
you use itus config well this is when I
want this resource to say configured a
specific way for compliance I want to
keep track of configuration changes to
resources I want a list of all resources
within a region and I want to use uh
analyze potential security weaknesses
and you need detailed historical
information so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andre Brown from exam Pro
and in this follow along we're going to
take a look at adus config so adus
config is a tool that allows you to
ensure that your services are configured
as expected so I've already activated it
in my North Virginia region so what I'm
going to do is just go over to Ohio here
uh because it is per region activated
and I'll go over to config and then what
we'll have to do is set it up so there
is this oneclick setup and it did Skip
me to the review step because it's kind
of piggybacking on the configuration of
my original one here but the idea is
that you'll just say uh record all
resources in this region or things like
that you'll have to create a service
roll link if you have not done so so
this will look a little bit different
but here it's using existing one you'll
have to choose a bucket so or create a
bucket uh it's not super complicated so
you get through there you hit confirm
and basically you're going to end up
with this so the inventory um lets you
see all the the resources that or not
all of them but most resources that are
in your adus account in this particular
region it this will not populate uh
right away so you will have to wait a
little bit of time for that to appear
one really nice thing our conformance
packs I really love these things when
any of us first brought these out there
was only like a couple but now they have
tons and tons and tons of conformance
packs so you can go deploy a conformance
pack and you can open up the templates I
just want to show you look at how many
they have so there some you might
recognize like
nist uh CIS things like that well
architected uh stuff and all these are
um and I'm not sure if it's easy to open
these up but all these are if we open
them up they're on GitHub is these are
just cloudformation templates to set up
configuration rules so there's a variety
of suggested rules uh like around IM
best practices and things like that that
we can load in um but the idea is that
you're just going to create rules so you
go here and you add a rule and they have
a bunch of manag rules here um that we
can look at but I think it might be fun
to actually run a um a conformance pack
I'll just show you what it looks like to
add a rule first so let's say we wanted
to do something for
S3 um and it was making sure that we are
blocking Public Access so we go next
here generally you'll have a trigger
type you can choose whether it's uh
configured when it happens or it's
periodic this is disabled in this case
here and you just scroll on down um and
then once you've added the rule what you
can
do is also manage remediation so if this
rule said hey this thing is
non-compliant we want you to take a
particular action and you have all these
databus actions that you can perform and
you can notify the right people to
correct it or have it auto correct if
you choose to do so um for rules you can
also make your own custom one so that's
just you providing your own Lambda
functions you're providing that Lambda
Arn and so basically you can have it do
anything that you want whatever you want
to put in a Lambda you can make adus
config check for okay so it's not super
complicated here but um this one here is
just going to go ahead and check and so
if we go and
re-evaluate it might just take some time
to show up either going to say that it's
compliant or non-compliant okay and I it
should be compliant but while we're
waiting for that to happen let's just
see how hard it is to deploy a
conformance pack because I feel like
that's something that's really important
oh you can just drop them down and
choose them that's great so we might
want to go to I am here oops identity
and access
management and hit next and say uh my
um uh I am best practices and you might
not want to do this because it does have
spend and when I say spend it's not
going to happen instantly but the idea
is that if you turn this on and forget
to remove it uh you will see some kind
of charges over time because it does
check check based on the rules it's not
super expensive but it is something to
consider about um but anyway so it looks
like we created that conformance pack so
if I refresh it looks like it's in
progress I wonder if that's going to set
up a cloud formation template I'm kind
of curious about that so we'll make our
way over to cloud
formation and it is so that's really
nice because once that is done what we
can do is just tear it down by deleting
the stack so I'm going to go back over
to our conformance pack
here let's take a look here
and so it still says it's in progress
but it is completed and we can click
into
it and we can see all the things that
it's doing so it says item groups have
user check informance pack um and so it
looks like there's a bunch of uh cool
rules uh here so what we'll do is we'll
just wait a little while and we'll come
back here and then just see if um this
updates and see how compliant we are
from a uh a basic account okay all right
so after waiting a little while there it
looks like some of them are being set so
I just gave it a hard refresh here uh
and here you can see that it's saying is
rooe account um whoops we'll give it a
moment here to refresh but uh is the
root account MFA applied yes have we
done a password policy no and actually I
never did a password policy which is
something I forgot to do but here
they're just talking about the minimums
and maximums of things that you can
do okay so that's a conformance pack um
but if we go to rules actually I guess
it's all the rules here I can't really
tell the difference between the
conformance pack rules and our plane
rules kind it's kind of all mixed
together here I
think yeah so it's a bit hard to see
what's going on there if we go to the
performance pack and click in again it
might show the rules yeah there we go so
here's the rules there we're seeing a
little bit more information so use a
hardware MFA so you know how they're
talking about using a security key like
what I showed you that I had earlier in
the course things like that um I am
password policy things like that so you
know not too complicated but um I think
I'm all done here so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to go over to cloud
formation and tear that on down but you
get the
idea well I might want to show you uh
drift so there used to be a way it's CU
I keep changing things on me here but
there's a way to see uh history over
time and so that was
something that they used to show and I'm
just trying to like find where they put
it because it is like somewhere else
resources
maybe ah resource timeline okay so they
moved it over into the resource
inventory and so if we were to take a
look at something anything maybe this
here resource timeline um and there
might not be much here but the idea is
it will show you over time how things
have changed so the idea is that not
only can you say with a was config is
something compliant but when was it
compliant and that is something that is
really important to know okay so very
simple example maybe not the best but
the idea is that we can see when it was
and was not compliant based on uh
changes to our stuff but uh anyway that
looks all good to me here so I'm going
to make my way over to cloud formation
actually already already have it open
over here we're going to go ahead and
delete that
stack um termination protection is
enabled you must first disable it so
we'll edit it disable it
whatever okay we'll hit delete there and
as that's deleting I'm going to go look
for and config my
original rule there
again I'm not really worried about it I
don't think it's going to really cost me
anything but uh I also just kind of
clear the house here just so you're
you're okay as well and so if we go over
to our rules um the one that I spun up
that was custom I think was this one
here CU these are all grayed out right
so I can go ahead there delete that rule
type in
delete and we are good so there you
go that
is it all
right
[Music]
adabs quick starts are pre-built
templates by adabs and adus partners to
help deploy a wide range of stacks it
reduces hundreds of manual uh procedures
into just a few steps the uh quick start
is composed of three parts it has a
reference architecture for the
deployment an adus cloud formation
templates that automate and configure
the deployment a deployment guide
explain the architecture implementation
and detail so here's an example of one
that you might want to launch like the
adus Q&A bot and then you will get an
architectural diagram and a lot of
information about it and from there you
can just go press the button and launch
this infrastructure most quick start
reference deployments enable you to
spend up a fully functional architecture
in less than an hour and there is a lot
as we will see here when we take a look
for
[Music]
ourselves all right so here is uh adabs
quick starts where we have a bunch of
cloudformation templates uh built by
adabs or Amazon or for adab best partner
networks APM partners and uh there's a
variety of different things here so I'm
just going to try to find something like
Q&A
bot Q&A bot just type in bot here and I
don't know why it was here the other day
now it's not showing up which is totally
fine but um you know I just want
anything to deploy just to kind of show
you what we can do with it so you scroll
on down we have uh this graphic here
that's representing what will get
deployed so we have cloudfront S3 Dynamo
DB assistance manager Le poly all these
kind of fun stuff um and there's some
information about how it is architected
and the idea is you can go ahead and
launch in the console or view the
implementation guide let's go take a
look here um and there's a bunch of
stuff so we have Solutions and things
like that conversational things like
that but what I'm going to do is go
ahead and see how far I can get to
launching with this it doesn't really
matter if we do launch it it's just the
fact that um I want to just show you
what you can do with it so if we go to
the designer it's always fun fun to look
at it in there because then we can kind
of visualize all the resources that are
available and I thought that that would
populate over there but maybe we did the
wrong thing so I'm just going to go back
and
click I'm just going to click out of
this oops cancel let's close that leave
yes and we will launch that
again and so this oh View and the
designer I hit the wrong button okay
and so now this should show us the
template might just be
loading there we go so this is what it's
going to launch and you can see there's
a lot going on here just going to shrink
that there uh and I don't know if you
can make any sense of it but clearly
it's doing a lot and so if we were happy
with this and we wanted to launch it I
know I keep backing out of this but
we're going to go back into it one more
time we can go here and we can go next
and then we we would just fill in what
we want so you name it put the language
in and this is stuff that they set up so
maybe you want a mail voice set the ab
in and stuff like that and it's that
simple really um and every stack is
going to be different so they're all
going to have different configuration
options but hopefully that gives you
kind of an idea of what you can do with
quick starts
[Music]
okay let's take a look at the concept of
tagging within AWS so a tag is a key and
value pair that you can assign to aabus
Resource so as you are creating a
resource it's going to prompt you to say
hey what tags do you want to add you're
going to give a key you're going to give
a value and so some examples could be
something like based on Department the
status the team the environment uh the
project as we have the example here the
location um and so tags allow you to
organize your resources in the following
way for resource management so specific
workload so you can say you know
developer environments cost management
and optimization so cost tracking
budgets and alerts operations management
so business commitments SLA operations
Mission critical Services security so
classification of data security impact
governance and Regulatory Compliance
automation workload Automation and so
it's important to understand that
tagging can be used in Junction with um
IM policy so that you can restrict
access or things like that based on
those tags
[Music]
okay all right I just want to show you
one interesting thing about tags um and
it's just the fact that it's used as the
name for some services so when you go to
ec2 and you launch an instance uh the
way you set the name is by giving it a
tag called name and I just want to prove
that to you just like one of those
little exceptions here so we choose an
instance
here we go to configure storage and then
what we do is we add a tag and we say
name um and my server name okay and then
we go ahead and review and launch we're
going to launch this I don't need a key
pair so we'll just say proceed without
key pair I
acknowledge
okay and we will go view the instances
and you'll see that is the name so um
that's just like one of those exceptions
or things that you can do with tags if
there's other things with tags I have no
idea that's just like a a basic one that
everybody should know and that's why I'm
shown to you with the tags but there you
go
so we just looked at tags now let's see
what we can do with resource groups
which are a collection of resources that
share one or more tags or another way to
look at it it it's a way for you to take
multiple tags and organize them uh into
resource groups so it helps you organize
and consolidate information based on
your project and the resources that you
use resource groups can display details
about a group of resources based on
metrics alarms configuration settings
and in any any time you can modify the
settings of your resource groups to
change what resources appear resource
groups appear in the global console
header uh which is over here and under
the systems manager so technically it's
part of AD simple systems manager or
systems manager interface but it's also
part of the global interface so
sometimes that's a bit confusing but uh
that's where you can find it
[Music]
okay all right so what I want to do is
explore resource groups and and also um
tagging so what I want you to do is type
in resource groups at the top here and
it used to be
accessible not sure where they put it
but it used to be accessible here at the
top but they might have moved it over to
systems manager so I'm going to go to
SSM here not sure why I can't seem to
find it today and on the left hand side
we're going to look
for resource
groups
for
all right so what I want to do is take a
look at resource groups and I'm really
surprised because it used to be
somewhere in the global now but I think
they might have changed it um and what's
also frustrating is if I go over to
systems manager it was over here as well
and so on the left hand side I'm looking
for resource groups it's not showing up
so I don't know best you keep moving
things around on me and I'm I can only
update things so quickly in my courses
but if you type in resource groups and
tag editor it's actually over here um I
guess it's its own Standalone service
now why they keep changing things I
don't know but uh the idea is we want to
create a resource Group so you can
create unlimited single region groups in
your A's account use the group to view
related insights things like that so I'm
going to go ahead and create a resource
Group you can see it can be tag based or
cloud formation based but I don't have
any tags I don't really have anything
tags so what I'm going to do is make my
way over to S3 we're just going to
create some resources or a couple
resources here with some tags so that we
can do some filtration so I can go ahead
and create a bucket going say my bucket
uh this like that
whoops and then down below I'm going to
go down to tags and we're going to say
project and we're going to say um RG for
Resource
Group
okay and then I can go back over here
and then I'm going to just say I can say
exactly what type I want I'm going to
support all resource
types and I'm going to say
project RG see how it
autocompletes and we'll go down below
we'll just
say my
RG a test
RG we'll create
that and so now we have a resource Group
and we can see them all in one place uh
resource groups are probably useful for
using in um policies so I can say say
like Resource Group IM
policies that's probably what they're
used
for okay so before you use IM am manag
to access resource groups you should
understand IM am features things like
that and so administrators can use Json
policies to specify who has access to
what and so a policy action a resource
Group is is used following the prefix
resource groups so my thought process
there is that if you want to say okay
you have access to a resource you can
just specify a resource Group and it
will include all the resources within
there and so that might be um a better
way to apply permissions at a per
project basis um and that could save you
a lot of time writing out IM policies so
that's basically all there really is to
it also you kind of get an overview of
of the resources that are there so that
can be kind of useful as well there's
the tag editor here I can't remember
what you use this for you can set up tag
policies um tag policies help you
standardize tags on resource groups in
your accounts used uh to Define tag
policies and Abus or to attach them to
the entire organization um we're not in
the OR account so I'm not going to show
you this and it's not that important um
but just understand that resource groups
can be created and they are used within
IM policies in order to um uh Grant or
deny access to stuff you go ahead and
delete that Resource Group and really ad
stop moving that on me if you move it
one more time I'm just never going to
talk about resource groups again
[Music]
okay hey this is Andie Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at business
Centric services and you might say well
why because in the exam guide It's
explicitly says that these are not
covered but the thing is is that when
you're taking the exam some of the uh
choices might be some of these Services
as distractors and if you know what they
are it's going to help make sure that
you um uh guess correctly and the thing
is that some of these services are
useful and you should know about them so
that's another reason why I'm talking
about them here so the first one is
Amazon connect this is a virtual call
center you can create workflows to Route
callers you can record phone calls
manage a queue of callers based on the
same proven system used by Amazon
customer service teams we have
workspaces this is a virtual Remote
Desktop Service secure manage service
for provision either windows or Linux
desktops in just a few minutes which
quickly scales up to thousands of
desktops we have work docs which is a
shared collaboration service a
centralized storage to share content in
files it is similar to Microsoft
SharePoint think of it as a shared
folder where the company has ownership
we have chime which is a video
conference service it is similar to zoom
or Skype you can screen share have
multiple people on the on the same call
it is secure by default and can show you
a calendar of upcoming calls we have
workmail this is a manag business uh
email contacts calendar service with
support of existing desktop and mobile
email client applications that can
handle things like IMAP similar to Gmail
or exchange we have pinpoint this is a
marketing campaign Management Service
pinpoint is for sending targeted emails
Via SMS push notifications voice
messages you can perform um A to B
testing or create Journey so complex
email response workflows we have SCS
this is a transactional email service
you can integrate SCS into your
application to send emails you can
create common templates track open rates
keep track of your reputation we have
quick site this is a business
intelligence uh service connect multiple
data sources and quickly visualize data
in the form of graphs with little to no
knowledge definitely you want to
remember quick site sces pinpoint uh
because those definitely will show up in
the exam the rest probably not but they
could show up as distractors
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at
provisioning services so let's first
what is provisioning so provisioning is
the allocation or creation of resources
and services to a customer and
provisioning services are responsible
for setting up and managing those Ada
Services we have a lot of services that
do provisioning most of them are just
using cloud formation underneath which
we'll mention here but let's get to it
the first is elastic beanock this is a
platform as a service to easily deploy
web apps EB will provision various a
services like ec2 S3 SNS cloudwatch E2
Auto scaling groups load balancers uh
and you can think of it as the Heroku
equivalent to AWS then you have opsworks
this is a configuration Management
Service that also provides managed
instances of Open Source configuration
managed software such as chef and p
puppet so you'll say I want to have a
load balancer or I want to have servers
and it will provision those for you uh
indirectly then you have Cloud
information itself this is an
infrastructure modeling and provisioning
service it automates the provisioning of
AD Services by writing Cloud information
templates in either Json or yaml and
this is known as IAC or infrastructures
a code you have quick starts these are
pre-made packages that can uh be
launched and configure your a compute
network storage and other services
required to deploy a workload ons we do
cover this in this course but quick
starts is basically just Cloud
information templates that are authored
by the community or um by um Amazon
partner Network okay then we have abis
Marketplace this is a digital catalog
for thousands of software listings of
independent software vendors that you
can use defined by intes and deploy
software so the idea is that um you know
you can go there and provision whatever
kind of resource you want we have Abus
amplify this is a mobile web app
framework that will provision multiple
Abus Services as your backend it's
specifically for serverless services I
don't know why I didn't write that in
there um but you know like Dynamo DB um
things like uh whatever the graphql
service is called API Gateway things
like that uh then we have app
Runner this is a fully managed service
that makes it easy for developers to
quickly deploy containerized web apps
and apis at scale with no prior
information experience required it's
basically a platform as a service but
for containers we have AIS co-pilot this
is a command line interface that enables
customers to quickly launch and manage
containerize applications any us it
basically is a a CLI tool that sets up a
bunch of scripts to set up pipelines for
you makes things super easy we have Adis
code start this provides a unified user
interface enabling you to manage your
software development activities in one
place usually launch common types of
stacks like lamp then we have a cdk and
so this is infastructure as a code tool
allows you to use your favorite
programming language generates out Cloud
information templates as a means of I so
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at ad
elastic beant stock before we do let's
just Define what passes so platform as a
service allows customers to develop run
and manage applications without uh the
complexity of building and maintaining
the infrastructure typically associated
with developing and launching an app and
so elastic beanock is a pass for
deploying apps with little to no uh
knowledge of the underlying
infrastructure so you can focus on
writing application code instead of
setting up an automated deployment
pipeline or devops tasks the idea here
is you choose a platform upload your
code and it runs with little uh
knowledge of the infrastructure and
adabs will say that it's generally not
recommended for production apps but just
understand that they are saying this for
Enterprises and large companies if
you're a small to medium company you can
run elastic beanock for quite a long
time it'll work out great elastic
beanock is powered by Cloud information
temp templates and it sets up for you
elastic load balancer asgs RDS ec2
instances preconfigured for particular
platforms uh monitoring integration with
cloudwatch SNS uh deployment strategies
like in place blue green uh deployment
has security built in so it could rotate
out your passwords for your databases
and it can run dockerized environments
and so when we talk about platforms you
can see we have Docker multicontainer
Docker uh go.net Java nodejs Ruby PHP
python tom cat go a bunch of stuff and
just to kind of give you that
architectural diagram to show you that
it it can launch of multiple things
[Music]
okay hey it's Andre Brown from exam Pro
and in this follow along we're going to
learn all about elastic beanock maybe
not everything but we're going to
definitely know how to at least um use
the service so elastic beanock is a
platform as a service and what it does
is it allows you to uh deploy web
applications very easily so here I've
made my way over to elastic beanock I
mean environment and app and then we set
up our application we have two tiers a
web server environment a worker
environment worker environment is great
for long running workloads performing uh
background jobs and things like that and
then you have your web server which is
your web server and you can have both
and it's generally recommended to do so
um but anyway what we'll do is create a
new application so let's say my app here
and uh there's some tags we can do and
then it will name based on the
environment
then we need to choose an environment
name so say my environment and just put
a bunch of numbers in there hit the
check availability scroll on down and we
have two options manage platform custom
platform and I'm not sure why custom is
blanked out but it would allow you to um
it would allow you to I think use your
own containers so I'm a big fan of Ruby
so I'm going to drop down to Ruby and
here we have a bunch of different
versions and so 2.7 is pretty pretty new
which is pretty good and then there's
the platform version which is fine and
the great thing is it comes with a
sample application now you could hit
create environment but you'd be missing
on a lot if you don't hit this configure
more options I don't know why they put
it there it's a not very good UI but um
if you click here you actually get to
see everything possible and so up here
we have some presets where we can have a
single instance so this is where it's
literally running a single E2 instance
so it's very cost effective you can have
it with spot uh spot pricing so you save
money um there's High availability so
you know if you want it set up with a
load balance an auto scaling group it
will scale very well or you can do
custom configuration we scroll on down
here you can enable Amazon x-ray you can
rotate out logs you can do log
streaming um there's a lot of stuff here
and basically it's just like it sets up
most for you but you can pretty much
configure what you want as well if we
had the load bouncer set if I go here go
to High availability now we'll be able
to change our load balancer options you
have different ways of deploying so you
can go here and and then change it from
all at once rolling immutable traffic
splitting depends on what your use case
is um we can set up a key pair to be
able to log into the
machine there's a whole variety of
things you can connect your database as
well so it can create the database
alongside with it and then it can
actually rotate out the key so you don't
have to worry about it which is really
nice what I'm going to do is go to the
top here and just choose a single
instance because I want this to be very
cost- effective we're going to go ahead
and hit create environment
and so we are just going to wait for
that to start up and I'll see you back
when it's done
okay okay so it's been uh quite a while
here and it says a few minutes so if it
does do this what you can do is just
give it a hard refresh I have a feeling
that it's already done is it done yeah
it's already done so and here it says on
September 2020 elastic be talk Etc
default default I don't care um but
anyway so this application I guess it's
in a pending State um I'm not sure why
let's go take a look here causes
instance has not sent any data since
launch uh none of the instances are
sending data so that's kind of
interesting because um I shouldn't have
any problems you know what I mean so
what I'm going to do is just reboot this
machine and see if that fixes the issue
there but usually it's not that
difficult because it's the sample
application it's not up to me um as to
how to fix this you know what I mean
so I'm not sure but um what we'll do is
we will let the machine reboot and see
if that makes any difference okay all
right so after rebooting that machine
now it looks like the server is healthy
so it's not all that bad right if you do
run into issues that is something that
you can do and so uh let's go see if
this is actually working so the top here
we have a link and so I can just right
click here it says congratulations your
first 8us elastic uh beanock Ruby
application is now running so it's all
in good shape um there's a lot of stuff
that's going on here in elastic beanock
that we can do uh we we can go back to
our configuration and change any of our
options here so there's a lot of stuff
as you can see uh we get logging uh so
click the request log so if we click on
this and say last 100
lines we should be able to get uh
logging data we have to download it I
wish it was kind of in line but here you
can kind of see what's going on so we
have STD access logs error logs Puma
logs elastic beam stock engine so you
could use that to debug very common to
take that over to uh support if you do
have issues uh for Health it monitors
the health of the instances which is
great then we have some uh monitoring uh
data here so it gives you like a built
dashboard so that's kind of nice you can
set up alarms um you have not defined
any alarms you can add them via the
monitoring dashboard so I guess you'd
have
to you'd have to somehow add them um I
don't think I've ever added alarms for
um classic beanock but it's nice to know
that they have them you can set up
schedules for managed events then this
is event data so it's just kind of
telling you it's kind of like logs it
just tells you of things that have
changed so there's stuff like that what
I'm looking for is to see how I can
download the existing
application because there's a version
uploaded here oh the source is over here
okay
so I think it's probably over here the
one that's
running so that's
it if it was easy to find what I
probably would do is just modify it and
oh yeah it's over here so if we go here
and download the
zip I wonder if it'd be even worth um
playing with this so let's I'm just
going to see if we can go over to
Cloud9 and give this a go
quickly so if we go over and launch a
Cloud9 environment maybe we can tweak it
and upload a revised version so we say
create new we'll say EB
um uh environment for elastic bean stock
uh we'll set it all the defaults that's
all fine it's all within the free tier
we'll create that environment what I'm
going to do is just take this uh Ruby
zip file and move it to my
desktop and as that is loading we'll
give it a moment here I'm just going to
go back and I was just curious does it
let you download it directly from here
no so only thing is that you know if you
download that application elastic
beanock usually has a configuration file
with it and so I don't know if they
would have given that to us but if they
did that would be really great
but we just have to wait for that to uh
launch there as well I guess you can
save configurations and roll back on
those as
well um but we will just wait a moment
here while it's going I might just peek
inside of this file to see what it is
this ZIP
contains just going to go to my desktop
here open up that
zip so it looks pretty simple it doesn't
even look like a rails app it looks like
maybe it's a Sinatra app I thought
before that it would it would have
deployed a Ruby on Rails application but
maybe they keep it really simple
um I don't see usually it's like yamell
files they use for configuration I don't
see that
there so it might be that the default
settings will work fine uh there's a
king fig. Ru and stuff like that but
once Cloud9 is up here we will upload
this and see what we can do with it okay
so there we go uh Cloud9 is ready to go
and so if we right click here whoops
right click here we should be up be able
to upload a file if not we can go up
here to the
top or it's here or
there where is the upload I've I've
uploaded things in here so I absolutely
know we can I just got to find
it is that the
upload upload files
Cloud9
oh boy that's not helpful that's not
helpful at all so let me just click
around a little bit here I mean worst
case I can always just bring it in Via a
curl oh upload local files there it is I
was just not um being patient okay so
we'll drag that on in there and we
will did it upload yep it's right there
okay great so we need to unzip it so
what I'll do is just drag this on up
here I'll do an LS and we'll say unzip
rubyzip and so that unzipped the
contents there I think the readme was
part of Cloud9 so I'm going to go ahead
and delete that out not that it's going
to hurt anything and so now what we can
do and we'll delete the
original original zip
there um and let's see if we can make a
change here so I'm just going to open up
see what it is so yeah it's running
Sinatra so that's pretty clear there we
have a proc file to say how it runs we
have a worker sample sample so that just
tells how the requests go you don't need
to know any of this I'm just kind of
clicking through it because I know Ruby
very well we have a cron yamel file so
that could be something that gets loaded
in here so I think basically a Sinatra
app probably just works off the bat here
but if we want to make a change we
probably just make a change over to here
so I'll go down here and this is
your second ads elastic beanock
application so the next thing we need to
do is actually zip the contents here I
don't know if it would let us zip it
with in here but I'll have to look like
Zip the contents of a
directory Linux this goes to
show Google is
everything so the easiest way to zip a
folder
um
zip everything in the current
directory
Linux okay that's easy so we'll go back
over here and we will type in
zip and it wants hyphen R for recursive
which makes sense and then the name of
the zip so
um uh Ruby 2.zip and we'll do
period zip warning found is who is
zip
oh uh yum install zip maybe we have to
install uh ZIP but maybe it's not
installed pseudo yum install
zip since it's Amazon El 2 it uses
yum and so package already installed so
I'm going to type zip again so zip is
there now great oops don't need to
install
twice
zip warning Ruby 2 zip not found or
empty okay so install zip and use zip
hyphen R you can use the flag to best
compensate so if that's not working what
I'm going to do is just go up a
directory why is it saying not found or
[Music]
empty maybe I need to
use okay so I think the problem was is I
was using the wrong flag so I put F
instead of R I don't know why I did that
so I probably should have done this okay
and so that should have copied all the
contents of that file so what I'm going
to do is go ahead whoops make sure I
have that select it and download that
file and once I have downloaded that
file I'm going to just open the contents
to make sure it is what I expect it to
be so we're going to open that up and
whoops get out of here when RAR and it
looks like everything I want so what I'm
going to do is go back over to here I'm
going to make sure I have my Ruby 2 on
my desktop and we're going to see if we
can upload another version here so
upload and deploy choose the file we're
going to go all the way to my desktop
here and we're going to choose Ruby 2
and um like Ruby 2 will be the version
name or we'll just say two and we'll
deploy and we'll see if that works okay
but there are like uh elastic be
configuration files like gamble files
that can sit in the root directory and
so generally you're used to seeing them
there but you know I imagine that a US
probably engineered these examples so
that it uses all the default settings
but uh once this is deployed I'll see
you back here in a moment okay after a
short little wait it looks like it has
deployed so what I'm going to do is just
close my other tabs here and open this
up and see if it's worked it says your
second ads elastic being stock Ruby
application so uh we were successful uh
deploying that out which is really great
so what we can do now is just close that
tab there and uh since we have that
cloud environment it will shut down on
its own but you know just for your
benefit I think that we should shut it
off right now so go ahead and delete
that I'm going to go back over to
elastic beanock here and I just want to
destroy all of it so we'll see if we can
just do that from here terminate the
application enter the name so I think we
probably have to enter that in
there and so I think that oh a problem
occurred rate
exceeded what that's AWS for you so it's
not a big deal I would just go and check
it
again and maybe what we'll do is just
delete the application
first okay so that one is possibly
deleting let's go in here is anything
changing can't even tell we'll go ahead
oh can't take that one
out
delete application
again if it takes you a couple times
it's not a big
deal it's AWS 4 yes so there's a lot of
moving parts so it looks like it is
terminating the instance and so we just
have to wait for that to complete uh
once that is done we might have to just
tear down the environment so I'll see
you back here when it has finished
tearing this down okay all right and so
after a short little wait here I think
it's been destroyed we'll just double
check by going to the applications going
to the environments yeah and it's all
gone probably cuz I initially deleted
that environment and then took the
application with it so I probably didn't
have to delete the app separately um but
uh yeah so there you go and just make
sure your Cloud9 environment's gone and
you are a okay there'll probably be some
like lingering S3 buckets so if you do
want to get rid of those you can it's
not going to hurt anything having those
around uh but they do tend to stack up
after a while which is kind of annoying
so if you don't like them you can just
empty them out as I am doing here whoops
oh just permanently
delete copy that text
there we can go
back to here and then just go take out
that bucket let's delete that
there oh if you get this this is kind of
annoying but uh elastic beanock liks to
put in an i permission or policy here so
if you go down here there's a bucket
policy you just have to delete it out it
prevents it from being
deleted and we'll go back over here and
then we will delete
it okay and yeah there we go that's
[Music]
it so let's take a look at serverless
services on AWS and this is not
including all of them because we're
looking at the most purely serverless
services
uh if we tried to include all the
serverless services it would just be too
long of a list uh but let's take a look
here so um before we do let's just
redefine what is serverless so when the
underlying servers infrastructure and
operating system is taken care of by the
CSP serverless is generally by default
highly available scalable cost effective
you pay for what you use the first one
is Dynamo DB which is a serverless nosql
key value and document database it's
designed to scale to billions of records
with guaranteed consistent data return
in at least a second you do not have to
worry about managing chards you have
simple storage service S3 which is a
seress object storage service you can
upload very large and unlimited amounts
of files you can pay for what you store
you don't worry about the underlying
file system or upgrading the disk size
we have ECS fargate which is a servess
orchestration container service is the
same as ECS except you pay on demand per
running container with ECS you have to
keep a ec2 server running even if you
have no containers running where adus
manages the underlying server so you
don't have to scale or upgrade the ec2
server we have adus Lambda which is a
serverless function service you can run
code without provisioning or managing
servers you upload a small piece of code
choose uh how much memory you want how
long you want the function is allowed to
run before timing out your charge based
on the runtime of the service function
rounded to the nearest 100 milliseconds
we have step functions this is the state
machine service it coordinates multiple
Services into serverless workflows
easily share data among lambdas have a
group of lambdas wait for each other
create logical steps also work with
fargate tasks we have Aurora servus this
is a serous on demand version of Aurora
so when you want most of the benefits of
Aurora but trade you have to trade off
those cold starts or you don't have lots
of traffic or demand so things Ser
services that we could have put in here
as well is like API Gateway Apps sync a
amplify um and those are like the the
first two were app Integrations you
could say sqs SNS those are all serous
services but you know again we'd be here
all day if I I I list to the all
[Music]
right all right let's take a look at
what is serverless and we did look at it
from a server perspective earlier in the
course but let's just try to abstractly
Define it and talk about the
architecture so serverless architecture
generally describes fully managed cloud
services and the classification of a
cloud service being being serverless is
not a Boolean answer it's it's not a yes
or no but an answer on a scale where a
cloud service has a degree of serverless
and I do have to point out that this
definition might not be accepted by um
everybody because serverless is one of
those uh terms where um we've had a
bunch of different cloud service
providers Define it differently and then
we have thought leaders that have a
particular concept of what it is so you
know I just do my best to try to make
this practical here for you but a
serverless service could have all or
most of the following characteristics
and so it could be highly elastic and
scalable highly available highly durable
secure by default it abstracts away the
underlying infrastructure and are build
based on the execution of your business
tasks a lot of times that uh that cost
is not uh is not always represented as
something that is like I'm paying X for
compute it could be abstracted out into
some kind of um credit that uh doesn't
necessarily map to something physical
then we have serus can scale to zero
meaning when it's not in use the
serverless resources cost nothing uh and
these two last topics basically pull
into pay for Value so you don't pay for
idle servers you're paying for the value
uh that your service
provides and uh my friend Daniel who
runs the serverless Toronto group he
likes to describe serverless as being
similar to like energy efficient rating
so an analogy of serus could be similar
to energy rating labels which allows
consumers to compare the Energy
Efficiency of a product so some services
are more servoless than others and again
you know some people might not agree
with that where there's a a definitive
yes or no answer but I think that's the
best way to look at it
[Music]
okay hey it's Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at windows on
ads so adabs has multiple cloud services
and tools to make it easy for you to run
window workloads on ads so let's get to
it so the first is Windows servers on
ec2 so you can select from a number of
Windows Server versions including the
latest version like Windows Server 2019
uh for uh databases we have SQL server
on RDS you can select from a number of
SQL Server database versions then we
have adabs directory service which lets
you run Microsoft active directory ad as
a managed service we have adus license
manager which makes it easier to manage
your software licenses from software
vendors such as Microsoft we have have
Amazon FSX for Windows file server which
is a fully managed scalable storage
built for Windows we have the ads SDK
which allows you to write code in your
favorite language to interact with adus
API but it specifically has support forn
net a language favorite for Windows
developers we have Amazon workspaces so
this allows you to run a virtual desktop
you can launch a Windows 10 desktop to
provide secure and durable workstations
that is accessible from wherever you
have an internet connection a Lambda
supports power shell is a programming
language to write your serverless
functions and we have Aus migration
acceleration program map for Windows is
a migration methodology for moving large
Enterprises it us has Amazon partners
that specialize in providing
Professional Services for map this is
not just everything for Windows on AWS
like if you want to move your SQL Server
over to RDS postest I believe they've
like they created an adapter to do that
um but yeah hopefully that gives you an
idea what you can do with windowss on
AWS
[Music]
okay hey this is Andre Brown from exam
Pro and I want to show you how you can
launch a Windows uh server on AWS so
what you're going to do is go to the top
here and we are going to type in ec2 and
from here uh what we'll do is we'll go
ahead and launch ourselves a new ec2
instance and we are going to have um a
selection of instances that we can
launch and so we're looking for for the
Microsoft Windows server and this is
interesting there's actually a free tier
eligible that is crazy because if you go
over to Azure they don't have a free
tier Windows
Server does so that's pretty crazy um
and it runs on a T2 micro no that can't
be right there's no way it can run a T2
micro that seems like that's too small
let's try it okay I just don't believe
it because when you use Azure you have
to choose a particular size of instance
by default and it's a lot more expensive
and there is no free tiar so we'll go
here there are free tiar just not really
for Windows in particular so we'll go
here this looks good security groups
this opens up RDP so we can get into
that machine we're going to go next here
and launch this
machine says if you plan to use Ami the
benefits the Microsoft license Mobility
check out this form that's not something
we're worried about today and I mean I
guess we can create a key pair
I'm not sure what we would use a key
pair for here um for Windows Amis the
private key file is required to obtain
the password used to log into the
instance okay so I guess we're going to
need it
so Windows
key great we'll launch that
instance and uh I'll see you back here
when it launches but I just don't
believe that it would launch that fast
you know all right so after a short
little wait here the server is ready and
so let's see if we can actually go ahead
and connect to this so I'm going to hit
connect here and we're go over to rdb
client so you connect to your windows
instance using a remote desktop client
of your choice and downloading and
running the RDP shortcut below so I'm
going to go ahead and download this and
you're going to have to be on a um
Windows machine to be able to do this or
have an rdb client installed I think
there's one for Mac that you can get
from the Apple Store um but all I'm
going to do is just double click the
file
so you probably can't see it here I'm
just going to expand this trying to oh
my computer is being silly but anyway
there we go we moved it over there I'm
just going to drag over here and just
double click this image so you can see
that I'm doing it I'm saying
connect
okay and it's going to ask for a
password so I'm going to hope that I can
just click that and get the password so
to decrypt the password you will need
your key PA instance you'll have to
upload that and I don't know if I
remember having to do that before but
it's a great security measure so I'm
fine with it I'm going to drag my key to
my desktop so I can see what's going on
there as
well and we're going to go grab that and
decrypt the password and so
now um where's our password oh it's
right here okay so we're going to grab
that password
there we will paste that in said
okay say yes and see if we can connect
to this instance and if this is running
on a T2 micro I'm going to lose it
because that is just
cheap it just just doesn't seem possible
to me because again on Azure you have to
launch an instance with a lot of stuff
and it just uh seems uh crazy what's
also interesting is that iTab us uh on
Windows like launches so fast it's
unbelievable how fast these servers uh
spin up and it's just very unusual but
yeah so we are in
here
um it's not asking me to activate or
anything so I guess there's already a
Windows license
here and um I'm not sure if there's any
kind of like games installed like do we
have mind sweeper can I play mind
sweeper on
here it's a data center server so I'm
assuming not um but yeah so this is a
Windows server and it's pretty
impressive that this works I'm not sure
if this is going to have an outbound
connection here um just because we
probably would have to configure it let
just say okay I just I really don't
think it's going to go to the Internet
by
default yeah so You' probably have
to do some stuff you
know oh no there we go so yeah we got to
the Internet so it's totally possible
but uh yeah that's about it that's all I
really wanted to show you so what I'm
going to do is just go back to ec2 and
we're going to shut down the server here
just expand that
there
and we will go here and we will
terminate that
instance good we'll give that a refresh
that's shutting down and we are
[Music]
done hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at Abus
license manager and before we do let's
talk about what b y l or bring your own
license mean so this is the process of
reusing an existing software license to
run vendor software on a cloud vendor
Computing service byol allows companies
to save money since they may have
purchased the license in bulk or the
time that provided a greater discount
than if purchased again and so an
example of this could be the license
Mobility provided by Microsoft's volume
licensing to customers with eligible
server applications covered by the
Microsoft software Assurance program uh
and I don't know what I was trying to do
there I guess maybe it's just essay and
I missed the parentheses there on the
end no big big deal um but Aus license
manager is a service that makes it
easier for you to manage your software
licenses from software vendors centrally
across ads in your on- premise
environments ads license manager
software uh that is licensed based on
Virtual cores uh physical cores sockets
or a number of machines this includes a
variety of software products for
Microsoft IBM sap Oracle and other
vendors so that's the idea you say what
is my license type it's it's bound to
this amount of CPUs AAS license manager
works with ec2 with dedicated instances
dedicated hosts and even spot instances
and for RDS there's only for Oracle
databases so you can import that license
for your Oracle server um just
understand that um if you're doing
Microsoft Windows servers or Microsoft
SQL Server license you're generally
going to need a dedicated host because
of the Assurance program uh and this can
really show up on your exam so even
though a license manager works on
dedicated instances and spot instances
just try to gravitate towards dedicated
hosts on the server or on the exam okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the
logging services that we have available
in AWS so the first one here is cloud
trail and this logs all API calls
whether it's SDK or the CLI so if it's
making a call to the API it's going to
get tracked between adaa services and
this is really useful to say who can we
blame who was the person that did this
so who created this bucket who spent up
that expense of vc2 instance who
launched the stagemaker notebook um and
the idea here is you can detect
developer misconfiguration detect
malicious actors or automate responses
through the system then you have
cloudwatch which is a collection of
multiple Services I commonly say this is
like an umbrella service because it has
so many things underneath it so we have
cloudwatch logs which is a centralized
place to store your cloud services log
data application logs metrics which
represents a Time ordered set of data
points a variable uh to monitor uh event
Bridge or previously known as cloudwatch
events triggers an event based on a
condition so every hour take a snapshot
of the server alarms triggers
notifications based on metrics
dashboards creates visualizations based
on metrics and that's not all of the
things that are under cloudwatch but
those are the core five ones you should
always know um absolutely there then we
have adus x-ray this is for a
distributed tracing system so you can
use it to pinpoint issues within your
microservices so you see how data moves
from one app to another how long it took
to move and if it failed uh to move
forward
[Music]
okay let's take a close CL look here at
Aus cloud trail because it's a very
important service so it's a service that
enables governance compliance
operational auditing and risk auditing
of your Aus account and the idea is that
every time you make an API call it's
going to show up as some kind of
structured data that you can uh interact
with or read through so abis cloud trail
is used to monitor API calls and actions
made on the AWS account easily identify
which users and accounts made the call
to AWS so you might have the WHERE so
the source IP address the when the event
time the who the user agent uh and the
what the region resource in action so
I'm just going to get my pen tool out
here for a moment and just notice you
have the event time so when it happened
the source the name the region The
Source IP address the user agent uh who
was doing it so here was LE Forge the
response element so you know it's very
clear what is going on here um and then
you know Cloud tra is already logging by
default and will collect logs for the uh
for the last 90 days via event history
if you need more than 90 days you need
to create a trail which is very common
you'll go into AWS and make one right
away trails are outputed to S3 and do
not have guy like event history to
analyze a trail you have to use Amazon
Athena and I'm sure there are other ways
to analyze it within AWS but here's just
what the event history looks like so
right off the bat you can already see
that there are information there I'm not
sure if they've updated the UI there
they might have uh as even when I'm
recording this I kind of feel like if we
go into the follow along which we will
um I bet they might have updated that
the idea here is that you know you can
browse the last 90 days but anything
outside of that you're going to have to
do a little bit of work yourself
[Music]
okay so we're not going to cover all the
cloudwatch services there's just too
many but let's look at the most
important ones and one of that those
important ones is cloudwatch alarms so
cloudwatch alarms monitors a cloudwatch
metric based on a defined threshold uh
so here you can see there's kind of a
condition being set there so if the
network in is greater than 300 for one
data points within 5 minutes it's going
to breach an alarm so uh that's when it
goes outside it's defin threshold and so
the state's going to either be something
like okay so the metric or expression is
within the defined threshold so do
nothing alarm the metric or expression
is outside of the defined threshold so
do something or insufficient data the
alarm has just started the metric is not
available not enough data is available
and so when the state has change you can
Define actions that it should take and
so that could be doing a notification
autoscaling group or any C2 action um so
cloudwatch alarms are really useful for
a variety of reasons the one that we
will come across right away will be
setting up a bilding alarm
[Music]
so let's take a look here at the
autonomy of an alarm and so I have this
nice graphic here to kind of explain
that there and so the first thing is we
have our threshold condition uh and so
here you can just set a value and say
okay the value is a TH or 100 whatever
you want it to be and this is going to
be for a particular metric the actual
data we are measuring so maybe in this
case we're measuring Network in so the
volume of incoming Network traffic
measured in bytes so when using 5minute
monitoring divide by 3 00 we get bytes
per second if you're trying to figure
out that calculation there you have data
points so these represent the metrics
measurement at a given point then you
have the period how often it checks to
evaluate the alarm so we could say every
five minutes uh you have the evaluation
period so the number of previous periods
and the data points to alarm so you can
say one data point is breached and
evaluation period going back four
periods so this is what triggers the
alarm uh the thing I just want you to
know is that you can set a value right
and that it's based on a particular
metric and there is a bit of logic here
in terms of uh the alarm so it's not as
simple as just it's breached but there's
this period thing happening
[Music]
okay let's take a look at cloudwatch
logs so to understand that we have log
streams and log groups so a log stream
is uh a stream that represents a
sequence of events from an application
or instance being monitored so imagine
you have an ec2 instance running a web
application and you want those logs to
be streamed to cloudwatch logs that's
what we're talking about about here so
you can create log streams manually uh
but generally this is automatically done
by the service you are using uh unless
you were collecting application logs on
any2 instance as I just described here
is a log group of a Lambda function you
can see the log streams are named after
the running instance lambda's frequency
run on New instances so the stream
contains timestamps so what I'm trying
to say here is that there's a variety of
different Services Lambda RDS what have
you and they already send their logs to
cloudwatch logs and they're and they're
going to vary Okay so here's a log group
of an application log running on uc2 you
can see here the log streams are named
after the running instance ID here is
the log group for Adis glue you can see
that the log streams are named after the
glue jobs um and so you know we have the
streams but let's talk about the actual
data that's made up of it the log events
so this represents a single event in a
log file log events can be seen within
the log stream and so here's an example
of you would open this up in cloudwatch
logs and you can actually see what what
was being reported back by your server
you can filter these events to filter
out uh logs based on simple or pattern
matching uh syntax so here I'm just
typing in saying give me all those debug
stuff and you know this isn't very
robust but adus does have a better way
of analyzing your logs which is log
insights which we'll look at here in a
moment so we were just looking at uh
cloudwatch log events and how those were
collected but there's an easier way to
analyze them and that's with log
insights so you can interactively search
and analyze your cloudwatch log data and
it has the following advantages more
robust filtering than using the simple
filter in the in a log stream less
burdensome than having to export logs to
S3 and analyze them via Athena
cloudwatch log Insight supports all
types of logs so cloudwatch log insights
is commonly used via the console to do
ad hoc queries against log groups so
that's just kind of an example of Solon
writing a query and cloudwatch log
insights uses a query syntax so a single
request can query up to 20 logs query
time out after 50 minutes if not
completed and queries result are
available for 7 days so abis provides
sample queries that you can get started
for common tasks and uh and ease the
learning into the query syntax a good
example is filtering VPC flow logs so
you go there you click it and you start
to getting some data you can create and
save your own queries uh to make future
repetitive tasks easier on the certified
Cloud preder they're not going to ask
you all these details about this stuff
but I just conceptually want you to
understand that in login sites you can
use it to uh robustly filter your logs
based on this query syntax language you
get this kind of visual and it's really
really
useful let's take a look here at
cloudwatch metrics which represents a
Time ordered set of data points it's a
variable that is monitored over time so
cloudwatch comes with many predefined
metrics that are generally named spaced
by adus Services uh so the idea is that
like if we were to look at the ec2 it
has these particular metric so we have
CPU utilization disre Ops dis write Ops
disre bytes disr bytes Network in
Network out Network packet in uh Network
packets out and the idea is that you can
just like click there into ec2 and then
kind of get that data there and so Cloud
metrics are leveraged by other things
like Cloud watch events Cloud watch
alarms cloudwatch dashboards so just
understand that
[Music]
okay all right so what I want to do in
this follow along is show you a bit
about cloud trail so we're going to go
to the top here and type in cloud trail
the great thing about cloud trail is
it's already turned turned on by default
so it's already kind of collecting some
information and so here it says now use
I access analyzer on cloud trail trails
that sounds pretty cool to me but uh we
shouldn't have to create a trail right
off the bat because we'll have some
event history and the event history
allows us to see things that are
happening within our account in the last
90 days um but the thing is if you want
something Beyond 90 days you're going to
have to create a trail but if we just
take a look here we can kind of see uh
as we've been doing a lot of things all
the kind of actions that's been
happening so here we have an that I
terminated so if I go in here and and
look at it I can kind of see uh more
information about it so we can see when
it terminated who had done that what
access key they had used the Event
Source the request
ID um The Source IP what whether it was
readon what was the event type that was
called the resource there and this is
the actual raw record so this is
generally how I would look at it or this
is how you had to look at it back in the
day um but the idea is that you would
have that uh user identity described the
event time the source the event name the
region The Source IP the uh the agent
all the information there okay and so
this is a great way to kind of find
stuff so you can go through here and try
to debug things this way so you can go
to the event name and so if you if you
go here you can kind of get uh see a bit
of stuff here so if I was just trying to
say like maybe create I'm just trying to
find something that I know that I've
been doing like create access keys I can
see the access keys that going be
created within this uh sandbox account
here for the user and things like that
so it's a great way to kind of find
things but generally you're going to
always want to turn on uh or create your
own trail so if you go here and hit
create Trail say my new Trail and um
you're going to need an S3 bucket for
that you'll probably want encryption
turned
on which sounds good to me you'll
absolutely want log file validation and
generally you don't want to store your
your cloud trail logs within the
existing account you want to have a
isolated hardened account that that is
uh infrequently accessed or only by your
your Cloud security Engineers um away
from here because you don't want people
tampering with it deleting it or
changing stuff but um we'll just take an
existing one here I don't want a
customer manage don't I have one that is
managed by ads here new
custom uh we'll choose that one I don't
know which one that is we'll just hit
next usually adab us gives you a manage
key there so I was kind of surprised um
you can also include additional data so
if you do data events this would collect
information from S3 um but the thing is
you might not want to track everything
because if you track to everything it
can get very expensive very quickly uh
but if you don't you just leave on
management events it'll save you more
money there's inside events uh this is
new I haven't seen this yet so ident I
identify unusual activity errors users
behavior that sounds really good but
these could come also at additional
charges but I'm going to hit next anyway
for fun I'm going to create that
trail okay
and uh the key policy does not Grant
sufficient access to etc etc so I'm
going to go turn that off even though I
should really have a turned on but I
just want to be able to show you
this okay so we have this new
Trail and so this Trail is being dumped
to S3 so we might not be able to see
anything in here as of yet but I'm just
going to pop over here and just see
right I probably have one in my other
account but it's not um it's not that
important and we basically saw what the
data would look like so we go into here
there's a digest I don't remember there
being a digest so that's nice so there's
no data yet but when there is it will
pop into there um I'm not sure if we're
going to be able to do anything with
insights here at least not in this
account insights are events that are
show unusual API activity and things
like that so that's kind of cool I don't
know what cloudwatch insights looks
like uh inside events are shown in the
table for 90 days okay so I'm just uh
curious if we can see kind of a
screenshot of what that looks like
whoops well we're at least on the
article here so I guess you get kind of
get like some kind of graphs or
something saying like hey this looks
unusual and they might select it so not
pretty clear in terms of what that looks
like but I mean sounds like a cool
feature and I'm sure when I when working
on my uh security certification course
I'll will definitely include in there
but that's pretty much all there is to
it um I'm going to go ahead and delete
um that Trail because I I just don't
really need in this account but
generally you always want to go in and
create a trail um and what you can do is
if you're in your root account I'm not
this is actually a an account that's
part of an organization but if you're at
that organization level you can create a
trail that that spands all the regions
that spans all the ad accounts with an
organization and that's what you should
be doing okay but uh that's about
[Music]
it hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro we're looking at ML and AI services
on AWS but let's first just Define what
is AI ML and deep learning so AI also
known as artificial intelligence is when
machines that perform jobs that may make
human behavior ml or machine learning
are machines that get better at a task
without explicit programming and deep
learning or DL are machines that are
have an artificial neural network
inspired by the human brain to solve
complex problems and a lot of times
you'll see this kind of onion where
they're showing you that um you know AI
uh can be using ml or deep learning and
then deep learning is definitely using
machine learning but it's using neural
networks and so for AWS their Flagship
product here is Amazon sagemaker it is a
fully managed service to build train
deploy machine learning models at scale
um and there's a bunch of different kind
of Open Source Frameworks you can use
with it like apachi mxnet ons which is
an open source deep learning framework
that is the one that abis decided to say
hey we are going to back this one and so
you'll see a lot of example code for
that one we have tensor flow that you
can use pie torch uh hugging face other
things as well okay um and so there's a
lot of uh Services underneath some that
might be of interest to mention right
away is like Amazon sagemaker ground
truth which is a data labeling service
where you have humans that label a data
set that will be used to train machine
learning models or maybe something like
Amazon uh augmented AI so human
intervention review Services when
sagemaker uses machine learning to make
a prediction that is not confident uh
and it has the right answer cue up to
the predict for a human review and these
are all about just labeling data um you
know when you're using supervised um
supervised learning but there are a lot
of Services Under sagemaker itself and
just AI services in general so we'll
look at that next
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look at all
the ML and AI services and there's a lot
on AWS so the first is Amazon code Guru
this is a machine learning code anal
service and cod Guru performs code
reviews and will suggest to improve the
code quality of your code it can show
visual code profiles to show the
internals of your code to pinpoint
performance next we have Amazon Lex this
is a conversation interface service with
Lex you can build Voice and text chat
Bots we have Amazon personalized this is
a real-time recommendation service it's
the same technology used to make product
recommendations to customer shopping on
the Amazon platform then we have Amazon
poly this is a text to speech service
upload your text and an audio file
spoken by synthe synthesized voice uh
and that will be generated you have
Amazon recognition this is an image and
video recognition Service uh analyze
image and videos to detect and label
objects peoples and celebrities then we
have Amazon transcribe this is a speech
to text service so you upload your audio
and that'll be converted into text we
have Amazon text extract this is an OCR
tool so it extracts text from scan
documents when you have uh paper forms
and you want to digitally extract that
data we have Amazon translate this is a
neural machine learning translation
service so use deep learning mod models
to deliver more accurate and natural
sounding translations we have Amazon
comprehend this is an NLP so natural
language processing service find
relationships between text to produce
insights looks at data such as customer
email support tickets social media and
makes
predictions then we we have Amazon
forecast this is a Time series
forecasting service and it's you know uh
I mean technically I guess it's a bit of
a database but the idea here is that it
can forecast business outcome such as
product demand resource needs or
financial uh performance and it's
powered by ml or AI if you want to call
it we have adabs deep learning Ami so
these are Amazon ec2 instances they're
pre-installed with popular deep learning
Frameworks and interfaces such as
tensorflow pytorch apachi mxnet chainer
GL uh glue on uh horovod and
kirz we have adabs deep learning
containers so Docker images instances
pre-installed with popular deep learning
Frameworks and interfaces such as
tensorflow pytorch Apachi mxnet uh we
have adus deep composer this is machine
learning enabled musical keyboard uh I
don't know many people using this but it
sounds like fun it was deep lens is a
video camera that uses deep learning
it's more of like a learning tool so
again we don't see many people using
this adus deep racer is a toy race card
that can be powered with machine
learning to perform autonomous driving
again this is another learning tool for
learning ml they like to do these at
reinvent to have like these racing
competitions Amazon elastic interface so
this allows you to attach lowcost GPU
perform uh powered acceleration to ec2
instances to reduce the cost of running
deep learning interfaces by
75% we have Amazon fraud detector so
this is a fully managed fraud detection
uh as a service uh it identifies
potentially fraudulent uh online
activities such as online payment fraud
and the creation of fake accounts
Amazon Kendra so this is an Enterprise
machine learning search engine service
it uses natural language to suggest
answers to questions instead of just
simple keyword matching so there you
[Music]
go hey it's Andie Brown from exam Pro
and we're going to do a quick review
here of the big data and analytic
services that are on AWS but before we
do let's just Define what big data is so
it's a term used to describe massive
volumes of structured or unstructured
data that is so large it is difficult to
move and process using traditional
database and software techniques so the
first here we have is Amazon Athena this
is a serverless interactive query
service it can take a bunch of CSV or
Json files in an S3 bucket and load them
into a temporary SQL table and so you
can run SQL queries so it's when you
want to quate CSV or Json files if
you've ever heard of um apachi Presto
it's basically that okay then we have
Amazon Cloud search so this is a fully
managed full teex search service so when
you want to add search to your website
we have Amazon elastic search service um
commonly abbreviated to es and this is a
manage elastic search cluster and
elastic search is an open source full
Tech search engine it is more robust
than Cloud search but requires more
server and operational maintenance then
we have Amazon elastic map produce
commonly known as EMR and this is for
data processing and Analysis it can be
used for creating reports just like red
shift but is more suited when you need
to transform unstructured data into
structured data on the Fly and it
leverages opsource um technology so like
spark um Hive Pig things like
that then we have Kinesis data Stream So
This is a real-time streaming data
service it creates producers uh which
sends data to a stream it has multiple
consumers that can consume data within a
stream and use uh it for realtime
analytics click streams ingestion data
from Fleet of iot
devices then we have Kinesis fire hose
this is a serverless and a simple
version of a data stream and you pay on
demand based on how much data is
consumed through the stream and you
don't worry about the underlying
servers then you have Amazon Kinesis
data analytics this allows you to run
queries against data that is flowing
through your real-time stream so you can
create reports and Analysis on emerging
data and last on the Kinesis side here
we have Amazon Kinesis video streams
this allows you to analyze or apply
processing on real-time streaming videos
onto the second page here we have manage
kofka service
msk um and it might be MKS um now that
I'm looking at it here so just be aware
that that might be incorrect but a fully
manage Apachi kofka service kofka is an
open-source platform for building
real-time streaming data pipelines and
applications it is similar to Kinesis
but with more robust functionality then
we have red shift which is um a with is
flagship
uh Big Data tool it's a petabyte size
data warehouse the data warehouses are
for online uh online analytical
processing olap so data warehouses can
be expensive because they are keeping
data hot meaning that we can run a very
complex query in a large amount of data
and get that data back very fast but
this is great when you need to quickly
generate analytics or reports from a
large amount of data we have Amazon
quick site this is a business
intelligence tool or a business
intelligence dashboard bi for short you
can use it to create business dashboard
to power business decisions it requires
little to no programming and connect and
adjust to many different types of
databases if you ever heard of Tableau
or powerbi this is just the adus
equivalent we have adus data pipelines
this automates the movement of data you
can reliably move data between compute
storage and services we have adus glue
this is an ETL service so it allows you
to move data from one location to
another where you need to perform
Transformations before the Final
Destination it's simar similar to DMS
but it's more robust
we have AB Lake formation this is a
centralized curated and secured
repository that stores all your data so
it's a data Lake it uh is a storage
repository that holds a vast amount of
raw data in its native format until it
is needed and then last on here we have
adab data exchange this is a catalog of
third-party data sets you can download
for free uh or subscribe or purchase
data sets so they might have like the
covid-19 foot traffic data the IMDb TV
movie data historical weather data and
sometimes this is really great if you're
just trying to learn how to to work with
these tools
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look here at
Amazon quick site which is a business
intelligence dashboard or bi dashboard
that allows you to ingest data from
various databus storage or database
services to quickly visualize business
data with minimal programming or data
formula knowledge so here's an example
of a quick site dashboard um and so the
way quick site is able to make these
dashboards super fast is if you have
spice the super fast parallel inmemory
calculation engine um and the thing is
you don't have to use spice um but
generally it is good to use it uh and
there are some caveats when getting your
data into Quick site sometimes it can't
ingest data directly from a particular
uh data store so you might have to dump
it to S3 first but it's not too bad
because you can use AIS glue to
transform that data over um there are
additional features sometimes Market is
services but we have quick site ml
insights this detects anomalies perform
accurate uh forecasting it can generate
natural language narrative so basically
like you know describe it as if you're
going to read it out as a business
report you know then there's Amazon
quick site Q this allows you to ask
questions using natural language on all
your data and receive answers in seconds
so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and let's go take a look at Amazon
quick sites which is a or quick site
which is um a business intelligence tool
so when you go here you have to uh sign
up because it's kind of part of ads but
on its own separate thing and then you
have to choose what you want so we have
Enterprise and standard um I do not want
to pay that much so I'm going to go to
standard over here I'm not really sure
what the difference is it's not really
telling me what um between standard and
Enterprise but I'm going to assume
standard is more cost effective but here
we it says user use I am Federated
identities which is fine use I am
Federate enties only um we can stick
with the top one there that seems fine
to me we need to enter a name so just
say my quick site
account and we probably have to fill
something in there so let's say Andrew
exam pro. and these are the services
that are going to integrate with Athena
S3 RDS things like that I guess we could
select some of those buckets I'm not too
worried about doing that right now the
provided account name is not available
that is a terrible UI but that's AWS for
you I'm just going to dump some numbers
there going put my email in here
again um we probably want some S3
buckets I'm going
to make a new
bucket because I think that's how we're
going to do this we're going to have to
make a bucket here and say uh quick
site
data okay and we're going to create
ourselves a bucket here I'm going to go
back and hopefully that shows
up
uh it does not so what I'll have to do
is just back
out and I'm just going to give it a hard
refresh here and we're hit quick sign up
for quicksite again and we'll choose
standard and we'll say my quick site
account a bunch of numbers there Andrew
exam pro. I don't really care about
adjusting data from everywhere else I
just want it from
S3 there's my
data uh sure we'll give it right
permissions even though I don't plan to
do anything with Athena here today
he and we'll give it a moment to
load so what I'm thinking
is so what I'm thinking is just making
like an Excel spreadsheet here and just
filling in some data so oh says our
account is set up here so we'll go to
Quick site because I bet it can import
like a CSV or something
um I'm more of a tableau or powerbi kind
of person um but uh you know for the
purpose of the cloud practitioner I am
going to show you this Amazon quick set
lets you easily visualize data and Etc
that sounds great next next next I know
what I'm doing oh do we have some
examples great so I don't even have to
make a spreadsheet okay so what we'll do
is just click on
that and we have stuff it looks like
they've really improved this since the
last time I've seen it which is quite
nice
um but I could try and make my
own I'm just trying to think how do we
do this
again yeah we have the spice there so
it's a lot easier from starting from
scratch I'm just going to say
close
and user analysis we want data sets in
here oh we already have some data sets
these are coming from S3 I think that's
the old S3 logo I'm not sure why they're
using that one we can go here and create
a new data set oh we can upload directly
so I don't even have to use use S3
that's great so what I'm going to do is
just have some values in here so I'm
going to just say
um uh type value so we'll say
banana 125 123 we'll say
apple
orange nobody likes
oranges I shouldn't say I'm sure it's
like lots of people like
oranges oh we got to put pairs on
there
I actually really like pairs people
think I like bananas which is not true I
actually like pears that's what I like
so I'm going to go ahead and save this
save
as and I'm just going to save this to my
desktop here so just give me a moment
just doing this offc
screen and I'm just save this uh data
set quick
site CSV it can even take an XLS so I
don't have to save it as a uh I'll just
save it as a an
XLS okay and so we're going to just
upload that so there is that data
set it's going to scan that file it's
going to see that sheet you even preview
it there's the information we're going
to add that
data uh I get add it as a data data
set well how do I where where do I it's
like it says add the data I just want to
add it as a data set so they said up
here save and visualize up
here and is it autographing yet maybe if
I drag in is it working is it thinking
okay it's at 100% so I'm going to just
drag that onto
there and it says pear orange
banana just kind of trying to make sense
of this here is it taking and count the
value maybe put the value down there wow
that's so much easier I hav't used this
for like a year and and um I'm going to
tell you this has gotten a lot easier to
use so I'm quite impressed with this but
yeah I mean this is pretty much what
quick site is if you want to visualize
things in different types you can drag
them out you can probably like click on
the the wheel here and change
it again I'm not
sure exactly how all the uh the dials
and knobs work here but I mean another
thing we could do is just drag out like
another object and do the same thing so
maybe I'd want a pie
chart um
so uh a
visual yeah it's not as nice as powerbi
but like it's still great that it's here
you know type
value so we got a nice pie chart
there uh let's try something weird let's
give this one a
go doesn't color it which is not very
nice um there's probably some kind of
way to color it but focus on banana only
I don't know I don't know what the point
of there but anyway that's quick sight
so um I really don't want to pay for
this this so what I'm going to do is go
up
here um there's you have to deactivate
I'm just trying to remember
how because they change the interface
again they change everything on
you so maybe we go I'm on a trial for
four days here maybe quantity for just
the four 29 day trial so if I want to
get out of this trial what do I do I
don't want to use it anymore um
so how to delete AWS quick
site canceling your subscription so
before you can unsubscribe uh you're
signed in the IM account you're quick
site administrator you're the root IM
administrator sure uh you deleted any
secondary name spaces to find the
existing name space Etc so choose your
username in the application bars manage
quick site account settings
unsubscribe so I was almost there I
thought I was in the right place
uh this one
no I was just
there manage quick
site your
subscriptions
edit there's no unsubscribe
option so I'm not
sure can I
cancel
unsubscribe
button does not appear in quick
site and it could just be because we're
on trial and so maybe after the end of
the trial it will uh it will vanish
there they are not making this easy for
me account settings ah delete accounts
so this is what we're probably want to
do permanently delete the account
yes I mean that has to get rid of the
subcription because it gets rid of
everything there we
go we'll say
confirm delete
account unless you're using them in the
services blah blah blah blah blah um
successful okay great so now I should go
back to ads. amazon.com and just to
confirm that it's gone I'm going
to go to quicksite again and just see if
it's trying to ask me to sign again so
it is so I've gotten R of my account so
we're all in good shape and uh yeah that
is that is quick
site all right let's take a look at some
more machine learning AI Services
because eight of us won't stop making
these things um and basically last time
I made uh the videos all this generative
stuff did not exist so we need to cover
it the first is Amazon Bedrock so the uh
this uses large language models and
makes it a cloud service is offering to
generate text and images responses if
you know what chat GPT is you know what
Bedrock is we have Amazon code Whisperer
it's an AI code generator that will
predict code to meet your use case uh so
if youve heard ever heard of GitHub
co-pilot it's the same thing basically
uh it's going to write code for you or
along with you I should say uh we have
Amazon devops Guru this uses ml or
machine learning to analyze your
operational data and application metrics
and the vents to detect operational
abnormalities um imagine if you had kind
of like a junior devops person digging
into your metrics to figure out if
there's something wrong then we have
Amazon Lookout this is actually three
different um offerings we have Amazon
lookout for equipment Amazon uh lookout
for metrics and Amazon lookout for
vision they all seem to have to do
something with quality control and
Performing automated inspection so
vision of course would use Vision to
detect anomalies uh one would be for
equipment to detect if there's anything
wrong with operational equipment uh and
then metrics would be you know with
metric data so something probably more
for um the hard Industries uh to
utilized and you have Amazon monotron so
this uses machine learning models to
predict unplanned equipment downtime and
so the way they do that is they have
these uh iot sensors that's going to
capture vibrations and sensor data from
your Hardware then we also have adus
neuron this is an ad SDK used to run
deep learning workloads on adus uh infer
I can't say that word but I know what it
is it's basically um it's a machine
learning acceleration on gpus that you
can attach and adus train
trainum so yeah I wish the words weren't
so hard there's actually more um stuff
that Aus has for machine learning I
didn't include them because they were
just too far out there and they're
definitely not going to show up in your
exam you'll definitely never see them
but we now have better coverage what I
really wanted to show was Bedrock H
Whisperer because I feel like those two
uh will show up on future exam so I'm
just trying to get those in front of you
now even if they're not on the exam uh
at the time of this recording okay
[Music]
ciao all right so you probably already
know what generative AI is but just in
case you don't I want to just quickly
cover it and show a very tiny example uh
so generative AI which also can be
shorten to gen AI though most people
don't say that uh is a type of
artificial intelligence capable capable
of generating new content such as text
images music or other forms of media so
an example would be something like a
software that I like to use called mid
Journey uh where you can put in a prompt
and so it will then go ahead and
generate out an image um so all the
cloud service providers have some kind
of offering with both image and text um
but yeah hopefully that makes sense the
idea is that you can plug stuff in and
you get stuff out okay
[Music]
Let's us take a look here at machine
learning and deep learning Frameworks
and so these are Frameworks that can be
used with sagemaker or have direct
support for them I just want to get you
some uh exposure and to uh get you some
context in terms of these because
machine learning and Ai and all this
stuff is becoming more popular so you
should at least have heard of these
things so I have all the logos on the
left hand side and we'll go through them
the first is Apachi mxnet so this is a
machine learning framework adopted by
AWS basically um every single cloud
service provider backs their own kind of
open- source framework and they try to
make that the one that they suggest you
to use but in practice uh there's ones
that are good and there's ones that
people just don't want to use and apach
mxnet is not fun to use whatsoever um
and so you'll see it all over in the
marketing and pushed everywhere but
really people want to use things like
curus tensorflow but anyway I just
wanted to point that out that it was has
a bias because they've invested energy
into uh their team of machine learning
Frameworks you got pytorch uh optimized
for tensor Library uh for deep learning
using GPU and CPU it's created by
Facebook Facebook does not necessarily
um have its own cloud service provider
offering so it's kind of out there and
so you'll see good support for pytorch
and all the major providers U the next
is tensorflow this is made by Google
what's in with tensor flow is Google
made uh their own um GPU or TPU they
call it a tensor Processing Unit so
tensor is a a unit of thing in tensor
flow and it they have optimized hardware
for it I personally find tensorflow the
easy to use or I should say cires so um
cures is a highlevel machine learning
framework built on top of tensorflow
because these lower level ones were just
really hard to use and so basically
pytorch came along and it was much
easier to use and then then everyone
noticed how easier pytorch was and so
that's where curus came from was to be
competitive with pytorch and be easier
to use then you have Apachi spark which
is a unified analytics engine for large
scale data processing but they do have
ml offerings within it called spark ml
um so there's definitely things you can
do there uh there's a piece of software
called chainer um and it's for it's a
deep learning framework that supports
Cuda then there's hugging face which is
not exactly a framework or tool it's
just a way of accessing a lot of models
online and data sets and quickly
launching them for whatever reason I uh
adus has uh strong synergies with
hugging face I've seen like developer
Advocates and other uh folks that worked
at AOS go over to hugging face and so
there seems to be strong uh
relationships between hugging face and
adabs for whatever reason there's a lot
of ml Frameworks out there but because
uh ml is uh just uh
progressively um are rapidly innovating
you'll see Frameworks come and go and so
I remember when I researched this and I
was just trying to understand all the
Frameworks out there there's just a lot
and I just kept digging into them
finding oh they're not active anymore
they're not active anymore so I just
want to point out that we have all these
ones up on screen if they become
unactive tomorrow I would not be
surprised but uh for the most part all
of these seem to be very popular uh and
uh they're being well supported uh but
yeah hopefully that gives you an idea of
these Frameworks okay
ciao
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
Apachi mxnet a little bit more in detail
because this is the framework that iTab
us wants you to use whether you want to
use it or not is a different story uh
but you'll see it all over in their
marketing pages and things like that so
apoi mxnet is a deep learning machine
learning framework which supports many
many different programming languages so
that is one advantage of it uh the key
features uh is that it's scalable it's
flexible it's portable it's it supports
multiple programming language iTab has
made Apachi mxnet their framework of
choice so there's lots of support for it
within ad sagemaker and the ad ml
containers but I have noticed that
they've been increasing support for p
torch so maybe you know they're just
trying to meet the customer where they
are but anyway um there is a lot of
stuff for mxnet mxnet has two highlevel
interfaces uh one's called glue on and
there is module API so uh depending on
which one you use one is imperative
programming one's symbolic programming
uh this is more of a deeper concept for
machine learning but I'm going to tell
you one is really easy one is really
hard um but uh let's look at a very
simple example of uh some code for using
the gluon API so it kind of looks like
that you can see that they are using
python so hopefully that gives you an
idea of uh mxnet and its offering the
key thing is that it offers it in a lot
of different programming languages will
this appear on your exam absolutely not
but should you know it you absolutely
should um just so you have good context
with adabs and ml so there you
[Music]
go I want to talk a little bit about
Intel because I think it's very
important to remember the hardware that
is running with these um cloud service
providers because it really does matter
um and there's a couple terms you might
see when using a compute that you're not
aware of and I want to make sure you
know what they are so let's talk about
what is Intel so Intel is a
multinational corporation is one of the
world's largest semiconductor chip
manufacturers Intel is the inventor of
the
x86 instruction set so basically uh they
released this chip back in 1978 this
one's called the Intel 88086 chip and
the idea is that um they came up with an
instruction set um it's basically a
bunch of words that you can use um to
program the chip and it's a lower level
language so um that lower level language
would be an assembly um if if that makes
any sense so the idea is that you have
this um
instruction set and you have to write an
assembly and so basically most modern
programs like when you use uh
programming languages like uh C it will
actually compile down to assembly um or
other languages will compile down to
assembly because that is what the chip
understands and then assembly is turned
into machine code like the zeros and
ones and the reason I'm mentioning this
is that when you go and you uh launch uh
a compute uh instance let's say on ads
uh you're launching a E2 instance you
have to choose uh whether it's x86 or a
different instruction set or
architecture and so the other one is arm
and they're both really really good it
just depends on whether uh uh your stuff
can support it but for the most part
Intel has arm chips as well so um there
is no company that produces armed chips
per se it's just an architecture and uh
the way it works is that it just has
fewer instruction sets so there's fewer
uh rules that you can write in so it's a
more limited writing it in assembly but
at the end of the day it doesn't matter
because your programming language is
going to compile it down so you don't
have to worry about those fewer
instructions but because it has fewer
instructions it generally results in a
better uh Power efficiency and so it can
have better performance or better or
better cost to you the customer so when
I can I try to run arm and for the most
part it's always great to run arm but uh
it really depends on if your software is
going to be able to run on arm um and
stuff like that so I just wanted to
point out those two things
there about uh at least Intel and then
instruction sets
[Music]
okay all right I want to talk about two
things um that Intel has with ads and
the first is Intel xon scalable
processor and the second is Intel Gotti
um so it of course does work with or
purchases um Hardware from other um uh
other companies like they use AMD and
Nvidia but I think it's worth mentioning
Intel in a little bit more detail here
here because every time I go to reinvent
Intel has a big giant booth and you can
go scour the ads website and it just
looks like ADS works more closely with
Intel as opposed to the other uh
providers not to say that Intel is not
being utilized on gcp and Azure and
others but uh I just noticed something
more going on there with AWS but let's
first talk about Intel xon scalable
processors these are high performance
CPUs designed for Enterprise and server
applications commonly used in ESS
instances
um that scalable part makes them very
good for machine learning so you often
are going to be be using Intel xon
processors whether you know or not on
ads the Intel is the Intel uh Habana
Gotti processor so this is a uh
processor specialized for AI training uh
you could say that this is a direct
competitor to Nvidia or a similar
competitor because uh they uh they uh do
something very similar um I believe that
Intel Gotti has their own SDK called
synapse AI uh that you can use to
interact with it so you launch up Sage
maker and then use uh that uh that API
or SDK in order to uh best utilize uh
that Hardware there but both of these um
pieces of Hardware are offered uh on a
and I think it's just good to know them
at least to name uh what they are
[Music]
okay hey this is angrew brown and let's
talk about gpus I'm sure most people
know what gpus are here but I'm going to
talk about it anyway because I want to
talk about cudas so a GPU stands for
General processing unit and it's a
processor that is specialized to quickly
render high resolution images and videos
concurrently if you've ever played video
games you know you need a good GPU
because it's all about those images
however gpus can perform parallel
operations on multiple sets of data so
they can also be used for non-graphical
tasks and this makes it really good for
machine learning and scientific
computation so if you're trying to uh
convince your significant other that you
need a better graphics card you can just
tell them it's for work I need it for
machine learning and scientific comp
computation it's not your fault that you
can also play video games with it and so
we have like a graphic there on the
right hand side I think I got that from
Nvidia and so they're kind of trying to
demonstrate the difference between uh
the paralyzation with GPU versus serial
tasks with CPU but let's go and just
read a littleit more so CPUs can have an
average of four to 16 processor cores
gpus can have thousands of processor
cores how that works I have no idea but
I just know that that's how it works uh
so we have 48 gpus can provide as many
as 40,000 cores so that is a lot gpus
are best suited for repetitive and
highly parallel Computing tasks such as
rendering Graphics cryptocurrency mining
if people are even still doing that and
deep learning and machine learning so
you know there you go that's
[Music]
gpus all right let's take a look here at
Cuda but before we do let's talk about
Nvidia so Nvidia is a company that
manufactures graphical processing units
for gaming and professional markets if
you have ever played video games and you
build your own rig um a lot of people
like to choose Nvidia but Nvidia can do
things other than video games and this
is due to their framework uh called Cuda
which stands for compute unified device
architecture so it's a parallel
Computing platform and API I said
framework but I guess it's an API by a
video that allows developers to use Cuda
enable gpus for general purpose
Computing gpus and it says GP GPU
because it's saying general purpose gpus
I know that's a mouthful there um so
over on AWS they have a bunch of
instances that um can utilize uh Nvidia
GPU so I adus is always changing the
instances so these could be old but you
can see we have a P3 which has the Tesla
Tesla V100 you have the G3 with a Tesla
M M60 the G4 with the T4 uh the P4 with
the Tesla a 100 so there's probably
these are probably old ones there's new
instances with newer Nvidia cards but my
point is is that adus has uh gpus that
you can utilize another thing I want to
point out with Cuda is that all major
deep learning Frameworks are integrated
with Nvidia deep learning sdks there's a
big fight or War over um uh these
companies that make uh gpus and CPUs
because they really want the uh Theirs
to be used for machine learning so you
can definitely be sure that AMD probably
has some kind of similar offering or
something uh and definitely Intel as
well um but Nvidia has done a very good
job in uh making sure that theirs is the
most popular um so EnV deep learning SDK
is a collection of uh Nvidia libraries
for deep learning so this is something
that this is the SDK you can use with
Cuda to interact with their API uh so
one of those libraries are called cuda
deep neural network library so that's
something you can use with it and it's
uh tuned for a bunch of stuff if it
looks like it's getting a little bit too
um uh technical it's because this slide
was was for my machine learning uh
inabus specialty and I didn't do a whole
lot to change it and Brad it over uh so
you don't don't really need to know that
last part there but just understand what
Cuda is and that it's uh very important
uh for working with machine learning and
AD us has uh good offerings uh for
instances with it
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the ads
well architectur framework so this is a
white paper created by AWS to help
customers build using best practices
defined by AWS you can find this at AWS
amazon.com architecture forwell
architected this idea is not unique to
AWS the other providers have it but I
believe AWS was the first one to Define
this and they have a really good uh a
good approach to this and this is pretty
much Essential Knowledge that you have
to have uh four certifications when
we're looking at the cloud practitioner
the soci architect associate and
professional because um there's a lot of
principles here best practices that adus
uses themselves to architect their
infrastructure okay so the framew is
divided into five sections called
pillars which address different aspects
or lenses that can be applied to a cloud
workload so imagine you have your Cloud
workload you're going to want to adopt
an aable architect framework some things
that you know people don't consider
outside the Five Pillars is that you
need to know General definitions uh
General design principles and the review
process um and then from there you have
your five pillars so you have
operational excellence security
reliability performance efficiency and
cost optimization and all of these have
major SE sections in this uh white paper
but outside of just the main white paper
each of these have their own white
papers that go even into farther detail
so if you really want to uh really focus
on security and get a lot more
information they have that as well
[Music]
okay let's take a look at the general
definitions for the well architecture
framework starting with the pillars so
the operational excellent pillar is
there to run and monitor systems the
security pillar is to protect data and
systems to mitigate risk the reliability
pillar is to mitigate and recover from
uh disruptions the performance
efficiency pillar is about using
Computing resources efficiently or
effectively and the cost optimization
pillar is about getting the lowest price
and this is where you're going to find
all the business value and I put an
aster there because uh you know you
might obsess saying we need to meet the
requirements for all these pillars and
that's not the case you can trade off
pillars based on the business context so
you know don't take it as uh literally
Implement every single thing but just
consider that uh you know you might have
to adapt it based on your workloads then
we have some general definitions that we
will come across so there's components
so code configuration itless resources
against the requirement a workload so a
set of components that work together to
deliver business value mileston so key
changes of your architecture through the
product life cycle then there's
architecture itself so how components
work together in a workload and then we
have technology portfolio so a
collection of workloads required for the
business to operate
[Music]
okay so the well architected framework
is designed around a different kind of
team structure so when you're looking at
Enterprises they generally have a
centralized team with specific roles
where ADS structures their teams as
being distributed with flexible roles
and so this new kind of methodology of
distributed teams uh has some major
advantages but it does come with some
risks and so adus has baked in some uh
practices or uh things that they do to
mitigate these issues okay so let's
compare on premise Enterprise uh to what
databus is proposing for your team
structure so on premise what we'd see is
a centralized team consisting of
technical Architects solution Architects
data Architects Network Architects
security Architects and you kind of see
that they all have a specialized
vertical and they are usually managed by
either to GF or Zack man framework so
those are just ways of structuring your
teams those are very popular and so what
aabus is proposing here is that you have
a distribute team and uh the way you're
going to make that team work because
obviously just thinking about distribute
team they're going to be a lot more
agile but to make sure that they
effectively work you have practices like
team experts who raise the bar uh making
sure that you know uh in any areas we
can always say how can we do this better
uh then there are mechanisms in place
for automated checks for standards so
that's the great thing about Cloud can
all be automated to say hey does it meet
our Regulatory Compliance or or or what
have you and then there's the concept of
the Amazon leadership principles which
we will cover on in the next slide in
detail and so um you know itus is not
obviously using uh these other
Frameworks because it has its own which
is this one here but the the mechanism
to which they stay organized and up to
date is they are supported by a virtual
community of subject matter experts
principal Engineers so that what they'll
do is they'll engineer things like
lunchtime talks and then recycle that
into their onboarding material or into
this framework itself okay
[Music]
so we're taking a look here at Amazon's
leadership principles and these are a
set of principles used during the
company's decision- making problem
solving simple brainstorming and hiring
all right um and so I can't say that I
like all of these but definitely some of
them really stand out as being great
especially the first one which is
customer Obsession so instead of
worrying about what your competitors are
doing think about what the customer
wants work your way back and uh you know
really focus on the customer needs needs
then there's ownership so if you're
going to go do something uh you know try
to be your own mini boss uh and take
responsibility for whatever it is you're
building event and simplify so you know
always look for the simplest solution
don't try to engineer something super
complicated if it's not necessary uh or
right a lot so you know try to be right
uh learn and be curious so that's pretty
self-explanatory hire and develop the
best insist on the high standards adus
always refers to this as raising the bar
think big buys for Action fr it andus is
really Frugal if you didn't know that
but not just for like themselves but
also for their customers they want
customers to uh spend the least amount
of money possible when using their
infrastructure earn trust uh dive deep
have a backbone disagree and commit
deliver results strive to be the earth's
best employer success and scale bring
broad responsibility and if you want to
read these in detail because they have a
big block of text for each of these uh
you can go to amazon. jobs uhen
principles and read all about it
[Music]
okay all right let's talk about some
general design principles uh that you
should be considering when you are
designing your infrastructure no matter
what pillar that you are looking to
adopt the first is stop guessing your
capacity needs so the great thing with
cloud computing is you use as little or
much based on demand whereas on premise
you would have to purchase a machine and
you'd have to make sure you have
additional capacity so that you could
grow into it right and so here with uh
cloud you do not have to worry about
that uh test systems at production scale
so be able to clone your production
environment to testing tear down testing
while not in use to save money so a lot
of people will have a staging server
that they run all the time but the great
thing here is that with Cloud you know
it's you can just spin it up and have it
right away and then tear it down and
save money um there's automating to make
architectural experimentation easier
this is talking about using
infrastructure as a code so for ads this
to be using cloud formation creating
change sets which kind of um uh say
exactly what is going to change stack
updates drift detection to see if your
stuff is uh being changed over time by
developers through manual configuration
things like that then we have allow for
evolutionary architectures so this is
about adapting cicd um doing nightly
releases or if you're using serverless
if you adopted lambdas they deprecate
over time forcing you to use the latest
version uh and so that is evolutionary
architectures then we have drive
architectures using data so um when
you're using Cloud there's a lot of
Tooling in there to automatically start
collecting data so Cloud watch will be
collecting some things by default and
cloud trail will as well so you know
that is another thing and then improving
things through game days so this is
about stimulating traffic on production
or purposely killing ec2 instances or or
messing with your services to see how
well they recover all
[Music]
right before we jump into each of the
pillars let's go open them up and take a
look at what structure we should expect
to see so we have design principles
definition best practices and resources
all the pillars follow this to a t so
let's just talk about what these are so
the design principles are a list of
design principles that needs to be
considered during implementation and
that's where we're going to focus a lot
of our energy then you have definition
so this is an overview of the best
practice categories then you have the
best practices themselves these are
detailed information about each practice
with uh various a services and then you
have resources these are additional
documentation white papers uh and videos
to implement this pillar and I just want
to tell you that if you're doing the
certified Cloud practitioner we're
really just going to cover the design
principles but for the solutions
architect associate or anything uh
that's associate or above that's where
we're going to actually dive deep into
the implementation of the best practices
because there is a lot of stuff there so
uh yeah there we
[Music]
go let's take a look here at the design
principles for operational excellence so
the first here is perform operations as
code so apply the same engineering
discipline you would to application code
to your infrastructure so by training
your operations as code you can limit
human error and enable consistent
responses to events generally we're
talking about infrastru infrastructure
as a code here so this would probably be
like things like cloud formation there's
other things you could do like policy as
a code and a bunch of other ones then we
have make frequent small reversible
changes so design your workloads to
allow components to be updated regularly
uh this could be talking about doing
roll backs incremental changes Blu green
deployments having a cicd pipeline
refined operations procedures frequently
so look for continuous opportunities to
improve your operations uh here you use
game days to simulate traffic or event
failure on your production workloads
anticipate failures to perform post
modems on system failures to better
improve write test code kill production
servers um there's a small spelling
mistake it should have an R here so
servers to test recovery learn from all
operational failure so share Lessons
Learned in a knowledge base for
operational events and failures across
your entire organization but you know if
you can just remember these headings
here uh and be able to categorize what
would be under operational excellence
you'll be okay all
[Music]
right all right let's take a look at the
design principles for the security
pillar so the first here is Implement a
strong identity foundation so implement
the principle of lease privilege or PP
that's a very popular concept meaning
give people only the permissions that
they need use centralized identity so
that would be using adus am avoid longl
credentials then we have enable
traceability so monitor alerts and audit
actions and changes to your environment
in real time integrate log and Metric
collection and automate investigations
and Remediation then we have apply
security at all layers so take defense
in depth approach with multiple security
controls for everything from Edge
networks vbcs load balancing instances
OS application code we might have a
slide in this course on defense into
depth where basically you see like a
ring of things and you can kind of see
how like there's layers that go from
outward to Inward and that's what
they're talking about when they're
listing out all these things here
automate security best practices uh
protect your data in transit at rest uh
keep people away from your data the
reason I don't have descriptions there
is because those are pretty self-evident
prepare for security events so Incident
Management systems and investigation
policies and processes tools to detect
investigate and recovery from incidences
and uh there are a lot of security tools
out there and they all have funny
initialisms I didn't put any of them in
here but I'm sure there are some there
um but yeah there you go for
[Music]
security all right let's take a look at
design principles for reliability and
the first here is automatically recover
from failure so Monitor kpis and Trigger
automations when the threshold is breach
test recovery procedures so test how
your workload fails and you validate
your recovery procedures you can use
automation to simulate different
failures or to recreate scenarios that
led to failures before scale
horizontally to increase aggregate
system availability so replace one large
resource with multiple small resources
to reduce the impact of a single failure
on the over overall workload distribute
requests across multiple smaller
resources to ensure that they don't
share a common point of failure so we're
talking about multi-az uh High
availability okay stop guessing capacity
we've seen this multiple times so in on
premise it takes a lot of guess work to
determine the elasticity of your
workloads uh workload demands with Cloud
you don't need to guess how much you
need because you can request the right
size of resources on demand that's going
to give you better reliability okay
manage change and automation so making
changes via infrastructure as a code
will allow for a formal process to track
and review infrastructure you're going
to see IC show up a lot in this
framework
[Music]
okay let's take a look at design
principles for performance efficiency so
the first here is democratize advanced
techn technology so focus on product
development rather than procurement
provisioning and management of services
because if you're on Prem you'd have to
order those machines set them up and so
take advantage of advanced technology
specialized and optimized for your use
case with on demand cloud services
because again if you're using on Prem uh
you you know you might not have the
option to have Sage maker right it's
just going to be a VM and you're going
to have to do all the work yourselves
whereas ads has all these specialized
things so you can move quickly uh Go
Global in minutes so deploying your
workload in multiple abis regions around
the world allows you to provide lower
latency and a better experience for your
customers at a minimal cost we have used
seress architecture so servess
architecture removes the need for you to
run and maintain physical servers for
traditional Computing activities removes
the operational burden of managing
physical servers and can lower
transaction costs because manage
services operate at Cloud scale and it
us can be a lot better at um running
them efficiently than you will uh
experiment more often so with virtual
and automatable uh resources you can
quickly carry out comparative testing
using different types of instan and
Storage or configurations to make the
best choice we call this right sizing
choosing the right size consider
mechanical sympathy so understand how
cloud services are consumed and always
use technology approach that aligns best
with your workload goals for example
consider data access patterns when you
select database or storage
[Music]
approaches let's take a look here at
design principles for cost optimization
so the first one here is Implement Cloud
financial management so dedicate time
and resources to build capacity uh via
Cloud financial management and cost
optimization tooling stus is saying hey
take advantage of all our tooling they
makes it easy for you to know exactly
what you're spending adopt a consumption
model so pay only for computing
resources that you require uh an
increase or decrease using uh depending
on the business requirements we're
talking about on demand pricing measure
overall efficiency so measure the
business output of the workload and the
cost associ associated with delivering
use this measure to know the gains you
make from increasing inreasing output
and reducing costs so stop spending
money on
undifferentiated that's a hard word to
say
undifferentiated heavy lifting so adus
does the heavy lifting of the data
center operations like racking stacking
and power servers it also removes the
operational burden of managing operating
systems and applications with managed
services this allows you to focus on
your customers and business projects
rather than your it infrastructure and
the last one here is analyze and
attribute expenditure so the cloud makes
it e easier to uh accurately identify
the usage and cost of systems which then
allow transparent uh attribution of it
cost to individualize workload owners
this helps measure return on investment
and gives workload owners an opportunity
to optimize the resources and reduce
costs so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the adus
well architected tool so this is an
auditing tool to be used to assess your
Cloud workloads for alignment with the a
well architected framework and so what
it is it's essentially a checklist uh
but it also has nearby references so you
know as you're reading through it it
will show you information uh and
resources so that it can help you with
this checklist here and the idea is when
you're done you can generate out a
report and then you can provide that
report to your Executives and key
stakeholders to prove uh you know how
well architected your workload is on AWS
[Music]
okay hey this is angre Brown from exam
Pro and in this video I want to show you
two things the well architected
framework and the well architected tool
so first let's go look for the well
architected framework so we're going to
look up white papers uh
AWS and so if we go here to AWS
amazon.com white papers we have a bunch
of pages here and so I'm going to just
checkbox on white papers so that we can
kind of reduce the amount there and then
I'm going to checkbox well architected
framework if we scroll all the way top
here one of these you think it'd be
right at the top but one of these is the
well architected framework and here it
is and so if we open it up used to just
directly open up as a PDF I'm sure you
can still download it as is but
generally you're going to open up as
this HTML page and you can basically
read through it see all the stuff see
the multiple pillars we can click into
here see the design principles read the
definitions and then start reading about
uh the best practices and they have
these things at the bottom of each one
uh very boring very very boring but but
um you know when you get to the
solutions architect and things like that
you're going to need to know this stuff
inside and out it's going to really help
you out this Cloud practitioner we only
need to know surface level information
um but that's the little architect
framework let's take a look at the well
architected tool so we going type in
well here we'll get the well architected
tool and if we go here you can see that
I've created a couple before probably
demos for um our videos and so I'm going
to go Define a new workload I'm going to
say my my workload Lo here uh my
workload whoops my workload it is
messing up because I probably have
grammarly installed so it does not like
grammarly so I'm just going to turn it
off for now so my
workload and it's still not typing
correctly so I have to kill out kill out
grammarly here which is kind of
frustrating so that's a bug that that's
not grammarly's fault that's adab Us's
fault for not playing well with grammar
and that's something I will definitely
report to them because it's very
annoying so I'm going to go ahead and
refresh this
page my workload my
workload um and this is Andrew
Brown production or pre-production
doesn't matter pick your regions Us East
or Us East 2
sure I'm selecting
it there we go uh optional optional
optional optional you go to next and
then you can choose your lens serus lens
FTR lens so that's the foundational
technical review SAS lens we can go with
architected framework and then once that
is there we can start
reviewing okay and then we get this big
checklist and so we can go through this
and read each one so we say Ops one how
do you determine what your priori are
and all these things like Ops and stuff
like that these are all the summaries in
each of the well architected framework
sections so you pretty much don't need
to really read the dock you just go
through this so everyone needs to
understand their part in enabling
business success have shared goals in
order to set priorities of resources
this will maximize the benefit of your
efforts so select from the following
evaluate the customers's external needs
external customer needs evaluate
internal customer needs if you click
info it's going to highlight each one
here so evolve key stakeholders
including Business Development
operations teams this will ensure Etc
and so you just go through this and uh
you know you know once you have that and
you save an
exit Okay uh you'll have uh the
questions that are answered it'll say
what's high risk what's not things like
that very simplistic it's really just a
way of making a very organized report or
checklist and proving that you went
through it uh to the executive level or
to the management level there so
hopefully that makes sense to you um
it's not too complicated but there you
[Music]
go hey it's Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the ads
architecture Center so the architecture
Center is a web portal that contains
best practices and reference
architectures for a variety of different
workloads and you can find this at adab.
amazon.com architecture so if you're
looking for best practices in terms of
security they have a huge section on
that and they have it for pretty much
every kind of category on AWS or if
you're looking for uh practical examples
you can view the large library of
reference architectures so here's one to
make an ads Q&A bot and it will have an
architectural diagram but you can also
uh deploy via cloud formation or
possibly cdk um and this way you can get
a working example and then tweak it for
your use case so this is a really great
tool um when you are done the adus well
architect framework and you're saying
okay how do we apply it can we get more
concrete examples and I wouldn't be
surprised if a lot of the resources
within the well architectur framework
white paper are just pointing to the
center
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at the concept
of total cost of ownership also known as
TCO so what is TCO well it is a
financial estimate intended to help
buyers and owners determine the direct
and indirect cost of a product or
service so here is an example of you
know TCO for maybe like a data center so
we have Hardware monitoring installation
IT personnel training software uh
security licensing and taxes but that's
not just the limit of it it's just kind
of the examples we show here uh the idea
of creating TCO is useful when your
company's looking to migrate from on
Prem to cloud and we will have a better
uh kind of visual here to kind of
understand how you would contrast
against on Prem to Cloud but let's just
talk about how it actually works in
practicality which I think gets kind of
overlooked when cloud service providers
are selling you on TCO so the idea is a
gardener um you know they uh they were
they wrote this article based on This
research where an organization had moved
2,500 virtual machines over to Amazon
dc2 and so what you're seeing here is
that there is a an additional cost that
we're not considering which is the
migration cost See This Bar up here um
so the idea is that the company was
paying around 400,000 and so they
started to move over and as you see uh
their costs initially went up for a
short period of time here uh but then
once that migration cost was over uh you
can notice that they had a 55% reduction
so it's uh totally possible to save
money
uh and clearly there is great savings uh
now is it exactly what AWS promises
probably not and that's that could be
the reason why they update their TCO
calculator but let's now just do that
contrast against the two so we have on
premise on the left and adus on the
right or any class service provider and
what I want to do is help you think
about what cost do people generally
think about because if we have like
Iceberg the idea here is that these are
the costs that we always think about
above the iceberg and then there's these
hidden costs that we just don't consider
when factoring are move and that's the
idea of T TCO is to consider all the
costs not just the superficial ones and
so people say these look like teeth and
that's why I add penguins and a whale
here um and so when we're talking about
on premise what we generally think are
software license fees and subscription
fees but when you compare those against
each other they might look the same um
ad us might just look slightly cheaper
or even more and so the idea is you need
to then factor in everything so on on
premise there's implementation
configuration training physical security
Hardware IT personnel maintenance and on
the adus side you know you are you don't
have to do as much of that stuff so you
just have implementation configuration
and training and so adus with their TCO
calculator their old one used to make a
promise of 75% in savings um again you
know this is going to really vary based
on what your migration strategy looks
like um but you know it's totally
possible you could save 75% or you could
save 50% over a third year a three-year
period And there's a an initial Spike so
that's just something you have to
consider but the nice thing though is
that once you've moved over all the
stuff over here on the left hand side
will be ais's responsibility
[Music]
okay all right so let's take a look at
Capital versus operational expenditure
so there's capex and Opex so on the
capex side the idea here is you're
spending money upfront on physical
infrastructure deducting that expenses
from your tax bill over time uh a lot of
companies that are running their own
data centers uh or have a lot of on-
premise stuff understand what capex is
because um it's something that a lot of
times they get tax breakes on and that's
why we see a lot of people that have a
hard time moving away from the cloud
because you know they keep on thinking
about that money they save from the
government but capex costs would be
things like server costs storage Network
costs backups and archives Disaster
Recovery costs data center costs
technical Personnel so the idea is with
capital exp expenses you have to guess
upfront what you plan to spend okay with
operational expenditure the idea here is
the cost associated with an on- premise
data center that has shifted the cost to
the service provider the customer only
has to be concerned with non-physical
costs so leasing software and
customizing features uh training
employees and cloud services paying for
cloud support uh billing based on cloud
metrics so compute usage storage usage
and so the idea here is with operational
expenses you can try a product or
service without investing in equipment
so basically kex is what we think about
when we think of on premise and then
Opex is what we think think about um you
know when we're thinking about cloud or
AWS
[Music]
okay all right let's ask a very
important question about Cloud migration
so does cloud make it Personnel
redundant so a company is considering
migrating their workloads from on-
premise to the cloud to take advantage
of the savings there is a concern among
the staff that there will be Mass
layoffs does cloud make it Personnel
redundant and that's a very important
question to to have an answer to and
this all talks about shifting your it
team into different responsibilities so
a company needs it Personnel during the
migration phase as we saw with that
Gardener research report that there was
a period at least like a year where they
needed that for you know depending on
the size of your company so you're still
going to need those people around a
company can transition some roles to new
Cloud roles so a very traditional
example would be you have your
traditional networking roles where
people have like their CCNA and now
they're moving over to Cloud networking
uh they have a reduced workload but
there's other things uh that they could
be doing in the cloud um a company may
decide to take a hybrid approach so
they'll always need to have a
traditional it team and a cloud uh it
team um and the last one and this one
You' actually see on the exam which is a
company can change employees activities
from managing infrastructure to re
Revenue generating activities okay so
the idea is that you know if you're a
company why would you get rid of all
your staff when you can just put them
all into Revenue generation I suppose
you know you could uh you know uh lay
them off and some companies might do
that um or you know you could just
retrain them because uh if that IT
personnel team has uh technical
expertise I'm sure they can translate
that to the
[Music]
cloud let's talk about the adus pricing
calculator and this is a free cost
estimate tool that can be used within
your web browser without the need of an
adus account to estimate the cost of a
various IT services and this is um
available at calculator. AWS and the
reason we're bringing this up is because
there used to be a TCO calculator but
now this is the calculator that you use
so the adabs pricing calculator contains
100 plus services that you configure for
cost estimate and so you can just click
through a bunch of knobs and uh boxes to
uh you know uh exactly figure out a very
accurate cost so the idea here is that
to calculate your TCO an organization
needs to compare that existing cost
against their adus costs and so the adus
pricing calculator can be used to deter
DET uh you know the adus costs and
obviously the organization knows its
cost so it can compare it against that
um and the way you can get data out of
this is you can export it as a final
estimate to AC CSV
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the AWS
pricing calculator so to get there it's
calculator. AWS what you're going to do
is hit create estimate and then here you
have a bunch of services so you just
choose what you want so you type in ec2
we're going to configure that and from
there we can do a quick estimate or an
advanced estimate so choose this option
for fast and easy route to Ballpark and
estimate choose this option for detailed
estimate for accounts workloads and
stuff so notice down below very
simplistic we hit
Advanced and we get all sorts of stuff
okay so you know it's really up to you
I'm very comfortable with the advanced
options so I might be running a Linux
machine what is my usage it's going to
have uh daily spikes of traffic because
of the use cases you could say it's not
busy on Saturday and Sunday that it has
a baseline of one a peak of two eight
things like that then you can choose
what you're using um t4g I don't even
know what that is uh but we'll just say
like
t uh T2 micro which is not that big T3
micro and you can say we're doing on
demand because a lot of people would be
doing that and you see like $7 a month
it's not a lot of money then you're
looking at your storage data in data
out okay so we can add that another
thing that we might see is something
like
RDS so we go to RDS and we add postest
and not all of them have the simple and
complex sometimes they're simple so
production
database we'll have one here and we're
just going to be say a dbt2 micro T T3
micro there we go uh 100 that's fine
we're not going to have multi a will
have single a on demand show the
calculation $13 a month add that to our
estimate so you're kind of getting the
idea there
right um and so you know we have our
summary that's our monthly
$391 um oh sorry over 12 months our
monthly cost is
$32 okay you can go back there clone the
service edit it stuff like that you can
export the estimate I think it goes out
as a CSV you can also hit
share uh and then hit agree and so then
you have a public link and if I have
that link we can just see what happens
if I paste it okay it just brings them
to the same estimate so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at
migration evaluator so it was formerly
known as TCL logic and then abis
acquired the company and it is an
estimate tool used to determine an
organization existing on premise costs
so it can compare it against its adabs
cost for Planned Cloud migration uh so
the idea is that you can get a very very
detailed information and the way it
collects information is via an agentless
collector to collect data from your on
premise infrastructure to extract from
your own on premise costs I don't know
if you can see there but you can see
that it works with a lot of different
kinds of on- premise technology like
VMware Microsoft uh tsql all sorts of
things
okay
[Music]
one migration tool that we can use with
AWS is the VM import export and this
allows us to import virtual machines
into ec2 so inabus has import
instructions for VMware Citrix Microsoft
hyperv Windows vhd from Azure and also
Linux vhd from Azure and so the way this
works is that you prepare your virtual
image for upload and adus has a bunch of
instructions for that once it is ready
you're going to upload that to an S3
bucket and once it's uploaded to an S3
bucket then what you can do is use the
ad CLI to import your image um and so
that is the CLI command down below and
once it is produced it will generate out
an Amazon machine image and so from an
Ami you can then go launch your ec2
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the
database migration service which allows
you to quickly and securely migrate one
database to another DMS can be used to
migrate your on- premise database to ads
and that's why we're talking about it uh
and so here's a general diagram where
you have your Source database which
connects to a source endpoint goes
through a replication instance so that's
a ec2 instance that's going to replicate
the data to the Target endpoint onto the
target database uh and so we have a
bunch of possible sources so we have
Oracle database Microsoft SQL MySQL
Mario DB post SQL mongodb Sapa ASC
IMDb db2 Azure SQL database Amazon RDS
Amazon S3 and I'm assuming these are
database dumps Amazon Aurora Amazon
document DB and so for possible targets
it's very similar we got Oracle database
Microsoft SQL MySQL Mario DB post SQL
reddis saps SE Amazon redshift Amazon
RDS Amazon Dynamo DB Amazon S3 Amazon
Aurora Amazon open search service Amazon
elasticache for reddis Amazon document
DB Amazon Neptune Apachi Kafka I'm just
showing you the list to give you an idea
of how flexible this service is uh but
you can tell that these are very
different databases so how can it uh
move them over right and so in not all
cases can it easily do it like it's very
easy to go from myql to postrest um but
you know for ones that are like
relational to uh nosql uh this is where
the adabas schema conversion tool comes
into play it's used in many cases to
automatically convert a source database
schema to a Target database schema or
semi-automate it so that you can kind of
like uh you know uh figure out how to
map the new schema uh each migration
path requires a bit of research since
not all combinations of sources and
targets are possible and it really comes
down to even versions of these things so
but I just want you to know about that
it's an option as a database migration
service and I've migrated a very large
database before and it's super fast uh
so and it's not that hard to use so
something you definitely want to
remember when you're
[Music]
migrating hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are taking a look at the
cloud adoption framework so this is a
white paper to help you plan your
migration from on- premise to AWS at the
highest level the adus CAF organizes
guidance into six Focus areas we got
business people governance platform
security and operations and this white
paper is pretty high level uh so you
know it doesn't get into uh granular
details on how that migration should
work uh but gives you kind of a holistic
approach and I believe that probably
through the adus uh Amazon partner
Network there's people that specialize
in using this particular framework to
help organizations move over and I
believe that Abus has Professional
Services through the APN but let's just
kind of break down what these six
categories are we're not going to go too
deep into this um but let's do it so the
first is the business perspective so
these are business managers Finance
managers budget owners strategy
stakeholders so it's how to up update
the staff skills and organizational
processes to optimize business value as
they move Ops to the cloud you have
people perspectives so Human Resources
Staffing people managers so how to
update the staff skills and
organizational processes to optimize and
maintain the workforce and ensure
competencies are in place at the
appropriate time you have governance
perspective so cios program managers
project managers Enterprise Architects
business analysts so how to update the
staff skills and organizational
processes that are necessary to ensure
business governance in the cloud and
manage and measure Cloud Investments to
evaluate the business outcomes we have
platform perspectives so CTO it managers
solution Architects so how to update the
staff skills and organizational
processes that are necessary to deliver
and optimize Cloud Solutions and
services security perspective so ciso it
security managers it security analysts
so how to update the staff skills and
organizational processes that are
necessary to ensure that the
architecture deployed in in the cloud
aligns to the organization security
control requirements resilience
and compliance requirements we have
operational or operations perspective so
it operations managers it support
managers so how to update the staff
skills and organizational processes that
are necessary to ensure system health
and reliability during the move of
operations to the cloud and then to
operate operate using agile ongoing
cloud computing best practices so this
just Taps the surface of what the CAF is
uh and I think for each of these they
actually have a more detailed breakdown
so you know business is going to break
down to even more uh uh finite things
there
[Music]
okay so itus has free services that are
free forever unlike the free tier that
are up to a point of usage or time um
and so there are a lot here this is not
even the full list there's definitely
more and we have IM am Amazon VPC Auto
scaling cloud formation elastic bean
stock Ops Works amplify appsync code
star organizations Consolidated building
a was cost Explorer uh Sage maker
systems manager there's a lot of them
okay um but the thing is is that uh
these services are free but some of
these um can spin up other resources so
the services are free themselves however
ones that provision Services May cost
you money so cloud formation which is an
infrastructure is a code tool could
launch virtual machines those virtual
machines will cost money right opsworks
can launch servers that can cost money
amplifly can launch um lambdas that can
cost money so that's something you just
have to consider um but yeah there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the adus
support plans so we got basic developer
business and Enterprise and you
absolutely absolutely need to need to
know this stuff inside and out for your
exam they will ask you questions on this
okay so basic is for email support only
uh such as billing and account so if you
think it got over bu and that's
something you should do if if you''ve uh
uh misconfigured something and you end
up with a big Bill just go Um open up a
support ticket under basic for billing
and they're likely to refund you but if
you do have questions about billing
accounts that's what we're going to be
using for everything else that is for
tech support um and so for developer
business Enterprise you're going to get
email support which they'll uh roughly
reply within 24 hours I believe this is
business hours so if you message them on
Friday um or sorry Saturday you might be
waiting till Monday for it okay um um in
terms of thirdparty support the only one
that doesn't have third party support is
developer so if you are using something
like Ruby on Rails or Azure or something
that has interruptibility between AD and
something else business Enterprise will
absolutely help you out with it same
with Enterprise but the developer one
not so much uh if you like to use the
phone or you like to chat with people um
that's available at the business
Enterprise tier this is the way I end up
talking to people if you are um you know
like if you're in North America and
you're calling between 9 to 5 and a
Monday and Friday you're likely to get
somebody that is within North America if
not it'll be one of uh one of the
supports from some other area so just be
aware of that that can also affect the
time they pick up uh sometimes it's 5
minutes sometimes it's 30 minutes to to
an hour uh you know it just depends on
what service you're asking for and you
know what time a day okay um in terms of
responsiveness uh for General guidance
everything is 24 hours or less for
developer business Enterprise if your
system is impaired it's within 12 hours
or less with production system impaired
it's four hours or less with production
system down it's 1 hour or less and if
you're for Enterprise um it's going to
be business critical system down less
than 50 minutes so just notice who has
what for these things um I've definitely
waited like three days on General
guidance before so just take these with
a grain of salt that they're not you
know they don't really stick to these
that or maybe I'm just not paying enough
for them to care okay um in terms of uh
getting actual people assigned to you
this only happens at the Enterprise
level where they have their coner team
so they uh help your um organization uh
learn how to use datab best asking them
any questions personally and then you
have a tam a technical account manager
that is somebody that knows um aide
inside and out and they'll help you
architect things and make correct
choices or they'll check your bill and
help you try to reduce that bill things
like that okay in terms of trusted
advisory checks at the basic developer
you get seven advisory checks once
you're paying for business you get all
the checks the cost here for business is
zero um for developer it's starting at
$29 a month for business it's starting
at $100 a month and then for Enterprise
it's 15,000 a month so I said starting
at because it's dependent on your usage
okay so let's just look at developer
business and Enterprise here because
basic's not going to be applicable here
so for developers $29 us a month or 3%
of the monthly adus usage which
whichever is greater on the exam they're
only going to ask you like is it $2,900
like generally do you know the tier of
expensiveness but they're not going to
ask you the percentage of usage okay
there's not going to be formulas here um
when you get into business it's a little
bit uh different where they have it in
different brackets so it's going to be
10% for the first uh 10,000 and the next
is going to be the next 7,000 stuff like
that similar for Enterprise as well so
let's just do some math so we know that
we understand how this works so if you
if you had a monthly spend of $500 at
the developer tier that's 3% of $500 is
$1 so they go okay what is greater $29
or $15 so you're paying $29 if you're
spent is $1,000 that comes up to $30 uh
so you're going to end up paying $30
because that's greater than 29 okay for
business uh if your monthly spend is a
th000 that's 10% of ,000 that's $100 if
your spend is $5,000 then you're going
to be paying $500 if your monthly spend
is 12,000 then the first 10% of a of
10,000 is a th000 and then the next is
7% of 2,000 so your total bill is 140
USD we're not going to do a calculation
for Enterprise because it's the same for
business but hopefully that gives you an
idea there
[Music]
okay hey it's Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at a technical
account manager also known as a tam and
these provide both proactive guidance
and reactive support to help you succeed
with your adus journey so what does a
tam do and this is straight from an adus
job
posting what they would do is build
Solutions provide technical guidance and
advocate for the customer ensure ad
environments remain operationally
healthy while reducing cost and
complexity develop trusting
relationships with customers
understanding their business needs and
Technical challenges using your
technical uh Acumen and customer
Obsession you'll drive technical
discussions regarding incidents
tradeoffs risk management consult with a
range of Partners from developers
through the seite executives collaborat
with a Solutions architect business
developers Professional Service
consultants and sales account managers
proactively find opportunities for
customers to gain additional value from
AWS provide detailed reviews of service
disruptions metrics detailed pre-launch
planning being uh part of a wider
Enterprise support team providing post
scale cons uh uh consultative expertise
solve a variety of problems across
different customers as they migrate
their workloads to the cloud uplift
customer uh capabilities by running
workshops Brown Bag sessions Brown Bag
sessions being sessions that occur at
lunchtime something you can learn in 30
minutes an hour and so one thing that's
really important to understand is that
Tams follow the Amazon leadership
principles especially about customer uh
being customer obsessed and we do cover
the Amazon leadership principle
somewhere in this course and Tams are
only available at the Enterprise support
tier so hopefully that gives you an idea
what a
[Music]
does hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro in this fall along I'm going to show
you um adus support and in order to use
adus support or to change your level
support you're going to need to be
logged into the root account I should
say you can use support with IM users
but if you want to change the support
plan you're going to have to be the root
user so in the top right corner I'm
going to support and notice here on the
left hand side right now I have a basic
plan
and so before we look at changing our
plan I'm just going to go create a case
and we're going to uh just take a look
at some of the options that are open to
us so we have account billing support
service limit increase technical support
notice this is gray out so we cannot
select anything here I can go to here
and increase our service limit and this
is something that you might have to do
uh pretty soon early in your account you
might say hey I need more of something
like ec2 or um a very common thing is
SCS
so for SC you might say hey um I need to
have this amount of emails for ETC okay
so um if we go over to count and billing
support uh we can go here and ask
anything we want so if it's about the
free tier I could say ask a general
question getting started and saying uh
what is free on
AWS um I want to know what is free on
AWS and you can attach uh three
attachments there you can choose via uh
web and phone which is really nice um
but today I'm just going to do web here
and submit that just to kind of show you
that as an example and so what that is
going to do is open a case and then we
will see probably respond in 24 hours to
48 hours just depends on um whether it's
the weekend or not because it's based on
business hours of course so now that we
have an understanding of basic let's go
take a look at what the other tiers look
like so we have basic developer business
and ENT enterprise Enterprise being
extremely expensive developer being
affordable and then business being um
you know affordable for businesses so I
would say developer is okay it gives you
um uh it gives you a better support but
it's all via email and so you know if
you really want good support you're
going to have to pay the business one
and that's the one that I use quite a
bit so if I change my plan I'm going to
go over to business and this is going to
cost me 93 bucks just to do to show you
here today so I'm going to go ahead and
click that and so it's now processing it
and so what's going to happen is I'm G
to have to wait for this basic to switch
to business so if I go to the case here
it hasn't happened as of yet so noce I
cannot select this so I'm going to see
you back here in maybe like four or five
minutes or however long it takes and
we'll take a look then okay great so
after a few minutes it says my plan is
now business and what I can do is go
ahead and create a new case and so I can
go over to technical support and ask a
question so if I was having issues with
anything it doesn't matter what I could
go over to ec2
Linux and then I could choose my
category so I could say I'm having an
issue with um systems
manager and a lot of times they like you
to provide the instance ID it's going to
change based on what service you choose
here um but you'll get different
information I'll just say I need
help with um logging into my ec2
instance managed by SSM so I can say I
created an ec2 instance
and I am attempting to access uh the
instance
via sessions
manager but it is not
working I think I have a rooll issue and
then I'm just going to go down here and
say this is not a real
question I am filming a demo video for
or tutorial
video on how to use support okay and so
once we do that we have the option of
web chat and phone so if you use phone
you're going to enter your phone number
in and they're going to call you back uh
usually you will be on hold for anywhere
for 5 minutes to an hour it just depends
usually it's within 15 minutes so it's
very good of course it depends on the
time of day and your location things
like that and the service because
there's different uh support Engineers
for different types of services and the
the balance of those are different but
generally chat is pretty good so I can
go here and I'm just going to hit submit
and it's going to open a chat box and so
you just wait okay and sometimes it's
super fast and sometimes it takes uh
minutes okay so we are going to just sit
here for a bit and um you know I'll just
pop back here when there is somebody to
talk to
okay okay so after waiting a little
while looks like uh we've been connected
here so it took a bit of time so we're
just going to say hello hi um uh this
this is Andrew
Brown um I am recording a video to teach
people how to use
AWS and I wanted to show them how AWS
support
works so I'm just showing them how the
chat system
works say
hello
and hopefully they'll appreciate or they
won't it just doesn't really
matter we'll give them a
moment there we go
that's
it thanks for your
help okay and so that's pretty much it
um so you know there's nothing really uh
uh special about that but the idea is
when you are typing with them it will
appear in the correspondence there so
I'm just going to end the chat okay uh
and then I'm just going to mark that
case as resolve sometimes they will ask
you to resolve it if I go to cases I
probably have some previous ones here um
I have a lot but I don't know why they
don't all show up here so you can see
this one is pending this one is resolved
I go back to this one you can kind of
see that the uh history of a
conversation is kept and you can go back
and forth uh with the people there um
yeah that's pretty much it uh you can
also do screen sharing so they might
send you request to go on Zoom or
download this piece of software that
shares your screen and so that is
another option as well so they can get
pretty handson to help you uh with your
problems there but that's pretty much
all I want to to show you with support
I'm going to downgrade this and I'm not
sure if they're going to give me back my
money sometimes they'll prate it for you
but I'm go here and go back to basic um
so we will also refund your credit card
directly in the month's remaining fees
on your old plan which you previously
paid you're obligated to pay a minimum
of 30 days of support each time you
register so I'm not going to get any
money back which is totally fine because
I just wanted to show you how that works
but business support is definitely worth
it and uh you know that's
it
[Music]
so the anabis marketplace is a curated
digital catalog with thousands of
software listings from independent
software vendors uh easily find buy test
and deploy software that already runs an
ads the product can be free to use or
can have an Associated charge the charge
becomes part of your adus bill and once
you pay adus Market pays the provider
the sales channel for isv and Consulting
Partners allow you to sell your
solutions to other adus customers
products can be offered such as Ami
a CL information templates software of
service offerings web ACLS ABS WAFF and
rules so it sounds great um if you want
to sell here I think you need like a US
bank account to do it um and you know
sometimes Aus Marketplace is just part
of AWS so like when you're using the ec2
marketplace you are technically using
the itus marketplace um but they also
have like a dedicated page for it so
it's integrated with some services and
it's also Standalone
okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this follow along we're going to
take a look at the adus marketplace so
what I want you to do is go on the top
and type in Marketplace and that will
bring us over to here the marketplace
can be found in a variety of different
places on the platform here you can see
that uh previously it was using
something called guacamole Bastian host
to launch a server um but the idea is
that um you can discover products and
subscriptions that you might want to
utilize so if I go over here there's a
variety of different things
and so it could be like I want to have
something like a firewall that might be
something that we might be interested in
so we could search there and there's
like bring your own license firewall so
maybe you have a license with this and
you want to run it on an ect2 instance
something like that again it's not like
super complicated U what's going on here
but a lot of times you know when you're
using Services you're accessing the
marketplace anyway so like when I'm
launching an ec2
instance notice on the left hand side
says ABS Marketplace and so I don't have
to go to the marketplace there I can
just kind of like check out the thing I
want um and that's pretty much all there
really is to it okay so you know
hopefully that makes
sense let's take a look here at
Consolidated billing so this is a
feature of Abus organizations that
allows you to pay for multiple accounts
via one bill so the idea here is we have
a master account and we have member
accounts and I I'm pretty sure that we
probably call this root account now I
don't think uh master account might be a
data term but it's still showing up in
the document mentation the idea is that
if you have member accounts within your
organization they're all going to be
Consolidated under the single account if
you have an account outside of your
organization um you know this is not
going to give you uh this is going to be
basically a separate bill um as if it's
like a standalone organization or what
have you okay so uh for billing adus
treats all accounts in an organization
as if they were one account you can
designate one uh uh master or root
account that pays the charges for all
the other member accounts consolidate
billing is offered at no additional cost
you can use uh cost Explorer to
visualize usage for Consolidated billing
which we can see I have the icon here uh
you can combine the usage across all
accounts in the organization to uh to
share the volume pricing discount which
we did Cover in this course separately
if you want an account to be able to
leave the organization you do have to
attach it to a new payment method so if
let's say you had an account and you
want to give it to your friend or
whatever they're have to hook up their
uh their credit card but you can totally
have have uh an account leave an
organization but you have to deal with
that billing aspect
[Music]
okay all right so there's a really cool
way to save an ads and that's through
volume discounts and it's available for
many services the more you use the more
you save is the idea behind it um and so
consolidating building lets you take
advantage of volume discounts this is a
particular feature of adus organization
so if you do not have the or turn on
you're not going to be able to take
advantage of that okay so example would
be something like data transfer where it
is build uh for the first 10 terabytes
at at 17 cents or sorry 17 cents and
then the next 40 terabytes it will be
AT3 cents okay so if we had two accounts
um such as Odo and Dax and they're not
within an abl organization we can
calculate those and see what they are
unconsolidated and just so you know one
terab equals 1024 gabes and that's what
you're going to see in these
calculations so for Odo uh you know if
you has 4 terabytes and that is uh we
calculate the gigabytes there we times
it by uh the um scent value there we're
going to get
$696 okay for Dax we're going to end up
with uh about $ 1392 there and so if we
were to add those up the bill would come
out to
$2,088 okay so the idea is that there's
an organization and they like a your
company and they created two accounts
but they're just not within an
organization by having them in the
organization you're going to save um
about almost $80 there so um that is a
reason why you'd want to use volume
discounts
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're taking a look at Abus
trusted advisor so trusted advisor is a
recommendation tool which automatically
and actively monitors your adus accounts
to provide actional recommendations
across a series of categories so this is
what it looks like I personally prefer
the older dashboard but this is what
they have now and you can see along the
side we have a bunch of categories and
then we have some checks here saying uh
you know what are we meeting what are we
not and you can go in and read each one
and they'll tell you so much information
they'll even show you like what things
are not meeting that requirements in
some case you can easily remediate by
pressing a button not in all cases but
the thing with ad trust advisor is think
of AD trust advisor like an automated
checklist of best practices on AWS and
they kind of map to the pillars of the
well architecture framework not exactly
but pretty close but there are five
categories of adus trusted advisor so we
have cost optimation how much money can
we save performance so how can uh we
improve performance security how can we
improve security fall tolerance how we
can we prevent a disaster or data loss
and service limits so are we going to
hit the maximum limit for a service and
so uh the next thing we need to discuss
is um there's a VAR creation of the
amount of checks that are available to
you based on your support plan so you
know if you're using basic or developer
you have seven trusted advisor checks
and if you have business Enterprise you
have all the trusted advisor checks so
uh if we're talking about just the ones
that are available to you the ones that
come for free is MFA on root account
security groups specified ports of
unrestricted Amazon S3 bucket
permissions Amazon EBS public snapshots
Amazon RDS public snapshots I amus so
this is just about alerting you about
discouraging the use of the root account
service limits so all service limit
checks are free um it's weird cuz they
call it the like seven Security checks
but if you counted all the service
limits it obviously be too large of a
number but notice that 1 through six are
all Security checks so you're not
getting anything from the other tiers
just the security tier and what I want
to do is just go over a bunch of
available checks out there it's probably
not the full list because I couldn't
even be bothered to update it if they've
added more but it will give you a
general idea of what you could expect
under each category so for cost
optimization um it could be things like
looking at idle load bouncers so you
know if you have load bouncers you're
not using you're paying for them so get
rid of them unassociated elastic IP
addresses so for every IP that's not
associated you're paying for as well
maybe under performance you have um High
utilization of Amazon ec2 instances so
maybe you can save money by switching to
smaller instances under security we saw
MFA on rout account very popular one
making sure you turn on key rotation
could be something as well there under
fault tolerance um it could be making
sure that you're using backups on your
Amazon RDS database maybe that's turned
off uh for service limits there's just a
ton of them and so uh one that that you
know might be PR to use vpcs or ec2
limits so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're going to take a look at
trusted advisor so what I want you to do
is go to the top and type in trusted
advisor
and once you're there you're going to
notice on the left hand side we have
cost optimization performance security
fault tolerance and service limits right
now there are no recommended actions
because there's not much going on this
account and when you uh have the uh Free
level of support the basic support
you're not going to have all these
checks but if we go in here we can still
see kind of what they do um so we have
like performance security things like
that so these are the ones that we
actually can see and they generally work
all the same way if you expand here it's
going to say
Amazon EBS public snapshot so check the
permission settings for the EBS volume
snapshots and alert you if the any
snapshots are marked as public and so if
you scroll on down if there were ones
that were an issue it would tell you
right here okay then down below here we
see like check buckets in Amazon S3 that
have open access permissions or allow
access to authenticated adist users so
yellow the ACL allows uh list access for
everyone uh a bucket policy allows for
any kind of Open Access bucket policy
statements have public Grant access so
maybe what we can do is to see if we can
get this to
trigger and so what I'm going to do here
is go over to S3 and what we're going to
do is make a B bucket that has a full
axis okay so I'm going to create a new
bucket and it'll say my exposed
bucket we'll scroll on down here and
we'll just checkbox that off and create
the bucket we say I acknowledge that is
totally fine
okay so now I have a bucket that is 100%
exposed if we go back to trust advisor
give this a
refresh I'm not sure how fast it will
show up here but if I
expand so it says the bucket ACL allows
upload delete for everyone The Trusted
adviser does not have permissions to
check the policy uh bucket policy has
statements that Grant Public
Access so what we could try to do is
make a
policy
and try to Grant all access here so I'm
not writing these every single day but
I'm sure we could try to figure this
out
um we'll say S3 bucket policy Public
Access public
read and so that one might be a good
example so I'm going to go ahead and
copy this one granting readon permission
to anomymous
users I don't recommend you doing this
I'm just doing this to show you to see
if we can get the trusted advisor to
check because I don't want you to uh do
this and forget about it and then have a
serious issue but the principle is set
to anybody so anyone can read it here
it's saying get object Etc then it's
saying what particular resource so this
one is going to be for uh the bucket in
question here which is my
exposed
bucket we're going to scroll on down
save the
changes okay so this bucket is publicly
accessible we're going to go back over
here refresh and see what we can
see okay so checks buckets in S3 Etc so
it should appear under
here and it could be that it's just
going to take some time so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to hang
tight for a little bit oh there we go
okay so it's showing up and I guess it
just took some time top poate and so
here we can see we have a a yellow
symbol it's a warning saying hey there's
a problem here if we go back to the
dashboard I wonder if that shows up so
this one's for investigation and
recommendation so you know hopefully
that kind of makes sense to you I think
in some cases you can do remediation
from from here or at least you can go
and check box and say okay um
ignore could of swore there was
remediation for some of
these but in any case you know that's
generally what trusted advisor does um I
think that you probably can have it so
it gives you alerts so yeah you could
set recipients for particular things
like if there's a security issue then I
could email a particular person on your
team and they could deal with it but
that's pretty much it so what I'm going
to do is go ahead and delete this bucket
I'm all done with
it we'll go
delete and say my delete uh my exposed
bucket here to delete it and that is it
okay
[Music]
let's cover the concepts of service
level agreements also known as SLA so an
SLA is a formal commitment about the
expected level of service between a
customer and provider when a service
level is not met and if customer meets
its obligation under the SLA customer
will be eligible to receive compensation
so Financial or service credits and so
when we talk about slas then we talk
about SLI so SLI service level indicator
is a metric or measurement that
indicates what measure per performance
the customer is receiving at a given
time a SLI metric could be uptime
performance availability throughput
latency error rate durability
correctness and if we're talking about
sis then we're talking about slos
service level objectives so the
objective that that the provider has
agreed to meet SLS are represented as a
specific Target percentage over a period
of time and so an example of a Target
percentage would be something that says
an availability SLA of
99.99% in a period of three months all
right
and let's just talk about Target
percentages and the way they can be
represented very common ones we will see
is
99.95%
99.99% uh then we have 99 followed by
99 and so commonly we just say we call
this 99 okay and then there's one 911s
so if somebody says we have an SLA
guarantee of of 9911 it's going to be
the 99 followed by 911s all
right
[Music]
let's take a look at Abus service level
agreements and so there are a lot of
them and I just wanted to just show you
a few services to give you an idea how
they work uh on the exam they're not
going to ask you like oh what's dnb's
SLA for Global tables um but generally
we should just go through this because
it's good practice so let's take a look
at dynamodb SLA so adus will use
commercially reasonable efforts to make
dyab to be available with a monthly
uptime percentage of each adus region
during any monthly billing cycle uh so
for a at least
99.999% if Global tables slas applies or
99.99% if the standard SLA applies and
the event Dynamo DB does not meet the
service commitment you'll be eligible to
receive service credits described below
so we have monthly uptime percentage and
the service credit percentage we get
Global tables standard tables so let's
take a look here so if less than
99.999% but equal to or greater than 9
9.0% is met so if if the service ends up
being this you'll get 10% back of what
you spent as service credits if it drops
between U 99.0 and 95.0 you get 25% back
if it's less than 95 uh percent um then
it's 100% back okay and you get the
general idea here SLA is going to be
slightly different with their drops now
let's take a look at um a compute and so
compute is going to apply across a bunch
of compute services
probably because they're all using ec2
underneath so that's probably the reason
for it so we have ec2 EBS ECS eks and
Abus uh makes two SLA commitments uh for
the included services so we have a
region level SLA that uh governs
included Services deployed across
multiple azs or regions and an instance
level SLA that governs Amazon ec2
instances individually and again we have
our monthly up up time percentage our
service C percentage region and instance
level so you can just see the same thing
it's like it's going to change based on
uh what it can meet then we'll take a
look at one more like RDS so a
relational database service so it will
use commercially reasonable efforts to
make multi- a instances available with
monthly uptime percentage of 99.95%
during any monthly billing cycle and
again you know if if they don't meet
those requirements you're going to get
service credits back which basically
equal USD dollars on the platform and so
for this it looks like that so just
notice that you know with like compute
it was for a a bunch of services for
Dynamo DB it was based on uh particular
features like global standard tables SLA
it's very straightforward uh we didn't
do S3 because I just did not want to
show you that one it was just too
complicated but my point is is that it's
going to vary so you have to look up per
service
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at Amazon's
service level agreements and so the way
you find slas is you pretty much just
type in SLA for whatever it is so if
you're looking for compute you type in
SLA or you look for a particular service
so maybe you say sage maker SLA AWS I
don't think there's like a generic SLA
page at least I don't know where it is I
always just type in SLA to find what it
is and through that you can just kind of
read through and try to find out uh the
things that that matter to you for your
business
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at the
service Health dat board and so the
service Health dashboard shows General
status of adus services and it's really
simple the idea is that you can uh check
based on the geographic area so you'd
say North America Europe Etc and what
you'll see is an icon that says whether
the service is in in good standing and
the details whether the service is
operating normally Etc notice they also
have an RSS feed the reason I'm talking
about service Health dashboards is
because I want to talk about personal
health dashboards and because they're
both called Health dashboards it's
confusing so I wanted to to tell you
about this one first so now we'll jump
into the adus personal health
dashboard so we saw the service Health
dashboard now let's take a look at the
adus personal health dashboard so this
is what it looks like and it provides
alerts and guidance for adus events that
might affect your environment all adus
customers can access the personal health
dashboard the personal health dashboard
shows recent events to help you manage
active events and show proactive
notifications so that you can plan for
scheduled activities you uh you can use
these alerts to get notified about
changes that can affect your aess
resources and then follow the guidance
to diagnose and resolve the issue so
this is very similar to the service
Health dashboard but it's personalized
for you um and it's uh you know I I
don't see it crop up very often but if
you had to create alerts or be reactive
to uh things that are happening within
your bus this is where you do it
okay
so there's a team called adus trust and
safety that specifically deals with
abuses occurring on the adus platform
and so I'm going to just list of all the
cases where you'd want to be contacting
them as opposed to support so the first
is Spam so you're receiving unwanted
emails from an Abus owned IP address or
adus resources are used to spam websites
or forms Port scanning your log show
that one or more adus owned IP addresses
are sending packets to multiple ports on
your server uh you also believe uh this
is an attempt to discover unsecured
ports
uh dos attack so your logs show that one
or more itus owned IP addresses are used
to flood ports on your resources with
packets you also believe this is an
attempt to overwhelm or crash your
server or the software running on your
server intrusion attempts so your logs
show that one or more ad owned IP
addresses are used to attempt to log
into your resources hosting prohibited
content so you have evidence that adus
resources are used to host distribute
prohibited content such as illegal
content or copyrighted content without
the consent of the copyright holder
Distributing malware so you you have
evidence that abis resources are used to
distribute software that was knowingly
created to compromise or cause harm to
computers machines that it's installed
on and so in any of these cases you're
not going to adus support you're going
to open up an abuse ticket and so you
got to contact abuse at Amazon
aus.com or fill out the uh uh Amazon
abuse uh form so and this is whether
it's coming from uh an outside AOS
account or even you're internally if you
think that some someone is compromise
your account and it's being used in any
of these ways uh this is what you're
going to do
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're looking at ads abuse so uh
we were saying that ads has the ads
trust and safety team and what you'll
want to do is if you uh find that
there's an issue you're going to report
it to this email at abuse Amazon.com or
you're going to use this form which is
the report Amazon a abuse so you'll go
down here you'll sign in you'll put your
email email in your first name last name
or phone number um The Source IP the the
details uh uh in uh here you can even
select the type of abuse so you say if
it's this kind or that kind things like
that it's very straightforward um and
that's pretty much it
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the itus
free tier and this allows you to use
adus at no cost um and when we say free
tier there there there's the idea of the
first 12 months of sign up there's going
to be special offerings or it's free
usage up to a certain monthly Limit
Forever um and then there's just
services that are inherently free which
we have a total separate slide on but
let's talk about just the free tier
stuff and this is absolutely not the
full list um but uh it's a good ide like
it gives you a good um overview of stuff
that is free so for ec2 which you use a
web server you get a T2 micro for 750
hours per month for one year and so
there's about 730 hours
um in a month and so that means you
could have a server
running uh the entire month for free uh
and an additional server for a bit as
well so for RDS which is a relational
database service for either my school or
postgress we can do it T2 DB micro for
750 hours for free so there we get our
free database and you would be surprised
how far you can get with a uh a T2 DB
micro um you know even for a mediumsized
startup you can run it on uh a T2 DB
micro with no problems then you have
your elasic load balancer you get 750
hours per month for one year um so that
is a really good thing uh load balancers
usually cost $15 a month so that's great
actually all these pretty much cost $15
a month so that's about um 1530 $45
month over month for a year that's uh
free then you have Amazon cloudfront
this is where you'd have your homepage
caching your videos things like that so
you get 50 GB data transfer out for the
total of year then there's Amon connect
you get your total free number there 90
minutes of a call time per month for one
month or for one year sorry Amazon
allows to cash so you could launch a
redis or elastic cach server you get 70
hours on a cash T3 micro for a year um
elastic search service so this is full
Tech search so again 750 hours per month
for one year pinpoint campaign markting
email so you can send out 5,000 targeted
users per month for one year SC so um
simple email uh service so this is for
um transactional emails um so that you
send out from your web app so 62,000
emails per month forever it those code
pipeline so one pipeline free it was
code build so uh this is for building
out projects or things like that so 100
build minutes per month forever it was
Lambda service compute 1 million free
requests per month 3.2 million uh
million seconds of compute time per
month for free uh and you know I like to
highlight these ones because for
traditional architecture you're always
going to have a web server a database a
load balancer um and you might even have
cloudfront in there as well but uh yeah
again there's a huge list and this does
not even tap the surface of what's free
on
[Music]
AWS hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at adus
promotional credits and these are the
equivalent to USD dollars on adus
platform adus credits can be earned
several ways this could be joining ad
activate startup program winning a
hackathon participating surveys and any
other reason that ad us wants to give
credits out uh once you uh have um a
promotional code you click the redeem
credit button in the billing console you
enter it in and then your credits will
be shown there you can monitor them via
it budgets or uh via cost Explorer and
probably even building alarms itus
credits generally have an expired dat
tax them could be a few months uh to a
year itus credits can be used for most
services but there are exceptions where
itus credits cannot be used like
purchasing a domain via row 53 because
uh that domain costs money outside of
adses cost like for their infrastructure
and virtual stuff and so for things like
that uh you know they're not going to be
you're not going to be able to use
credits for that
[Music]
okay the adabas partner Network also
know as APN is a global partner program
for ad best so joining the APN will open
your organization up to business
opportunities and allow exclusive
training and marketing events so when
joining the APN you can either be a
Consulting partner so you help companies
utilize datab bus or a technology
partner you build technology on top of
ABS as a service offering and a partner
belongs to a specific tier so it's
either going to be select advance or
Premiere when you sign up it's free to
sign up but you're not going to be able
to do much until you start uh committing
to an annual fee so that's it's like a
certain amount of money to uh be able to
be part of that tier and it starts in
the thousands okay so I think the first
tier is like something like a th000 or
$2,000 and it gets uh more expensive as
you go up as a tier and you also have to
have particular knowledge requirements
so this could be holding uh particular
adus certifications at the at the
foundational level at the associate
level things like that um or it could be
adus APN exclusive certification so
training that um is not adus
certifications but there's
certifications that are only available
to Partners saying like how do you it
could be like something like how do you
uh talk to customers or communication
things like that you can get back
promotional Abus credits so you know if
you say Oham I spent uh
$22,000 on just being able to uh get
into the APN at least the idea is that
you can generally get back that uh that
spend on AWS so it's like you committing
if you give like $2,000 it's like you're
going to commit to keep using AWS I'm
not showing the annual fee commitments
here and the promotional credits that
you get back just because they've
changed it a couple times on me and I
just don't want this slide to go stale
in case they happen to change it again
so you'll have to look that up to find
out what they actually are right now uh
you can have unique speak speaking
opportunities in the official adus
marketing channels like the blogs or
webinars being part of the APN is a
requirement to be a sponsor with a
vendor booth at ads event so when you
when you go to reinvent or any ads um
event all the vendors are part of the
APN all right so they've paid their fee
and now they paid an additional fee to
get their Booth but um yeah AB partner
network uh is very good for uh uh
helping you find new business and
connecting with other people that are
building workloads on AWS but hopefully
that gives you an idea of how works
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at abis
budgets so Abus budgets gives you the
ability to set up alerts if you exceed
or approaching your defined budget
create cost usage or reservation budgets
it can be tracked at the monthly
quarterly or yearly levels with
customizable start and end dates alert
support ec2 RDS red shift elastic cast
reservations uh and so the idea here is
you can choose your budget amount so it
could be like $100 it'll even show you
what was the last amount if you're uh
resetting the budget there something new
you can choose based on a different kind
of unit so if you wanted to be based on
running hours on ec2 you could totally
do that is budgets can be used to
forecast costs but is limited compared
to cost Explorer or doing your own
analysis related with cost and usage
reports along with business intelligence
tools budgets uh based on a fixed cost
or or you can plan your cost uh UPF
front based on your chosen level can be
easily managed from the ads budgets
dashboard via the ads budgets API get
notified by providing email or chatbot
and threshold uh how close to the
current or forecasted budget um so you'd
see a list of budgets here uh current
versus forecasted the amount used things
like that you can see your budget
history you can download a CSV uh it'll
show you the cost history right in line
there which I can't show you it it's
hard to see there you get the first two
budgets are free so there's no reason
not to set a budget when you first first
get into AWS and each budget costs about
uh 002 cents a day so it's like 60 cents
um uh USD per month for budget so
they're very cheap to use and you got a
limit of 20,000 budgets you're going to
be in good shape
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at Abus
budget reports which is used alongside
abos budgets to create and send daily
weekly or monthly reports to monitor the
performance of your Aus budgets it will
be emailed to specific emails so it's
not too complicated here you say create
the report budget choose your frequency
uh the emails you want um and budget
report serves as a more convenient way
of staying on top of report since
they're delivered to your email instead
of logging into the abis Management
console so it's just for those people
that just can't be bothered to log in
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at abis cost
and uses report so generate a detailed
spreadsheet enabling you to better
analyze and understand your Aus cost so
this is kind of what it looks like and
when you turn this feature on it will
place it into an S3 bucket you could use
something like Athena to turn the report
into a queriable database since it's
very easy to consume S3 csvs into Athena
you could use Quick site to visualize
your building data as grass so quick
site is a business intelligence tool
similar to Tableau or powerbi you could
also ingest this into red shift um but
the idea here is when you turn it on you
can choose how granular you want the
data to be hourly daily or monthly if
you turn on daily you'll be able to even
see spikes of uh of of of costs for uc2
instances which is kind of nice the
report will contain cost allocation tags
um which I think we have a separate
slide on that type of tags and the data
is stored in e as either a CSV it'll be
zipped or it will be a parket format it
just depends on how you want it um uh
for that
[Music]
okay let's talk about cost allocation
tags so these are optional metadata that
can be attached to adus resour resources
so when you generate out a cost and uses
report you can use that data to better
analyze your data so what you'd have to
do is make your way over to cost
allocation tags and need to activate the
tags you want to show up there are two
types of tags so we have user Define so
whatever you've previously tagged will
show up probably there you turn it on so
if you made one with project you turn on
project and there's a lot of adus
generated ones that you can turn on so
there's a huge list there but uh yeah
that's particular with cost um usage and
reports if it says like cost allocation
reports it's just that's what cost and
usage reports used to be called um and
some of the documentations a bit old
there but yep there you
[Music]
go so you can create your own alarms in
cloudwatch alarms to monitor spend and
they're commonly called building alarms
uh and so it's just a regular alarm but
it's just focused on spend but in order
to do this you have to turn on building
alerts first in order to uh be able to
use it uh and then you'll go to
cloudwatch alarms and you can choose
billing as your metric and then you just
set your alarm however you'd want
billing alarms are much more flexible
than abess budgets and are ideal for
more complex use cases for monitoring
spend and usage in terms of alerting so
you just have to decide what you want to
do uh before it those budgets this was
the only way to do it and so this is the
way I'm used to doing it and I still do
it this way today but uh you know both
options are valid and just have to
decide what is your use case
okay
let's take a look at Abus cost Explorer
which lets you visualize understand and
manage your Abus cost and usage over
time so uh here's a big graphic of Adis
cost Explorer and you can specify time
and range and aggregation and it has a
lot of robust filtering um what's really
nice is that they have a bunch of
default reports for you so I'm just
going to get my pen tool just to show
you where that button is it's over uh
here uh if you can see my marker there
but but you know you can look at things
like monthly cost by service monthly
cost by linked account daily cost a this
Marketplace R utilization so there's a
bunch there you can also notice you can
create your own report so if you do find
something that you like you can save it
for later um you can you could have
access to forecasting here so you get an
idea of the future costs and whether
it's been it's gone up or down just to
kind of zoom in on some of those
filtration options you can choose um
either monthly or daily level of of how
you want the data to be grouped together
and you have a lot of filter control so
if I want to just have ec2 instances for
a particular region then I can get that
filtered information over here and you
can see you have a breakdown of the
different types so it's very detailed
and class Explorer shows up in Us East
one I'm pretty sure if you click on
class Explorer it will just switch you
over to that region but just understand
that's where it lives
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from
exampro and in this video I want to show
you ad cost Explorer so what we'll do is
go to the top here and and actually on
the right hand side we're going to click
on the right and go to my billing
dashboard and from there on the left
hand side we're going to look for cost
Explorer and then click launch cost
Explorer and this is where we're going
to get to the ad ofs cost management
dashboard where this is where we find
savings plans reservations things like
that on the left hand side click on cost
Explorer and you can get this nice chart
and so the idea is you can change it
from monthly to daily if you if you uh
prefer okay you can change the scope
here maybe we don't need six months we
can just go back
um three months here so there's less
data it is a bit delayed when I'm
clicking here so it also could be just
because I'm doing the daily instead of
monthly so you just have to be a little
bit patient when uh using this interface
you can change it to stack line graph
you can kind of see the details there
it's not always clear like what others
is or things like that and so uh you can
drill down and there's like ways of
applying fil filters and things like
that I always forget how to uh do this
it's because it's it's bringing
everything in so you have to hit clear
all first I
think and
um oh you have to click into it so like
if you wanted to click into it and pick
a particular service we could go here
and type in
ec2 and say ec2 instances and then apply
that filter so now we can just see
exactly that cost or if we want to
choose use like maybe just
RDS okay so you know that could be
useful for you to see but yeah sometimes
it's not always clear and so what I
recommend is just go back to your
billing dashboard and from there just go
to bills okay bills is really really
useful because here it shows you exactly
every single little service that you're
being built for you can expand it and
see exactly where if you have other
accounts you can go into this side here
as well and find spend that way um but
cost Explorer is very useful just it's
useful in a different way okay so there
you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at the adus
pricing API so with adus you can
programmatically access pricing
information to get the latest pricing
offerings for services this makes sense
because databus can change them at any
time and so uh you know you might want
to know exactly what the current price
is uh there are two versions of this API
so we have the career API known as the
pricing service API and you access this
via Json and then there's the batch API
also known as the price uh list API via
HTML what's odd is that um the batch API
returns Json but you're accessing it via
HTML so you can literally paste those
links in your browser for the query API
you're actually sending an an
application Json request so you'd have
to use something like Postman or
something uh you can also subscribe to
SNS uh notifications to get alerts when
pricing for the Services change adabs
prices change periodically such as when
adabs Cuts prices when new instance
types are launched or when new services
are introduced so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and what I want to do here is show you
savings plans and so savings plan is
going to be found under the a cost
Explorer so just type in cost Explorer
at the top here or if you want you can
type in savings plan as well and once we
are here on the left hand side we are
going to have uh savings plans options
so we're going to go to the overview and
here it just describes um what are
savings plans if you want to read
through it but down below if you have
already some spend happening it's going
to make some suggestions and in this
particular account it's saying that I
could save some money on compute before
we take a look here I'm just going to go
to the form here and see what we can see
so up here we can say a commitment
through three years by the way you have
compute savings which applies to ec2
fargate or Lambda then you have the ec2
specific one where uh we can select a
very particular type of instance family
and then there's the sage maker savings
plans um but if we go here and we just
enter in like
$2 all up front uh I don't really
understand it from here because it
doesn't make it clear what the savings
are um but uh I what it does make it
very easy is probably if we go over here
and then click down on the compute so I
kind of feel like here would autofill it
in for you and so here I filled it in uh
or sorry it's filled in for me and so
here it's saying with a one-year plan
all up front for based on the past 30
days that it's going to see that I'm
going to see a monthly savings of
$25 36 and then I can add it to the cart
that way and I kind of feel like that is
the easiest way to um figure that out
where with um with how it was going to
that form I just configured out myself
what the savings were uh there are some
utilization reports and coverage reports
honestly I've never really looked at
these before um but uh I'm just curious
like what we're looking at monthly
daily the
last let's go a few months here I've
been running stuff in this account for a
while so there should be
something
apply so nothing nothing of interest but
um I mean I guess you have a lot of use
and coverage report and utilization
report could be interesting but I
imagine it's maybe you have to be using
you have to have a savings plan before
you can see this so that's probably the
reason why um but yeah hopefully that
gives you a clear idea that you know you
can just go down to those
recommendations and and see exactly what
you can save and you just add it to your
cart and then once you want to pay for
it you just choose to submit that order
and you're all good to go all right so
that's savings
[Music]
plans let's take a look here at defense
in depth to understand the layers of
security ads has to consider uh for
their data centers for their uh virtual
workloads and things that you also have
to consider when you are uh thinking
about security for your Cloud resources
so in the most interior we have data so
this is access to business and customer
data and encryption to protect your data
then we have applications so
applications are secure and free of
security vulnerabilities then you have
comput so access to Virtual machines
ports on premise and Cloud you have the
network layer so this limits
communication between resources using
segmentation and access controls you
have the perimeter itself so distributed
denial of service protection to filter
large scale attacks before they can
cause denial of service of users you
could say that's part of the network
layer and that's what I say there are
variants on this but we're just
separating it out uh explicitly there we
have identity and access so controlling
access to infrastructure and change
control and then there's the physical
layer so limiting access to data centers
to only authorized Personnel you'll
notice I highlighted identity and access
in yellow it's because that is
considered the new primary
um perimeter from the customer's
perspective of course ad has concern
about the physical perimeter and things
like that but as it as a customer that's
what you're going to be thinking about
especially with the zero trust model and
when you see these depths the idea is
that in order to get here you have to
pass through all this stuff so if this
um if this outward one is protected
pretty well then you generally don't
have to worry about the Interiors but of
course you should um but yeah there you
go
let's take a look here at
confidentiality integrity and
availability also known as the CIA Triad
is a model describing the foundation to
security principles and their trade-off
relationships so here is our Triad so we
have confidentiality so confidentiality
is a component of privacy that
implements to protect our data from
unauthorized viewers in practice this
can be using cryptographic keys to
encrypt our data and using keys to
encrypt our keys so envelope encryption
then we have integrity so maintaining
and ensuring the accuracy and
completeness of data over its entire
life cycle in practice utilizing asset
compliant databases for valid
transactions utilizing tamper evident or
tamper proof Hardware security modules
hsms availability so information needs
to be available when needed in practice
so high availability mitigating dos uh
decryption access so the CIA Triad was
first mentioned in N publication in 1977
there have been efforts to expand and
modernize or Alternatives the CIA triab
so one was in 1998 for the six Atomic
elements of information uh or in 2004 we
have the N engineering principles for uh
for information technology security so
has 33 security principles but this is
still a very popular um model for
security uh and it's just to kind of
tell you like you know you don't always
get everything you don't get all three
of them sometimes you have to trade off
in your scenario um you know and
hopefully some of the terminology here
will uh resonate as we go through more
security
[Music]
content what I want to do here is just
Define the term vulnerability so a
vulnerability is a whole or weakness in
an application which can be designed a
design flaw or implementation bug that
allows an attacker to cause harm to
stakeholders or applications and uh
there's a lot of great definitions of
vulnerabilities but OAS has a ton of
them and we talked about OAS when we
talk about Abus Waf uh but it's an
organization that creates security
projects that help you know what you
should protect uh or gives you a working
examples so that you can understand how
to get better at security and so they
have a lot of ones here but maybe you'll
might notice some here like using a
broken or risky cryptographic algorithm
maybe there's a memory leak least
privilege violation so that's um uh
lease privilege is something that is a
thing that you're always worried about
insecurity improper data validation
buffer overflows so you know just to
kind of set the tone of what a
vulnerability is and things you should
be thinking about
[Music]
okay let's understand what encryption is
but before we do we need to understand
what is cryptography so this is the
practice and study of techniques for
secure communication in the presence of
third parties called adversaries and
encryption is the process of encoding or
scrambling information using a key and a
cipher to store sensitive data in an
unintelligible format as a means of
protection uh an encryption takes in
plain text and produces produces a
cipher text
so here's an example of a very old um
encryption machine this is the igma
machine used during World War II and it
has a different key for each day that it
was used to set the position of the
rotors and it relied on simple Cipher
substitution and so you might be asking
what is a cipher and that's what we're
going to look at
[Music]
next so what is a cipher it is an
algorithm that performs encryption or
decryption so Cipher is synomous with
code uh and the idea is that you use the
code to either unlock or or lock up the
information that you have so what is a
cipher text a cyer text is the result of
encryption performed on Plain text via
an algorithm so you lock that up you
scramble it it doesn't make sense and
you need that code to unlock it to get
the information so a good practical
example back in the day was a code book
and this was a type of document used for
Gathering and storing cryptographic
codes or ciphers so the idea is if we
zoomed up on here notice where we have
cannot so uh and it would be 0 0 and
then there would be give them Authority
so the idea
is0 0 or if you had the word cannot it
would translate to z0 and then you use
z0 to match that up to say what does
that actually mean and so that is kind
of a very practical example of ciphers
in
[Music]
action so we just took a look at
encryption but what are cryptographic
keys so a c a cryptographic key an easy
way to think of it is a variable used in
conjunction with an encryption algorithm
in order to encrypt or decrypt data and
there are different kinds of um ones we
have so we have symmetric encryption so
this is where we have the same key that
is used for encoding and decoding uh and
a very popular one and the one you will
see on AWS is called Advanced encryption
standard AES so just take a look at that
graphic very closely so we have one key
and it is used to encrypt so it produces
the cipher and then or Cipher text we
should say and then it will uh decrypt
and we will get our plain text so one
single key then we have a symetric
encryption so two keys are used one to
encode and one to decode and a very
popular one here is RSA if you're
wondering what those uh those words are
it's three people's names put together
who helped uh invent this type type of
algorithm and so here we have uh one key
for encrypt and one key for decrypt and
they're two different Keys all
[Music]
right all right let's look at the
concept of hashing and salting so for
hashing we have a hashing function and
this accepts arbitrary size values and
Maps it to a fixed size data structure
hashing can reduce the size of a store
value and hashing is a one-way process
and is deterministic so a deterministic
function always returns the same output
output for the same input so if we have
something like John Smith and we pass it
to the hash function it's going to
create something that is not human
readable but it'll say something like 02
Fae X XY whatever um and it will always
produce the same thing if the same key
or you know value is being inputed there
so the reason we use hashing functions
or hashing General is to Hash passwords
so hash functions are used to store
passwords in a database so that the
password does not reside in a plain text
format so you've heard about all these
data breaches where they've stored the
password in plain text this is the thing
that helps us avoid that issue um and
the thing again is it because it's one
way you can't take that hash and unhash
it um well there are some conditions to
it but so to authenticate a user when a
user inputs their password it is then
hash so the one that was inputed at the
time of you know login and then that
hash is compared to the stored hash in
the database and if they match the user
is successfully logged in so in that
case we never ever had to know what the
original password looked like uh popular
hashing functions are md5 Shaw 256 or
bcrypt uh if an attacker knows the
function you are using uh and uh and
stole your database they could enumerate
a dictionary of passwords to determine
the password so they'll never see it but
they could just keep on going through
that so that's why we salt our passwords
so a salt is a random string not known
to the attacker that the hash function
accepts to mitigate the deterministic
nature of a hashing function so there
you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at digital
signatures and signing so what is a
digital signature it is a mathematical
scheme for verifying the authenticity of
digital messages or documents and a
digital signature gives us tamper
evidence so did someone mess or modify
the data is this data from uh someone we
did not expect it to be is it from the
actual sender and so we kind of have
this diagram where we have a person who
sends or is going to send a message so
they sign it and then uh Bob ver ifies
that it was for the person who it's from
so there are three algorithms to a
digital signature the key generation so
generates a public and private key um
then there is signing the process of
generating a digital signature with a
private key and the inputed value so
signing which is what is happening up
here signing verification verifies the
authenticity of the message with a
public key so remember the private key
is used for signing and the public key
is used for verifying SSH uses a public
and private key to authorize remote
access into a remote machine such as a
virtual machine it is common to use RSA
and we saw that RSA is a type of
algorithm earlier and so SSH hyphen
keyen is a well-known command to
generate a public and private key on
Linux I know this one off the top of my
head I always know to do this um and so
what is code signing so when you use a
digital signature to ensure computer
code has not been tampered and so that's
just a like subset of digital signatur
so you can use this as a means to get
into a virtual machine or you can use
signing as a means to make sure that the
code being committed to your repository
is who you expect it to be from so there
you
[Music]
go let's talk about intransit versus at
rest encryption so encryption and
Transit this is data that is secure when
moving between locations and the
algorithms here are TLS and SSL then you
have encryption at rest so this is data
that is secure when residing on storage
or within a database so we're looking at
AES or RSA which we both covered
previously these algorithms so ones that
we did not cover was TLS and SSL so
we'll cover them now so TLS transport
layer security is an encryption protocol
for data Integrity between two or more
commun communicating Computer
Applications so 1.0 and 1.1 are no
longer used but TLS 1.2 and 1.3 is the
current best practice then we have SS
cell secure socket layers so an
encrypted protocol for data Integrity
between two or more communicating uh
Computer Applications so 1.0 2.0 and 3.0
are deprecated um and honestly I always
get these two mixed up and I always fig
fig uh uh get confused which is being
used but um you know they're always
changing on us but just understand
generally what these concepts are and
that you're familiar with the terms
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown for
exampro and we are taking a look at
common compliance programs so these are
a set of internal policies and
procedures for a company to comply with
laws rules and regulations or to uphold
business reputation so here we have a
bunch of different compliance programs
and so some popular ones are like Hippa
or um PCI DSS the question is should you
know these yes you should generally know
the most popular ones because you're
going to see them throughout your Cloud
career um and so just getting familiar
now is a good time uh so let's jump into
it okay so the first one I want to
introduce you to is for I ISO and they
have a bunch of different ones so ISO is
the international organization of
standardization and there uh other one
called IEC which is the international
electrotechnical commission One deals
with uh you know like uh virtual things
the other one deals with Hardware things
but they have a lot of overlapping um
compliance programs okay and so the most
popular absolutely most popular one that
I know of is the 27100 I know a lot of
organizations that are going for the 271
this is for control implementation
guidance you have the
277 this is enhanced focus on cloud
security the 27018 this is protection of
personal data in the cloud then you have
the 2771 this is Privacy Information
Management System so pims framework this
outlines controls and processes to
manage data privacy and protect pii so
that's personally identifi information
then you have system and organization
control sock and this is a very popular
thing that organizations go for
especially the sock 2 so sock one is 18
standards and report on the
effectiveness of internal controls at
the service organization relevant to the
client's internal control over financial
reporting we have sock 2 evaluates
internal controls policies and
procedures that directly relate to the
security of the system at a service
organization and sock three a report
based on the trust uh service Services
criteria that can be freely
distributed then we have PCI DSS a set
of security standards designed to ensure
that all companies that accept process
store and transmit credit card
information maintains in a secure
environment we have a federal
information procedure standards or fips
so 140 hyphen 2 This Is Us and Canadian
government standard that specifies the
security requirements for cryptographic
modules that protect sensitive
information then we have uh phipa this
is more relevant to me because I'm
actually in Ontario in Canada but it's
also very uh wellknown
um uh went out there outside of HIPPA so
this regulates patient protected health
information then you actually have Hippa
this is the US federal law that
regulates patient procedure health
information then we have uh Cloud
security Alliance so CSA star
certification independent third-party
assessment of a cloud provider security
posture if you've never heard of CSA
they have a very uh well-known
fundamental uh security certification
called the cssk or ccsk I always get
that that mixed up then we have uh fed
ramp which we covered earlier in this
course or in the future depending on
where we put it but um fed ramp stands
for federal risk and authorization
Management program it's a US Government
standardization approach to security
authorizations for cloud service
offerings if you want to work with the
US government or places that sell the US
government you need fed ramp that
similar to criminal justice Information
Services any US state or local agency
that wants to access the FBI's cgis
database is required to adhere to the C
GIS security policy then we have gdpr uh
the general data protection regulation
everyone knows what this is in Europe
maybe not so much in North America or
other places a European Privacy Law
imposes new rules on companies
governments agencies nonprofits and
other organizations that offer goods and
services to people in the European Union
or that collect analyze data triy tied
to EU residents there's a lot of
compliance programs out there one that's
also very popular is fips but we'll get
to that when we talk about camp Ms um
but yeah there you
[Music]
go so I just wanted to quickly show you
here the adus compliance programs page
where they list out all the types of
compliance programs that adus is uh
working with and that it has different
types of certification and attestment
which we can use itus artifact or Amazon
artifact whichever prefix they decide to
use for the name there um to uh ensure
that it was has in order to meet those
regulatory compliance so you can see
them all there and if you want to know a
little bit more about any of these you
just go ahead and click them and you can
read and they have additional
information so you have a better idea
[Music]
okay let's talk about pen testing so pen
testing is an authorized simulated Cyber
attack on a computer system performed to
evaluate the security of the system and
on AWS you are allowed to perform uh pen
testing but um there are some
restrictions so permitted services are
ec2 instances KN gateways elbs RDS so
that's relational database service
cloudfront Aurora API gateways Lambda
Lambda Edge functions light cell
resources elastic beanock environments
things you cannot do or you should not
be doing is DNS Zone walking via row 53
hosted zones then there's dos simulation
testing so you should not be doing do or
dos
doses or simulated Doss or simulated
doses okay and that doesn't mean that
you can't necessarily do them uh again
there's a lot of exceptions to the pen
testing they have a whole page on this
but generally you're not allowed to do
dsing uh Port flooding protocol flooding
request flooding can't do any of those
things for other simulated events you
need to submit a request to bus a reply
could take up to seven days uh you know
again there's a lot of uh uh little
intricacies here so you'd have to really
read up on it if you're interested in
doing this
okay
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at pen testing
on the adus platform so they have this
page here that tells you what you're
allowed to do what you're not allowed to
do um and there's some additional things
you can read into like the stress test
policy the Dos simulate simulation
testing policy which I didn't cover in
detail uh in the course content but if
for whatever reason you're interested in
it I just want you to be aware of that
kind of stuff if you want to simulate
events there is a simulate events form
that you have to fill out so you open it
up up and you can kind of read about it
and it gives ad us a heads up of what
you're going to be doing stress test
fishing malware analysis other so that
way that if you are doing it you're not
going to get in trouble they're aware of
what you are doing okay so that's pretty
much
[Music]
it hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at itus
artifact which is a self serve portal
for ond demand access to adus compliance
reports so here's an example of a a
bunch of different compliance reports
that adus could be meeting and the idea
is that when you go to this portal
within the adus Management console
you'll have a huge list of reports that
you can go and access so here I'm
searching for Canada to get the
government of Canada partner package and
then I go ahead and I download that
report as a PDF and then within the PDF
we can click a link to get the
downloadable Excel and that's pretty
much what it is it's just if you want to
see that databus is being compliant for
different
programs
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're going to take a look at Aus
artifact so in the top here we're going
to type in
artifact and not be confused with code
artifact which I guess is a new service
there's just always releasing new
Services e and so here we have a video
and some things but uh it's not too hard
all we got to do is go to view
reports and from here we have all the
types of compliance programs or
Regulatory Compliance programs that ads
is uh meeting and we can do is search
for something so we type in Canada and
that's the government of Canada partner
package and I can go ahead and download
that report so when you download it you
really want to open this up
in um you're going to really want to
open this up in um uh Adobe Acrobat
because if you don't open up an Adobe
Acrobat you're not going to be able to
access the
downloadblack reader and once to have it
open and I'm just moving it over here
this is what you're going to see and um
it's going to say like hey um oops no I
don't want to do that so please scroll
to the next page to view the artifact
download and so I think that if we go
here you know they say scroll to the
next page but I'm pretty sure we can
just go here on the left hand side and
this is what we're looking for that
Excel spreadsheet so we're going to save
that
attachment or actually we just going to
open it up
open this
file okay and we'll give it a moment I
have Excel
installed and there we
go there it is okay so I know it's a
little bit odd way to get to those um
certificates or reports but that's just
how it works um but yeah I mean that's
the idea is like if you need to prove
that ABS is meeting whatever those
standards are you can just type them in
whatever it is I maybe there like fed
ramp right whatever it is and download
those certificate attestment whatever um
and just double check that ads is
Meeting those standards
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at AIS
inspector but before we can answer what
it does let's talk about hardening so
hardening is the act of eliminating as
many security risks as possible
hardening is common for virtual machines
where you run a collection of C Security
checks known as a security Benchmark so
abis inspector runs a security Benchmark
against specific spefic ec2 instances
and you can run a variety of security
benchmarks and you can perform Network
and host assessments and so here's an
example of those two check boxes there
which you'd say which assessments you
want to do so the idea is you have to
install the edus agent on your ec2
instance you run an assessment for your
assessment Target you review your
findings and remediate security issues
and one very popular Benchmark you can
run is the CIS which has 699 checks so
if you don't know what CIS it stands for
the center of Internet Security uh and
so they are this organization that has a
bunch of um uh security controls or
check marks uh that are published that
they suggest that you should check on
your
[Music]
machine hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam PR and we're looking at dos so dos
is a type of malicious attack to disrupt
normal traffic by flooding a website
with a large amount of fake traffic so
the idea is we have an attacker and the
victim the victim is us and it could be
our virtual machines our cloud services
the idea is that it's some kind of uh
resource which um can take in uh
incoming requests over the Internet so
the idea is the attacker is utilizing
the internet and so they may control a
bunch of uh virtual machines or servers
that are loaded up with malicious
software and the idea is that the
attacker is going to tell them all to
send a flood of traffic over the
Internet uh at your uh Computing
resource and uh this is where your
website is going to either start to
stall or it's going to become
unavailable for your users and so the
idea here is that you know if you want
to protect against CS you need some kind
of Dos protection traditionally those
used to be like third party services
that you uh would have to pay for and
and it would sit in front of uh your
load balancer or your uh end server but
now the great thing with cloud service
providers is that generally their
networks have built in DOS protection so
the idea is just by having your compute
or your resources on AWS you're going to
get uh built-in protection for free via
ad shield and we'll talk about that
[Music]
next hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at it
Shield which is a managed dos Protection
Service that safeguards applications
running on AWS so when you route your
traffic through R 53 or cloudfront you
are using a shield standard so here's a
diagram to kind of show you that it's
not just those services but these are
the most common ones where you'll have a
point of entry into AWS so here we could
also be including elastic IP it Global
accelerator but the idea is that when
you uh go through these Services into
the Aus Network it has Shield built in
and so you're going to get that
protection before those uh before that
traffic reaches your uh cloud services
and in this case we're showing uh ec2
instances so ad Shield protects against
layers three four and seven attacks uh
layer three four and seven is based off
the The OSI model which is a um a
fundamental networking concept so seven
is for the application layer four is the
transport Layer Three is the network
layer um there are two different types
of plans for you to Shield we have
Shield standard which is free and then
Shield Advance which starts at 3,000 USD
per year plus some additional uh costs
based on usage of the size of the tack
or what services you're using how much
traffic is moving in and out so
protection against the most common dos
attacks is what Shield standard does uh
you have access to tools and best
practices to build dos resiling
architecture it's automatically
available on all services for additional
protection against larger and more
sophisticated attacks that's where
Shield Advance comes into play it's
available for specific adus services so
R 53 cloudfront elb adus Global
accelerator elastic IP uh and some
notable features here is visibility
reporting on layer three four and seven
you're only going to get seven if you
are using idwa with it uh you have
access to team and support so these are
DOs experts but you're only going to get
it if you're paying for business or
Enterprise support as you're paying for
this as well uh you also get dodos cost
protection just ensure that you know
your bills don't go crazy uh and it
comes with an SLA so you have a
guarantee that it's going to work both
plants integrate with itless web
application firewall so w to give you
that layer set application protection so
understand that if you're not using Waf
you're not going to be having that layer
7 protection
[Music]
okay hey this is Andre Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Amazon guard
Duty so before we look at that we need
to understand what is an IDs IPS so an
intrusion detection system and intrusion
protection system is used as a device or
software application that monitors and
network or systems for malicious
activity or policy violations so guard
duty is a threat detection service which
is IDs IPS that continuously monitors
for malicious and suspicious activity
and unauthorized Behavior it uses
machine learning to analyze the
following adus logs your cloud trail
logs your VPC flow logs your DNS logs
and what it will do is report back to
you and say hey um there's this issue
here and this is actually one that's
very easy to replicate it's just saying
somebody is using the root credentials
and it's suggesting that you should not
be doing that right because you're never
supposed to be uh invoking API calls
with the root credentials or you should
be limiting that you'll might also
notice that if you want to investigate
you can kind of follow up that with uh
Amazon detective or adus detective
whichever uh prefix they decided to put
on that service it will alert you of
findings which you can automate an
incident uh response via cloudwatch
events which this uh it's been renamed
to event Bridge so you know or third
party service services so you can follow
up a remediation action um and here is a
graphic of Amazon guard Duty just a bit
up closer so you can see all the
findings and you can just see you have a
lot of detailed information there
[Music]
okay hey this is Andre Brown from exam
Pro and we're going to take a look at
guard Duty so guard duty is um an
intrusion protection and detection uh
service and so what I've done is I've um
I've done some bad practices purposely
so that I can show you um some
information in there so I'm going to go
over to guard Duty okay and you do have
to turn guard Duty on and so once guard
duty is on you're going to start getting
reports coming in so notice here that we
have some anomalous Behavior 8 days ago
and so uh that's B he's uh my co-founder
he's also named Andrew as well and so we
can kind of see some details here about
who's accessing what and what they were
doing he's not doing anything malicious
but we can have an idea where they're
from even shows generally where he is
which he is near Thunder Bay and his his
provider would be
TB um and you can see that he is making
uh API calls to describe account
attributes and things like that then the
other issue is the root account so
there's MFA I turned it off so that we
can or maybe this just usage here I
actually do have it turned on I suppose
here we see root credential usage and so
it's saying hey you used it 77 times
because sometimes I go in and and use uh
the root account for tutorials but
saying you're using this way too much
you got stop doing that okay so that's
something that is uh pretty interesting
with guard Duty um and it's really cost
effective and easy to turn on so you can
turn it on looks like they have a new
thing for S3 um have not looked at that
as of yet but that's kind of cool kind
of feels like that would overlap with uh
Amazon Macy but whatever and here we get
a breakdown of cost so we see cloud
trail VPC flow logs DS logs and this is
where it would be ingesting data if you
want to use that S3 protection you'd
have to probably be turning or creating
a custom cloudwatch Trail that has data
events to consume that information um
you know so you know hopefully that
gives you kind of an idea of things you
can do and you can also centralize guard
Duty uh into one account so you can have
one thing that takes care of everything
and and move all the data across all
your accounts into a single place so
that's kind of interesting and you can
set up follow follow-ups um it's
possible that uh I'm not see in this
this here but generally it would show
you uh it would show show you a way of
like triggering into Cloud watch
probably you can do it pragmatically
this is something interesting like the
list management you can add trusted IPS
or threat list so if there's people that
you know are fine you can just Whit list
them or if there's people that you know
that are bad make sure that they are
never allowed to get through so that's
pretty much it with guard Duty
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at Amazon
Macy so Macy is a fully managed service
that continuously monitors S3 data
access activity for anomalies and
generates detailed alerts when it
detects risks of unauthorized access or
inadvertent data leaks so Macy works by
using machine learning to analyze your
cloud trail logs and Macy has a variety
of alerts so we have anomaly access
config compliance credential loss data
compliance file hosting identity
numeration information loss um location
anomaly open permissions privilege
escalation ransomware service disruption
suspicious access andac will identify
your most at risk users which could lead
to compromise so here's just one little
kind of uh tidbit from the um app itself
where you have the total users and they
categorize them into different uh risks
I can't remember which flag means what
in here uh Amazon Macy is an okay
Service uh it's it's very important if
you're storing things in
S3 but uh I don't I don't use it very
often to be
[Music]
honest hey this is Andie Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at adus
virtual private Network also known as
VPN so adus VPN lets you establish a
secure and private tunnel from your
network or device to the itus global
Network it's very important to emphasize
the word secure here uh because when
you're using Direct Connect that will
establish a private connection but it's
not using any kind of protocol to secure
that data in transit whereas a VPN will
be using a secure protocol there are two
options here we have itus sight to site
VPN so securely connect on premise
Network or branch office site to VPC and
itus cvpn that securely connect users to
adabs or on premises
networks one thing that we need to
understand alongside vpns is IPC this
stands for Internet Protocol security
and is a secure network protocol Suite
that authenticates and encrypts the
packets of data to provide secure
encrypted communication between two
computers over Internet Protocol Network
and it is used in vpns and Abus
definitely uses it
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at Abus web
application firewall also known as WF
which protects you uh protects your web
application from common web exploits so
the idea here is you write your own
rules to allow or deny traffic based on
the contents of an HTP requests you use
a rol set from a trusted Abus security
partner in the Abus Waf rule Marketplace
Waf can be attached to either cloudfront
or an application load balancer so here
is that diagram the idea is you see
cloudfront with the Waf or ALB with the
WAFF and what it does is it can protect
uh web applications from attacks covered
and the OAS 10 uh top 10 most dangerous
attacks if you don't know OAS they're
the open web application security
project and they basically have all
these uh security projects which are
things to say hey these are things that
you should commonly protect against or
they might have like example
applications that uh serve as a means to
learn security so when we look at the
top 10 it's injection broken
authentication sensitive data exposure
XML external entities so xxe broken
Access Control security
misconfigurations cross-site scripting
so xss uh insecure deserialization using
components with known vulnerabilities
and insufficient logging and monitoring
so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are going to take a quick
look at adus web application firewall
also known as WF and so um in this
account I happen to have a Waf running
uh so we don't have to create one uh we
already have something we can take a
look here so I'm going to go to Waf and
shield and then on the left hand side
you'll notice it's a global Service but
on the left hand side we're going to be
looking for our web acl's and so the
idea is that when you want a w you
create a web ACL and then within within
that web ACL you have uh the overview
and then you have it can kind of show
you kind of the traffic that's going on
here we can have our rules and so um
there's a lot of different kind of
manage rule groups that you can use so
these are ones that are provided by AWS
so and a lot of these some of these can
be paid some of these are free so you
see there's these free rule groups where
you're like hey hey I don't want any
nominus IPS you checkbox that on you
know or I want to protect against SQL
injection now the interesting thing is
that abis has this capacity unit so um
you can't add all of these you can add a
certain amount of capacity before you
have to um um uh pay for more or
something like that it's just kind of a
way to um uh kind of cap the amount of
stuff that you can put in in terms of
rules um but there's a lot of other um
rule groups from third party services
like security companies that know what
they're doing so if you like Fort Net's
OS top 10 you can uh subscribe to that
in the marketplace and be able to use it
but uh yeah so that's how you apply
rules there's something called bot
control I've never used this before get
real-time visibility into bot activity
on your resource and controllers what
Bots allow and block from your resources
that sounds really cool I cannot stand
bots so I might turn that on myself or
take a look at the cost there and see
what we can find out but that's pretty
much it with WAFF um one thing I would
say is that you can block out specific
IP addresses or Whit list specific IP
addresses and you might do that through
rules I'm just going to see yeah like
maybe the bypass here and so these IP
addresses are some of our um Cloud
support Engineers where they're using
our admid panel and um uh WF is being
too aggressive in terms of protection
and so sometimes you have to uh say hey
allow this IP address and let my um you
know let my cloud support engineer be
able to use the mid panel because
they're not malicious okay so that's one
little exception there but that's pretty
much it
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at Hardware
security modules also known as HSM and
it's a piece of Hardware designed to
store encryption keys and it holds keys
in memory and never writes on the dis so
the idea is that if the HSM was shut
down uh that key would be gone and that
would be a guarantee of protection
because nobody could you know take the
drive and steal it so here is an example
of an HSM uh these are extremely
expensive so you definitely don't want
to have to buy them yourselves uh they
generally follow fips so fips is the
federal information processing standard
so it's a us and Canadian government
standard that specifies the security
requirements for cryptographic modules
that protect sensitive information fips
is something you want to definitely
remember um and there are two different
um protocols here there's actually a
bunch of different uh fips versions but
we have fips 142 level two and then fips
143 level three so let's talk about the
difference here so hsms that are multi
tenant are going to be using fips 142
hyphen 2 level two compliant where you
have multiple customers virtually
isolated on the
HSM and then there are hsms that are
single tenant and so they're going to be
utilizing fips 140 hyphen to level three
compliant so a single customer on a
dedicated
HSM and so the reason why we have these
two levels is that when you have
multiple tenants you can say all right
this thing is uh has temperate evidence
evence so we can see that somebody was
trying to break into it but there's no
guarantee of uh T it being tamper proof
where level three is tamper proof
there's also uh fips 140 hyphen 3 which
is the new uh the newer um standard but
not all uh Cloud resources uh can meet
that standard just because of how they
offer the service uh so again fips 142
is really good but just understand that
there are other ones out there and it's
very easy to get fips 142 level three
mixed up with pips 140 hyphen 3
something that I always had um a hard
time remembering the distinguishing
between those two so for multi-tenant
this is where we're using adus Key
Management Service and for single tenant
we're using adus Cloud HSM and the only
time you're really using Cloud HSM is if
you're a large Enterprise and you need
that Regulatory Compliance of getting
fips 14052 Level 3
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at Key
Management Service also known as KMS and
it is a managed service that makes it
easy for you to create and control the
encryption Keys you use to encrypt your
data so KMS is a multi-tenant HSM so
it's a Hardware security module and many
adaba services are integrated to use KMS
to encrypt your data with a simple
checkbox and K KMS uses envelope
encryption so here's that example of a
simple checkbox in this case it's for
RDS and what you'll do is choose a
master key A lot of times ads will have
a default for uh key for you that's
managed by them that is free to use
which is really great uh so for KMS it's
using envelope encryption so when you
encrypt your data your data is protected
but you have to protect your encryption
key when you encrypt your data key with
a master key as an additional layer of
security so that's how it works so just
to make this really clear I have my data
I use this key to encrypt this data and
now I need to protect this key so I use
another key to encrypt uh this key which
forms an envelope and then I store this
uh master key in KMS and this one's
considered the data key all
[Music]
right hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're going to take a look at
Key Management Service also known as KMS
so type in KMS on the top here and we'll
pop over here and KMS is a way for you
to create your own keys or you can use
adus manage keys so up here and not all
these appear right away but as you use
Services um you will it us will generate
out manage keys for you and these are
free you can uh create your own Keys um
and these cost a dollar each so if I go
ahead here and create a key I can choose
whether it's symmetric or asymmetric
which we definitely learned in the
course which is nice for asymmetric you
can make it encrypt and decrypt sign and
verify and they're just kind of
narrowing down the type of key would use
um for this you know if I went to
symmetric I go here I'm just kind of
seeing if if I can enter the uh actual
material into the key here um so I'm
just going to keep clicking through here
U my custom key generally you don't
really need to do this but um you know
if it's interesting you can set up
administrators to say who's allowed to
administer the key and then you have
someone that um is allowed to use the
key and you usually want to keep those
two accounts separate you don't want to
have the same person administrating and
using the key okay keep those two
separate and so we would have a key
policy so you can change this to say the
rule tools that is allowed to use um and
then we can go here and hit finish and
so there we now have our own custom key
and one thing we can
do is it's possible to rotate out these
Keys when you need to be um but anyway
when we want to use CS it's built into
basically everything and we've seen it
multiple times throughout this course
when we gone over to ec2 we'll just go
take a peek at a few different places
here so when we've gone to go launch an
ec2 instance and we go over to uh
storage so we say
select and review or next and we go over
to storage notice that here this is
using encryption right so I can choose
that or even my custom key if you're in
Dynamo DB or anywhere else it's always
something like a checkbox and you choose
your key so that's pretty much all there
really is to KMS it's very easy to use
and there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are going to take a look here
at Cloud HSM it is a single tenant uh
HSM as a service that automates Hardware
provisioning software patching High
availability and backups so here's the
idea is that you have your ads Cloud HSM
you have your developers interacting
with it your application interacting
with it you have an HSM client installed
in your uh ec2 instance so that it can
access uh the cloud HSM keys so adus
Cloud HSM enables you to generate and
use your encryption keys on fips 140
hyphen 2 level 3 validated Hardware it's
built on open HSM industry standards to
integrate with things like PK uh
cs1 Java cryptography uh extension so
jce Microsoft crypto and G libraries you
can transfer your keys to other
commercial commercial HSM Solutions to
make it easy for you to migrate keys on
or off AWS configure a KMS to use ads
Cloud HSM uh cluster as a custom uh key
store rather than the default KMS key
store uh so Cloud HSM is way more
expensive than KMS KMS is like free or a
dollar per key where Cloud HSM is a
fixed cost per month because you are
getting a dedicated piece of Hardware um
and there's not a lot of stuff around it
so other than the ad KMS integration a
lot of times it can be really hard to
use this as well so the only time you're
really going to be using Cloud HSM is if
you're an ENT prise and you need to meet
fips 140 hyphen 2 level three compliancy
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are taking a look at know
your initialism so a lot of AD services
and Concepts and Cloud Technologies use
initialisms to just kind of shorten uh
common things that we need to use on a
frequent basis and it's going to really
help if you learn these because then
what you can do is substitute them when
you are uh seeing a service name or
something particular and that's going to
get you through content a lot faster um
and in the wild you're going to see
these all over the place because people
aren't going to say the full name
they're going to say the initialism so
let's go through them so for I am it's
identity and access management for S3
that's simple storage for S swf it's uh
swf that's simple workflow service SNS
is simple notification service sqs is
simple Q service SCS is simple email
service SSM is simple systems manager
but uh you know when we see the name
it's usually just systems manager but we
still use the uh initialism SSM then
there's RDS relational database service
VPC virtual private Cloud VPN virtual
private Network CFN cloud formation WF
web application firewall and that is a
very common initialism not just adabs
but outside of it as well mq for Amazon
active m Q ASG for Autos scaling groups
Tam for technical account manager elb
for elastic load bouncer ALB for the
application load bouncer NLB for the
network load bouncer G wlb for the
Gateway load balcer clb for the classic
load bouncer ec2 for elastic cloud or
Cloud compute ECS for elastic container
service ECR for elastic container
repository EBS for elastic block storage
EMR for elastic map produce EFS for
elastic FAL store EB or EB for elastic
beant stock es for elastic search eks
for elastic kuber netti service msk for
managed kofka service and if you think I
got the SNK backwards I did not for
whatever reason it's mskk uh then uh
there's abis resource manager which is
known as RAM ACM for Amazon certificate
manager Pol for principal of lease
privilege which is a concept not a
service iot internet of things this is
not a service but is a Tech concept or
Cloud concept RI for reserved instances
and I'm sure there are more but these
are the ones that I know off the top of
my head uh and they're in my uh usual
use case uh for what I'm doing dayto day
but a lot of times you'll probably just
end up needing to remember ASG
elb um ec2 S3 things like that
[Music]
okay all right let's compare adus config
and app config which both have config in
the name but there are two completely
different services so adus config and
app config so Adis config is a
governance tool for compliance as code
you can create rules that will check to
see if resources are configured the way
you expect them to be if a resource
drifts from the expected configuration
you are notified or adus config can auto
remediate correct the configuration back
to the expected state for app config it
is used to automate the process of
deploying application configuration
variable changes to your web application
you can write a valid Val Ator to ensure
the changed variable will not break your
web app uh you can monitor deployments
and automate Integrations to catch
errors or roll backs so config is for
compliance governance app config is for
conf application configur configuration
variables so there you
[Music]
go let us take a look at SNS versus sqs
and uh these things have something in
common and it's they both connect apps
via messages uh so they're for
application integration so let's take a
look at SNS so simple notification
service and then simple Q service okay
so SNS is intended to pass along
messages via a pub sub model whereas sqs
cues up messages and has a guaranteed
delivery so the idea with SNS you send
notifications to subscribers of topics
via multiple protocols so it could be H
HTTP email sqs smns and SNS is generally
used for sending plain text emails which
is triggered via other adab services the
best example here is billing alarms I
know we mentioned this but I like to
repeat it so that you absolutely know uh
it can retry sending in the case of
failur of https so it does have a retry
attempt but that doesn't mean there's a
guarantee of delivery it's really good
for web hooks simple internal emails
triggering Lambda functions if you had
to compare these to thirdparty Services
it's similar to Pusher or uh pubnub so
sqs is uh the idea here is that messages
are placed into a queue applications
pull the queue using the itus SDK you
can uh uh retain a message for up to 14
days you can send them in sequential
order sequential order or in parallel
you can ensure only one message is sent
you can ensure messages are delivered at
least once it's really good for delayed
task queuing up emails um comparable uh
stuff would be something like rabbit mq
or uh Ruby on Rails sidekick
[Music]
okay hey this is Andy Brown from exam
Pro and we're doing variation study with
SNS versus SC versus pinpoint versus
workmail and so SNS and SCS get confused
quite often but all of these Services uh
have something in common they all send
emails but uh the utility of email is
completely different for each one so the
first one is simple notification service
is for practical and internal emails so
you send notifications to subscribers of
topics via multiple protocols so it's
not just for email it can handle HTTP it
can send sqs it can send SNS me or SMS
messages so um messages to your phone um
but uh it does send emails and so SNS is
generally used for sending plain text
emails which is triggered via other a
Services the best example of this is a
building alarm so most exam questions
are going to be talking about SNS
because lots of services can trigger um
SNS for notifications and so that's the
idea it's like oh um you know did
somebody spend server send off an email
through via SNS uh did we spend too much
money here you know all sorts of things
can go through SNS to send out emails
and you need to know what are topics and
subscriptions regarding SNS then you
have sces so simple email service and
this is for transactional emails and
when I say transactional emails I'm
talking about emails that should be
triggered based on inapp action so sign
up reset password invoices um so a
cloud-based email service that is
similar to this would be like send grid
sces sends HTML emails uh SNS cannot so
that is the distinction is that SCS can
do HTML and pl text but SNS just do does
plain text and you would not use SNS for
transactional emails SCS can receive
inbound emails uh SCS uh can create
email templates custom uh domain name
emails so when you use SNS it's whatever
Amazon gives you it's going to be some
weird address but sces is whatever
custom domain you want you can also
monitor your email reputation for SCS
then you have Amazon pinpoint and so
this is for promotional emails so these
uh when we say promotional we're talking
about emails for marketing so you can
create email campaigns you can segment
your contacts you can create customer
Journeys via emails um it can do a Tob
email testing and so sces and pinpoint
get mixed up because a lot of people
think well can I just use my transaction
emails for promotion emails absolutely
you can it's not recommended because um
you know pinpoint has a lot more
functionality around promotional emails
they're built differently uh and so you
know just understand that those two have
overlapping responsibilities but
generally you should use them for what
they're for then you have Amazon
workmail and this is just an email web
client so it's similar to Gmail or
Outlook you can create company emails
read write and send emails from a web
client within the adus Management
console so there you
[Music]
go let us compare Amazon inspector
versus adus trusted advisor so both of
these are security tools and they both
perform audits but what they do is
slightly different so Amazon inspector
audits a single ec2 instance that you've
selected or I suppose you could select a
multiple e2s it generates a report from
a long list of Security checks um and so
trusted advisor has checks but uh the
the key difference here is that it
doesn't generate out a PDF report though
I'm sure you could export CSV data if
you wanted to and then then turn that
into a report uh it it gives you a
holistic view of recommendations across
multiple services and best practices so
for example if you have an open port on
the security groups I can tell you about
about that you should enable MFA on your
root account when using trusted adviser
things like that um one thing though is
that trust advisor isn't just for
security does checks across um uh five
different things um but they both do
security and they both technically do
checks
okay
so there are a few services that have
connected the name you'd think they' be
related in some way but they absolutely
are not and they don't even have similar
functionality but let's take a look here
so we know the difference the first is
direct connect it is a dedicated fiber
optics connection from your data center
DWS it's intended for large Enterprises
with their own Data Center and they need
an insanely fast and private connection
directly uh to AWS and you'll notice
they give private and enthesis because
if you need a secure connection you need
to apply
uh an adus virtual private network
connection on top of direct connect then
you have Amazon connect this is a call
center as a service get a toll-free
number accept inbound and outbound calls
set up automated phone systems uh so if
you ever heard of an interactive voice
system at IVs this is basically what
Amazon connect is you have media connect
this is the new version of elastic trans
coder it it converts videos to different
video types so if you have let's say a
th videos you need to transcode them
into different video formats maybe you
need to apply watermarks insert
introduction videos in in front of each
one uh this is what you use media
connect for
[Music]
okay just in case you see elastic
transcoder as an option I just want you
to know what it is compar it to Media
connect so both these services are used
for transcoding and technically elastic
transcoder is the old way and it us
Elemental media convert or just media
convert is the new way so elastic
transcoder was the original transcoding
service it may still have promatic apis
or workflows not available in media
convert so this could be reasons why we
see Legacy customers still using it or
you know it's just too much effort for
them to uh upgrade to the new one it
transcodes videos to streaming formats
uh media convert is more robust
transcoding service that can perform
various operations during transcoding so
it also transcodes videos to streaming
different streaming formats but it
overlays images it inserts uh video
clips extracts captions data it has a
robust UI so generally it's recommended
to use the uh media convert terms of
costs are basically the same so there's
no reason not to use media convert
[Music]
okay so itus artifact versus Amazon
inspector get commonly mixed up all the
time but both artifact inspector compile
out PDF reports so that's where the
confusion comes from but let's talk
about what is different about the
reports so abis artifact and Abus
inspector so for artifact you're
answering why should an Enterprise trust
AWS it generates a security report
that's based on global compliance
framework such as sock or PCI or a
variety of others where Amazon inspector
is all about how do we know this ec2
instance is secure can you prove it so
it runs a script that analyzes your ec2
instance then generates a PDF report
telling you which Security checks had
passed um so the idea here is it's an
audit tool for security of ec2 instances
so there you
[Music]
go so let us compare elb versus ALB
versus lb versus J wlb versus clb uh
because you know when I was first
learning AWS I was getting confused
because there was elastic load balcer
but there was these other ones so what
gives right so what's happening here is
that there is a main service called
elastic load balcer elb and it has four
different types of possible load balcers
so we'll go through all the types so the
first is application load balcer
commonly uh initialized as ALB and so
this operates on layer 7 for htps this
makes sense because that is the
application layer and it has some
special powers in terms of routing rules
so the idea here is you can create rules
to change routing based on information
found within the htps request so let's
say you wanted some uh routes to go that
have a particular subdomain to this
server and a different subdomain to
another one you could do that and
because it is an application load
balancer uh you can attach a web
application firewall for protection you
can attach on the NLB or other ones
because they're not application based so
that is just a little caveat there then
you have Network load bouncer uh
commonly abbreviated to NLB this
operates on layer three and four so
we're talking TCP UDP this is great for
when you have Extreme Performance that
that requires T TCP and TLS traffic it's
capable of handling millions of requests
per seconds uh while maintaining ultra
low latency it's optimized for sudden
and volatile traffic patterns while
using a single St static IP address per
availability Zone uh if you're making
video games this is what they like to
use is the network load balcer but it
has other utilities outside of that then
you have Gateway load bouncer G wlb this
is when you need to deploy a fleet of
third-party virtual appliances that
support uh I don't know how to say that
in abbreviation but I'll just uh say
it's GE NE v um and there's not much we
need to know outside of that okay then
there is the classic load balancer uh
commonly initializes C B this operates
on layer 3 4 and 7 it's intended for
applications that were built within the
ec2 classic Network it doesn't support
Target groups so albs nlbs uh use Target
groups which is just an easier way of
grouping together um a bunch of uh
Target resources like compute uh that
we're going to load balance to and with
classic load balcer you just directly
assign ec2 instances uh and it's going
to be retired on August 15th of 2022 so
yeah it looks like it can do a lot of
stuff but um it also doesn't have any of
the superpowers of these specialized
ones and so there's no reason to keep it
around and generally you should not be
using it um and so yeah that's about it